hey this is anthony tavelos your cloud
instructor at exam pro
bringing you a complete study course for
the google cloud associate cloud
engineer made available to you here on
free code camp and so this course is
designed to help you pass and achieve
google issued certification the way
we're going to do that
is to go through lots of lecture content
follow alongs and using my cheat sheets
on the day of the exam so you pass
and you can take that certification and
put it on your resume or linkedin
so you can get that cloud job or
promotion that you've been looking for
and so a bit about me is that i have 18
years industry experience
seven of it specializing in cloud and
four years of that as a cloud trainer i
previously been a cloud and devops
engineer and i've also published
multiple cloud courses and i'm a huge
fan of the cartoon looney tunes as well
as a coffee connoisseur and so i wanted
to take a moment to thank viewers like
you
because you make these free courses
possible and so if you're looking for
more ways of supporting more free
courses just like this one
the best way is to buy the extra study
material at
co example.com in particular for this
certification you can find it at gcp
hyphen ace there you can get study notes
flash cards quizlets
downloadable lectures which are the
slides to all the lecture videos
downloadable cheat sheets which by the
way are free if you just go sign up
practice exams
and you can also ask questions and get
learning support and if you want to keep
up to date with new courses i'm working
on
the best way is to follow me on twitter
at antony's cloud
and i'd love to hear from you if you
passed your exam
and also i'd love to hear on what you'd
like to see next
[Music]
welcome back
in this lesson i wanted to quickly go
over how to access the course resources
now the resources in this course are
designed to accompany the lessons and
help you understand not just the theory
but to help with the demo lessons that
really drive home the component of
hands-on learning
these will include study notes lesson
files scripts as well as resources that
are used in the demo lessons
these files can be found in a github
repository that i will be including
below that are always kept up-to-date
and it is through these files that you
will be able to follow along and
complete the demos on your own to really
cement the knowledge learned
it's a fairly simple process but varies
through the different operating systems
i'll be going through this demo to show
you how to obtain access through the
three major operating systems being
windows mac os and ubuntu linux
so i'm first going to begin with windows
and the first step would be to open up
the web browser
and browse to this url which i will
include in the notes below
and this is the course github repository
which will house all the course files
that i have mentioned before
keeping the course up to date will mean
that files may need to be changed and so
as i update them they will always be
reflected
and uploaded here in the repo
so getting back to it there are two ways
to access this repository so the easiest
way to obtain a copy of these files will
be to click on the clone or download
button and click on download zip
once the file has been downloaded you
can then open it up by clicking on it
here
and here are the files here in downloads
and this will give you a snapshot of all
the files and folders as you see them
from this repository
now although this may seem like the
simple way to go this is not the
recommended method to download as if any
files have changed you will not be up to
date with the latest files and will only
be current from the date at which you've
downloaded them now the way that is
recommended is using a source control
system called git and so the easiest way
to install it would be to go to this url
https
colon forward slash forward slash
git dash scm.com
and this will bring you to the git
website where you can download the
necessary software for windows or any
other supported operating system
and so i'm going to download it here
and this should download the latest
version of git
for windows and it took a few seconds
there but it is done
and no need to worry about whether or
not you've got the proper version
usually when you click that download
button it will download the latest
version for your operating system
so i'm going to go over here and open
this up
you'll get a prompt where you would just
say yes
and we're going to go ahead and accept
all the defaults here this is where it's
going to install it let's hit next
these are all the components that
they're going to be installed let's
click on next
and again we're going to go through
everything
with all the defaults
and once we've reached
installing all the defaults it's gonna
take a couple minutes to install
and again it took a minute or so
we're going to just click on next
and it's going to ask if you want to
view the release notes and we don't
really need those so
we can click on ok
and simply close that
and we're just going to go over and see
if git is installed
we're going to run the command prompt
and i'm going to just zoom in here so we
can see a little better
and there we go and we are just going to
type in git
and as you can see it's been installed
and so now that we've installed git we
want to be able to pull down all the
folders and the files within them from
the repository to our local system and
so i'm just going to clear the screen
here
and we're going to do a cd to make sure
that i'm in my home directory
and then we're going to make a directory
called repos
and in order to do that we're going to
do mkdir
space
repos and then we're going to move into
that directory
so cd
space repos and so again here we want to
clone those files that are in the
repository to our local system
so in order to do that we're going to
use the command git clone so get space
clone
and then we're going to need our
location of the git repository so let's
go back to the browser
and we're going to go over here to clone
or download
and here you will see clone with https
so make sure that this says https and
you can simply click on this button
which will copy this to the clipboard
and then we'll move back to our command
prompt
and paste that in
and once that's pasted just hit enter
and it will clone your repository into
the repos directory and so just to
verify that we've cloned all the
necessary files
we're going to cd into the master
directory that we had just cloned
and we're going to do a dir
and there you have it all of the files
are cloned exactly as it is here in the
repository
now just as a note in order to keep
these files up to date we need to run a
different command which would be a git
pull
and this can be run at any time in order
to pull down any files or folders that
have been updated since you did the
first pull which in this case
would be cloning of the repository
again this will provide you with the
latest and most up-to-date files at any
given moment in time and in this case
since nothing has changed i have been
prompted with a message stating that i'm
up to date if nothing is changed you
will always be prompted with this
message
if there was
it will pull your changes down to your
synced local copy and the process for
windows is completed and is similar in
mac os and i'll move over to my mac os
virtual machine and log in
and once you've logged in just going to
go over here to the terminal and i'm
just going to cd
to make sure i'm in my home directory
then i'm going to do exactly what we did
in windows so i'm going to run the
command mk
dir
space repos
and create the repos directory and i'm
going to move in to the repos directory
and then i'm going to run git
now for those of you who do not have get
installed you will be prompted with this
message to install it and you can go
ahead and just install you'll be
prompted with this license agreement you
can just hit agree
and depending on your internet
connection this will take a few minutes
to download and install so as this is
going to take a few minutes i'm going to
pause the video here and come back when
it's finished installing
okay and the software was successfully
installed
so just to do a double check i'm going
to run git
and as you can see it's been installed
so now that we have git installed we
want to clone all the directories and
the files from the github repository to
our local repos folder so i'm going to
open up my browser and i'm going to
paste my github repository url right
here
and
you'll see the clone button over here so
we're going to click on this button
and here we can download zip but like i
said we're not going to be doing that
we're going to go over here
and copy this url for the github
repository again make sure it says https
and we're going to copy this to our
clipboard
and we're going to go back to our
terminal
and we are going to
run the command git space
clone
and we're going to paste in our url
and as you can see here i've cloned the
repository and all the files and folders
within it and so as is my best practice
i always like to verify that the files
have been properly cloned and so i'm
going to run the command ls
just to make sure and go into the master
directory
and do a double check and as you can see
the clone was successful as all the
files and folders are here and again to
download any updates to any files or
directories we can simply run the
command git space poll and because we've
already cloned it it's already up to
date and so the process is going to be
extremely similar on linux so i'm going
to simply move over to my linux machine
and log in
i'm going to open up a terminal
and i'm going to make my terminal a
little bit bigger for better viewing and
so like the other operating systems i
want to clone all the files and
directories from the github repository
to my machine and so i'm going to cd
here to make sure i'm in my home
directory and like we did before we want
to create a directory called repos so
i'm going to run the command mkdir space
repos and we're going to
create the repos directory we're now
going to move into the repos directory
and here we're going to run the git
command
and because git is not installed on my
machine i've been prompted with the
command in order to install it so i'm
going to run that now so the command is
sudo
space
apt
install
space
get
and i'm going to enter in my password
and install it
and just to verify i'm going to run the
command git and i can see here it's been
installed so now i'm going to go over
here to my browser and i'm going to
paste in the url to my repository and
over here we'll have the same clone
button and when i click on it i can get
the url for the github repository in
order to clone it again make sure before
you clone that this says https
if it doesn't say https you'll have the
option of clicking on a button that will
allow you to do so once it says https
then you can simply copy this url to
your clipboard by clicking on the button
and then move over back to the terminal
and we are going to clone this
repository by typing in the get space
clone command
along with the url of the repository
and when we hit enter it'll clone it
right down to our directory so i'm just
going to move into the master directory
just to verify that the files are there
and again they're all here so again if
you're looking to update your repository
with any new updated changes you can
simply run
the get space pull command
to update those files
and so that's the linux setup so you
have a local copy of the lesson files
now there's just one more thing that i
highly recommend you do and to
demonstrate it i'm going to move back
over to my windows virtual machine now
i'm going to open up the web browser
again
open up a new tab
and i'm going to browse to this url
https colon forward slash forward slash
code.visualstudio.com
[Music]
and i'll make sure that the url is in
the text below there is a version of
this code editor available for windows
mac os and linux you can simply click on
this drop down and you'll find the link
to download it for your operating system
but in most cases it should
automatically show the correct version
so just go ahead and click on download
and it should start downloading
automatically and you should be able to
run it right away
now the reason behind me asking you to
install this utility is for editing code
of different sorts
whether you're adjusting yaml or python
documents for deployment manager
or even managing scripts
a code editor will give you the ease of
use when it comes to managing editing
and even syntactical highlighting of
code as shown here below
it will highlight the code to make it
easier to understand now if you have
your own editor that you would prefer to
use go ahead and use that but for those
that don't my recommendation will be to
use visual studio code so to install
visual studio code we're just going to
accept this license agreement
and then we're going to click on next
and we're just going to follow all the
defaults
to install it
it's going to take a minute or two
and for those running windows you want
to make sure that this box is checked
off so that you can launch it right away
let's hit finish
another recommendation would be to go
over here to the task bar so you can pin
it in place so that it's easier to find
and so now you have access to all the
resources that's needed for this course
but with that that's everything that i
wanted to cover for this lesson so you
can now mark this lesson as complete and
let's move on to the next one
[Music]
welcome back and in this lesson i wanted
to discuss the various certifications
available for google cloud as this
number keeps on growing and i am looking
to keep this lesson as up to date as
possible so with that being said let's
dive in
now google cloud has released a slew of
certifications in many different areas
of expertise as well as different
experience levels
now there are two levels of difficulty
when it comes to the google cloud
certifications starting off with the
associate level we see that there is
only the one certification which is the
cloud engineer the associate level
certification is focused on the
fundamental skills of deploying
monitoring and maintaining projects on
google cloud this is a great starting
point for those completely new to cloud
and google recommends the associate
cloud engineer as the starting point to
undergoing your certification journey
this was google cloud's very first
certification and to me was the entry
point of wanting to learn more as an
engineer in cloud in my personal opinion
no matter your role this certification
will cover the general knowledge that is
needed to know about starting on google
cloud and the services within it which
is why i labeled it here as the
foundational level course i also
consider this the stepping stone
into any other professional level
certifications which also happens to be
a recommended path by google with a
great course and some dedication i truly
believe that anyone with even a basic
skill level in it should be able to
achieve this associate level
certification now it is recommended from
google themselves that prior to taking
this exam that you should have over six
months experience building on google
cloud for those of you with more of an
advanced background in google cloud or
even other public clouds this
certification should be an easy pass as
it covers the basics that you should be
familiar with adding a google twist to
it at the time of this lesson this exam
is two hours long and the cost is 125 us
dollars the exam is a total of 50
questions which consists of both
multiple choice and multiple answer
questions each of the questions contain
three to four line questions with single
line answers that by the time you finish
this course you should have the
confidence to identify the incorrect
answers
and be able to select the right answers
without a hitch moving into the
professional level certifications there
are seven certifications that cover a
variety of areas of specialty depending
on your role you might want to take one
or maybe several of these certifications
to help you gain more knowledge in
google cloud or if you love educating
yourself and you're really loving your
journey in gcp you will probably want to
consider pursuing them all in my
personal opinion the best entry point
into the professional level would be the
cloud architect it is a natural step up
from the associate cloud engineer and it
builds on top of what is learned through
that certification with a more detailed
and more thorough understanding of cloud
architecture that is needed for any
other certification there is some
overlap from the cloud engineer which is
why in my opinion doing this
certification right after makes sense it
also brings with it the ability to
design develop and manage secure
scalable and highly available dynamic
solutions it is a much harder exam and
goes into great depth on services
available the professional cloud
architect is a great primer for any
other professional level certification
and can be really helpful to solidify
the learning that is needed in any other
technical role i find it the most common
path that many take who look to learn
google cloud which is why i personally
recommend it to them and at the time of
this lesson it also holds the highest
return on investment
due to the highest average wage over any
other current cloud certification in the
market google recommends over three
years of industry experience including
one year on google cloud before
attempting these exams with regards to
the exams in the professional tier they
are much harder than the associate level
and at the time of this course is two
hours long and the cost is 200 us
dollars these exams are a total of 50
questions which consists of both
multiple choice and multiple answer
questions it's the same amount of
questions with the same amount of time
but it does feel much harder each of the
questions contain four to five line
questions with one to three line answers
it's definitely not a walk in the park
and will take some good concentration
and detailed knowledge on google cloud
to solidify a pass after completing the
cloud architect certification depending
on your role my suggestion would be to
pursue the areas that interest you the
most to make your journey more enjoyable
for me at the time i took the security
engineer out as i am a big fan of
security and i knew that i would really
enjoy the learning and make it more fun
for me this is also a great
certification for those who are looking
to excel their cloud security knowledge
on top of any other security
certifications such as the security plus
or cissp
now others may be huge fans of
networking or hold other networking
certifications such as the ccna and so
obtaining the network engineer
certification might be more up your
alley and give you a better
understanding in cloud networking now if
you're in the data space you might want
to move into the data engineer exam as
well as taking on the machine learning
engineer exam to really get some deeper
knowledge in the areas of big data
machine learning and artificial
intelligence on google cloud now i know
that there are many that love devops me
being one of them and really want to dig
deeper and understand sre and so they
end up tackling the cloud developer and
cloud devops engineer certifications so
the bottom line is whatever brings you
joy in the area of your choosing start
with that and move on to do the rest all
the professional certifications are
valuable but do remember that they are
hard and need preparation for study last
but not least is the collaboration
engineer certification and this
certification focuses on google's core
cloud-based collaboration tools that are
available in g suite or what is now
known as google workspaces such as gmail
drive hangouts docs and sheets now the
professional level collaboration
engineers certification dives into more
advanced areas of g suite such as mail
routing identity management and
automation of it all using tools
scripting and apis
this certification is great for those
looking to build their skill set as an
administrator of these tools but gives
very little knowledge of google cloud
itself so before i move on there is one
more certification that i wanted to
cover that doesn't fall under the
associate or professional certification
levels and this is the google cloud
certified fellow program
now this is by far
one of the hardest certifications to
obtain as there are very few certified
fellows at the time of recording this
lesson it is even harder than the
professional level certifications and
this is due to the sheer level of
competency with hybrid multi-cloud
architectures using google cloud anthos
google's recommended experience
is over 10 years with a year of
designing enterprise solutions with
anthos then a four-step process begins
first step is to receive a certified
fellow invitation from google and once
you've received that invitation then you
need to submit an application with some
work samples that you've done
showing google your competency in hybrid
multi-cloud once that is done the third
step is a series of technical hands-on
labs that must be completed and is a
qualifying assessment that must be
passed in order to continue and after
all that the last step is a panel
interview done with google experts in
order to assess your competency of
designing hybrid and multi-cloud
solutions with anthos so as you can see
here this is a very difficult and highly
involved certification process
to achieve the title of certified fellow
this is definitely not for the faint of
heart but can distinguish yourself as a
technical leader in anthos and a hybrid
multi-cloud expert in your industry now
i get asked many times whether or not
certifications hold any value are they
easy to get are they worth more than the
paperwork that they're printed on and
does it show that people really know how
to use google cloud and my answer is
always yes as the certifications hold
benefits beyond just the certification
itself and here's why targeting yourself
for a certification gives you a
milestone for learning something new
with this new milestone it allows you to
put together a study plan in order to
achieve the necessary knowledge needed
to not only pass the exam but the skills
needed to progress in your everyday
technical role this new knowledge helps
keep your skills up to date therefore
making you current instead of becoming a
relic now having these up-to-date skills
will also help advance your career
throughout my career in cloud i have
always managed to get my foot in the
door with various interviews due to my
certifications it gave me the
opportunity to shine in front of the
interviewer while being able to
confidently display my skills in cloud
it also allowed me to land the jobs that
i sought after as well as carve out the
career path that i truly wanted on top
of landing the jobs that i wanted i was
able to achieve a higher salary due to
the certifications i had i have doubled
and tripled my salary since i first
started in cloud all due to my
certifications and i've known others
that have obtained up to five times
their salary because of their
certifications now this was not just
from achieving the certification to put
on my resume and up on social media but
from the knowledge gained through the
process and of course i personally feel
that having your skills constantly up to
date
advancing your career and getting the
salary that you want keeps you motivated
to not only get more certifications but
continue the learning process i am and
always have been a huge proponent of
lifelong learning and as i always say
when you continue learning you continue
to grow so in short google cloud
certifications are a great way to grow
and so that about covers everything that
i wanted to discuss in this lesson so
you can now mark this lesson as complete
and i'll see you in the next one
[Music]
welcome back
and in this lesson i'm going to be
talking about the fictitious
organization called bow tie inc that i
will be using throughout the course
now while going through the
architectures and demos in this course
together i wanted to tie them to a real
world situation
so that the theory and practical
examples are easy to understand
tying it to a scenario is an easy way to
do this as well it makes things a lot
more fun
so the scenario again
that i will be using is based on bow tie
ink
so before we get started with the course
i'd like to quickly run through the
scenario
and don't worry it's going to be very
high level and i will keep it brief
so bow tie ink is a bow tie
manufacturing company that designs and
manufactures bow ties within their own
factories
they also hold a few retail locations
where they sell their bow ties as well
as wholesale to other thai and men's
fashion boutiques and department stores
across the globe
being in the fashion business
they mainly deal with commerce security
and big data sets
bow tie inc is a global company and they
are headquartered in montreal canada
they employ about 300 people globally
with a hundred of them being in sales
alone to support both the brick and
mortar stores and wholesale branches
there are many different departments to
the company that make it work such as
in-store staff
i.t
marketing for both in-store and online
sales
manufacturing finance and more
the types of employees that work in bow
tie inc vary greatly due to the various
departments and consists of many people
such as sales for both in-store and
wholesale managers that run the stores
and sewers that work in the
manufacturing plant
and many more that work in these various
departments
the business has both offices
and brick and mortar stores
in montreal
london and los angeles
now due to the thrifty mindset of
management concentrating all their
efforts on commerce and almost none in
technical infrastructure has caused
years of technical debt
and is now a complete disaster
within the brick and mortar location
there contains two racks with a few
servers and some networking equipment
the global inventory of bow ties are
updated upon sales in both stores
and wholesale as well as new stock that
has been manufactured from the factory
there are point-of-sale systems in each
store or office location
these systems are all connected to each
other over a vpn connection in order to
keep updates of the inventory fresh
all office and store infrastructure are
connected to each other and the montreal
headquarters
and the point of sale systems and kiosk
systems are backed up to tape in the
montreal headquarters as well and like i
said before
management is extremely thrifty but they
have finally come to the realization
that they need to start spending money
on the technical infrastructure in order
to scale so diving into a quick overview
of exactly what the architecture looks
like the head office is located in
montreal canada
it has its main database for the crm and
point-of-sale systems
as well as holding the responsibility of
housing the equipment for the tape
backups the tapes are then taken off
site within montreal by a third-party
company for storage
the company has two major offices one in
london covering the eu
and the other in the west coast us
in los angeles these major offices
are also retail locations that consume
i.t services from the headquarters in
montreal again being in the fashion
business bowtie inc employs a large
amount of sales people and the managers
that support them
these employees operate the
point-of-sale systems so we're
constantly looking to have the website
sales and the inventory updated at all
times each salesperson has access to
email and files for updated forecasts on
various new bowtie designs
most sales people communicate over a
voice over ip phone and chat programs
through their mobile phone the managers
also manually look at inventory on
what's been sold
versus what's in stock
to predict the sales for stores in
upcoming weeks
this will give manufacturing a head
start to making more bow ties for future
sales
now whatever implementations that we
discuss throughout this course
we'll need to support the day-to-day
operations of the sales people and the
managers
and because of the different time zones
in play
the back-end infrastructure needs to be
available
24 hours a day seven days a week
any downtime will impact updated
inventory for both online sales as well
as store sales at any given time
now let's talk about the current
problems that the business is facing
most locations hold on premise hardware
that is out of date and also out of
warranty
the business looked at extending this
warranty but became very costly as well
management is on the fence about whether
to buy new on-premise hardware or just
move to the cloud they were told that
google cloud is the way to go when it
comes to the retail space and so are
open to suggestions
yet still very weary now when it comes
to performance there seems to be a major
lag from the vpn connecting from store
to store
as well as the head office that's
responsible for proper inventory
thus slowing down the point of sale
systems and to top it all off
backups taking an exorbitant amount of
time
is consuming a lot of bandwidth with the
current vpn connection now bowtie inc
has always struggled with the lack of
highly available systems and scalability
due to cost of new hardware this is
causing extreme stress for online
e-commerce whenever a new marketing
campaign is launched
as the systems are unable to keep up
with the demand
looking at the forecast for the next two
quarters the business is looking to open
up more stores in the eu
as well as in the us
and with the current database in place
providing very inefficient high
availability or scalability
there is a major threat of the main
database going down
now when it comes to assessing the
backups the tape backups have become
very slow especially backing up from
london and the off-site storage costs
continuously go up every year
the backups are consuming a lot of
bandwidth and are starting to become the
major pain point
for connection issues between locations
on top of all these issues the small it
staff that is employed have outdated i.t
skills and so there is a lot of manual
intervention that needs to be done
to top it all off all the running around
that is necessary to keep the outdated
infrastructure alive
management is also now pushing to open
new stores to supply bow ties globally
given the ever-growing demand
as well as being able to supply the
demand of bow ties online through their
e-commerce store
now these are some realistic yet common
scenarios that come up in reality for a
lot of businesses that are not using
cloud computing
and throughout the course we will dive
into how google cloud can help ease the
pain
of these current ongoing issues
now at a high level with what the
business wants to achieve and what the
favorable results are
they are all interrelated issues so
bowtie inc requires a reliable and
stable connection between all the
locations of the stores and offices
so that sales
inventory and point-of-sale systems are
quick and up-to-date at all times
this will also allow all staff in these
locations to work a lot more efficiently
with a stable and reliable connection in
place
backups should be able to run smoothly
and also eliminate the cost of off-site
backup
not to mention the manpower and
infrastructure involved to get the job
done
while scaling up offices and stores due
to increase in demand
the business should be able to deploy
stores in new regions using pay as you
go billing while also meeting the
requirements and regulations when it
comes to gpdr and pci
this would also give the business
flexibility of having a disaster
recovery strategy in place
in case there was a failure of the main
database in montreal now as mentioned
before the business is extremely thrifty
especially when it comes to spend on it
infrastructure
and so the goal is to have the costs as
low as possible yet having the
flexibility of scaling up when needed
especially when new marketing campaigns
are launched during high demand sales
periods
this would also give bowtie inc the
flexibility of analyzing sales ahead of
time
using real-time analytics and catering
to exactly what the customer is
demanding
thus making inventory a lot more
accurate and reducing costs in
manufacturing items that end up going on
sale and costing the company money in
the end
finally when it comes to people
supporting infrastructure automation is
key
removing manual steps and a lot of the
processes can reduce the amount of
manpower needed to keep the
infrastructure alive
and especially will reduce downtime when
disaster arises
putting automation in place will also
reduce the amount of tedious tasks that
all departments have on their plate
so that they can focus on more important
business needs
now that's the scenario at a high level
i wanted to really emphasize that this
is a typical type of scenario that you
will face as a cloud engineer and a
cloud architect
the key to this scenario is the fact
that there are areas that are lacking in
detail
and areas that are fully comprehensible
and this will trigger knowing when and
where to ask relevant questions
especially in your day-to-day role as an
engineer
it will allow you to fill the gaps so
that you're able to figure out what
services you will need and what type of
architecture to use
this is also extremely helpful when it
comes to the exam
as in the exam you will be faced with
questions that pertain to real life
scenarios that will test you in a
similar manner knowing what services and
architecture to use based on the
information given
will always give you the keys to the
door with the right answer and lastly
when it comes to the demos
this scenario used throughout the course
will help put things in perspective
as we will come to resolve a lot of
these common issues
real world scenarios can give you a
better perspective on learning as it is
tied to something that makes it easy to
comprehend
and again bow tie inc is the scenario
that i will be using throughout the
course to help you grasp these concepts
so that's all i have to cover this
scenario so you can now mark this lesson
as complete and let's move on to the
next one
[Music]
hey this is anthony cevallos and what i
wanted to show you here is where you can
access the practice exam on the exam pro
platform
so once you've signed up for your
account you can head on over to the
course
and you can scroll down to the bottom of
the curriculum list and you will see the
practice exams here at the bottom
now just as a quick note
you should generally not attempt the
practice exam unless you have completed
all the lecture content including the
follow alongs as once you start to see
those questions you will get an urge to
start remembering these questions
and so i always recommend to use the
practice exam as a serious attempt
and not just a way to get to the final
exam at a faster pace taking your time
with the course
will allow you to really prevail through
these practice exams and allow you for a
way better pass rate on the final exam
looking here we can see two practice
exams with 50 questions each and so i
wanted to take a moment here and dive
into the practice exam
and show you what some of these
questions will look like and so clicking
into one of these exams we can get right
into it and so as you can see i've
already started on practice exam one and
so i'm going to click into that right
now and as you can see the exam is
always timed and in this case will be
120 minutes for this specific exam there
are 50 questions for this practice exam
and you will see the breakdown in the
very beginning
of the types of questions you will be
asked now for the google cloud exams at
the associate level they are usually
structured in a common format
they generally start with one or two
lines of sentences which will typically
represent a scenario followed by the
question itself this question tends to
be brief and to the point immediately
following that you will be presented
with a number of answers
usually four or five in nature and can
sometimes be very very technical as they
are designed for engineers like asking
about which gcloud commands to use to
execute in a given scenario as well as
theoretical questions that can deal with
let's say best practices or questions
about the specific services themselves
now these answers will come in two
different styles either multi-choice or
multi-select the multi-choice is usually
about identifying the correct answer
from a group of incorrect or less
correct answers whereas the multi-select
will be about choosing multiple correct
solutions to identify the answer as well
for this associate exam the overall
structure is pretty simple in nature and
typically will be either right or wrong
now sometimes these questions can get
tricky where there are multiple possible
answers
and you will have to select the most
suitable ones
now although most of these types of
questions
usually show up in the professional exam
they can sometimes peek their heads into
the associate and so a great tactic that
i always like to use is to immediately
identify what matters in the question
itself
and then to start ruling out any of the
answers that are wrong and this will
allow you to answer the question a lot
more quickly and efficiently as it will
bring the more correct answer to the
surface as well as making the answer a
lot more obvious
and making the entire question less
complex so for instance with this
question here you are immediately asked
about google's recommended practices
when it comes to using cloud storage as
backup for disaster recovery and this
would be for a specific storage type and
so quickly looking at the answers you
can see that standard storage and near
line storage will not be part of the
answer and so that will leave cold line
storage or archive storage as the two
possible choices
for the answer of this question and so
these are the typical techniques that i
always like to use
for these exams and so provided that
you've gone through all the course
content you will be able to answer these
technical questions with ease and
following the techniques i've just given
and applying them to each question
can really help you in not only this
practice exam but for the final exam
landing you a passing grade getting you
certified
[Music]
welcome back and in this section i
wanted to really hone in on the basics
of cloud computing the characteristics
that make it what it is
the different types of computing
and how they differ from each other as
well as the types of service models now
in this lesson i wanted to dive into the
definition of cloud computing and the
essential characteristics that define it
now for some advanced folk watching this
this may be a review
and for others
this may fulfill a better understanding
on what is cloud now cloud is a term
that is thrown around a lot these days
yet holds a different definition or
understanding to each and every
individual
you could probably ask 10 people on
their definition of cloud and chances
are
everyone would have their own take on it
many see cloud as this abstract thing in
the sky
where files and emails are stored but
it's so much more than that
now the true definition of it can be put
in very simple terms
and can be applied to any public cloud
being google cloud
aws
and azure
moving on to the definition
cloud computing is the delivery of a
shared pool of on-demand computing
services over the public internet
that can be rapidly provisioned
and released
with minimal management effort or
service provider interaction
these computing services
consist of things like servers
storage
networking and databases they can be
quickly provisioned and accessed from
your local computer
over an internet connection now coupled
with this definition are five essential
characteristics that define the cloud
model that i would like to go over with
you and i believe that it would hold
massive benefits to understanding when
speaking to cloud this information can
be found in the white paper published by
the national institute of standards and
technology i will include a link to this
publication in the lesson notes for your
review now these essential
characteristics are as follows the first
one
is on-demand self-service
and this can be defined as being able to
provision resources automatically
without requiring human interaction on
the provider's end
so in the end you will never need to
call up or interact with the service
provider in order to get resources
provisioned for you
as well you have the flexibility of
being able to provision and de-provision
these resources
whenever you need them and at any given
time of the day
the second characteristic is broad
network access
now this simply means that cloud
computing resources are available over
the network and can be accessed by many
different customer platforms such as
mobile phones
tablets or computers
in other words
cloud services are available over a
network moving into the third
is resource pooling
so the provider's computing resources
are pooled together to support a
multi-tenant model that allows multiple
customers to share the same applications
or the same physical infrastructure
while retaining privacy and security
over their information
this includes things like processing
power
memory storage and networking
it's similar to people living in an
apartment building sharing the same
building infrastructure like power and
water yet they still have their own
apartments and privacy within that
infrastructure
this also creates a sense of location
independence in that the customer
generally has no control or knowledge
over the exact location of the provided
resources
but they may be able to specify location
at a higher level of abstraction so in
the end the customer does not really
have the option of choosing exactly
which server server rack or data center
for that matter
of where the provided resources are
coming from
they will only be able to have the
option to choose things like regions or
sections within that region
the fourth essential characteristic is
rapid elasticity
this to me
is the key factor of what makes cloud
computing so great and so agile
capabilities can be elastically
provisioned and released
in some cases automatically to scale
rapidly outwards and inwards in response
with demand
to the consumer the capabilities
available for provisioning often appear
to be unlimited
and can be provisioned in any quantity
at any time and touching on the fifth
and last characteristic cloud systems
automatically control and optimize
resource usage by leveraging a metering
capability
resource usage can be monitored
controlled and reported providing
transparency for both the provider and
consumer of the service
now what this means is that cloud
computing resource usage is metered and
you can pay accordingly for what you've
used
resource utilization
can be optimized by leveraging
pay-per-use capabilities
and this means that cloud resource usage
whether they are instances that are
running
cloud storage or bandwidth it all gets
monitored measured and reported by the
cloud service provider the cost model is
based on
pay for what you use and so the payment
is based on the actual consumption
by the customer
so knowing these key characteristics of
cloud computing along with their
benefits
i personally find can really give you a
leg up on the exam
as well as speaking to others in your
day-to-day role
as more and more companies start moving
to cloud i hope this lesson has
explained to you on what is cloud
computing and the benefits it provides
so that's all i have for this lesson
so you can now mark this lesson as
complete and let's move on to the next
one
welcome back
in this lesson i wanted to go over the
four common cloud deployment models and
distinguish the differences between
public cloud
multi-cloud
private cloud and hybrid cloud
deployment models
this is a common subject that comes up a
fair amount in the exam
as well as a common theme in any
organization moving to cloud knowing the
distinctions between them can be
critical to the types of architecture
and services that you would use for the
specific scenario you are given
as well as being able to speak to the
different types of deployment models as
an engineer in the field getting back to
the deployment models let's start with
the public cloud model which we touched
on a bit in our last lesson
now the public cloud is defined as
computing services offered by
third-party providers
over the public internet
making them available to anyone who
wants to use or purchase them so this
means that google cloud will fall under
this category as a public cloud
there are also other vendors that fall
under this category such as aws and
azure
so again public cloud is a cloud that is
offered over the public internet
now public clouds can also be connected
and used together within a single
environment for various use cases
this cloud deployment model is called
multi-cloud
now a multi-cloud implementation can be
extremely effective if architected in
the right way
one implementation that is an effective
use of multi-cloud is when it is used
for disaster recovery this is where your
architecture would be replicated across
the different public clouds in case one
were to go down
another could pick up the slack what
drives many cases of a multi-cloud
deployment
is to prevent vendor lock-in where you
are locked into a particular cloud
provider's infrastructure and unable to
move due to the vendor-specific feature
set the main downfall to this type of
architecture is that the infrastructure
of the public cloud that you're using
cannot be fully utilized
as each cloud vendor has their own
proprietary resources that will only
work in their specific infrastructure in
other words
in order to replicate the environment it
needs to be the same within each cloud
this removes each cloud's unique
features which is what makes them so
special and the resources so compelling
so sometimes finding the right strategy
can be tricky depending on the scenario
now the next deployment model i wanted
to touch on is private cloud private
cloud refers to your architecture that
exists on premise
and restricted to the business itself
with no public access
yet it still carries the same five
characteristics that we discussed with
regards to what defines cloud each of
the major cloud providers shown here
all have their own flavor of private
cloud that can be implemented on site
google cloud has anthos
aws
has aws outposts
and azures is azure stack
they show the same characteristic
and leverage similar technologies that
can be found in the vendor's public
cloud yet can be installed on your own
on-premise infrastructure please be
aware
any organizations may have a vmware
implementation which holds cloud-like
features yet this is not considered a
private cloud
true private cloud will always meet the
characteristics that make up cloud now
it is possible to use private cloud with
public cloud
and this implementation is called hybrid
cloud
so hybrid cloud is when you are using
public cloud in conjunction with private
cloud as a single system a common
architecture used is due to compliance
where one cloud could help organizations
achieve specific governance
risk management and compliance
regulations while the other cloud could
take over the rest
now i'd really like to make an important
distinction here
if your on-premise infrastructure is
connected to public cloud this is not
considered hybrid cloud this is what's
known as hybrid environment or a hybrid
network as the on-premises
infrastructure holds no private cloud
characteristics true hybrid cloud allows
you to use the exact same interface and
tooling as what's available in the
public cloud so being aware of this can
avoid a lot of confusion down the road
so to sum up everything that we
discussed when it comes to public cloud
this is when one cloud provided by one
vendor that is available over the public
internet
multi-cloud is two or more public clouds
that are connected together to be used
as a single system a private cloud
is considered an on-premises cloud that
follows the five characteristics of
cloud
and is restricted to the one
organization with no accessibility to
the public and finally hybrid cloud
is private cloud connected to a public
cloud
and being used as a single environment
again as a note
on-premises architecture connected to
public cloud is considered a hybrid
environment and not hybrid cloud
the distinction between the two
are very different and should be
observed carefully as gotchas may come
up in both the exam
and in your role as an engineer so these
are all the different cloud deployment
models which will help you distinguish
on what type of architecture you will be
using in any scenario that you are given
and so this is all i wanted to cover
when it comes to cloud deployment models
so you can now mark this lesson as
complete
and let's move on to the next one
welcome back
so to finish up the nist definition of
cloud computing i wanted to touch on
cloud service models which is commonly
referred to as zas
now this model is usually called zas or
xaas
standing for anything as a service it
includes all the services in a cloud
that customers can consume and x can be
changed to associate with the specific
service
so in order to describe the cloud
service models i needed to touch on some
concepts that you may or may not be
familiar with this will make
understanding the service models a
little bit easier as i go through the
course and describe the services
available and how they relate to the
model this lesson will make so much
sense by the end
it'll make the services in cloud easier
to both describe and define
now when it comes to deploying an
application they are deployed in an
infrastructure stack
like the one you see here
now a stack is a collection of needed
infrastructure that the application
needs to run on it is layered and each
layer builds on top of the one previous
to it to create what it is that you see
here now as you can see at the top this
is a traditional on-premises
infrastructure stack that was typically
used pre-cloud now in this traditional
model
all the components are managed by the
customer the purchasing of the data
center and all the network and storage
involved the physical servers the
virtualization the licensing for the
operating systems the staff that's
needed to put it all together
including racking stacking cabling
physical security was also something
that needed to be taken into
consideration in other words for the
organization to put this together by
themselves they were looking at huge
costs
now the advantages to this is that it
allowed for major flexibility as the
organization is able to tune this any
way they want to satisfy the application
compliance standards
basically anything that they wanted now
when talking about the cloud service
model concepts
parts are always managed by you and
parts are managed by the vendor now
another concept i wanted to touch on is
that unit of consumption is how the
vendor prices what they are serving to
their customer now just before cloud
became big in the market there was a
model where the data center was hosted
for you so a vendor would come along and
they would take care of everything with
regards to the data center
the racks
the power to the racks the air
conditioning
the networking cables out of the
building and even the physical security
and so the unit of consumption here was
the rack space within the data center so
the vendor would charge you for the rack
space and in turn they would take care
of all the necessities within the data
center now this is less flexible than
the traditional on-premises model but
the data center is abstracted for you so
throughout this lesson i wanted to
introduce a concept that might make
things easier to grasp which is the
pizza as a service so now the
traditional on-premises model
is where you would buy everything and
make the pizza at home
now as we go on in the lesson
less flexibility will be available
because more layers will be abstracted
so the next service model that i wanted
to introduce is infrastructure as a
service
or i as for short this is where all the
layers from the data center up to
virtualization is taken care of by the
vendor this is the most basic model
which is essentially your virtual
machines in a cloud data center
you set up configure
and manage instances that run in the
data center infrastructure and you put
whatever you want on them on google
cloud google compute engine would
satisfy this model and so the unit of
consumption here would be the operating
system as you would manage all the
operating system updates and everything
that you decide to put on that instance
but as you can see here you are still
responsible for the container the run
time the data and the application layers
now bringing up the pizza as a service
model is would be you picking up the
pizza and you cooking it at home moving
on to platform as a service or paz for
short this is a model that is geared
more towards developers and with pass
the cloud provider provides a computing
platform typically
including the operating system the
programming language execution
environment the database and the web
server now typically with pass you never
have to worry about the operating system
updates or managing the runtime and
middleware and so the unit of
consumption here would be the runtime
now the runtime layer would be the layer
you would consume as you would be
running your code in the supplied
runtime environment that the cloud
vendor provides for you the provider
manages the hardware and software
infrastructure and you just use the
service this is usually the layer on top
of is and so all the layers between the
data center and runtime is taken care of
by the vendor a great example of this
for google cloud is google app engine
which we will be diving into a little
bit later getting back to the pizza as a
service model
pass would fall under the pizza being
delivered right to your door
now with the past model explained i want
to move into the last model which is sas
which stands for software as a service
now with sas all the layers are taken
care of by the vendor so users are
provided access to application software
and cloud providers manage the
infrastructure and platforms that run
the applications g suite and microsoft's
office 365 are great examples of this
model now sas doesn't offer much
flexibility but the trade-off is that
the vendor actually takes care of all
these layers so again the unit of
consumption here is the application
itself and of course getting to the
pizza as a service model sas
is pretty much dining in the restaurant
enjoying your pizza now to summarize
when you have a data center on site you
manage everything
when it's infrastructure as a service
part of that stack is abstracted by the
cloud vendor with platform as a service
you're responsible for the application
and data
everything else is abstracted by the
vendor with software as a service again
using the pizza as a service analogy on
premise you buy everything and you make
the pizza at home infrastructure as a
service
you pick up the pizza and you cook it at
home when it comes to platform as a
service the pizza is delivered
and of course software as a service is
dining in the restaurant now there will
be some other service models coming up
in this course such as function as a
service and containers as a service and
don't worry i'll be getting into those
later but i just wanted to give you a
heads up so now for some of you this may
have been a lot of information to take
in but trust me
knowing these models will give you a
better understanding of the services
provided in google cloud as well as any
other cloud vendor so that's all i
wanted to cover in this lesson so you
can now mark this lesson as complete and
let's move on to the next one
welcome back in this lesson i wanted to
discuss google cloud global
infrastructure how data centers are
connected how traffic flows when a
request is done
along with the overall structure of how
google cloud geographic locations are
divided for better availability
durability and latency
now google holds a highly provisioned
low latency network where your traffic
stays on google's private backbone for
most of its journey ensuring high
performance and a user experience that
is always above the norm google cloud
has been designed to serve users all
around the world by designing their
infrastructure with redundant cloud
regions connected with high bandwidth
fiber cables as well as subsea cables
connecting different continents
currently google has invested in 13
subsea cables connecting these
continents at points of presence as you
see here in this diagram hundreds of
thousands of miles of fiber cables have
also been laid to connect points of
presence for direct connectivity
privacy and reduced latency
just to give you an idea of what a
subsea cable run might look like i have
included a diagram of how dedicated
google is to their customers as there is
so much that goes into running these
cables that connect continents as you
can see here this is the north virginia
region being connected to the belgium
region from the u.s over to europe a
cable is run from the north virginia
data center as well as having a point of
presence in place
going through a landing station before
going deep into the sea on the other
side the landing station on the french
west coast
picks up the other side of the cable and
brings it over to the data center in the
belgium region and this is a typical
subsea cable run for google so
continents are connected for maximum
global connectivity
now at the time of recording this video
google cloud footprint spans 24 regions
73 zones and over
144 points of presence across more than
200 countries and territories worldwide
and as you can see here the white dots
on the map are regions that are
currently being built to expand their
network for wider connectivity now to
show you how a request is routed through
google's network i thought i would
demonstrate this by using tony bowtie
now tony makes a request to his database
in google cloud and google responds to
tony's request
from a pop or edge network location that
will provide the lowest latency this
point of presence is where isps can
connect to google's network google's
edge network receives tony's request and
passes it to the nearest google data
center over its private fiber network
the data center generates a response
that's optimized to provide the best
experience for tony at that given moment
in time the app or browser that tony is
using retrieves the requested content
with a response back from various google
locations including the google data
centers edge pops and edge nodes
whichever is providing the lowest
latency this data path happens in a
matter of seconds and due to google's
global infrastructure it travels
securely and with the least amount of
latency possible
no matter the geographic location that
the request is coming from
now i wanted to take a moment to break
down how the geographic areas are broken
out and organized in google cloud
we start off with the geographic
location such as the united states of
america and it's broken down into
multi-region into regions and finally
zones and so to start off with i wanted
to talk about zones now a zone is a
deployment area for google cloud
resources within a region a zone is the
smallest entity in google's global
network you can think of it as a single
failure domain within a region now as a
best practice resources should always be
deployed
in zones that are closest to your users
for optimal latency
now next up we have a region
and regions are independent geographic
areas that are subdivided into zones so
you can think of a region as a
collection of zones and having a region
with multiple zones is designed for
fault tolerance and high availability
the intercommunication between zones
within a region is under five
milliseconds so rest assured that your
data is always traveling at optimal
speeds
now moving on into a multi-region
now multi-regions are large geographic
areas that contain two or more regions
and this allows google services to
maximize redundancy and distribution
within and across regions
and this is for google redundancy or
high availability having your data
spread across multiple regions
always reassures that your data is
constantly available
and so that covers all the concepts that
i wanted to go over when it comes to
geography and regions within google
cloud
note that the geography and regions
concepts are fundamental not only for
the exam but for your day-to-day role in
google cloud
so just as a recap a zone is a
deployment area for google cloud
resources within a region a zone is the
smallest entity of google's global
infrastructure now a region is an
independent geographic area that are
subdivided into zones and finally when
it comes to multi-region
multi-regions are large geographic areas
that contains two or more regions
again
these are all fundamental concepts that
you should know for the exam and for
your day-to-day role in google cloud and
so that's all i had for this lesson so
you can now mark this lesson as complete
and let's move on to the next one
[Music]
welcome back
this lesson is going to be an overview
of all the compute service options that
are available in google cloud
how they differ from each other
and where they fall under the cloud
service model again this lesson is just
an overview of the compute options as we
will be diving deeper into each compute
option
later on in this course so google cloud
gives you so many options when it comes
to compute services ones that offer
complete control and flexibility others
that offer flexible container technology
managed application platform and
serverless environments and so when we
take all of these compute options and we
look at it from a service model
perspective you can see that there's so
much flexibility starting here on the
left with infrastructure as a service
giving you the most optimal flexibility
moving all the way over to the right
where we have function as a service
offering less flexibility but the upside
being less that you have to manage and
we'll be going through these compute
options starting on the left here with
infrastructure as a service we have
compute engine now compute engine is
google's staple infrastructure the
service product that offers virtual
machines or vms called instances these
instances can be deployed in any region
or zone that you choose you also have
the option of deciding what operating
system you want on it as well as the
software so you have the option of
installing different types of flavors of
linux or windows and the software to go
with it google also gives you the
options of creating these instances
using public or private images
so if you or your company have a private
image that you'd like to use you can use
this to create your instances google
also gives you the option to use public
images to create instances and are
available when you launch compute engine
as well there are also pre-configured
images and software packages available
in the google cloud marketplace and we
will be diving a little bit deeper into
the google cloud marketplace in another
lesson just know that there are slew of
images out there that's available to
create instances giving you the ease to
deploy now when it comes to compute
engine and you're managing multiple
instances these are done using instance
groups
and when you're looking at adding or
removing capacity for those compute
engine instances automatically you would
use auto scaling in conjunction with
those instance groups compute engine
also gives you the option of attaching
and detaching disks as you need them as
well google cloud storage can be used in
conjunction with compute engine as
another storage option and when
connecting directly to compute engine
google gives you the option of using ssh
to securely connect to it so moving on
to the next compute service option
we have google kubernetes engine also
known as gke
now gke
is google's flagship container
orchestration system
for automating
deploying
scaling and managing containers
gke is also built on the same open
source kubernetes project that was
introduced by google to the public back
in 2014
now before google made kubernetes a
managed service there was many that
decided to build kubernetes on premise
in their data centers and because it is
built on the same platform
gke
offers the flexibility of integrating
with these on-premise kubernetes
deployments now under the hood gke uses
compute engine instances as nodes in a
cluster and as a quick note a cluster is
a group of nodes or compute engine
instances and again we'll be going over
all this in much greater detail in a
different lesson so if you haven't
already figured it out google kubernetes
engine is considered container as a
service now the next compute service
option that i wanted to go over
that falls under platform as a service
is app engine
now app engine is a fully managed
serverless platform for developing and
hosting web applications at scale now
with app engine google handles most of
the management of the resources for you
for example if your application requires
more computing resources because traffic
to your website increases google
automatically scales the system to
provide these resources if the system
software needs a security update as well
that's handled for you too and so all
you need to really take care of is your
application
and you can build your application in
your favorite language go java.net and
many others
and you can use both pre-configured
runtimes or use custom runtimes to allow
you to write the code in any language
app engine also allows you to connect
with google cloud storage products and
databases seamlessly app engine also
offers the flexibility of connecting
with third-party databases as well as
other cloud providers and third-party
vendors app engine also integrates with
a well-known security product in google
cloud called web security scanner as to
identify security vulnerabilities and so
that covers app engine in a nutshell
moving on to the next compute service
option
we have cloud functions and cloud
functions fall under function as a
service this is a serverless execution
environment
for building and connecting cloud
services with cloud functions you write
simple single purpose functions that are
attached to events
that are produced from your
infrastructure and services in google
cloud your function is triggered when an
event being watched is fired your code
then executes in a fully managed
environment there is no need to
provision any infrastructure or worry
about managing any servers and cloud
functions can be written using
javascript python 3
go or java runtimes so you can take your
function and run it in any of these
standard environments which makes it
extremely portable now cloud functions
are a good choice for use cases that
include the following
data processing or etl operations such
as video transcoding and iot streaming
data web hooks that respond to http
triggers
lightweight apis that compose loosely
coupled logic into applications as well
as mobile back-end functions
again cloud functions are considered
function as a service and so that covers
cloud functions
now moving to the far right of the
screen on the other side of the arrow we
have our last compute service option
which is cloud run now cloud run is a
fully managed compute platform for
deploying and scaling containerized
applications quickly and securely
cloudrun was built on an open standard
called k native and this enabled the
portability of any applications that
were built on it cloudrun also abstracts
away all the infrastructure management
by automatically scaling up and down
almost instantaneously depending on the
traffic now cloud run was google's
response to abstracting all the
infrastructure that was designed to run
containers and so this is known as
serverless for containers cloudrun has
massive flexibility as you can write it
in any language
any library using any binary this
compute service is considered a function
as a service now at the time of
recording this video i have not heard of
cloud cloudrun being in the exam but
since it is a compute service option i
felt the need for cloudrun to have an
honorable mention and so these are all
the compute service options that are
available on google cloud and we will be
diving deeper into each one of these
later on in this course
again this is just an overview of all
the compute service options that are
available on the google cloud platform
and so that's all i wanted to cover for
this lesson
so you can now mark this lesson as
complete and let's move on to the next
one
[Music]
welcome back
now in the last lesson i covered all the
different options for compute services
in this lesson we're going to cover the
options that are available that couple
well with these compute services by
diving deeper into the different storage
types and the different databases
available on google cloud again this is
strictly an overview as i will be diving
deeper into these services later on in
the course
now when it comes to storage options
there are three services that are
readily available to you in google cloud
each of them have their own specific use
case that i will be diving into in just
a second
the first one i wanted to go over is
cloud storage
now with cloud storage this is google's
consistent scalable
large capacity and highly durable object
storage
so when i refer to object storage this
is not the type of storage that you
would attach to your instance and store
your operating system on i'm talking
about managing data as objects such as
documents or pictures and shouldn't be
confused with block storage which
manages data at a more granular level
such as an operating system not to worry
if you fully don't grasp the concept of
object storage i will be going into
further detail with that
later on in the cloud storage lesson
cloud storage has 11 9's durability and
what i mean by durability is basically
loss of files so just to give you a
better picture on cloud storage
durability if you store 1 million files
statistically google would lose one file
every 659
000 years and you are about over 400
times more likely to get hit by a meteor
than to actually lose a file so as you
can see cloud storage is a very good
place to be storing your files another
great feature on cloud storage is the
unlimited storage that it has with no
minimum object size so feel free to
continuously put files in cloud storage
now when it comes to use cases cloud
storage is fantastic for content
delivery data lakes and backups and to
make cloud storage even more flexible it
is available in different storage
classes and availability which i will be
going over in just a second now when it
comes to these different storage classes
there are four different classes that
you can choose from the first one is the
standard storage class and this storage
class offers the maximum availability
with your data with absolutely no
limitations this is great for storage
that you access all the time the next
storage class is near line and this is
low-cost archival storage so this
storage class is cheaper than standard
and is designed for storage that only
needs to be accessed less than once a
month and if you're looking for an even
more cost effective solution cloud
storage has cold line storage class
which is an even lower cost archival
storage solution this storage class is
designed for storage that only needs to
be accessed less than once every quarter
and just when you thought that the
prices couldn't get lower than cold line
cloud storage has offered another
storage class called archive and this is
the lowest cost archival storage which
offers storage at a fraction of a penny
per gigabyte but is designed for
archival or backup use that is accessed
less than once a year now when it comes
to cloud storage availability there are
three options that are available
there is region dual region and
multi-region region is designed to store
your data in one single region dual
region is exactly how it sounds which is
a pair of regions now in multiregion
cloud storage stores your data over a
large geographic area consisting of many
different regions across that same
selected geographic area and so that
about covers cloud storage as a storage
option the next storage option that i
wanted to talk about is file store
now file store is a fully managed nfs
file server from google cloud that is
nfs version 3 compliant you can store
data from running applications from
multiple vm instances and kubernetes
clusters
accessing the data at the same time file
store is a great option for when you're
thinking about accessing data from let's
say an instance group and you need
multiple instances to access the same
data and moving on to the last storage
option we have persistent disks
now with persistent disks this is
durable block storage for instances now
as i explained before block storage is
different than object storage
if you remember previously i explained
that object storage is designed to store
objects such as data or photos or videos
whereas block storage is raw storage
capacity that is used in drives that are
connected to an operating system in this
case persistent disks are doing just
that persistent disks come in two
options
the first one is the standard option
which gives you regular standard storage
at a reasonable price and the other
option is solid state or ssd
which gives you lower latency
higher iops and is just all around
faster than your standard persistent
disk both of these options are available
in zonal and regional options depending
on what you need for your specific
workload so now that i've covered all
three storage options i wanted to touch
into the database options that are
available on google cloud these database
options come in both the sql and nosql
flavors depending on your use case now
getting into the options themselves i
wanted to start off going into a little
bit of detail with the sql relational
options so the first option is cloud sql
and cloud sql is a fully managed
database service that is offered in
postgres mysql and sql server flavors
cloud sql also has the option of being
highly available across zones now moving
into cloud spanner this is a scalable
relational database service that's
highly available not only across zones
but across regions and if need be
available globally cloud spanner is
designed to support transactions strong
consistency and synchronous replication
moving into the nosql options there are
four available services that google
cloud offers moving into the first one
is bigtable
and bigtable is a fully managed scalable
nosql database that has high throughput
and low latency bigtable also comes with
the flexibility of doing cluster
resizing without any downtime the next
nosql option available is datastore and
this is google cloud's fast fully
managed
serverless
nosql document database datastore is
designed for mobile web
and internet of things applications
datastore has the capabilities of doing
multi-region replication
as well as acid transactions for those
of you who don't know i will be covering
acid transactions in a later lesson next
up for nosql options is firestore and
this is a nosql real-time database
and is optimized for offline use if
you're looking to store data in a
database in real time firestore is your
option and like bigtable you can resize
the cluster in firestore without any
downtime and the last nosql option is
memorystore and this is google cloud's
highly available
in memory service for redis and
memcached this is a fully managed
service and so google cloud takes care
of everything for you now i know this
has been a short lesson on storage and
database options but a necessary
overview nonetheless of what's to come
and so that's about all i wanted to
cover in this lesson so you can now mark
this lesson as complete and let's move
on to the next one
[Music]
welcome back now while there are some
services in gcp that take care of
networking for you
there are still others like compute
engine that give you a bit more
flexibility in the type of networking
you'd like to establish
this lesson will go over these
networking services at a high level and
provide you with strictly an overview to
give you an idea on what's available for
any particular type of scenario when it
comes to connecting and scaling your
network traffic i will be going into
further details
on these networking services in later
lessons now i wanted to start off with
some core networking features for your
resources and how to govern specific
traffic
traveling to and from your network this
is where networks firewalls and routes
come into play so first i wanted to
start off with virtual private cloud
also known as vpc now vpc
manages networking functionality for
your google cloud resources
this is a virtualized network within
google cloud so you can picture it as
your virtualized data center vpc is a
core networking service
and is also a global resource that spans
throughout all the different regions
available in google cloud each vpc
contains a default network as well
additional networks can be created in
your project but networks cannot be
shared between projects
and i'll be going into further depth on
vpc in a later lesson so now that we've
covered vpc i wanted to get into
firewall rules and routes now firewall
rules segment your networks with a
global distributive firewall to restrict
access to resources so this governs
traffic coming into instances on a
network each default network has a
default set of firewall rules that have
already been established but don't fret
you can create your own rules and set
them accordingly depending on your
workload now when it comes to routes
this specifies how traffic should be
routed within your vpc to get a little
bit more granular routes specify how
packets leaving an instance should be
directed so it's a basic way of defining
which way your traffic is going to
travel moving on to the next concept i
wanted to cover a little bit about low
balancing and how it distributes
workloads across multiple instances
now we have two different types of load
balancing and both these types of load
balancing can be broken down to even a
more granular level now when it comes to
http or https low balancing this is the
type of load balancing that covers
worldwide auto scaling and load
balancing over multiple regions or even
a single region on a single global ip
https load balancing distributes traffic
across various regions and make sure
that the traffic is routed to the
closest region or in case there's
failures amongst instances or in
instances being bombarded with traffic
http and https load balancing can route
the traffic to a healthy instance in the
next closest region another great
feature of this load balancing is that
it can distribute traffic based on
content type now when it comes to
network load balancing this is a
regional load balancer and supports any
and all ports
it distributes traffic among server
instances in the same region
based on incoming ip protocol data such
as address port and protocol now when it
comes to networking
dns plays a big part and because dns
plays a big part in networking google
has made this service 100 available
on top of giving any dns queries the
absolute lowest latency with google
cloud dns you can publish and maintain
dns records by using the same
infrastructure that google uses and you
can work with your managed zones and dns
records such as mx records tax records
cname records and a records and you can
do this all through the cli
the api
or the sdk now some of the advanced
connectivity options that are available
in google cloud are cloudvpn and direct
interconnect now cloudvpn connects your
existing network whether it be
on-premise or in another location
to your vbc network through an ipsec
connection
the traffic is encrypted and travels
between the two networks over the public
internet now when it comes to direct
interconnect this connectivity option
allows you to connect your existing
network to your vpc network using a
highly available
low latency connection this connectivity
option does not traverse the public
internet and merely connects to google's
backbone and this is what gives it the
highly available low latency connection
a couple of other advanced connectivity
options is direct and carrier peering
these connections allow your traffic to
flow through google's edge network
locations and pairing can be done
directly or it can be done through a
third-party carrier and so although this
is a very short lesson i will be going
into greater depth on all these concepts
in later lessons in the course so that's
all i had to cover for this lesson so
you can now mark this lesson as complete
and let's move on to the next one
welcome back in this lesson we're going
to learn about how resources and
entities
are organized within google cloud and
how permissions are inherited through
this approach knowing this structure
is a fundamental concept that you should
know while working in gcp at any
capacity so before defining what the
resource hierarchy is i'd like to take a
little bit of time to define what is a
resource now in the context of google
cloud a resource can refer to the
service level resources that are used to
process your workloads such as compute
instance vms
cloud storage buckets
and even cloud sql databases as well as
the account level resources that sit
above the services
such as the organization itself
the folders
and the projects of course which we will
be getting into a little bit deeper in
just a minute
the resource hierarchy is google's way
to configure and grant access
to the various cloud resources for your
company within google cloud both at the
service level
and at the account level
the resource hierarchy in google cloud
can truly define the granular
permissions needed for when you need to
configure permissions to everyone in the
organization that actually makes sense
so now that we covered what is a
resource i wanted to start digging into
the resource hierarchy and the structure
itself now google cloud resources are
organized hierarchically using a
parent-child relationship this hierarchy
is designed to map an organization's
operational structure to google cloud
and to manage access control and
permissions for groups of related
resources
so overall
resource hierarchy will give
organizations better management of
permissions and access control
the accessibility of these resources or
policies are controlled by identity and
access management also known as iam a
big component of gcp which we will be
digging into a little bit later on in
this course and so when an iam policy is
set on a parent the child will inherit
this policy respectively access control
policies and configuration settings on a
parent resource
are always inherited by the child also
please note that each child object can
only have exactly one parent
and that these policies are again
controlled by iam so now to understand a
little bit more about how the gcp
resource hierarchy works
i wanted to dig into the layers that
support this hierarchy
so this is a diagram of exactly what the
resource hierarchy looks like in all of
its awesomeness
including the billing account along with
the payments profile but we're not going
to get into that right now i'll actually
be covering that in a later lesson so
more on that later
so building the structure from the top
down we start off with the domain or
cloud level and as you can see here the
domain of bowtieinc.co
is at the top
this is the primary identity of your
organization at the domain level this is
where you manage your users in your
organizations
so users policies and these are linked
to g suite or cloud identity accounts
now underneath the domain level we have
the organization level and this is
integrated very closely with the domain
so with the organization level this
represents an organization and is the
root node of the gcp resource hierarchy
it is associated with exactly one domain
here we have the domain set as bowtie
inc
all entities or resources
belong to and are grouped under the
organization
all controlled policies applied to the
are inherited by all other entities and
resources underneath it so any folders
projects or resources will get those
policies that are applied from the
organization layer now i know that we
haven't dug into roles as of yet
but the one thing that i did want to
point out is that when an organization
is created
an organization admin role is created
and this is to allow full access to edit
any or all resources
now moving on to the folders layer this
is an additional grouping mechanism and
isolation boundary between each project
in essence
it's a grouping of other folders
projects and resources so if you have
different departments and teams within a
company
this is a great way to organize it now a
couple of caveats when it comes to
folders
the first one is you must have an
organization node and the second one is
while a folder can contain multiple
folders or resources
a folder or resource can have exactly
one parent
now moving into the projects layer this
is a core organizational component of
google cloud as projects are required to
use service level resources
these projects are the base level
organizing entity in gcp
and parent all service level resources
just as a note
any given resource can only exist in one
project and not multiple projects at the
same time and moving on to the last
layer we have the resources layer and
this is any service level resource
created in google cloud
everything from compute engine instances
to cloud storage buckets to cloud sql
databases apis users
all these service level resources that
we create in google cloud fall under
this layer now giving the hierarchy a
little bit more context i want to touch
on labels for just a second
labels help categorize resources by
using a key value pair and you can
attach them to any resource
and so what labels help you do is to
break down and organize costs when it
comes to billing now to give you some
more structure with regards to the
hierarchy
under the domain level
everything underneath this is considered
a resource
and to break it down even further
everything you see from the organization
layer to the projects layer is
considered an account level resource
everything in the resource layer is
considered a service level resource and
so this is how the google cloud resource
hierarchy is split up and organized and
so before i finish off this lesson i
wanted to give you a quick run-through
on how policies can be applied at a
hierarchical level
so i thought i'd bring in tony bowtie
for a quick demo
so just to give you an example
tony bowtie is part of department b and
tony's manager lark
decides to set a policy on department
b's folder and this policy grants
project owner role to tony at
bowtieinc.co so tony will have the
project owner role for project x and for
project y at the same time
lark assigns laura at bowtieinc.co
cloud storage admin role on project x
and thus she will only be able to manage
cloud storage buckets in that project
this hierarchy and permission
inheritance comes up quite a bit not
only in the exam but is something that
should be carefully examined when
applying permissions
anywhere within the hierarchy in your
day-to-day role as an engineer
applying permissions or policies to
resources
with existing policies
may not end up getting you the desired
results you're looking for and may have
a chance to be overlooked now i hope
these diagrams have given you some good
contacts with regards to resource
hierarchy its structure and the
permissions applied down the chain now
that's all i have for this lesson on
resource hierarchy so you can now mark
this lesson as complete and let's move
on to the next one
[Music]
welcome back
in this lesson i will be covering a few
different topics that i will touch on
when creating a new google cloud account
i will be covering going over the free
tier and the always free options the
differences between them and a demo
showing how you can create your own free
tier account as well i'll also be going
into what you will need in order to
fulfill this demo so for the remainder
of this course all the demos will run
under the free tier now when i built
this course i built it with budget in
mind and having viewed on ways where i
can keep the price to a minimum while
still keeping the demos extremely useful
and so the free tier falls within all
these guidelines and will help you learn
without the high ticket price and so
getting into a quick overview of the
differences between the free tier and
the always free option i have broken
them down here with their most
significant differences in the free tier
google cloud offers you a 12 month free
trial with a 300
u.s credit this type of account ends
when the credit is used or after the 12
months whichever happens first and so
for those of you who are looking at
taking advantage of this on a business
level unfortunately the free tier only
applies to a personal account and cannot
be attached to a business account now
moving over to the always free option
the always free option isn't a special
program but it's a regular part of your
google cloud account it provides you
limited access to many of the google
cloud resources free of charge and once
these limits have been hit
then you are charged at the regular per
second billing rate
and i will show you a little bit later
how to monitor these credits so that you
don't go over using this in conjunction
with the free tier account is not
possible you have to have an upgraded
billing account which can also include a
business account now there are a bunch
more stipulations in this program and i
will include a link to both of them in
the lesson text below for later viewing
at your convenience
now lastly before we get into the demo
i wanted to go through a quick
run-through of exactly what's needed to
open up your free tier account
so we're going to start off with a fresh
new gmail address so that it doesn't
conflict with any current gmail address
that you may have you're gonna need a
credit card for verification and this is
for google to make sure that you're an
actual human being and not a robot and
you won't be charged unless you go above
the 300 credit limit as well i highly
recommend going into a private browsing
session so whether you're using chrome
you would use an incognito session if
you're using firefox you would use
private browsing and in microsoft edge
you would be using the in private mode
and so in order to start with this free
trial you can head on over to the url
listed here and i'll also include this
in the lesson text so head on over to
this url and i'll see you there in just
a second
okay so here we are at the free trial
url i'm here in google chrome in an
incognito session and so we're not going
to sign up we're going to go over here
to create account you can just click on
create account
for myself because as i mentioned
earlier you're not able to create a free
trial account with your business
so i'm going to click on for myself
and it's going to bring you to this page
where it says create your google account
and you're going to go to create a new
gmail address instead
and now you're going to fill in all the
necessary information that's needed in
order to open up this new gmail account
once you're finished typing your
password you can hit next
and now i got prompted for six digit
verification code that i have to plug in
but in order to do that google needs my
telephone number so i'm gonna type that
in now and just to let you know this
verification is done to let google know
that you're not a bot and you're a real
human and google just sent me a
verification code
and this is a one-time verification code
that i'm going to plug in
and i'm going to hit verify
and you can plug in the necessary
information here for recovery email
address your birthday and gender and
this is so that google can authenticate
you in case you accidentally misplace
your password
and then just hit next and here google
gives you a little bit more information
on what your number can be used for and
so i'm going to go ahead and skip it
and of course we're going to read
through the terms of service and the
privacy policy
click on agree
and as you can see we're almost there
it shows here that we're
signing up for the free trial i'm in
canada so
depending on your country this may
change of course i read the terms of
service and i'm going to agree to it and
i don't really want any updates so you
can probably skip that and just hit
continue
and so this is all the necessary
information that needs to be filled out
for billing and so here under account
type be sure to click on individual as
opposed to business and again fill in
all the necessary information with
regards to your address and your credit
card details and once you fill that in
you can click on start my free trial
and once you've entered in all that
information you should be brought to
this page with a prompt
asking you exactly what you need with
regards to google cloud and you can just
hit skip here
and i'm going to zoom in here just see a
little better and so here you're left
with a checklist where you can go
through all the different resources and
it even gives you a checklist to go
through but other than that we're in
and so just to verify that we're signed
up for a free tier account i'm going to
go over to billing and i'm going to see
here that i have my free trial credit
and it says 411 dollars and due to the
fact that my currency is in canadian
dollars it's been converted from us
dollars and so we'll be going through
billing in a later lesson
but right now we are actually logged in
and so that's all i wanted to cover for
this lesson on how to sign up for your
free trial account
so you can now mark this lesson as
complete and you can join me in the next
one
where we will secure the account
using a method called two-step
verification
[Music]
welcome back
so in the last lesson we went ahead and
created a brand new gcp account in this
lesson we'll be discussing how to secure
that gcp account by following some best
practices
whenever any account is created in
google cloud and this can be applied
with regards to personal accounts as
well as the super admin account as it's
always good to keep safety as a priority
this lesson may be a refresher for those
who are a bit more advanced as for
everyone else these steps could help you
from an attack on your account i'd first
like to run you through a scenario of
the outcome on both secure and
non-secure accounts
as well as the different options that
reside in google cloud
when it comes to locking down your
account i'll then run through a hands-on
demo in the console
to show you how you can apply it
yourself
so in this specific scenario a username
and password is used to secure the
account
here lark a trouble causing manager
looks over the shoulder of tony bowtie
while he plugs in his username and
password
so that he can later access his account
to wreak havoc on tony's reputation as
tony leaves for coffee
lark decides to log in and send a
company-wide email from tony's account
to change an already made decision about
next season's store opening in rome
italy that would not look good for tony
it was that easy for lark to steal
tony's password and in a real life
scenario it would be that easy for
someone to steal your password now when
someone steals your password they could
do even more devious things than what
lark did not just sending out harmful
emails they could lock you out of your
account or even delete emails or
documents this is where two-step
verification comes in this can help keep
bad people out
even if they have your password two-step
verification is an extra layer of
security most people only have one layer
to protect their account which is their
password with two-step verification
if a bad person hacks through your
password they'll still need your phone
or security key to get into your account
so how two-step verification works is
that sign-in will require something you
know
and something that you have
the first one is to protect your account
with something you know which will be
your password and the second is
something that you have
which is your phone or security key
so whenever you sign into google you'll
enter your password as usual
then a code will be sent to your phone
via text
voice call or google's mobile app or if
you have a security key you can insert
it into your computer's usb port
codes can be sent in a text message or
through a voice call depending on the
setting you choose
you can set up google authenticator or
another app that creates a one-time
verification code which is great for
when you're offline you would then enter
the verification code on the sign in
screen to help verify that it is you
another way for verification is using
google prompts and this can help protect
against sim swap or other phone number
based hacks google prompts are push
notifications you'll receive on android
phones that are signed into your google
account or iphones with the gmail app or
google app that's signed into your
google account now you can actually skip
a second step on trusted devices
if you don't want to provide a second
verification step each time you sign in
on your computer or your phone you can
check the box next to don't ask again on
this computer and this is a great added
feature if you are the only user on this
device
this feature is not recommended if this
device is being used by multiple users
security keys are another way to help
protect your google account from
phishing attacks when a hacker tries to
trick you into giving them your password
or other personal information now a
physical security key is a small device
that you can buy to help prove it's you
signing in when google needs to make
sure that it's you
you can simply connect your key to your
computer and verify that it's you and
when you have no other way to verify
your account you have the option of
using backup codes and these are
one-time use codes that you can print or
download and these are multiple sets of
eight-digit codes that you can keep in a
safe place in case you have no other
options for verification i personally
have found use in using these backup
codes as i have used them in past when
my phone died
so ever since lark's last email
tony not only changed his password
but added a two-step verification to his
account so that only he would have
access and would never have to worry
again about others looking over his
shoulder to gain access to his account
as tony leaves for coffee
lark tries to log in again but is
unsuccessful due to the two-step
verification in place tony has clearly
outsmarted the bad man in this scenario
and lark will have to look for another
way to foil tony's plan to bring
greatness to bow ties across the globe
and this is a sure difference between
having a secure account and a not so
secure account and so now that i've gone
through the theory of the two-step
verification process i'm going to dive
into the console and implement it with
the hands-on demo just be aware that you
can also do this through the gmail
console but we're going to go ahead and
do it through the google cloud console
using the url you see here so whenever
you're ready feel free to join me in the
console
and so here we are back in the console
and over here on the top right hand
corner you will find a user icon and you
can simply click on it
and click over to your google account
now i'm just going to zoom in for better
viewing
and so in order to enable two-step
verification we're gonna go over here to
the menu on the left and click on
security and under signing into google
you will find two-step verification
currently it's off as well as using my
phone to sign in is off so i'm going to
click on this bar here for two-step
verification
and i definitely want to add an extra
layer of security and i definitely want
to keep the bad guys out so i'm going to
go ahead and click on the get started
button
it'll ask me for my password
and because i've entered my phone number
when i first signed up for the account
it actually shows up here this is i
antony which is my iphone and so now i
can get a two-step verification here on
my iphone and again this is going to be
a google prompt as it shows here but if
i wanted to change it to something else
i can simply click on show more options
and here we have a security key as well
as text message or voice call i highly
recommend the google prompt as it's
super easy to use with absolutely no
fuss and so as i always like to verify
what i've done i'm going to click on
this try it now button and so because i
wanted to show you exactly what a live
google prompt looks like i'm going to
bring up my phone here on the screen so
that you can take a look
and it actually sent me a google prompt
to my phone and i'm just going to go
ahead and open up my gmail app so i can
verify that it is indeed me that wants
to log in which i will accept
and so once i've accepted the google
prompt another window will pop up asking
me about a backup option and so i'll
simply need my phone number
and i can either get a text message or a
phone call and again you have other
options as well so you can use the
one-time backup codes which we discussed
earlier and you can print or download
them but i usually like to use a text
message and so i'm going to use that
i'm going to send it to my phone
and so just to verify it
i'm gonna now plug in the one-time code
that was sent to me
and then just hit next
so the second step is the google prompt
it's my default and my backup options if
i can't get google prompt is a voice or
text message and again this is for my
account antony gcloud ace at gmail.com
sending it to my i antony device so turn
on two-step verification absolutely
and so there you have it there is
two-step verification enabled and if i
wanted to change the available steps i
can do so here i can also edit it i can
edit my phone number and i can also set
up any backup codes in case i need it in
my personal opinion two-step
verification
is a must-have on any account best
practice is to always do it for your
super admin account which would be my
gmail account that i am currently signed
up with but i find is a necessity for
any other users and always make it a
policy for people to add two-step
verification to their accounts i highly
recommend that you make it your best
practice to do this in your role as an
engineer in any environment at any
organization again two-step verification
will allow to keep you safe your users
safe and your environment safe from any
malicious activities that could happen
at any time and that's all i have for
this lesson on two-step verification and
securing your account
so you can now mark this lesson as
complete and let's move on to the next
one
[Music]
welcome back
now there are many different ways in
which you can interact with google cloud
services and resources this lesson is an
overview of the gcp console and how you
can interact with it using the graphical
user interface and so for this hands-on
demo
i will be diving into how to navigate
through the gcp console and point out
some functions and features that you may
find helpful so with that being said
let's dive in
and so here we are back in the console
up here you can see the free trial
status and then i still have 410 credit
again this is canadian dollars so i
guess consider me lucky so i'm going to
go ahead over here and dismiss this
don't activate it because otherwise this
will kill your free trial status and you
don't want to do that so i'm just going
to hit dismiss so over here on the main
page you have a bunch of cards here that
will give you the status of your
environment as well as the status of
what's happening within google cloud
with these cards you can customize them
by hitting this button over here
customize and you can turn them on or
off and you can go ahead and move these
around if you'd like
and i'm going to put this up here as
well i'm going to turn on my billing so
i can keep track of exactly what my
spend is i don't really need my get
starting card so i'm going to turn that
off as well as the documentation i'm
going to turn that off as well
and the apis is always nice to have
as well up here on the project info this
reflects the current project which is my
first project
and the project name here is the same
the project id is showing and the
project number and i'm going to dive
deeper into that in another lesson also
note that your cards will reflect
exactly what it is that you're
interacting with and so the more
resources that you dive into the cards
will end up showing up here
and you can add them and turn them off
at will so i'm going to go up here and
click on done because i'm satisfied with
the way that things look
here on my home page and over here to
your left i wanted to focus on
all the services that are available in
their own specific topics so for
instance all of compute
you will find app engine compute engine
kubernetes and so on so note that
anything compute related you'll find
them all grouped together also another
great feature is that you can pin
exactly what it is that you use often so
if i am a big user of app engine i can
pin this and it will move its way up to
the top this way it saves me the time
from having to go and look for it every
time i need it and if i'm using it
constantly it's great to have a shortcut
to unpin it i simply go back to the pin
and click on it again as well if i'd
like to move the menu out of the way to
get more screen real estate i can simply
click on this hamburger button here
and make it disappear and to bring it
back i can just click on that again and
i'll bring it back again now i know that
there's a lot of resources here to go
through so if you're looking for
something specific you can always go up
to the search bar right here
and simply type it in so if i'm looking
for let's say cloud sql i can simply
type in sql
and i can find it right here
i can find the api and if anything
associated with the word sql if i'm
looking for cloud sql specifically i can
simply type in
cloud sql
and here it is
another thing to note is that if you
want to go back to your homepage you can
simply go up to the left hand corner
here and click on the google cloud
platform logo and it'll bring you right
back and right here under the google
cloud platform logo you'll see another
set of tabs we have dashboard we also
have activity and this will show all the
latest activity that's been done
and because this is a brand new account
i don't have much here now because this
is my first time in activity this is
going to take some time to index
and in the meantime i wanted to show you
filters
if this were a long list to go through
where activity has been happening for
months i can filter through these
activities either by user or by
categories or by resource type as well
as the date i can also combine these to
search for something really granular and
beside the activity tab we have
recommendations which is based on the
recommender service and this service
provides recommendations and insights
for using resources on google cloud
these recommendations and insights are
on a per product or per service basis
and they are based on machine learning
and current resource usage a great
example of a recommendation is vm
instance right sizing so if the
recommender service detects that a vm
instance is underutilized it will
recommend changing the machine size so
that i can save some money and because
this is a fresh new account and i
haven't used any resources this is why
there is no recommendations for me so
going back to the home page
i want to touch on this projects menu
for a second and as you can see here i
can select a project now if i had many
different projects i can simply search
from each different one and so to cover
the last part of the console i wanted to
touch on this menu on the top right hand
corner here so clicking on this present
icon will reveal my free trial status
which i dismissed earlier next to the
present we have a cloud shell icon and
this is where you can activate and bring
up the cloud shell which i will be
diving into deeper in a later lesson and
right next to it is the help button in
case you need a shortcut to any
documentations or tutorials as well some
keyboard shortcuts
may help you be a little bit more
efficient and you can always click on
this and it'll show you exactly what you
need to know and so i'm going to close
this
and to move over to the next part in the
menu this is the notifications so any
activities that happen you will be
notified here and you can simply click
on the bell and it'll show you a bunch
of different notifications for either
resources that are created or any other
activities that may have happened now
moving on over
three buttons over here is the settings
and utilities button
and over here you will find the
preferences
and under communication you will find
product notifications and updates and
offers and you can turn them off or on
depending on whether or not you want to
receive these notifications as well you
have your language and region and you
can personalize the cloud console as to
whether or not you want to allow google
to track your activity and this is great
for when you want recommendations so i'm
going to keep that checked off getting
back to some other options you will find
a link to downloads as well as cloud
partners and the terms of service
privacy and project settings and so to
cover the last topic i wanted to touch
on is the actual google account button
and here you can add other user accounts
for when you log into the console with a
different user as well as go straight to
your google account and of course if
you're using a computer that's used by
multiple users you can sign out here as
well and so that's just a quick
run-through of the console and so feel
free to poke around and get familiar
with exactly what's available in the
console so that it's a lot easier for
you to use and allow you to become more
efficient and so that's all i have for
this lesson so you can now mark this
lesson as complete and let's move on to
the next one
welcome back
in this lesson i'm going to be going
through a breakdown of cloud billing and
an overview of the various resources
that's involved with billing billing is
important to know
and i'll be diving into the concepts
around billing and billing interaction
over the next few lessons
as well i'll be getting into another
demo going through the details on how to
create
edit
and delete a cloud billing account
now earlier on in the course i went over
the resource hierarchy and how google
cloud resources are broken down starting
from the domain level down to their
resource level
this lesson will focus strictly on the
billing account
and payments profile
and the breakdown are concepts that are
comprised within them
so getting right into it let's start
with the cloud billing account a cloud
billing account is a cloud level
resource managed in the cloud console
this defines who pays for a given set of
google cloud resources billing tracks
all of the costs incurred by your google
cloud usage as well it is connected to a
google payments profile which includes a
payment method defining on how you pay
for your charges a cloud billing account
can be linked to one or more projects
and not to any one project specifically
cloud billing also has billing specific
roles and permissions to control
accessing and modifying billing related
functions that are established by
identity and access management cloud
billing is offered in two different
account types there is the self-service
or online account or you can also choose
from the invoiced or offline payments
when it comes to the self-service option
the payment method is usually a credit
or debit card and costs are charged
automatically to the specific payment
method connected to the cloud billing
account and when you need access to your
invoices you can simply go to the cloud
console and view them online now when it
comes to the invoice account first you
must be eligible for invoice billing
once you are made eligible the payment
method used can be check or wire
transfer your invoices are sent by mail
or electronically as well they're also
available in the cloud console as well
as the payment receipts
now another cool feature of billing
account is sub-accounts and these are
intended for resellers so if you are a
reseller you can use subaccounts to
represent your customers and make it
easy for chargebacks cloud billing
subaccounts allow you to group charges
from projects together on a separate
section of your invoice and is linked
back to the master cloud billing account
on which your charges appear
sub-accounts are designed to allow for
customer separation and management so
when it comes to ownership of a cloud
billing account it is limited to a
single organization
it is possible though for a cloud
billing account to pay for projects that
belong to an organization that is
different than the organization that
owns the cloud billing account now one
thing to note is that if you have a
project that is not linked to a billing
account you will have limited use of
products and services available for your
project that is projects that are not
linked to a billing account cannot use
google cloud services that aren't free
and so now that we've gone through an
overview of the billing account let's
take a quick step into the payments
profile now the payments profile is a
google level resource managed at
payments.google.com
the payments profile
processes payments for all google
services and not just for google cloud
it connects to all of your google
services such as google ads as well as
google cloud it stores information like
your name address and who is responsible
for the profile it stores your various
payment methods like credit cards debit
cards and bank accounts the payments
profile
functions as a single pane of glass
where you can view invoices payment
history and so on it also controls who
can view and receive invoices for your
various cloud billing accounts and
products
now one thing to note about payments
profile is that there are two different
types of payment profiles the first one
is individual and that's when you're
using your account for your own personal
payments if you register your payments
profile as an individual then only you
can manage the profile you won't be able
to add or remove users or change
permissions on the profile now if you
choose a business profile type you're
paying on behalf of a business or
organization a business profile gives
you the flexibility to add other users
to the google payments profile you
manage so that more than one person can
access or manage a payments profile all
users added to a business profile
can then see the payment information on
that profile another thing to note is
that once the profile type has been
selected it cannot be changed afterwards
and so now that we've quickly gone
through an overview of all the concepts
when it comes to billing i am now going
to run through a short demo where i will
create a new billing account edit that
billing account and show you how to
close a billing account so whenever
you're ready join me in the console and
so here i am back in the console and so
the first thing i want to do is i want
to make sure that i have the proper
permissions in order to create and edit
a new billing account so what i'm going
to do is go over here to the hamburger
menu up here in the top left hand corner
and click on it
and go over to i am an admin and over to
iam
now don't worry i'm not going to get
really deep into this i will be going
over this in a later section where i'll
go through iam and roles but i wanted to
give you a sense of exactly what you
need with regards to permissions so now
that i'm here i'm going to be looking
for a role that has to do with billing
so i'm simply going to go over here on
the left hand menu and click on roles
and you'll have a slew of roles coming
up
and what you can do is filter through
them just by simply typing in billing
into the filter table here at the top
and as you can see here
there is billing account administrator
billing account creator and so on and so
forth and just to give you a quick
overview on these roles and so for the
billing account administrator this is a
role that lets you manage billing
accounts but not create them so if you
need to set budget alerts or manage
payment methods you can use this role
the billing account creator allows you
to create new self-serve online billing
accounts the billing account user allows
you to link projects to billing accounts
the billing account viewer allows you to
view billing account cost information
and transactions and lastly the project
billing manager allows you to link or
unlink the project to and from a billing
account so as you can see these roles
allow you to get pretty granular when it
comes to billing so i'm going to go back
over to the left hand menu over on iam
and click on there and i want to be able
to check my specific role and what
permissions that i have or i will need
in order to create a new billing account
and so if i click on this pencil it'll
show me exactly
what my role is and what it does and as
it says here i have full access to all
resources which means that i am pretty
much good to go so i'm going to cancel
out here
and i'm going to exit i am an admin
so i'm going to click on the navigation
menu
and go over to billing
and so this billing account is tied to
the current project and because it's the
only billing account it's the one that
shows up and so what i want to do is i
want to find out a little bit more
information with regards to this billing
account so i'm going to move down the
menu and click on account management
here i can see the billing account which
is my billing account i can rename it if
i'd like
and i can also see the projects that are
linked to this billing account so now
that we've viewed all the information
with regards to the my billing account
i'm going to simply click on this menu
over here
and click on the arrow and go to manage
billing accounts and here it will bring
me to all my billing accounts and
because i only have one is shown here my
billing account but if i had more than
one they would show up here and so now
in order for me to create this new
billing account i'm going to simply
click on create account
and i will be prompted with a name a
country and a currency for my new
billing account and i'm actually going
to rename this billing account and i'm
going to rename it to gcloud
ace
dash billing
i'm going to leave my country as canada
and my currency in canadian dollars and
i'm going to simply hit continue
and it's giving me the choice in my
payments profile
and because i want to use the same
payments profile i'm just going to
simply leave everything as is but for
demonstration purposes
over here you can click on the payments
profile
and the little arrow right beside the
current profile will give me the option
to create a new payments profile
and we're going to leave that as is
under customer info i have the option of
changing my address and i can click on
this pencil icon and change it as well i
can go to payment methods and click on
the current payment method with that
little arrow
and add a new credit or debit card and
as i said before we're going to keep
things the way they are and just hit
submit and enable billing
now as you can see here i got a prompt
saying that a confirmation email will be
sent within 48 hours now usually when
you're setting up a brand new billing
profile with an already created payments
profile you'll definitely get a
confirmation email in less than 48 hours
now in order for me to finish up this
demo i'm gonna wait until the new
billing account shows up and continue
with the demo from then and so here i am
back in the billing console and it only
took about 20 minutes and the gcloud ace
billing account has shown up and so with
part of this demo what i wanted to show
is how you can take a project and attach
it to a different billing account and so
currently my only project is attached to
the my billing account so now if i
wanted to change my first project to my
gcloud ace dash billing account
i can simply go over here to actions
click on the hamburger menu
and go to change billing
here i'll be prompted to choose a
billing account and i can choose g cloud
a stash billing
and then click on set account
and there it is my first project is now
linked to g cloud a stash billing so if
i go back over to my billing accounts
you can see here that my billing account
currently has zero projects and g cloud
a stash billing has one project now just
as a quick note and i really want to
emphasize this
is that if you're changing a billing
account for a project
and you are a regular user
you will need the role of the billing
account administrator
as well as the project owner role
so these two together will allow a
regular user to change a billing account
for a project
and so now what i want to do is i want
to take the gcloud a stash billing and i
want to close that account
but before i do that i need to unlink
this project and bring it back to
another billing account which in this
case would be my billing account so i'm
going to go back up here to the menu
click on my projects and we're going to
do the exact same thing that we did
before
under actions i'm going to click on the
hamburger menu and change billing
i'm going to get the prompt again and
under billing account i'm going to
choose my billing account and then click
on set account
so as you can see the project has been
moved to a different billing account i'm
going to go back to my billing accounts
and as you can see here the project is
back to my billing account and so now
that the project is unlinked from the
gcloud a stash billing account i can now
go ahead and close out that account now
in order to do that i'm going to click
on gcloud a stash billing i'm going to
go down here on the hand menu all the
way to the bottom to account management
click on there and at the top here you
will see close billing account i'm going
to simply click on that and i'll get a
prompt that i've spent zero dollars and
is linked to zero projects
now if i did have a project that was
linked to this billing account i would
have to unlink the project before i was
able to close this billing account so as
a failsafe i'm being asked to type close
in order to close this billing account
so i'm going to go ahead and do that now
and click on close billing account just
as a note google gives me the option to
reopen this billing account in case i
did this by mistake and i really needed
it
i can reopen this billing account so now
moving back over to billing you'll see
here
that i'm left with my single billing
account called my billing account with
the one project that's linked to it and
so that covers my demo on creating
editing and closing a new billing
account as well as linking and unlinking
a project to and from a different
billing account so i hope you found this
useful
and you can now mark this lesson as
complete and let's move on to the next
one
[Music]
welcome back
in this lesson i'm going to be going
over controlling costs in google cloud
along with budget alerts
i will be touching on all the available
discounts the number of ways to control
costs
and go over budget alerts to get a more
granular and programmatic approach so
starting off i wanted to touch on
committed use discounts now committed
use discounts provide discounted prices
in exchange for your commitment to use a
minimum level of resources for a
specified term the discounts are
flexible cover a wide range of resources
and are ideal for workloads with
predictable resource needs when you
purchase google cloud committed use
discounts you commit to a consistent
amount of usage for a one or three year
period there are two commitment types
available
and as you can see here they are spend
based and resource based commitment
types
and unlike most other providers the
commitment fee is billed monthly so
going over the specific commitment types
i wanted to start off with spend based
commitment now for spend based
commitment you commit to a consistent
amount of usage measured in dollars per
hour
of equivalent on-demand spend for a one
or three year term in exchange you
receive a discounted rate on the
applicable usage your commitment covers
so you can purchase committed use
discounts from any cloud billing account
and the discount applies to any eligible
usage in projects paid for by that cloud
billing account any overage is charged
at the on-demand rate spend based
commitments can give you a 25 discount
off on-demand pricing for a one-year
commitment and up to a 52 discount off
of on-demand pricing for a three-year
commitment now spend-based commitments
are restricted to specific resources
which is cloud sql database instances
and google cloud vmware engine
and this commitment
applies to the cpu and memory usage for
these available resources now the other
committed use discount is the
resource-based commitment
so this discount is for a commitment to
spend a minimum amount for compute
engine resources in a particular region
resource-based commitments are ideal for
predictable workloads when it comes to
your vms
when you purchase a committed use
contract you purchase compute resources
such as vcpus
memory
gpus
and local ssds and you purchase these at
a discounted price in return for
committing to paying for those resources
for one or three years the discount is
up to 57 percent for most resources like
machine types or gpus the discount is up
to 70 percent for memory optimized
machine types and you can purchase a
committed use contract for a single
project or purchase multiple contracts
which you can share across many project
by enabling shared discounts and sharing
your committed use discounts across all
your projects reduces the overhead of
managing discounts on a per project
basis
and maximizes your savings by pooling
all of your discounts across your
project's resource usage if you have
multiple projects that share the same
cloud billing account you can enable
committed use discount sharing so all of
your projects within that cloud billing
account share all of your committed use
discount contracts and so your sustained
use discounts are also pooled at the
same time so touching on sustained use
discounts
these are automatic discounts for
running specific compute engine
resources a significant portion of the
billing month
sustained use discounts apply to the
general purpose
compute and memory optimize machine
types as well as sole tenant nodes and
gpus again sustained use discounts are
applied automatically to usage within a
project separately for each region so
there's no action required on your part
to enable these discounts so for example
when you're running one of these
resources for more than let's say 25
percent of the month
compute engine automatically gives you a
discount for every incremental minute
that you use for that instance now
sustained use discounts automatically
apply to vms created by both google
kubernetes engine and compute engine but
unfortunately do not apply to vms
created using the app engine flexible
environment as well as data flow and e2
machine types
now to take advantage of the full
discount you would create your vm
instances on the first day of the month
as discounts reset at the beginning of
each month and so the following table
shows the discount you get at each usage
level of a vm instance these discounts
apply for all machine types but don't
apply to preemptable instances and so
sustained use discounts can save you up
to a maximum of a 30 percent discount so
another great way to calculate savings
in google cloud is by using the gcp
pricing calculator this is a quick way
to get an estimate of what your usage
will cost on google cloud so the gcp
pricing calculator can help you identify
the pricing for the resources that you
plan to use in your future architecture
so that you are able to calculate how
much your architecture will cost you
this calculator holds the pricing for
almost all resources encapsulated within
gcp and so you can get a pretty good
idea of what your architecture will cost
you without having to find out the hard
way this calculator can be found at the
url shown here and i will include this
in the lesson text below now moving
right along to cloud billing budgets so
budgets enable you to track your actual
spend
against your plan spend
after you've set a budget amount you set
budget alert threshold rules that are
used to trigger email notifications and
budget alert emails help you stay
informed about how your spend is
tracking against your budget this
example here is a diagram of a budget
alert notification and is the default
functionality for any budget alert
notifications
now to get a little bit more granular
you can define the scope of the budget
so for example you can scope the budget
to apply to the spend of an entire cloud
billing account or get more granular to
one or more projects
and even down to a specific product you
can set the budget amount to a total
that you specify
or base the budget amount on the
previous month's spend when costs exceed
a percentage of your budget based on the
rules that you set by default alert
emails are sent to billing account
administrators and billing account users
on the target cloud billing account and
again this is the default behavior of a
budget email notification
now as said before the default behavior
of a budget is to send alert emails to
billing account administrators and
billing account users on the target
cloud billing account when the budget
alert threshold rules trigger an email
notification now these email recipients
can be customized by using cloud
monitoring to specify other people in
your organization to receive these
budget alert emails a great example of
this would be a project manager or a
director knowing how much spend has been
used up in your budget and the last
concept i wanted to touch on when it
comes to cloud billing budgets is that
you can also use pub sub for
programmatic notifications to automate
your cost control response based on the
budget notification
you can also use pub sub in conjunction
with billing budgets to automate cost
management tasks and this will provide a
real-time status of the cloud billing
budget and allow you to do things like
send notifications to slack or disable
billing to stop usage as well as
selectively control usage when budget
has been met and so these are all the
concepts that i wanted to cover when it
came to cloud billing budgets now i know
this lesson may have been a bit dry and
not the most exciting service to dive
into but it is very important to know
both for the exam
and for your role as an engineer when it
comes to cutting costs in environments
where your business owners deem
necessary and so that's all i had for
this lesson
so you can now mark this lesson as
complete and please join me in the next
one where i dive into the console and do
some hands-on demos when it comes to
committed use discounts
budget alerts and editing budget alerts
as well as adding a little bit of
automation into the budgeting alerts
[Music]
welcome back in the last lesson i went
over a few ways to do cost management
and the behaviors of budget alerts
in this lesson i will be doing a demo to
show you committed use discounts and
reservations along with how to create
budget alerts
and as well how to edit them so with
that being said let's dive in so now i'm
going to start off with committed use
discounts in order to get there i'm
going to find it in compute engine so
i'm going to simply go up here on the
top left hand corner back to the
navigation menu
i'm going to go down to compute engine
and i'm going to go over here to
committed use discounts
and as we discussed earlier these
commitments for compute engine are
resource based and as you can see here
we have hardware commitments and
reservations now reservations i will get
into just a little bit later but with
regards to hardware commitments we're
going to get into that right now and as
expected i have no current commitments
so i'm going to go up to purchase
commitment and so i need to start off
with
finding a name for this commitment and
so i'm going to name this commitment
demo dash commitment
it's going to ask me for a region i'm
going to keep it in us central one with
the commitment type here is where i can
select the type of machine that i'm
looking for so i can go into general
purpose and 1 and 2
and 2d e2 as well as memory optimize
and compute optimized and so i'm going
to keep it at general purpose and one
again the duration one or three years
and we get down to cores i can have as
many vcpus as i'd like
so if i needed 10 i can do that and i'll
get a pop-up here on the right showing
me the estimated monthly total as well
as an hourly rate for this specific vm
with 10 cores i can also select the
duration for three years and as expected
i'll get a higher savings because i'm
giving a bigger commitment so bring it
back down to one year and let's put the
memory up to 64 gigabytes here i can add
gpus and i have quite a few to choose
from as well as local ssds and here with
the local ssds i can choose as many
disks as i'd like as long as it's within
my quota and each disk size is going to
be 375 gigabytes so if you're looking
into committed use discounts and using
local ssds please keep that in mind
again the reservation can be added here
and i'll be getting into that in just a
second and now i don't want to actually
purchase it but i did want to show you
exactly what a committed use discount
would look like and how you would apply
it again here on the right hand side it
shows me the details of the estimated
monthly total and the hourly rate so i'm
going to go over here and hit cancel
and if i were to have applied it
the commitment would show up here in
this table and give me all the specified
configurations
of that instance right here now touching
on reservations
reservations is when you reserve the vm
instances you need
so when the reservation has been placed
the reservation ensures that those
resources are always available for you
as some of you might know when you go to
spin up a new compute engine vm
especially when it comes to auto scaling
instance groups the instances can
sometimes be delayed or unavailable now
the thing with reservations is that a vm
instance can only use a reservation if
its properties exactly match the
properties of the reservation which is
why it's such a great pairing with
committed use discounts
so if you're looking to make a
resource-based commitment and you always
want your instance available you can
simply create a reservation attach it to
the commitment and you will never have
to worry about having the resources to
satisfy your workload as they will
always be there so again going into
create reservation it'll show me here
the name the description i can choose to
use the reservation automatically or
select a specific reservation the region
and zone
number of instances and here i can
specify the machine type or specify an
instance template and again this is
another use case where if you need
compute engine instances spun up due to
auto scaling this is where reservations
would apply so getting back to machine
type i can choose from vcpus
as well as the memory i can customize it
i can add as many local ssds as my
quotas will allow me and i can select my
interface type and i'm going to cancel
out of here now when it comes to
committed use discounts and reservations
as it pertains to the exam
i have not seen it but since this is an
option to save money i wanted to make
sure that i included it in this lesson
as this could be a great option for use
in your environment so now that we
covered resource-based committed use
discounts i wanted to move into spend
based commitments and so where you would
find that would be over in billing
so again i'm going to go up to the
navigation menu in the top left hand
corner and go into billing
now you'd think that you would find it
here under commitments but only when you
have purchased a commitment will it
actually show up here but as you can see
here it's prompting us to go to the
billing overview page
so going back to the overview page
you'll find it
down here on the right and so i can now
purchase a commitment and as we
discussed before
a spend based commitment can be used for
either cloud sql or for vmware engine
i select my billing account
the commitment name the period either
one year or three years and it also
shows me the discount which could help
sway my decision as well as the region
as well as the hourly on-demand
commitment now you're probably wondering
what this is
and as explained here this commitment is
based on the on-demand price
and once this is all filled out the
commitment summary will be populated and
after you agree to all the terms and
services you can simply hit purchase
but i'm going to cancel out of here
and so that is an overview for the spend
based commitment and again these
committed use discounts i have not seen
on the exam
but i do think that it's good to know
for your day-to-day environment if
you're looking to save money and really
break down costs
so now that i've covered committed use
discounts and reservations
i wanted to move over to budgets and
budget alerts and because i'm already on
the billing page all i need to do is go
over here to the left hand menu and
click on budgets and alerts now setting
up a budget for yourself for this course
would be a great idea especially for
those who are cost conscious on how much
you're spending with regards to your
cloud usage and so we're to go ahead and
create a new budget right now so let's
go up here to the top to create budget
and i'm going to be brought to a new
window where i can put in the name of
the budget and i'm going to call this
ace
dash budget and because i want to
monitor all projects and all products
i'm going to leave this as is but if you
did have multiple projects you could get
a little bit more granular and the same
thing with products
so i'm going to go ahead and leave it as
is and just click on next now under
budget type
i can select from either a specified
amount or the last month's spend and so
for this demo i'm going to keep it at
specified amount
and because i want to be really
conscious about how much i spend in this
course i'm going to put in 10
for my target amount i'm going to
include the credits and cost and then
i'm going to click on next now these
threshold rules are where billing
administrators will be emailed when a
certain percent of the budget is hit
so if my spend happens to hit five
dollars
because i am a billing administrator i
will be sent an email telling me that my
spend has hit five dollars i also have
the option of changing these percentages
so if i decided to change it to forty
percent
now my amount goes to four dollars and
this is done automatically so no need to
do any calculations
but i'm going to keep this here at 50
percent
and vice versa if i wanted to change the
amount
the percentage of budget will actually
change now with the trigger i actually
have the option of selecting forecasted
or actual and so i'm going to keep it on
actual and if i want i can add more
threshold rules now i'm going to leave
everything as is and just click on
finish
and now as you can see here i have a
budget name of ace budget now because
the budget name doesn't have to be
globally unique in your environment you
can name your budget exactly the same
and again it'll give me all the specific
configurations that i filled out shows
me how much credits i've used and that's
it and that's how you would create a
budget alert now if i needed to edit it
i can always go back to ace budget and
here i can edit it but i'm not going to
touch it and i'm just going to hit
cancel
and so the last thing i wanted to show
you before we end this lesson is how to
create another budget but being able to
send out the trigger alert emails to
different users
and so in order to do that i'm going to
go back up here to create budget i'm
going to name this to ace dash
budget
dash
users i'm going to leave the rest as is
i'm going to click on next again i'm
going to leave the budget type the way
it is the target amount i'm going to put
ten dollars
leave the include credits and cost and
just click on next
and so here i'm going to leave the
threshold rules the way they are and
right here under manage notifications
i'm going to click off link monitoring
email notification channels to this
budget now because the email
notification channel needs cloud
monitoring in order to work i am
prompted here to select a workspace
which is needed by cloud monitoring so
because i have none i'm going to go
ahead and create one and so clicking on
managing monitoring workspaces will
bring you to the documentation but in
order for me to get a workspace created
i need to go to cloud monitoring now
workspace is the top level container
that is used to organize and control
access to your monitoring notification
channels in order for your notification
channels to work they must belong to a
monitoring workspace so you need to
create at least one workspace before
adding monitoring
notification channels and don't worry
we'll be getting into greater depth with
regards to monitoring in a later section
in this course so i'm going to go ahead
and cancel this
and i'm going to go up to the navigation
menu
click on there
and scroll down to monitoring
and then overview and this may take a
minute to start up
as the apis are being enabled and the
default workspace for cloud monitoring
is being built
okay and now that the monitoring api has
been enabled we are now in monitoring
the workspace that was created is my
first project so now that we have our
monitoring workspace created i need to
add the emails to the users that i want
the alerts to be sent out to and added
to the notification channel so in order
to do that i'm going to go over here to
alerting and up here at the top i'm
going to click on edit notification
channels
and here as you can see are many
notification channels that you can
enable by simply clicking on add new
over here on the right so now what i'm
looking for is under email i'm going to
click on add new now here i can add the
new email address and so for me i'm
going to add antony
at antonyt.com
and you can add whatever email address
you'd like
and under display name i'm going to add
billing admin
notification
and just click on save
and as you can see my email has been
added to the notification channel and so
this is all i needed to do in order to
move on to the next step and so now that
i've covered creating my monitoring
workspace as well as adding another
email to my email notification channels
i can now go back to billing and finish
off my budget alert
let's go over here to budgets and alerts
create budget
and we're gonna go through the same
steps
call this billing
alert
users
leave everything else as is and click on
next
i'm just going to change the target
amount to 10
click on next
i'm going to leave everything here as is
and i'm going to go back to click on
link monitoring email notification
channels to this budget now if you
notice when i click on select workspace
my first project shows up and here it
will ask me for my notification channels
and because i've already set it up i can
simply click on it and you'll see the
billing admin notification channel
and so if i didn't have this set up i
can always go to manage notification
channels and it'll bring me back to the
screen which you saw earlier
and so now that that's set up i can
simply click on finish
and so now that i have a
regular budget alert i also have another
budget alert that can go to a different
email so if you have a project manager
or a director that you want to send
budget alerts to this is how you would
do it and so that about covers this demo
on committed use discounts reservations
budgets and budget alerts and so that's
all i wanted to cover for this lesson
so you can now mark this lesson as
complete
and let's move on to the next one
[Music]
welcome back
in this short lesson i will be covering
the exporting of your billing data so
that you're able to analyze that data
and understand your spend at a more
granular level
i will also be going through a short
demo where i will show you how to enable
the export billing feature and bring it
into bigquery to be analyzed
now cloud billing export to bigquery
enables you to export granular google
cloud billing data such as usage
cost details and pricing data
automatically to a bigquery data set
that you specify then you can access
your cloud billing data from bigquery
for detailed analysis
or use a tool like data studio to
visualize your data just a quick note
here that billing export is not
retroactive and this should be taken
into consideration when planning for
analysis on this data and so there are
two types of cloud billing data that you
can export
there's the daily cost detail data
and the pricing data and these can be
selected right within the console
depending on your use case and so now
that we've gone through exactly what
billing export is i wanted to get into a
demo and show you how to export your
cloud billing data to bigquery and go
through all the necessary steps to get
it enabled so when you're ready join me
in the console and so here we are back
in the console and so in order to enable
billing export i'm going to be going to
the billing page so i'm going to move up
to the top left hand corner to the
navigation menu
and click on billing
here in the left hand menu you'll see
billing export and you can just click on
there
and so for those just coming to billing
export for the first time there's a
quick summary of exactly what the
bigquery export is used for and as we
discussed earlier there is an option for
the daily cost detail and for pricing
and i'm going to use the daily cost
detail in this demo and export that data
to bigquery so the first step i'm going
to do
is to click on edit settings and it's
going to bring me to a new page where it
will ask me for my project and this is
where my billing data is going to be
stored but as you can see here i'm
getting a prompt that says you need to
create a bigquery data set first now the
bigquery data set that is asking for is
where the billing data is going to be
stored so in order to move forward with
my billing export i need to go to
bigquery and set up a data set so i'm
going to simply click on this button
here that says go to bigquery
and it's going to bring me to the
bigquery page where i'll be prompted
with a big welcome note you can just
click on done and over here in the right
hand side where it says create data set
i'm just going to click on there and i'm
going to create my new data set and so
for my data set id i'm going to call
this
billing
export
and just as a note with the data set id
you can't use any characters like
hyphens commas or periods and therefore
i capitalize the b and the e now with
the data location the default location
is the us multi region but i can simply
click on the drop down and have an
option to store my data in a different
location
but i'm going to keep it at default i
have the option of expiring this table
in either a certain amount of days or to
never expire as well when it comes to
encryption i'm going to leave it as
google manage key as opposed to a
customer manage key and i'll get into
encryption and key management a little
later on in this course i'm going to go
ahead and move right down to the bottom
and click on create data set
and now my data set has been created i
can now see it over here on the left
hand side menu where subtle poet 28400
is the id for my project if i simply
click on the arrow beside it it'll show
my billing export data set because
there's nothing in it nothing is showing
and so now that the data set is set up i
can now go back to the billing export
page and finish setting up my billing
export so with that being said i'm going
to go back up to the navigation menu
head over to billing
and go to billing export under daily
cost detail i'm going to click on edit
settings and because i have a data set
already set up and since it's the only
one it has been propagated in my billing
export data set field if i had more data
sets then i would be able to select them
here as well so i'm going to leave the
data set at billing export
and simply click on save
and so now that billing export has been
enabled i'll be able to check on my
billing as it is updated each day as it
says here and to go right to the data
set i can simply click on this hot link
and it'll bring me right to bigquery and
so there is one last step that still
needs to be done to enable the billing
export to work and that is to enable the
bigquery data transfer service api so in
order to do that we need to go back to
the navigation menu
go into apis and services
into the dashboard
and now i'm going to do a search for the
bigquery data transfer service and i'm
going to simply go up here to the top
search bar
and simply type in bigquery
and here it is bigquery data transfer
api i'm going to simply click on that
and hit enable
and this might take a minute and you may
be asked to create credentials over here
on the top right and you can simply
ignore that as they are not currently
needed and so now that the bigquery data
transfer service api has been enabled
i'm now able to go over to bigquery and
take a look at my billing export data
without any issues now it's going to
take time to propagate but by the time i
come here tomorrow the data will be
fully propagated and i'll be able to
query the data as i see fit and so
although this is a short demo this is
necessary to know for the exam
as well being an engineer and looking to
query your billing data you will now
have the knowledge in order to take the
steps necessary that will allow you to
do so and so that's all i have for this
lesson and demo on export billing data
so you can now mark this lesson as
complete
and let's move on to the next one
welcome back
in this hands-on demo i'm going to go
over apis in google cloud
now the google cloud platform is pretty
much run on apis
whether it's in the console or the sdk
under the hood it's hitting the apis now
some of you may be wondering what is an
api
well this is an acronym standing for
application programming interface and
it's a standard used amongst the
programming community in this specific
context it is the programming interface
for google cloud services
and as i said before both the cloud sdk
and the console are using apis under the
hood and it provides similar
functionality now when using the apis
directly it allows you to enable
automation in your workflow by using the
software libraries that you use for your
favorite programming language now as
seen in previous lessons
to use a cloud api
you must enable it first so if i went to
compute engine or when i was enabling
monitoring
i had to enable the api so no matter the
service you're requesting here in google
cloud and some of them may be even
linked together it always has to be
enabled in order to use it now getting a
little bit more granular when using an
api you need to have a project so when
you enable the api you enable it for
your project
using the permissions on the project and
permissions on the api to enable it now
since this is a demo i want to go over
to the navigation menu and go straight
into apis and services
and so here is the dashboard of the apis
and services you can see the traffic
here the errors and the latency with
regards to these apis as well up here it
has a time frame for the median latency
that you can select for a more granular
search now when it comes to what is
enabled already you can see list here of
the apis that are enabled and since we
haven't done much there's only a few
apis that are enabled now this hands-on
demo is not meant to go into depth with
apis but is merely an overview so that
you understand what the apis are used
for in context with google cloud if
you'd like to go more in depth with
regards to apis and possibly get
certified in it the apogee certification
with its corresponding lessons would be
a great way to get a little bit more
understanding but for this demo we're
going to stick with this overview and so
in order to search for more apis that
need to be enabled or if you're looking
for something specific
you can come up here to enable apis and
services
or you can do a quick search on the
search bar at the top of the page but
just as a quick glance i'm going to go
into enable apis and services and so you
will be brought to a new page where you
will see the api library on the left you
will see a menu where the apis are
categorized and all the apis that are
available when it comes to google cloud
and other google services so as you saw
before when i needed to enable the api
for bigquery
i would simply type in bigquery
and i can go to the api and since the
api is enabled there's nothing for me to
do but if i needed to enable it i could
do that right there and just as a quick
note when going to a service that's
available in the console the api
automatically gets enabled when you go
and use it for the first time and so
again this is just a quick overview of
apis and the api library with regards to
google cloud a short yet important demo
to understand the under workings of the
cloud sdk and the console so just
remember that when using any service in
google cloud
again you must enable the api in order
to start using it and so that about
wraps up this demo for cloud apis so you
can now mark this lesson as complete and
let's move on to the next one
[Music]
welcome back
in this demo i'll be creating and
setting up a new gmail user as an admin
user for use moving ahead in this course
as well as following google's best
practices we need a user that has lesser
privileges than the user account that we
set up previously and i'll be going
through a full demo to show you how to
configure it
now in a google cloud setup that uses a
g suite or cloud identity account a
super administrator account is created
to administer the domain this super
admin account has irrevocable
administrative permissions
that should not be used for day-to-day
administration this means that no
permissions can be taken away from this
account and has the power to grant
organization admin role
or any other role for that matter and
recover accounts at the domain level
which makes this account extremely
powerful now since i do not have a
domain setup or using a g suite or cloud
identity account i don't need to worry
about a super admin account in this
specific environment as gmail accounts
are standalone accounts that are meant
to be personal and hold no organization
and usually start at the project level
and so to explain it in a bit more
detail
i have a diagram here showing the two
different accounts i will be using
and the structure behind it
now as we discussed before billing
accounts have the option of paying for
projects in a different organization so
when creating new projects using the two
different gmail accounts they were
created without any organization and so
each account is standalone and can
create their own projects now what makes
them different is that the antony gcloud
ace account owns the billing account and
is set as a billing account
administrator and the tony bowtie ace
account is a billing account user that
is able to link projects to that billing
account but does not hold full access to
billing
so in the spirit of sticking to the
principle of lease privilege
i will be using the tony bowtie ace
account that i had created earlier with
lesser privileges on billing it will
still give me all the permissions i need
to create edit and delete resources
without all the powerful permissions
needed for billing i will be assigning
this new gmail user the billing account
user role and it will allow you to
achieve everything you need to build for
the remainder of the course
so just as a review i will be using a
new google account that i have created
or if you'd like you can use a
pre-existing google account and as
always i recommend enabling two-step
verification on your account
as this user will hold some powerful
permissions to access a ton of different
resources in google cloud
so now that we've gone over the details
of the what and why for setting up this
second account let's head into the demo
and get things started so whenever
you're ready join me over in the console
and so here i am back in the console and
so before switching over to my new user
i need to assign the specific roles that
i will need for that user which is the
billing account user role so to assign
this role to my new user i need to head
over to billing so i'm going to go back
up here to the left-hand corner
and click on the navigation menu
and go to billing
again in the left-hand menu i'm going to
move down to account management and
click on there and over here under my
billing account you will see that i have
permissions assigned to one member of
the billing account administrator
and as expected i am seeing anthony g
cloud ace
gmail.com and so i want to add another
member to my billing account so i'm
going to simply click on add members and
here i will enter in my new second user
which is tony bowtie ace
gmail.com
and under select a role i'm going to
move down to billing and over to billing
account user and as you can see here
this role billing account user will
allow permissions to associate projects
with billing accounts which is exactly
what i want to do
and so i'm going to simply click on that
and simply click on save
and so now that i've assigned my second
user the proper permissions that i
needed i am now going to log out
and log in as my new user by simply
going up to the right hand corner in the
icon clicking on the icon and going to
add account by adding the account i'll
be able to switch back and forth between
the different users and i would only
recommend this if you are the sole user
of your computer if you are on a
computer that has multiple users simply
sign out and sign back in again with
your different user
and here i'm asked for the email which
would be tony bowtie ace
gmail.com
i'm gonna plug in my password
and it's going to ask me for my two-step
verification
i'm going to click on yes
and i should be in
and because it's my first time logging
into google cloud with this user i get a
prompt asking me to agree to the terms
of service i'm going to agree to them
and simply click on agree and continue
and so now i'm going to move back up to
overview and as you can see here i don't
have the permissions to view costs for
this billing account and so all the
permissions assigned for the billing
account administrator which is antony g
cloud ace is not applied to tony bowtie
ace and therefore things like budgets
and alerts even billing exports i do not
have access to
so moving forward in the course if you
need to access anything in billing that
you currently don't have access to like
budgets and alerts you can simply switch
over to your other account and take care
of any necessary changes but what i do
have access to is if i go up here to my
billing account click on the drop down
menu and click on manage billing
accounts but as you can see here i do
have access to view all the billing
accounts along with the projects that
are linked to them now because these
gmail accounts are standalone accounts
this project here that is owned by
antony gcloud ace i do not have access
to in order to access the project i
would have to have permissions assigned
to me directly in order for me to
actually view the project or possibly
creating any resources within that
project now if i go back to my home page
i can see here that i have no projects
available and therefore no resources
within my environment and so to kick it
off i'm going to create a new project
and so under project name i am going to
call this
project tony
and you can name your project whatever
you'd like
under location i don't have any
organization
and so therefore i'm just going to click
on create
and this may take a minute to
create and here we are with my first
project
named project tony as well as my
notification came up saying that my
project has been created and so now that
this project has been created it should
be linked to my billing account so in
order to verify this i'm going to go
over into billing
and under the drop down
i'm going to click on manage billing
accounts
and as you can see here the number of
projects has gone from one to two and if
i click on the menu up here under my
projects you can see that project tony
is a project that is linked to my
billing account i also have the
permissions to either disable billing or
change billing for this specific project
yet in order to change billing i will
have to have another billing account but
there are no other billing accounts
available
and so moving forward i will only have
this one billing account and so any
projects i decide to create will be
linked to this billing account and so
this is a great example of trimming down
the permissions needed for different
users and even though this is not a
domain owned account but a personal
account it's always recommended to
practice the principle of lease
privilege whenever you come across
assigning permissions to any user now as
i said before any billing related tasks
that you decide to do moving forward
you can simply switch over to your other
user and do the necessary changes and so
that's all i have for this lesson
so you can now mark this lesson as
complete
and let's move on to the next one
[Music]
welcome back
in this short lesson i'm going to be
covering an overview of the cloud sdk
and the command line interface as it is
an essential component of interacting
with google cloud for the exam you will
need to get familiar with the command
line and the commands needed in order to
create
modify and delete resources this is also
an extremely valuable tool for your tool
belt in the world of being a cloud
engineer as i have found that is a very
common and easy way to implement small
operations within google cloud as well
as automating the complex ones so what
exactly is the cloud sdk
well the cloud sdk is a set of command
line tools
that allows you to manage resources
through the terminal in google cloud and
includes commands such as gcloud
gsutil bq and cubectl using these
commands
allow you to manage resources such as
compute engine
cloud storage bigquery kubernetes and so
many other resources these tools can be
run interactively or through automated
scripts giving you the power and
flexibility that you need to get the job
done the cloud sdk is so powerful that
you can do everything that the console
can do yet has more options than the
console you can use it for
infrastructure as code autocompletion
helps you finish all of your command
line statements and for those of you who
run windows the cloud sdk has got you
covered with availability for powershell
now in order to access google cloud
platform you will usually have to
authorize google cloud sdk tools so to
grant authorization to cloud sdk tools
you can either use a user account or a
service account now a user account is a
google account that allows end users to
authenticate directly to your
application for most common use cases on
a single machine using a user account is
best practice now going the route of a
service account this is a google account
that is associated with your gcp project
and not a specific user a service
account can be used by providing a
service account key to your application
and is recommended to script cloud sdk
tools for use on multiple machines now
having installed the cloud sdk it comes
with some built-in commands that allow
you to configure different options using
gcloud init this initializes and
authorizes access and performs other
common cloud sdk setup steps using some
optional commands
gcloud auth login authorizes your access
for gcloud with google user credentials
and sets the current account as active
gcloud config
is another optional configuration that
allows you to configure accounts and
projects as well gcloud components
allow you to install
update and delete
optional components of the sdk that give
you more flexibility with different
resources now after having installed the
cloud sdk almost all gcloud commands
will follow a specific format shown here
is an example of this format and is
broken down through component
entity
operation positional arguments and flags
and i'll be going through some specific
examples in the demonstration a little
bit later on and so that's all i wanted
to cover in this overview of the cloud
sdk and the cli so you can now mark this
lesson as complete and you can join me
in the next one where i go ahead and
demonstrate installing the cloud sdk
[Music]
back in this demonstration i will show
you how to download install and
configure the cloud sdk and i will be
using the quick start guide that lies in
the cloud sdk documentation which holds
all the steps for installing the cloud
sdk on different operating systems and i
will make sure to include it in the
lesson text below this demo will show
you how to install the cloud sdk
on each of the most common operating
systems
windows
mac os and ubuntu linux all you need to
do is follow the process on each of the
pages and you should be well on your way
so with that being said let's get this
demo started and bring the cloud sdk to
life by getting it all installed and
configured for your specific operating
system
so as i explained before i'm gonna go
ahead and install the cloud sdk
on each of the three different operating
systems
windows mac os and ubuntu linux and i
will be installing it with the help of
the quick start guide that you see here
and as i said before i'll be including
this link in the lesson text and so to
kick off this demo i wanted to start by
installing the cloud sdk on windows so
i'm going to move over to my windows
virtual machine and i'm going to open up
a browser and i'm going to paste in the
link for the quick start guide
and you can click on either link for the
quick start for windows and each quick
start page will give me the instructions
of exactly what i need to do for each
operating system so now it says that we
need to have a project created which i
did in the last lesson which is project
tony so next i'm going to download the
cloud sdk installer
so i'm going to click on there
and i'll see a prompt in the bottom left
hand corner that the installer has been
downloaded i'm going to click on it to
open the file and i'm going to be
prompted to go through this wizard and
so i'm just going to click on next
i'm going to agree to the terms of the
agreement it's going to be for just me
anthony and my destination folder i'll
keep it as is and here's all the
components that it's going to install
i'm going to keep the beta commands
unchecked as i don't really need them
and if i need them later then i can
install that component for those who are
more experienced or even a bit curious
you could click on the beta commands and
take it for a test drive but i'm going
to keep it off and i'm going to click
install and depending on the power of
your machine
it should take anywhere from two to five
minutes to install and the google cloud
sdk has been installed and so i'm just
going to click on next and as shown here
in the documentation you want to make
sure that you have all your options
checked off is to create a start menu
shortcut a desktop shortcut you want to
start the google cloud sdk shell and
lastly you want to run gcloud init in
order to initialize and configure the
cloud sdk now i'm going to click on
finish to exit the setup and i'm going
to get a command shell that pops up and
i'm just going to zoom in for better
viewing
and so it says here my current
configuration has been set to default so
when it comes to configuration this is
all about selecting the active account
and so my current active account is
going to be set as the default account
it also needed to do a diagnostic check
just to make sure that it can connect to
the internet so that it's able to verify
the account and so now the prompt is
saying you must log in to continue would
you like to log in yes
you can just click on y and then enter
and it's going to prompt me with a new
browser window where i need to log in
using my current account so that i can
authorize the cloud sdk so i'm going to
log in with my tony bowtie ace account
click on next
type in my password
again it's going to ask me for my
two-step verification
and i'm going to get a prompt saying
that the google sdk wants to access my
google account
i'm going to click on allow
and success you are now authenticated
with the google cloud sdk
and if i go back to my terminal i am
prompted to enter some values
so that i can properly configure the
google cloud sdk so i'm going to pick a
cloud project to use
and i'm going to use project tony that i
created earlier so i'm going to enter 1
and hit enter
and again whatever project that you've
created use that one for your default
configuration and it states here that my
current project has been set to project
tony and again this configuration is
called default
so if i have a second configuration that
i wanted to use i can call it a
different configuration but other than
that my google cloud sdk is configured
and ready to use so just to make sure
that it's working i'm going to run a
couple commands i'm going to run the
gcloud
help
command
and as you can see it's given me a list
of a bunch of different commands that i
can run and to exit you can just hit
ctrl c i'm going to run gcloud
config list
and this will give me
my properties in my active configuration
so my account is tony bowtie ace
gmail.com i've disabled usage reporting
and my project is project tony and my
active configuration is set as default
now don't worry i'm going to be covering
all these commands in the next lesson
and i'm going to be going into detail on
how you can configure and add other
users
within your cloud sdk configuration so
as we go deeper into the course i'm
going to be using a lot more command
line just so you can get familiar with
the syntax and become a bit more
comfortable with it so now that i've
installed the cloud sdk on windows the
process will be a little bit different
when it comes to installation on the
other operating systems but will be very
similar when it comes to the
configuration so now let's head over to
mac os and install the cloud sdk there
and so here we are in mac os and so the
first thing i want to do is i want to
open up a web browser and i want to go
to the cloud sdk quick start page so i'm
just going to paste in the url here
and we're looking for the quick start
for mac os and so you can either click
on the menu from the left hand side or
the menu here on the main page
and so like i said before
this installation is going to be a
little bit different than what it was in
windows and so there's a few steps here
to follow and so the first step asks us
if we have a project already created
which we've already done and is project
tony and so the next step tells us that
the cloud sdk
requires python and so we want to check
our system to see if we have a supported
version so in order to check our version
we're going to use this command here
python minus v
and i'm going to copy that to my
clipboard
and then open up a terminal and i'm
going to zoom in for better viewing and
so i'm going to paste the command in
here
and simply click on enter and as you can
see here i'm running python 2.7
but the starred note here says that the
cloud sdk will soon move to python 3 and
so in order to avoid having to upgrade
later you'd want to check your version
for python 3 and so you can use a
similar command by typing in python 3
space minus capital v
and as you can see i'm running version
3.7.3
and so moving back to the guide i can
see here that it is a supportive version
if you do not have a supportive version
i will include a link on how to upgrade
your version
in the lesson text below and so now that
i've finished off this step let's move
on to the next one
where i can download the archive file
for the google cloud sdk again most
machines will run the 64-bit package so
if you do have the latest operating
system for mac os
you should be good to go so i'm going to
click on this package
and it'll start downloading for me and
once it's finished you can click on
downloads and click on the file itself
and it should extract itself in the same
folder with all the files and folders
within it and so just as another quick
note google prefers that you keep the
google cloud sdk in your home directory
and so following the guide i'm going to
do exactly that and so the easiest way
to move the folder into your home
directory is to simply drag and drop it
into the home folder
on the left hand menu it should be
marked with a little house icon and
nested under favorites i can now move
into my home folder and confirm that it
is indeed in here and so now moving to
the last step which shows as optional
the guide asks us to install a script to
add cloud sdk tools to our path now i
highly recommend that you install this
script so that you can add the tools for
command completion and i will get into
command completion a little bit later on
in the next couple of lessons and so
here is the command that i need to run
so i'm going to copy that to my
clipboard again and i'm going to move
back over to my terminal i'm going to
clear my screen and so to make sure i'm
in my home directory where the cloud sdk
folder is i'm going to simply type ls
and so for those who don't know
ls is a linux command that will list all
your files and folders in your current
path and as you can see here the google
cloud sdk is in my path and therefore i
can run that script so i'm going to
paste it in here
and i'm going to hit enter
and so a prompt comes up asking me
whether or not i want to disable usage
reporting and because i want to help
improve the google cloud sdk i'm going
to type in y for yes and hit enter and
so as i was explaining before
the cloud sdk tools will be installed in
my path and so this is the step that
takes care of it and so i'm going to
type y
and enter
for yes to continue and usually the path
that comes up is the right one unless
you've changed it otherwise so i'm going
to leave this blank and just hit enter
and that's it i've installed the tools
so now in order for me to run gcloud
init i have to start a new shell as it
says here for the changes to take effect
so i'm going to go up here to the top
left hand menu click on terminal and
quit terminal and so now i can restart
the terminal
again i'm going to zoom in for better
viewing
and now i'm able to run gcloud init in
order to initialize the installation
again the prompt to do the diagnostic
tests and i can see i have no network
issues but it shows me that i have to
login to continue i would like to log in
so i'm going to type y for yes and hit
enter
and so a new browser has popped open
prompting me to enter my email and
password and so i'm going to do that now
i'm going to authorize my account with
two-step verification
i'm not going to save this password and
yes i want to allow the google cloud sdk
to access my google account
so i'm going to click on allow
and it shows that i've been
authenticated so now i'm going to move
back to my terminal and so just as a
note before we move forward in case you
don't get a browser pop-up for you to
log into your google account you can
simply highlight this url copy it into
your browser and it should prompt you
just the same so moving right ahead it
shows that i'm logged in as
tonybowtieace
gmail.com which is exactly what i wanted
and it's asking me to pick a cloud
project to use now i want to use project
tony so i'm going to type in 1 and enter
and that's it the cloud sdk has been
configured and just to double check i'm
going to run the gcloud
config list command to show me my
configuration and as you can see here my
account is tonybowties
gmail.com my disable usage reporting is
equal to false
and my project is project tony and again
my active configuration is set as
default and so that about covers the
cloud sdk install for mac os and so
finally i'm going to move over to ubuntu
linux and configure the cloud sdk there
and so here we are in ubuntu and like i
did in the other operating systems i'm
going to open up the browser and i'm
going to paste in the url for the quick
start guide
and so we want to click on the quick
start for debian and ubuntu and so again
you have your choice from either
clicking on the link on the left hand
menu or the one here in the main menu
and so following the guide
it is telling us that when it comes to
an ubuntu release it is recommended that
the sdk should be installed on an ubuntu
release that has not reached end of life
the guide also asks to create a project
if we don't have one already which we
have already done
and so now we can continue on with the
steps and so since we are not installing
it inside a docker image we're gonna go
ahead and use the commands right here
now you can copy all the commands at
once
by copying this to the clipboard but my
recommendation is to install each one
one by one so i'm going to copy this
and i'm going to open up my terminal i'm
going to zoom in for better viewing and
i'm going to paste that command in and
click on enter it's going to prompt me
for my password
and it didn't come up with any errors so
that means it was successfully executed
and so i'm going to move on to the next
command
i'm going to copy this
go back over to my terminal
and paste it in
now for those of you who do not have
curl installed you will be prompted to
install it and given the command to run
it so i'm going to copy and paste this
command
and click on enter
i'm going to type in y for yes to
continue and it's going to install it
after a couple of minutes okay now that
curl has been installed i'm able to run
that command again i'm going to clear
the screen first
and that executed with no errors as well
and so now moving on to the last command
this command will download and install
the google cloud sdk
i am prompted to install some packages
and so i'm going to type y for yes to
continue so now it's going to download
and install the necessary packages
needed for the google cloud sdk and
depending on the speed of your internet
and the speed of your machine this could
take anywhere from two to five minutes
okay and the google cloud sdk has been
installed
and so now that the cloud sdk has been
installed we can now initialize the
configuration
so i'm going to type in gcloud init
again the prompt with the network
diagnostics i'm going to type y for yes
to log in
and i'm going to get the prompt for my
email and password
i'm going to take care of my two-step
verification and i'm going to allow the
google cloud sdk to access my google
account and success i am now
authenticated and moving back to the
terminal just to verify it and again i'm
going to pick project tony as the cloud
project to use
and the cloud sdk has been configured as
always i'm going to do a double check by
running a gcloud config list
and as expected the same details has
come up and so this is a quick run
through on all three operating systems
windows mac os and ubuntu linux on how
to install the google cloud sdk and this
will help you get started with becoming
more familiar and more comfortable using
the command line interface and so that
about wraps up for this lesson
so you can now mark this lesson as
complete
and let's move on to the next one
[Music]
welcome back in the last demo we went
through a complete install of the cloud
sdk
and configured our admin account to be
used within it in this demonstration i
will be walking through how to manage
the cloud sdk and this will involve how
to utilize it and how to customize it to
your environment as well as configuring
our other user account so that we are
able to apply switching configurations
from one user to another and so i will
be going through initializing and
authorization
configurations and properties installing
and removing components as well as a
full run through of the gcloud
interactive shell so let's kick off this
demo by diving into a pre-configured
terminal with the sdk installed and
configured with my second user tony
bowtie ace gmail.com
and so here i am in the mac os terminal
and just be aware that it doesn't matter
which operating system you're running as
long as the sdk is installed and you
have your user configured and so as you
saw in the last lesson after you install
the cloud sdk the next step is typically
to initialize the cloud sdk
by running the gcloud init command and
this is to perform the initial setup
tasks as well as authorizing the cloud
sdk to use your user account credentials
so that it can access google cloud and
so in short it sets up a cloud sdk
configuration and sets a base set of
properties and this usually covers the
active account the current project and
if the api is enabled the default google
compute engine region and zone now as a
note if you're in a remote terminal
session with no access to a browser you
can still run the gcloud init command
but adding a flag of dash dash console
dash only
and this will prevent the command from
launching a browser-based authorization
like you saw when setting up your last
user so now even though i have a user
already set up i can still run gcloud
init and it will give me a couple
different options to choose from so i
can re-initialize this configuration
with some new settings or i can create a
new configuration now for this demo
since we already have two users and to
demonstrate how to switch between
different users i want to create a new
configuration with my very first user so
i'm going to type in 2 and hit enter and
it's going to ask me for a configuration
name now it asks me for a configuration
name because when setting up your first
configuration it's set as default and
because i know that this user account
has full access to billing as well as
administration privileges i'm going to
call this configuration master and i'm
going to hit enter
it did the necessary network checks and
now it's asking me for which account i
want to use this configuration for now
if tony bowtie ace had access to two
different google cloud accounts i would
be able to add a different configuration
here and so because i'm going to log in
with a new account i'm going to put in
two
and hit enter
and so again it brought me to my browser
window and i'm going to log in using
another account
and so here you can type in the first
account that you created and for me it
was antony gcloud ace gmail.com
i hit next and i'm going to enter my
password
it's going to ask me for my two-step
verification
and i don't want to save this password
and i'm going to allow the google cloud
sdk to access my google account and i am
now authenticated so moving back to the
console you can see here that i am
currently logged in and it's asking me
to pick a cloud project to use now since
i only have one project in that google
cloud account which is subtle poet i'm
going to choose one
and since i have the compute engine api
enabled i am now able to configure a
default compute region and zone and so
i'm going to hit y for yes to configure
it and as you can see there are 74
different options to choose from and if
you scroll up a little bit you should be
able to find the zone that you're
looking for and so for this course we
are going to be using us central one
dash a and so this is number eight so
i'm going to scroll back down
and type in eight
and so now my master configuration has
been configured with my antony g cloud
ace account using us central 1a as the
compute engine zone now touching back on
authorization if i didn't want to set up
a whole configuration i can simply type
in gcloud
auth login
and this will allow me to authorize just
the user account only so gcloud init
would authorize access and perform the
cloud sdk setup steps and gcloud auth
login will authorize the access only now
as i mentioned in a previous lesson you
can use a service account for
authorization to the cloud sdk tools and
this would be great for a compute
instance or an application but would
need a service account key file in order
to authorize it and so moving back to
our user accounts when running the cloud
sdk you can only have one active account
at any given time and so to check my
active account i can type in the command
gcloud auth list
and this will give me a list of all the
accounts that have been authorized and
so whenever you run a gcloud init it
will use that account as the active
account and as you can see here the
antony gcloud ace gmail.com has a star
beside it and this is marked as the
active account and so in essence the
account with the star beside it is the
active account and so i'm looking to
change my active account back to tony
bowtie ace and in order for me to do
that the command is conveniently shown
here and so i'm going to go ahead and
run that
and the account would be the user shown
above and so when i do a gcloud auth
list
i can see that my active account is now
back to tony bowtie bowtieace gmail.com
now if you wanted to switch the account
on a per command basis you can always do
that using the flag dash dash account
after the command and put in the user
account that you want to use and so
let's say i wanted to revoke credentials
from an account that i don't need
anymore i can simply use the command
gcloud auth revoke
followed by the username and it will
revoke the credentials for that account
and so doing this
would remove your credentials and any
access tokens for any specific account
that you choose that's currently on your
computer and so if we're looking for
that specific account we can always use
the gcloud info command and it will give
us the path for the user config
directory and it is this directory that
holds your encrypted credentials and
access tokens
alongside with your active
configurations and any other
configurations as well now as you can
see here running the gcloud info command
will also give you some other
information everything from the account
the project the current properties and
where the logs can be found so now
moving on to configurations
a configuration is a named set of gcloud
cli properties
and it works kind of like a profile and
so earlier on i demonstrated how to set
up another configuration through gcloud
init so now if i run a gcloud config
list command it would give me all the
information of the active configuration
so as you can see here my user has
changed but my configuration has stayed
the same now as seen previously in a
different lesson tony bow tie ace does
not have access to the project subtle
poet this project belongs to antony g
cloud ace and the configuration was set
for that account now if tony bowtie ace
did have access to the subtle poet
project then i could use this
configuration but it doesn't and so i
want to switch back to my other
configuration and how i would do this is
type in the command
gcloud config configurations
activate and the configuration that i
set up for tony bowtie ace is the
default configuration
and so now that it has been activated i
can now run a gcloud config list and as
you can see here the configuration is
back to default setup during the
initialization process for tony bowtie
ace now if i wanted to create multiple
configurations for the same user account
i can simply type in the command gcloud
config configurations
create
but if i wanted to just view the
configuration properties i can always
type in the command gcloud config
configurations describe
and as you can see after the describe i
needed the configuration name to
complete the command and so i'm going to
do that now
and i've been given all the properties
for this configuration now another thing
that i wanted to share when it comes to
properties is that you can change the
project or the compute region and zone
by simply typing in the command
gcloud config set now if i wanted to
change the project i can simply type in
project and the project name if it was
for the compute instance i can simply
type in compute
forward slash zone for the specific zone
and just as a note only the properties
that are not in the core property
section are the ones that can be set as
well when you are setting the properties
this only applies to the active
configuration if you want to change the
configuration of one that is not active
then you'd have to switch to it and run
the gcloud config set command and so
moving on i wanted to touch on
components which are the installable
parts of the sdk and when you install
the sdk the components gcloud bq gsutil
and the core libraries are installed by
default now you probably saw a list of
components when you ran the gcloud init
command and so to see all the components
again you can simply type in the gcloud
components
list command
and if you scroll up you're able to see
all the components that are available
that you can install at your convenience
and so if i wanted to install the
cubectl component i can type in the
command gcloud components install
cubectl and a prompt will come up asking
me if i want to continue with this i
want to say yes and now it will go
through the process of installing these
components
and so just to verify if i run the
command gcloud components list you can
see here that i have the cube ctl
component installed now if i wanted to
remove that component i can simply type
in
gcloud components
remove
and then the component that i want to
which is cubectl i'm going to be
prompted if i want to do this i'm going
to say yes and it's going to go through
the stages of removing this component
and it's been successfully uninstalled
and so if you're working with a resource
that you need a component for you can
simply install or uninstall it using the
gcloud components command and so one
last thing about components before we
move on
is that you can update your components
to make sure you have the latest version
and so in order to update all of your
installed components you would simply
run the command gcloud components update
and so before i go ahead and finish off
this demonstration i wanted to touch on
the gcloud interactive shell the gcloud
interactive shell provides a richer
shell experience simplifying commands
and documentation discovery with as you
type autocompletion and help text
snippets below it produces suggestions
and autocompletion for gcloud bq gsutil
and cubectl command line tools as well
as any command that has a man page sub
commands and flags can be completed
along with online help as you type the
command and because this is part of the
beta component i need to install it and
so i'm going to run the command gcloud
components install beta and i want to
hit yes to continue and this will go
ahead and kick off the installation of
the gcloud beta commands
and so now that it's installed i'm going
to simply clear the screen and so now in
order to run the gcloud interactive
shell i need to run the command gcloud
beta
interactive
and so now for every command that i type
i will get auto suggestions that will
help me with my commands and so to see
it in all of its glory i'm going to
start typing
and as you can see it's giving me the
option between g cloud or gsutil and i
can use the arrow to choose either one
and below it it'll also show me the
different flags that i can use for these
specific commands and how to structure
them and so for now i'm going to run
gsutil version
minus l and as you can see here it's
giving me all the information about this
command and what it can do and so i'm
going to hit enter
and as you can see my gsutil version is
4.52
and along with the version number i'm
also given all the specific information
with regards to this gsutil version and
this can be used with absolutely any
command used on the google cloud
platform and so i'm going to go ahead
and do that again but running a
different command so i'm just going to
first clear the screen and i'm going to
type gcloud
compute
instances and as you can see the snippet
on the bottom of the screen is showing
me not only the command and how it's
structured but also the url for the
documentation so continuing on gcloud
compute instances i'm going to do a list
and i'm going to filter it by using the
flag dash dash filter and i'm going to
filter the us east one a zone and i'm
going to hit enter
and as expected there are no instances
in us east 1a and as you've just
experienced this is a great tool and i
highly recommend that you use it
whenever you can now i know this is a
lot to take in
and a lot of these commands will not
show up on the exam but again getting
comfortable with the command line and
the sdk will help you on your path to
becoming a cloud engineer as well it
will help you get really comfortable
with the command line and before you
know it you'll be running commands in
the command line and prefer it over
using the console and so that's all i
have for this demo on managing the cloud
sdk so you can now mark this lesson as
complete and let's move on to the next
one
welcome back in this demonstration i'm
going to be talking about the always
available browser-based shell called
cloud shell cloud shell is a virtual
machine that is loaded with development
tools and offers a persistent five
gigabyte home directory that runs on
google cloud cloud shell is what
provides you command line access to your
google cloud resources within the
console cloud shell also comes with a
built-in code editor that i will be
diving into and allows you to browse
file directories as well as view and
edit files while still accessing the
cloud shell the code editor is available
by default with every cloud shell
instance and is based on the open source
editor thea
now cloud shell is available from
anywhere in the console by merely
clicking on the icon showed here in the
picture
and is positioned in the top right hand
corner of the console in the blue
toolbar so let's get started with the
cloud shell by getting our hands dirty
and jumping right into it
and so here we are back in the console
and i am logged in as tony bowtie ace
gmail.com and as you can see up here in
the right hand corner
as mentioned earlier you will find the
cloud shell logo and so to open it up
you simply click on it and it'll
activate the cloud shell here at the
bottom and because it's my first time
using cloud shell i'll get this prompt
quickly explaining an overview of what
cloud shell is and i'm going to simply
hit continue
and i'm going to make the terminal a
little bit bigger by dragging this line
up to the middle of the screen and so
when you start cloud shell it provisions
an e2 small
google compute engine instance running a
debian-based linux operating system now
this is an ephemeral pre-configured vm
and the environment you work with is a
docker container running on that vm
cloud shell instances are provisioned on
a per user per session basis the
instance persists while your cloud shell
session is active and after an hour of
inactivity your session terminates and
the vm is discarded you can also
customize your environment automatically
on boot time and it will allow you to
have your preferred tools when cloud
shell boots up so when your cloud shell
instance is provision it's provisioned
with 5 gigabytes of free persistent disk
storage and it's mounted at your home
directory on the virtual machine
instance and you can check your disk
storage by simply typing in the command
df minus h and here where it shows dev
disk by id google home part one it shows
here the size as 4.8 gigabytes and this
would be the persistent disk storage
that's mounted on your home directory
now if you've noticed it shows here that
i'm logged in as tony bowtie ace at
cloud shell and that my project id is
set at project tony so the great thing
about cloud shell
is that you're automatically
authenticated as the google account
you're logged in with so here you can
see i'm logged in as tony bowtie ace and
so picture it like running gcloud auth
login and specifying your google account
but without having to actually do it now
when the cloud shell is started the
active project in the console is
propagated to your gcloud configuration
inside cloud shell so as you can see
here my project is set at project tony
now if i wanted to change it to a
different project i could simply use the
command stated up here
gcloud config set project along with the
project id and this will change me to a
different project now behind the scenes
cloud shell is globally distributed
across multiple regions so when you
first connect to cloud shell you'll be
automatically assigned to the closest
available region and thus avoiding
any unnecessary latency you do not have
the option to choose your own region and
so cloud shell does that for you by
optimizing it to migrate to a closer
region whenever it can so if you're ever
curious where your cloud shell session
is currently active
you can simply type in this command
curl metadata slash compute metadata
slash version one slash instance slash
zone
and this will give me the zone where my
instance is located and as shown here it
is in us east 1b now as you've probably
been seeing every time i highlight
something that there is a picture of
scissors coming up the cloud shell has
some automated and available tools that
are built in and so one of those
available tools is that whenever i
highlight something it will
automatically copy it to the clipboard
for me cloud shell also has a bunch of
very powerful pre-installed tools that
come with it such as the cloud sdk bash
vim helm
git
docker and more as well cloud shell has
support for a lot of major different
programming languages like java go
python node.js
ruby and net core for those who run
windows now if you're looking for an
available tool that is not pre-installed
you can actually customize your
environment when your instance boots up
and automatically run a script that will
install the tool of your choice and the
script runs as root and you can install
any package that you please and so in
order for this environment customization
to work there needs to be a file labeled
as dot customize underscore environment
now if we do an ls here you can see that
all we have is the readme dash cloud
shell text file if we do ls space minus
al to show all the hidden files as well
you can see that the dot customize
underscore environment file does not
exist and this is because we need to
create it ourselves and so for this
example i want terraform installed as an
available tool when my instance boots up
and so i have to create this file so i'm
going to do so by using the touch
command and then the name of the file
dot customize
underscore environment hit enter and if
i clear the screen and do another ls
space minus al i can see that my dot
customize underscore environment file
has been created and so now i'm going to
need the script to install terraform
which means i would have to edit it and
so another great feature of cloud shell
is that it comes with a code editor and
i can do it one of two ways i can either
come up here and click on the open
editor button which will open up a new
tab or i can simply use the edit command
with the file name and i'm going to do
just that so edit
dot customize underscore environment and
i'm just going to hit enter and as you
can see i got a prompt saying that it's
unable to load the code editor and this
is because when using code editor you
need cookies enabled on your browser and
because i am using a private browser
session cookies are disabled and because
my cloud shell environment persists i'm
going to open up a regular browser
window and i'm going to continue where i
left off and so here i am back with a
new browser window again logged in as
tony bowtie ace and so just to show you
the persistence that happens in cloud
shell i'm going to run the command ls
space minus al and as you can see here
the customize environment is still here
and so again i wanted to install
terraform as an extra tool to have in my
environment and so i'm going to open up
the editor by typing in edit dot
customize underscore environment and i'm
going to hit enter and here is the
editor that popped up
as you can see here it's built with
eclipse thea and this is an open source
code editor that you can download from
eclipse and this is what the editor is
built on now this menu here on the left
i can make it a little bit bigger and
because the only viewable file on my
persistent disk is the readme cloud
shell dot text file i'm not able to see
my dot customize underscore environment
so in order to open it and edit it i'm
going to go to the menu at the top of
the editor and click on file open
and here i'll be able to select the file
that i need so i'm going to select
customize environment and click on open
and so i'm going to paste in my script
to install terraform and i'm just going
to paste in my script from my clipboard
and i'll be including the script in the
github repo for those of you who use
terraform and i'm going to move over to
the menu on the left click on file and
then hit save and so now in order for me
to allow this to work
the customize environment needs to be
loaded into my cloud shell so i'm going
to have to restart it and so in order to
accomplish this i'm going to move over
to the menu on the right i'm going to
click on the icon with the three dots
and click on restart and you'll be
presented with a prompt it's saying that
it will immediately terminate my session
and then a new vm will be provisioned
for me and you'll also be presented with
an optional response from google telling
them why you're restarting the vm and
this is merely for statistical purposes
so i'm going to click on restart and i'm
going to wait till a new cloud shell is
provisioned and my new cloud shell is
provisioned and up and running and so i
want to double check to see if terraform
has been installed so i'm going to go
over here to the open terminal button on
the right hand side toolbar and i'm
going to move back to my terminal and
i'm going to simply run the command
terraform dash dash version
and so it looks like terraform has been
installed and as you can see i'm running
version.12 but it says my terraform
version is out of date and that the
latest version is dot 13. and so because
i really want to be up to date with
terraform i want to be able to go into
my customize environment file and edit
my version of terraform so that when my
cloud shell is initiated
terraform.13 can be installed and so i'm
going to simply type in the command edit
dot customize underscore environment and
i'm back to my editor and i'm going to
change the terraform version from dot 12
to dot 13 and then go over here to the
left-hand menu click on file and then
save and now i'm going to restart my
machine again
and come back when it's fully
provisioned and i'm back again my
machine has been provisioned and i'm
going to go back to my terminal by
clicking on the open terminal button and
so i'm going to type in the command
terraform dash dash version and as you
can see i'm at version dot 13 and i'm
going to run a simple terraform command
to see if it's working and as you can
see i am successful in running terraform
on cloud shell now customizing the
environment is not on the exam but it is
such an amazing feature that i wanted to
highlight it for you with a real world
example like terraform in case you're
away from your computer
and you're logged into a browser and you
need some special tools to use in cloud
shell this is the best way to do it now
as i mentioned before the cloud sdk is
pre-installed on this and so everything
that i've showed you in the last lesson
with regards to cloud sdk can be done in
the cloud shell as well so if i run the
command gcloud
beta interactive i'd be able to bring up
the interactive cloud shell and i'll be
able to run the same commands so now if
i go ahead and run the command
gcloud components list i'll be able to
see all the components installed and as
you can see with the cloud shell there
are more components installed than
what's installed on the default
installation of the sdk i can also run
the gcloud config list command to see
all the properties in my active
configuration and so this goes to show
you that the sdk installation that's on
cloud shell is just as capable as the
one that you've installed on your
computer the only difference here is
that the sdk along with all the other
tools that come installed in cloud shell
is updated every week and so you can
always depend that they're up to date
and so moving on to a few more features
of cloud shell i wanted to point out the
obvious ones
up here in the cloud shell toolbar right
beside the open terminal i can open
brand new tabs opening up different
projects
or even the same project
but just a different terminal and moving
over to the right hand menu of cloud
shell this keyboard icon can send key
combinations that you would normally not
have access to moving on to the gear
icon with this you're able to change
your preferences
and looking at the first item on the
list when it comes to color themes you
can go from a dark theme to a light
theme or if you prefer a different color
in my case i prefer the dark theme
as well you have the options of changing
your text size we can go to largest
but i think we'll just keep things back
down to medium and as well
we have
the different fonts the copy settings
from which i showed you earlier as well
as keyboard preferences you also have
the option of showing your scroll bar
now moving on to this icon right beside
the gear
is the web preview button and so the web
preview button is designed so that you
can run any web application that listens
to http requests on the cloud shell and
be able to view it in a new web browser
tab when running these web applications
web preview also supports applications
run in app engine now mind you these
ports are only available to the secure
cloud shell proxy service which
restricts access over https to your user
account only and so to demonstrate this
feature i am going to run a simple http
server running a hello world page so
first i'm going to clear my screen and
then i'm going to exit the interactive
shell and again i'm going to paste in
for my clipboard a simple script that
will run my simple http server and as
you can see it's running on port 8080
and now i'm able to click on the web
preview button and i'm able to preview
it on port 8080
and a new web browser tab will open up
and here i'll see my hello world page
now this is just a simple example and so
i'm sure that many of you can find great
use for this and so i'm going to stop
this http server now by hitting ctrl c
and just as a quick note web preview can
also run on a different port anywhere
from port 2000
all the way up to 65 000. now moving on
to the rest of the features
hitting on the more button here with the
three dots starting from the top we
covered restart earlier when we had to
restart our cloud shell you're able to
both upload and download a file within
cloud shell when the demands are needed
as well if i have a misconfigured
configuration i can boot into safe mode
and fix the issue instead of having to
start from scratch again moving on to
boost cloud shell also known as boost
mode is a feature that increases your
cloud shell vm from the default e2 small
to an e2 medium so in essence a memory
bump from 2 gigabytes to 4 gigabytes and
once it's activated all your sessions
will be boosted for the next 24 hours
and just as a quick note
enabling boost mode restarts your cloud
shell and immediately terminates your
session but don't worry the data in your
home directory will persist but any of
the processes that you are running will
be lost now when it comes to usage quota
cloud shell has a 50 hour weekly usage
limit so if you reach your usage limit
you'll need to wait until your quota is
reset before you can use cloud shell
again so it's always good to keep your
eyes on this in case you're a heavy user
of cloud shell
and moving back to the menu again you
have your usage statistics which
collects statistics on commands that
come pre-installed in the vm and you can
turn them on or off
and as well help for cloud shell is
available here as well if you wanted to
give feedback to the google cloud team
with regards to cloud shell this is the
place to do it and so one last thing
about cloud shell before we end this
demo is that if you do not access cloud
shell for 120 days your home disk will
be deleted now don't worry you'll
receive an email notification before its
deletion and if you just log in and
start up a session you'll prevent it
being removed now moving ahead in this
course i will be using cloud shell quite
a bit and so feel free to use either
cloud shell or the cloud sdk installed
on your computer or feel free to follow
along with me in the cloud shell within
your google cloud environment and so if
you are following along please make sure
that you keep an eye on your quota and
so i hope this demonstration has given
you some really good insight as to what
you can do with cloud shell and its
limitations and so that's pretty much
all i wanted to cover in this
demonstration of cloud shell so you can
now mark this as complete and let's move
on to the next one
[Music]
welcome back in this lesson and
demonstration i am going to go over
limits and quotas and how they affect
your cloud usage within google cloud i'm
going to quickly go over some theory
followed by a demonstration on where to
find the quotas and how to edit them
accordingly so google cloud enforces
quotas on resource usage for project
owners
setting a hard limit on how much of a
particular google cloud resource your
project can use and so there are two
types of resource usage that google
limits with quota the first one is rate
quota such as api requests per day this
quota resets after a specified time such
as a minute or a day the second one is
allocation quota
an example is the number of virtual
machines or load balancers used by your
project
and this quota does not reset over time
but must be explicitly released when you
no longer want to use the resource
for example by deleting a gke cluster
now quotas are enforced for a variety of
reasons
for example they protect other google
cloud users by preventing unforeseen
usage spikes
quotas also help with resource
management so you can set your own
limits on service usage within your
quota while developing and testing your
applications
each quota limit is expressed in terms
of a particular countable resource from
requests per day to an api to the number
of load balancers used by your
application not all projects have the
same quotas for the same services and so
using this free trial account you may
have very limited quota compared to a
higher quota on a regular account as
well with your use of google cloud over
time your quotas may increase
accordingly and so you can also request
more quota if you need it and set up
monitoring and alerts
and cloud monitoring to warn you about
unusual quota usage behavior or when
you're actually running out of quota now
in addition to viewing basic quota
information in the console
google cloud lets you monitor quota
usage
limits and errors in greater depth using
the cloud monitoring api and ui along
with quota metrics appearing in the
metrics explorer you can then use these
metrics to create custom dashboards and
alerts
letting you monitor quota usage over
time
and receive alerts when for example
you're near a quota limit only your
services that support quota metrics are
displayed and so popular supported
services include compute engine
data flow
cloud spanner cloud monitoring and cloud
logging common services that are not
supported include app engine cloud
storage and cloud sql now as a note be
aware that quota limits are updated once
a day
and hence new limits may take up to 24
hours to be reflected in the google
cloud console if your project exceeds a
particular quota while using a service
the platform will return an error
in general
google cloud will return an http
429 error code if you're using http or
rest to access the service
or resource exhausted if you're using
grpc if you're using cloud monitoring
you can use it to identify the quota
associated with the error
and then create custom alerts upon
getting a quota error and we will be
going into greater depth with regards to
monitoring later on in the course now
there are two ways to view your current
quota limits in the google cloud console
the first is using the quotas page which
gives you a list of all of your
project's quota usage and limits the
second is using the api dashboard which
gives you the quota information for a
particular api
including resource usage over time quota
limits are also accessible
programmatically through the service
usage api and so let's head into the
console where i will provide a
demonstration
on where to look for quotas
and how to increase them when you need
to
and so here we are back in the console
and so as i explained before there are
two main ways to view your current quota
limits
in the console and so the first one is
using the quotas page and so in order to
get to the quotas page i need to go to
iam so i'm going to do that now by going
up to the navigation menu in the top
left hand corner
i'm going to go to i am and admin and
over to quotas
and so here i am shown all the quotas of
the current apis that i have enabled as
you can see here it shows me the service
the limit name
the quota status and the details in this
panel here on the right hand side shows
me a little bit more information with
regards to the service and the quota
itself and so let's say i wanted to
increase my quota on the compute engine
api
within networks so i'm going to select
this service and over here on the right
hand panel i'm going to tick the box
that says global and i'm going to go
back over here to the top left
and click on the edit quotas button and
a panel will pop up and i am prompted to
enter a new quota limit
along with a description explaining to
google why i need this quota limit
increase and so once i've completed my
request
i can click on done and then submit
request and like i said before once the
request has been submitted it will go to
somebody at google to evaluate the
requests for approval and don't worry
these quota limit increases are usually
approved within two business days and
can often times be sooner than that also
a great way to enter multiple quota
changes is to click on the selected apis
let's do bigquery api
and cloud data store api and so i've
clicked off three and now i can go back
up to the top and click on the edit
quotas button and as you can see in the
panel i have all three apis that i want
to increase my quotas on so i can enter
all my new limit requests for each api
and then i can submit it as a bulk
request with all my new quota limit
changes and so doing it this way would
increase the efficiency
instead of increasing the quotas for
each service one by one and because i'm
not going to submit any quota changes
i'm going to close this panel and so
again using the quotas page will give
you a list of all your project quota
usage and its limits and allow you to
request changes accordingly and so now
moving on to the second way which you
can view your current quota limits i'm
going to go to the api dashboard which
will give me a more granular view
including the resource usage over time
so to get there i'm going to go back up
to the left hand side to the navigation
menu i'm going to go to apis and
services and click on dashboard
and here i will see all the names of the
apis and i'm going to click on compute
engine api for this demonstration
and over here on the left hand menu you
will see quotas
and in here as i said before
you can get some really granular data
with regards to queries read requests
list requests and a whole bunch of other
requests i'm going to drill down into
queries here and i can see my queries
per day per 100 seconds per user and per
100 seconds and i can see here that my
queries per 100 seconds is at a limit of
2 000 so if i wanted to increase that
limit i can simply click on the pencil
icon
and a panel on the right hand side will
prompt me to enter a new quota limit but
i currently see that my quota limit is
at its maximum and that i need to apply
for a higher quota so when i click on
the link it will bring me back to my iam
page where my services are filtered and
i can easily find the service that i was
looking at to raise my quota limit and i
can increase the quota by checking off
this box and clicking on the edit quotas
button at the top of the page and so as
you can see the quotas page as well as
the api dashboard work in tandem so that
you can get all the information you need
with regards to quotas and limits and to
edit them accordingly and so i hope this
gave you a good idea and some great
insight
on how you can view and edit your quotas
and quota limits according to the
resources you use and so that about
wraps up this brief yet important demo
on limits and quotas so you can now mark
this as complete and let's move on to
the next section
[Music]
welcome back
and in this section we're going to be
going through in my opinion one of the
most important services in google cloud
identity and access management also
known as iam for short and i'll be
diving into identities roles and the
architecture of policies that will give
you a very good understanding of how
permissions are granted and how policies
are inherited so before i jump into i am
i wanted to touch on the principle of
least privilege just for a second now
the principle of least privilege states
that a user program or process
should have access to the bare minimum
privileges necessary
or the exact resources it needs in order
to perform its function so for example
if lisa is performing a create function
to a cloud storage bucket
lisa should be restricted to create
permissions only on exactly one cloud
storage bucket
she doesn't need read edit or even
delete permissions on a cloud storage
bucket to perform her job and so this is
a great illustration of how this
principle works
and this is something that happens in
not only google cloud but in every cloud
environment as well as any on-premises
environment so note that the principle
of least privilege is something that i
have previously and will continue to be
talking about a lot in this course and
this is a key term that comes up quite a
bit
in any major exam
and is a rule that most apply in their
working environment to avoid any
unnecessary granted permissions a
well-known and unsaid rule when it comes
to security hence me wanting to touch on
this for a brief moment so now with that
out of the way i'd like to move on to
identity and access management or i am
for short so what is it really well with
iam you manage access control by
defining who the identity
has what access which is the role for
which resource and this also includes
organizations
folders and projects
in iam permission to access a resource
isn't granted directly to the end user
instead permissions are grouped into
roles and roles are then granted to
authenticated members an iam policy
defines and enforces what roles are
granted to which members
and this policy is attached to a
resource so when an authenticated member
attempts to access a resource iam checks
the resources policy to determine
whether the action is permitted and so
with that being said i want to dive into
the policy architecture breaking it down
by means of components in this policy
architecture will give you a better
understanding of how policies are put
together so now what is a policy a
policy is a collection of bindings audit
configuration and metadata now the
binding specifies how access should be
granted on resources
and it binds one or more members with a
single role and any contact specific
conditions that change how and when the
role is granted now the metadata
includes additional information about
the policy such as an etag and version
to facilitate policy management and
finally the audit config field specifies
the configuration data of how access
attempts should be audited and so now i
wanted to take a moment to dive deeper
into each component starting with member
now when it comes to members this is an
identity that can access a resource
so the identity of a member is an email
address associated with a user
service account or google group or even
a domain name associated with a g suite
or cloud identity domains now when it
comes to a google account this
represents any person who interacts with
google cloud any email address that is
associated with a google account can be
an identity including gmail.com or other
domains now a service account is an
account that belongs to your application
instead of an individual end user
so when you run your code that is hosted
on gcp
this is the identity you would specify
to run your code a google group is a
named collection of google accounts and
can also include service accounts now
the advantages of using google groups is
that you can grant and change
permissions
for the collection of accounts all at
once instead of changing access one by
one google groups can help you manage
users at scale and each member of a
google group inherits the iam roles
granted to that group the inheritance
means that you can use a group's
membership to manage users roles instead
of granting iam roles to individual
users moving on to g suite domains this
represents your organization's internet
domain name such as
antonyt.com and when you add a user to
your g suite domain a new google account
is created for the user inside this
virtual group such as antony
antonyt.com a g suite domain in
actuality represents a virtual group of
all of the google accounts that have
been created like google groups g suite
domains cannot be used to establish
identity but they simply enable
permission management now a cloud
identity domain is like a g suite domain
but the difference is that domain users
don't have access to g suite
applications and features so a couple
more members that i wanted to address
is the all authenticated users and the
all users members the all authenticated
users is a special identifier that
represents anyone who is authenticated
with a google account or a service
account users who are not authenticated
such as anonymous visitors are not
included and finally the all users
member is a special identifier that
represents anyone and everyone so any
user who is on the internet including
authenticated and unauthenticated users
and this covers the slew of the
different types of members now touching
on the next component of policies is
roles now diving into roles this is a
named collection of permissions that
grant access to perform actions on
google cloud resources
so at the heart of it permissions are
what determines what operations are
allowed on a resource they usually but
not always correspond one-to-one with
rest methods that is each google cloud
service has an associated permission for
each rest method that it has so to call
a method the caller needs that
permission now these permissions are not
granted to the users directly but
grouped together within the role you
would then grant roles which contain one
or more permissions
you can also create a custom role by
combining one or more of the available
iam permissions and again permissions
allow users to perform specific actions
on google cloud resources so you will
typically see a permission such as the
one you see here
compute.instances.list
and within google cloud iam permissions
are represented in this form
service.resource.verb
so just as a recap on roles this is a
collection of permissions
and you cannot grant a permission
directly to the user but you grant a
role to a user and all the permissions
that the role contains so an example is
shown here where the compute instances
permissions are grouped together in a
role now you can grant permissions by
granting roles to a user a group or a
service account so moving up into a more
broader level there are three types of
roles in iam
there are the primitive roles the
predefined roles
and the custom roles
with the primitive roles
these are roles that existed prior to
the introduction of iam
and they consist of three specific roles
owner editor and viewer and these roles
are concentric which means that the
owner role includes the permissions in
the editor role and the editor role
includes the permissions in the viewer
role and you can apply primitive roles
at the project or service resource
levels by using the console the api and
the gcloud tool just as a note you
cannot grant the owner role to a member
for a project using the iam api or the
gcloud command line tool you can only
add owners to a project using the cloud
console as well
google recommends avoiding these roles
if possible due to the nature of how
much access the permissions are given in
these specific roles google recommends
that you use pre-defined roles over
primitive roles and so moving into
predefined roles
these are roles that give granular and
finer-grained access control than the
primitive roles to specific google cloud
resources and prevent any unwanted
access to other resources predefined
roles are created and maintained by
google their permissions are
automatically updated as necessary when
new features or services are added to
google cloud now when it comes to custom
roles these are user defined and allow
you to bundle one or more supported
permissions to meet your specific needs
unlike predefined roles custom roles are
not maintained by google so when new
permissions features or services are
added to google cloud your custom roles
will not be updated automatically when
you create a custom role you must choose
an organization or project to create it
in you can then grant the custom role on
the organization or project as well as
any resources within that organization
or project and just as a note you cannot
create custom roles at the folder level
if you need to use a custom role within
a folder define the custom role on the
parent of that folder as well the custom
roles user interface is only available
to users who have permissions to create
or manage custom roles by default only
project owners can create new roles now
there is one limitation that i wanted to
point out
and that is that some predefined roles
contain permissions that are not
permitted in custom roles so i highly
recommend that you check whether you can
use a specific permission when making a
custom role custom roles also have a
really cool feature that includes a
launch stage which is stored in the
stage property for the role the stage is
informational and helps you keep track
of how close each role is to being
generally available and these launch
stages are available in the stages shown
here
alpha which is in testing beta which is
tested and awaiting approval and of
course ga which is generally available
and i'll be getting hands-on later with
these roles in an upcoming demonstration
so now moving on to the next component
is conditions and so a condition is a
logic expression and is used to define
and enforce
conditional
attribute-based access control for
google cloud resources conditions allow
you to choose
granting resource access to identities
also known as members only if configured
conditions are met for example this
could be done to configure temporary
access for users that are contractors
and have been given specific access for
a certain amount of time a condition
could be put in place to remove the
access they needed once the contract has
ended conditions are specified in the
role bindings of a resources im policy
so when a condition exists the access
request is only granted if the condition
expression is true so now moving on to
metadata this component carries both e
tags and version so first touching on e
when multiple systems try to write to
the same im policy at the same time
there is a risk that those systems might
overwrite each other's changes and the
risk exists because updating an im
policy involves multiple operations so
in order to help prevent this issue iam
supports concurrency control through the
use of an etag field in the policy the
value of this field changes each time a
policy is updated now when it comes to a
version
this is a version number that is added
to determine features such as a
condition
and for future releases of new features
it is also used to avoid breaking your
existing integrations on new feature
releases that rely on consistency in the
policy structure
also when new policy schema versions are
introduced and lastly we have the
auditconfig component and this is used
in order to configure audit logging for
the policy it determines which
permission types are logged and what
identities if any are exempted from
logging and so to sum it up this is a
policy in all its entirety each
component as you can see plays a
different part and i will be going
through policies and how they are
assembled in statements in a later
lesson and so there is one more thing
that i wanted to touch on before ending
this lesson and that is the policy
inheritance when it comes to resource
hierarchy and so as explained in an
earlier lesson you can set an im policy
at any level in the resource hierarchy
the organization level the folder level
the project level or the resource level
and resources inherit the policies of
all their parent resources the effective
policy for a resource
is the union of the policy set on that
resource and the policies inherited from
higher up in the hierarchy and so again
i wanted to reiterate that this policy
inheritance is transitive in other words
resources inherit policies from the
project
which inherit policies from folders
which inherit policies from the
organization therefore the organization
level policies
also apply at the resource level and so
just a quick example if i apply a policy
on project x
on any resources within that project the
effective policy is going to be a union
of these policies as the resources will
inherit the policy that is granted to
project x so i hope this gave you a
better understanding of how policies are
granted as well as the course structure
and so that's all i have for this lesson
so you can now mark this lesson as
complete and let's move on to the next
one
[Music]
welcome back and in this lesson i wanted
to build on the last lesson where we
went through iam and policy architecture
and dive deeper into policies and
conditions when it comes to putting them
together in policy statements as cloud
engineers you should be able to read and
decipher policy statements and
understand how they're put together by
using all the components that we
discussed earlier so just as a refresher
i wanted to go over the policy
architecture again now as i discussed
previously a policy is a collection of
statements that define who has what type
of access it is attached to a resource
and is used to enforce access control
whenever that resource is accessed now
the binding within that policy binds one
or more members with a single role and
any context specific conditions so in
other words the member roles and
conditions are bound together using a
binding combined with the metadata and
audit config we have a policy so now
taking all of this and putting it
together in a policy statement shown
here you can see the bindings which have
the role the members and conditions the
first member being tony beauties
gmail.com holding the role of storage
admin and the second member as
larkfetterlogin at gmail.com
holding the role of storage object
viewer now because lark only needs to
view the files for this project in cloud
storage till the new year a condition
has been applied that does not grant
access for lark to view these files
after january the 1st an e tag has been
put in and the version is numbered 3 due
to the condition which i will get into a
little bit later this policy statement
has been structured in json format and
is a common format used in policy
statements moving on we have the exact
same policy statement but has been
formatted in yaml as you can see the
members roles and conditions in the
bindings are exactly the same as well as
the etag and version but due to the
formatting it is much more condensed so
as you can see policy statements can be
written in both json or yaml depending
on your preference my personal
preference is to write my policy
statements in yaml due to the shorter
and cleaner format so i will be moving
ahead in this course with more
statements written in yaml when you are
looking to query your projects for its
granted policies
an easy way to do this would be to query
it from the command line as shown here
here i've taken a screenshot from tony
bowtie ace in the cloud shell and have
used the command gcloud projects get
dash iam
policy with the project id and this
brought up all the members and roles
within the bindings
as well as the etag and version for the
policy that has been attached to this
project and as you can see here i have
no conditions in place for any of my
bindings and so again using the command
gcloud projects
get dash iam dash policy along with the
project id will bring up any policies
that are attached to this resource and
the resource being the project id if the
resource were to be the folder id then
you could use the command gcloud
resource dash manager
folders get dash iam-policy
with the folder id and for organizations
the command would be gcloud
organizations get dash
iam-policy along with the organization
id now because we don't have any folders
or organizations in our environment
typing these commands in wouldn't bring
up anything and just as a note using
these commands in the cloud shell or in
the sdk will bring up the policy
statement formatted in yaml so now i
wanted to just take a second to dive
into policy versions now as i haven't
covered versions in detail i wanted to
quickly go over it and the reasons for
each numbered version now version one of
the i am syntax schema for policies
supports binding one role to one or more
members
it does not support conditional role
bindings and so usually with version 1
you will not see any conditions version
2 is used for google's internal use and
so querying policies
usually you will not see a version 2.
and finally with version 3 this
introduces the condition field in the
role binding which constrains the role
binding via contact space and attributes
based rules so just as a note if your
request does not specify a policy
version
iam will assume that you want a version
1 policy and again if the policy does
not contain any conditions
then iam always returns a version one
policy regardless of the version number
in the request so moving on to some
policy limitations each resource can
only have one policy and this includes
organizations folders and projects
another limitation
is that each iam policy can contain up
to 1500 members
and up to 250 of these members
can be google groups now when making
policy changes it will take up to seven
minutes to fully propagate across the
google cloud platform this does not
happen instantaneously as iam is global
as well there is a limit of 100
conditional role bindings per policy now
getting a little bit deeper into
conditions
these are attributes that are either
based on resource or based on details
about the request and this could vary
from time stamp to originating or
destination ip address now as you
probably heard me use the term earlier
conditional role bindings are another
name for a policy that holds a condition
within the binding conditional role
bindings can be added to new or existing
iam policies
to further control access to google
cloud resources so when it comes to
resource attributes this would enable
you to create conditions that evaluate
the resource in the access request
including the resource type the resource
name and the google cloud service being
used request attributes allow you to
manage access based on days or hours of
the week a conditional role binding can
be used to grant time bounded access to
a resource ensuring that a user can no
longer access that resource after the
specified expiry date and time and this
sets temporary access to google cloud
resources using conditional role
bindings in iam policies by using the
date time attributes shown here you can
enforce time-based controls when
accessing a given resource now showing
another example of a time-based
condition it is possible to get even
more granular and scope the geographic
region
along with the day and time for access
in this policy lark only has access
during business hours to view any
objects within cloud storage lark can
only access these objects from monday to
friday nine to five this policy can also
be used as a great example for
contractors coming into your business
yet only needing access during business
hours now an example of a resource-based
condition shown here a group member has
a condition tied to it where dev only
access has been implemented any
developers that are part of this group
will only have access to vm resources
within project cat bowties and tied to
any resources that's name starts with
the word development now some
limitations when it comes to conditions
is that conditions are limited to
specific services
primitive roles are unsupported and
members cannot be of the all users or
all authenticated users members
conditions also hold a limit of 100
conditional role bindings per policy as
well as 20 role bindings for the same
role and same member and so for the last
part of the policy statements i wanted
to touch on audit config logs and this
specifies the audit configuration for a
service the configuration determines
which permission types are logged and
what identities if any are exempted from
logging and when specifying audit
configs they must have one or more audit
log configs now as shown here
this policy enables data read data write
and admin read logging on all services
while exempting tony bowtie ace
gmail.com
from admin read logging on cloud storage
and so that's pretty much all i wanted
to cover in this lesson
on policies policy statements
and conditions and so i highly recommend
as you come across more policy
statements take the time to read through
it and get to know exactly
what the statement is referring to and
what type of permissions that are given
and this will help you not only in the
exam but will also help you in reading
and writing policy statements in future
and so that's all i have for this lesson
so you can now mark this lesson as
complete and let's move on to the next
one
[Music]
welcome back
and in this demonstration i'm going to
do a hands-on tour working with iam here
in the google cloud console we're going
to go through the available services in
the iam console as well as touching on
the command line in the cloud shell to
show how policies can be both added and
edited we're also going to be bringing
in another new user to really bring this
demo to life and to show you how to edit
existing policies so with that being
said let's dive in so if i go over here
to my user icon in the top right hand
corner i can see that i am logged in as
tony bowtie ace
gmail.com and as you can see at the top
i'm here in project tony so now to get
to iam i'm going to go over to the
navigation menu
and i'm going to go to i am in admin and
over to iam now moving over here to the
menu on the left i wanted to go through
the different options that we have in
iam so under iam itself this is where
you would add or edit permissions
with regards to members and roles for
the policy added to your given project
which in my case is project tony and
i'll be coming back in just a bit to go
greater in depth with regards to adding
and editing the policy permissions
moving on to identity and organization
now although we haven't touched on cloud
identity yet i will be covering this in
high level detail in a different lesson
but for now know that cloud identity is
google cloud's identity as a service
solution and it allows you to create and
manage users and groups within google
cloud now if i was signed into cloud
identity i would have a whole bunch of
options here but since this is a
personal account i cannot create or
manage any users as well i do not have a
domain tied to any cloud identity
account as well as any g suite account
so just know that if you had cloud
identity or g suite set up you would
have a bunch of different options to
choose from in order to help you manage
your users and groups and here under
organization policies
i'm able to manage organization policies
but since i am not an organization
policy administrator and i don't have an
organization there's not much that i can
do here just know that when you have an
organization set up you are able to come
here in order to manage and edit your
organization policies now moving under
quotas we went over this in a little bit
of detail in a previous lesson and again
this is to edit any quotas for any of
your services in case you need a limit
increase moving on to service accounts
i will be covering this topic in great
depth in a later lesson and we'll be
going through a hands-on demonstration
as well now i know i haven't touched
much on labels as of yet but know that
labels are a key value pair that helps
you organize and then filter your
resources based on their labels these
same labels are also forwarded to your
billing system so you can then break
down your billing charges by label and
you can also use labels based on teams
cost centers components and even
environments
so for example if i wanted to label my
virtual machines by environment i can
simply use environment as the key and as
the value i can use anything from
development
to qa
to testing
to production and i could simply add
this label and add all the different
environments and later i'd be able to
query based on these specific labels now
a good rule of thumb is to label all of
your resources so that this way you're
able to find them a lot easier and
you're able to query them a lot easier
so moving forward with any of your
resources that you are creating be sure
to add some labels to give you maximum
flexibility so i'm going to discard
these changes and we're going to move on
to settings and we touched on settings
in an earlier lesson with regards to
projects and so here i could change the
project name it'll give me the project
id the project number and i'm able to
migrate or shut down the project now
when it comes to access transparency
this provides you with logs that capture
the actions that google personnel take
when they're accessing your content for
troubleshooting so they're like cloud
audit logs but for google support now in
order to enable access transparency for
your google cloud organization
your google cloud account must have a
premium support plan or a minimum level
of a 400 a month support plan and
because i don't have this i wouldn't be
able to enable access transparency now
although access transparency is not on
the exam
this is a great feature to know about in
case you are working in any bigger
environments that have these support
plans and compliance is of the utmost
importance now moving into privacy and
security this is where google supplies
all of their clients of google cloud the
compliance that they need in order to
meet regulations across the world and
across various industries such as health
care and education and because google
has a broad base in europe google
provides capabilities and contractual
commitments created to meet data
protection recommendations which is why
you can see here eu model contract
clauses
and eu representative contacts as well
under transparency and control i'm able
to disable the usage data that google
collects in order to provide better data
insights and recommendations and this is
done at the project level and as well i
have the option of going over to my
billing account and i could select a
different billing account that's linked
to some other projects that you can get
recommendations on and so continuing
forward identity aware proxy is
something that i will be covering in a
later lesson and so i won't be getting
into any detail about that right now and
so what i really wanted to dig into is
roles now this may look familiar as i
touched on this very briefly in a
previous lesson and here's where i can
create roles
i can create some custom roles from
different selections and here i have
access to all the permissions
and if i wanted to i can filter down
from the different types the names the
permissions even the status so let's say
i was looking for a specific permission
and i'm looking all the permissions for
projects this could help me find exactly
what it is that i'm looking for and
these filters allow me to get really
granular so i can find the exact
permission and so you can get really
granular with regards to your
permissions and create roles that are
custom to your environment now moving on
to audit logs here i can enable the auto
logs without having to use a specific
policy by simply clicking on default
autoconfig and here i can turn on and
off
all the selected logging
as well as add any exempted users now i
don't recommend that you turn these on
as audit logging can create an extremely
large amount of data and can quickly
blow through all of your 300 credit so
i'm going to keep that off move back to
the main screen of the audit logs and as
well here i'm able to get really
granular about what i want to log now
quickly touching on audit logs in the
command line i wanted to quickly open up
cloud shell and show you an example of
how i can edit the policy in order to
enable audit logging just going to make
this a little bit bigger
and i'm going to paste in my command
gcloud projects get dash iam
dash policy
with the project id which is project
tony
286016 and i'm gonna just hit enter
and as you can see here this is my
current policy and as well as expected
audit logs are not enabled due to the
fact that the audit config field is not
present so in order for me to enable the
audit config logs i'm going to have to
edit the policy and so the easiest way
for me to do that is for me to run the
same command and output it to a file
where i can edit it and i'm going to
call this
new dash policy dot yaml and so now that
my policy has been outputted to this
file i'm going to now go into the editor
and as you can see my new policy.yaml is
right here and so for me to enable the
autoconfig logs i'm going to simply
append it to the file and then i'm going
to go over here to the top menu
and click on file and save and so now
for me to apply this new policy i'm
going to go back over to the terminal
and now i'm going to paste in the
command
gcloud projects set dash
iam-policy with the project id and the
file name new dash policy dot yaml and
i'm just going to hit enter
and as you can see the audit log configs
have been enabled for all services and
because this may take some time to
reflect in the console it will not show
up right away but either way audit logs
usually take up a lot of data and i
don't want to blow through my 300 credit
and so i'm going to disable them now the
easiest way for me to do this is to
output this policy to another file edit
it and set it again and so i'm going to
go ahead and do that i'm going to first
clear the screen and then i'm going to
paste in my command while outputting it
to a new file called updated dash policy
dot yaml and i'm gonna hit enter and now
i'm gonna go into the editor so i can
edit the file now the one thing i wanted
to point out is that i could have
overwritten
the file new dash policy but if you look
here in the updated policy the e-tag
is different than the e-tag in the old
policy and so this allowed me to
highlight e-tags when it comes to
editing and creating new policies and so
when editing policies make sure that the
etag is correct otherwise you will
receive an error and not be able to set
the new policy so going back to the
updated policy file i'm going to take
out the audit log configs and i'm going
to leave the auto configs field there
and i'm going to go to the menu click on
file and then save now i'm going to go
back to the terminal and i'm going to
paste in the new command and this will
update my policy and as you can see the
audit config logs have been disabled and
the policy has been updated now this is
the same process that you can use when
you want to update any parts of the
policy when it comes to your members or
roles and even adding any conditions so
now moving on to the last item on the
menu
is groups
and as you can see here because i do not
have an organization i'm not able to
view any groups and so if i did have an
organization i could manage my groups
right here in this page now moving back
over to iam
i wanted to dig into policies in a
little bit of further detail now what we
see here are the permissions and roles
that have been granted to selected
members in this specific project which
is project tony now remember an im
policy is a total collection of members
that have roles granted to them in
what's known as a binding and then the
binding is applied to that layer and all
other layers underneath it and since i'm
at the project layer this policy is
inherited by all the resources
underneath it and so just to verify
through the command line i'm going to
open up cloud shell
and i'm going to paste in the command
gcloud projects get dash
iam-policy with my project id
and i'm going to hit enter
and as you can see here the policy is a
reflection of exactly what you see here
in the console so as you can see here
here's the service agent which you will
find here and the other two service
accounts which you will find above
as well as tony bowtie ace gmail.com and
all the other roles that accompany those
members so as i mentioned earlier i've
gone ahead and created a new user and so
for those who are following along you
can go ahead and feel free to create a
new gmail user now going ahead with this
demonstration the user i created is
named laura delightful now tony needed
an extra hand and decided to bring her
onto the team from another department
now unfortunately in order for laura to
help tony on the project she needs
access to this project and as you can
see she doesn't have any access and so
we're going to go ahead and change that
and give her access to this project so
i'm going to go back over to my open tab
for tony bowtie ace and we're gonna go
ahead and give laura permissions and so
i'm gonna go ahead and click on this add
button at the top of the page and the
prompt will ask me to add a new member
so i'm gonna add laura in here now
and here she is and i'm going to select
the role
as project viewer i'm not going to add
any conditions and i'm simply going to
click on save and the policy has been
updated and as you can see here laura
has been granted the role of project
viewer so i'm going to move over to the
other open tab where laura's console is
open and i'm going to simply do a
refresh
and now laura has access to view all the
resources within project tony now laura
is able to view everything in the
project but laura isn't actually able to
do anything and so in order for laura to
get things done a big part of her job is
going to be creating files with new
ideas for the fall winter line of bow
ties in 2021 and so because laura holds
the project viewer role she is able to
see everything in cloud storage but she
is unable to create buckets
to upload edit or delete any files or
even folders and as you can see here
there is a folder marked bowtie inc
fallwinter 2021 ideas but laura cannot
create any new buckets because she
doesn't have the required permissions as
well drilling down into this bucket
laura is unable to create any folders as
explained earlier
and the same stands for uploading any
files and so i'm going to cancel out of
this and so in order to give laura the
proper permissions for her to do her job
we're going to give laura the storage
admin role and so moving back over to
the open console for tony bowtie i'm
going to give laura access by using the
command line so i'm going to go up to
the top right and open up cloud shell
and so the command i need to run
to give laura the role of storage admin
would be the following gcloud projects
add dash iam dash policy dash binding
with the project id dash dash member
user followed by colon and then the user
name which is laura delightful gmail.com
dash dash role and the role which is
storage admin and i'm going to go ahead
and hit enter
and as you can see it has been executed
successfully so if i do a refresh of the
web page here i'm going to be able to
see the changes reflected in the console
and after a refresh you can see here
storage admin has been added to the role
for laura delightful gmail.com and so if
i go over to the open tab where laura
has her console open i can simply do a
refresh
and if i go back to the home page for
cloud storage you can see here that
laura now has the permissions to create
a bucket laura also now has permissions
to create new folders create edit and
delete new files on top of being able to
create new storage buckets and so that
about wraps up this demonstration on
getting hands-on with iam
in both the console and the command line
and i also hope that this demo has given
you a bit more confidence
on working in the shell running the
commands needed in order to create new
bindings along with editing existing
policies
and this will get you comfortable for
when you need to assign roles to new and
existing users that are added to your
gcp environment and so you can now mark
this lesson as complete
and let's move on to the next one
welcome back in this lesson i'm going to
take a deep dive into service accounts
now service accounts play a powerful
part in google cloud and can allow a
different approach for application
interaction with the resources in google
cloud now service accounts being both an
identity and a resource can cause some
confusion for some and so i really
wanted to spend some time breaking it
down for better understanding and so i'm
first going to start off by explaining
what exactly is a service account and so
a service account is a special kind of
account that is used by an application
or a virtual machine instance and not a
person
an application uses the service account
to authenticate between the application
and gcp services so that the users
aren't directly involved in short it is
a special type of google account
intended to represent a non-human user
that needs to authenticate and be
authorized to access data in google apis
this way the service account is the
identity of the service and the service
accounts permissions control which
resources the service can access and as
a note a service account is identified
by its email address
which is unique to the account now the
different service account types
come in three different flavors
user managed
default and google managed service
accounts when it comes to the user
managed service accounts
these are service accounts that you
create
you're responsible for managing and
securing these accounts
and by default you can create up to 100
user managed service accounts in a
project or you can also request a quota
increase in case you need more now when
you create a user managed service
account in your project it is you that
chooses a name for the service account
this name appears in the email address
that identifies the service account
which uses the following format seen
here the service account name
at the project id dot
iam.gserviceaccount.com
now moving on to the default service
accounts
when you use some google cloud services
they create user managed service
accounts that enable the service to
deploy jobs that access other google
cloud resources these accounts are known
as default service accounts so when it
comes to production workloads google
strongly recommends that you create your
own user managed service accounts and
grant the appropriate roles to each
service account when a default service
account is created it is automatically
granted the editor role on your project
now following the principle of lease
privilege google strongly recommends
that you disable the automatic role
grant
by adding a constraint to your
organization policy
or by revoking the editor role manually
the default service account will be
assigned an email address
following the format you see here
project id
at appspot.gserviceaccount.com
for any service accounts created by app
engine and project number dash compute
at developer.gserviceaccount.com
for compute engine and so lastly when it
comes to google managed service accounts
these are created and managed by google
and they are used by google services the
display name of most google managed
service accounts
ends with a
gserviceaccount.com address now some of
these service accounts are visible but
others are hidden so for example
google api service agent is a service
account named with an email address that
uses the following format
project number at cloudservices.gerisa
and this runs internal google processes
on your behalf and this is just one
example of the many google managed
services that run in your environment
and just as a warning it is not
recommended to change or revoke the
roles that are granted to the google api
service agent or to any other google
managed service accounts for that matter
if you change or revoke these roles
some google cloud services will no
longer work now when it comes to
authentication for service accounts they
authenticate using service account keys
so each service account is associated
with two sets of public and private rsa
key pairs that are used to authenticate
to google they are the google manage
keys and the user manage keys with the
google manage keys google stores both
the public and private portion of the
key
rotates them regularly and the private
key is always held in escrow and is
never directly accessible iam provides
apis to use these keys to sign on behalf
of the service account now when using
user managed key pairs this implies that
you own both the public and private
portions of a key pair you can create
one or more user managed key pairs also
known as external keys that can be used
from outside of google cloud google only
stores the public portion of a user
managed key
so you are responsible for the security
of the private key as well as the key
rotation private keys cannot be
retrieved by google so if you're using a
user manage key
please be aware that if you lose your
key your service account will
effectively stop working google
recommends storing these keys in cloud
kms for better security and better
management user managed keys are
extremely powerful credentials and they
can represent a security risk if they
are not managed correctly and as you can
see here a user managed key has many
different areas that need to be
addressed when it comes to key
management now when it comes to service
account permissions
in addition to being an identity a
service account is a resource which has
im policies attached to it and these
policies determine who can use the
service account so for instance
lark can have the editor role on a
service account and laura can have a
viewer role on a service account so this
is just like granting roles for any
other google cloud resource just as a
note
the default compute engine and app
engine service accounts are granted
editor roles on the project when they
are created so that the code executing
in your app or vm instance has the
necessary permissions now you can grant
the service account user role at both
the project level for all service
accounts in the project or at the
service account level now granting the
service account user role to a user for
a project
gives the user access to all service
accounts in the project
including service accounts that may be
created in the future granting the
service account user role to a user for
a specific
service account gives a user access to
only that service account so please be
aware when granting the service account
user role to any member now users who
are granted the service account user
role on a service account can use it to
indirectly access
all the resources to which the service
account has access
when this happens the user impersonates
the service account to perform any tasks
using its granted roles and permissions
and is known as service account
impersonation now when it comes to
service account permissions there is
also another method use called access
scopes service account scopes are the
legacy method of specifying permissions
for your instance
and they are used in substitution of iam
roles these are used specifically for
default or automatically created service
accounts based on enabled apis now
before the existence of iam roles access
scopes were the only way for granting
permissions to service accounts and
although they are not the primary way of
granting permissions now
you must still set service account
scopes when configuring an instance to
run as a service account however when
you are using a custom service account
you will not be using scopes rather you
will be using iam roles
so when you are using a default service
account for your compute instance it
will default to using scopes instead of
iam roles and so i wanted to quickly
touch on how service accounts are used
now one way of using a service account
is to attach this service account to a
resource
so if you want to start a long-running
job that authenticates as a service
account you need to attach a service
account to the resource that will run
the job and this will bind the service
account to the resource now the other
way of using a service account is
directly impersonating a service account
which i had explained a little bit
earlier so once granted they require
permissions a user or a service can
directly impersonate the identity of a
service account in a few common
scenarios you can impersonate the
service account without requiring the
use of a downloaded external service
account key as well a user may get
artifacts signed by the google managed
private key of the service account
without ever actually retrieving a
credential for the service account and
this is an advanced use case and is only
supported for programmatic access now
although i'm going to be covering best
practices
at the end of this section i wanted to
go over some best practices for service
accounts specifically so you should
always look at auditing the service
accounts
and their keys
using either the service account dot
keys dot list method
or the logs viewer page in the console
now if your service accounts don't need
external keys
you should definitely delete them you
should always grant the service account
only the minimum set of permissions
required to achieve the goal
service accounts should also be created
for each specific service with only the
permissions required for that service
and finally when it comes to
implementing key rotation you should
take advantage of the iam service
account api to get the job done and so
that's all i have for this lesson on
service accounts
so you can now mark this lesson as
complete
and please join me in the next one where
we go hands-on in the console
[Music]
welcome back
so in this demonstration i'm going to
take a hands-on tour diving through
various aspects of working with both
default and custom-made service accounts
we're going to start off fresh
observing a new service account being
automatically created along with viewing
scopes observing how to edit them and
creating custom service accounts that
get a little bit more granular with the
permissions assigned so with that being
said let's dive in so as you can see
here from the top right hand corner that
i am logged in under tony bowtie ace
gmail.com and looking over here from the
top drop down menu you can see that i am
in the project of cat bow ties fall 2021
and this is a brand new project that i
had created specifically for this demo
and so i currently have no resources
created along with no apis enabled so
now i want to navigate over to iam so
i'm going to go up to the left hand
corner to the navigation menu
and i'm going to go to i am an admin
and over to iam and as expected i have
no members here other than myself tony
bowtie ace gmail.com with no other
members and if i go over here to the
left hand menu under service accounts
you can see that i have no service
accounts created so now in order to
demonstrate a default service account
i'm going to go over to the navigation
menu and go into compute engine and as
you can see the compute engine api is
starting up and so this may take a
couple minutes to get ready okay and the
compute engine api has been enabled so
now if i go back over to iam to take a
look at my service accounts as expected
i have my compute engine default service
account now again i did not create this
manually this service account was
automatically created when i had enabled
the compute engine api along with the
api's service agent and the compute
engine service agent and the same would
happen to other various apis that are
enabled as well and so now that i have
my default service account i want to go
back over to compute engine
and i'm going to go ahead and create a
vm instance so i'm going to just click
on create
i'm going to keep everything as the
default except i'm going to change the
machine type from an e2 medium to an e2
micro and so now i'm going to scroll
down to where it says identity and api
access
now here under service account you can
see that the compute engine default
service account has been highlighted and
this is because i don't have any other
service accounts that i am able to
select from now when a default service
account is the only service account you
have access to
access scopes are the only permissions
that will be available for you to select
from now remember access scopes are the
legacy method of specifying permissions
in google cloud now under access scopes
i can select from the allow default
access
allow full access to all cloud apis
and set access for each api and so i
want to click on set access for each api
for just a second and so as you can see
here i have access to set permissions
for each api the difference being is
that i only have access to primitive
roles and so now that i'm looking to
grant access to my service account i'm
going to grant access to cloud storage
on a read-only capacity
and so now that i have granted
permissions for my service account i'm
going to now create my instance by
simply clicking on the create button
and so now that my instance is created
i want to head over to cloud storage to
see exactly what my service account will
have access to so i'm going to go over
to my navigation menu and scroll down
and click on storage and as you can see
here i have created a bucket in advance
called bow tie ink fall winter 2012
designs and this is due to bow tie ink
bringing back some old designs from 2012
and making them relevant for today and
within that bucket there are a few files
of different design ideas that were best
sellers back in 2012
that tony bowtie wanted to re-release
for the fall winter 2012 collection and
so with the new granted access to my
default service account i should have
access to view these files so in order
to test this i'm going to go back over
to the navigation menu and go back to
compute engine and i'm going to ssh into
my instance
and so now that i've sshed into my
virtual machine
i wanted to first check to see who is it
that's running the commands is it my
user account or is it my service account
and so i'll be able to do this very
easily by checking the configuration and
i can do this by running the command
gcloud config list and as you can see my
current configuration is showing that my
service account is the member that is
being used to run this command in the
project of cat bow ties fall 2021 now if
i wanted to run any commands using my
tony bowtie ace
gmail.com user account i can simply run
the command gcloud auth login and it
will bring me through the login process
that we've seen earlier on in the course
for my tony bowtie ace
gmail.com account but now since i'm
running all my commands using my service
account from this compute engine
instance i'm using the permissions
granted to that service account that we
saw earlier and so since i set the
storage scope for the service account to
read only we should be able to see the
cloud storage bucket and all the files
within it by simply running the gsutil
command so to list the contents of the
bucket i'm going to type in the command
gsutil ls for list and the name of the
bucket and the syntax for that would be
gs
colon forward slash forward slash
followed by the name of the bucket which
would be bowtie inc
fw2012
designs
and as you can see we're able to view
all the files that are in the bucket and
so it is working as expected and so now
because i've only granted viewing
permissions for this service account i
cannot create any files due to the lack
of permissions so for instance if i was
to create a file
using the command touch
file one i have now created that file
here on the instance so now i want to
copy this file to my bucket and so i'm
going to run the gsutil command
cp for copy
file 1 which is the name of my file and
gs
colon forward slash forward slash along
with the name of the bucket which is bow
tie inc fw
designs and as expected i am getting an
access denied exception with a prompt
telling me that i have insufficient
permissions and so now that i've shown
you how to create a default service
account and give it permissions using
access scopes let's now create a custom
service account and assign it proper
permissions
to not only read files from cloud
storage but be able to write files to
cloud storage as well so i'm going to
now close down this tab
and i'm going to go back over to the
navigation menu
and go back to iam where we can go in
and create our new service account
under service accounts
and so as you can see here this is the
default service account and since we
want to create a custom one i'm going to
go ahead and go up to the top here and
click on the button that says create
service account
and so now i'm prompted to enter some
information with regards to details of
this service account including the
service account name the account id
along with a description and so i'm
going to call this service account sa
hyphen bowtie hyphen demo and as you can
see it automatically propagated the
service account id and i'm going to give
this service account a description
storage read write access
and i'm going to click on the button
create
and so now i've been prompted to grant
permissions to the service account and i
can do that by simply clicking on the
drop down and selecting a roll but i'm
looking to get a little bit more
granular and so i'm going to simply type
in storage and as you can see i'm coming
up with some more granular roles as
opposed to the primitive roles that i
only had access to prior to the search
so i'm going to click on storage object
viewer for read access to cloud storage
i'm not going to add any conditions and
i'm going to add another role and this
time
i'm going to add storage object creator
and so those are all the permissions i
need for read write access to cloud
storage and so now i can simply click on
continue and so now i'm being prompted
to add another user to act as a service
account and this is what we discussed in
the last lesson about service accounts
being both a member and a resource now
notice that i have an option for both
the service account users role and the
service account admins role now as
discussed earlier the service account
and men's role has the ability to grant
other users the role of service account
user and so because we don't want to do
that i'm going to leave both of these
fields blank
and simply click on done now i know in
the last lesson i talked about creating
custom keys for authentication
in case you're hosting your code on
premise or on another cloud and so if i
wanted to do that i can simply go to the
actions menu and click on create key and
it'll give me the option on creating a
private key either using json or p12
format and because i'm not creating any
keys i'm going to simply click on cancel
and so in order for me to apply this
service account
to our vm instance i'm going to now go
back over to the navigation menu and go
back into compute engine and so now in
order for me to change this service
account that's currently assigned to
this instance i'm going to go ahead and
check off this instance and click on
stop
now please note that in order to change
service accounts on any instance you
must stop it first before you can edit
the service account and so now that the
instance has stopped i'm going to drill
down into this instance one
and i'm going to click on edit
now i'm going to scroll down to the
bottom
and at the bottom you will find the
service account field and clicking on
the drop down i'll find my custom
service account as a bow tie demo so i
want to select this and simply click on
save and so now that i've selected my
new service account to be used in this
vm instance i can now start up the
instance again to test out the
permissions that were granted
and so just as a quick note here i
wanted to bring your attention to the
external ip whenever stopping and
starting an instance with an ephemeral
ip in other words it is not assigned a
static ip your vm instance will receive
a new ip address and i'll be getting
into this in a lot deeper detail in the
compute engine section of the course and
so now i'm going to ssh into this
instance
now i'm going to run the same gsutil
command that i did previously to list
all the files in the bucket so i'm going
to run the command gsutil ls for list
and gs
colon forward slash forward slash bow
tie inc fw 2012 designs
and as you can see i'm able to read all
the files in the bucket now the
difference in the permissions granted
for the service account is that i'm able
to write files to cloud storage and so
in order to test that i'm going to use
the touch command again and i'm going to
name the file file2 and so now i'm going
to copy this file to the cloud storage
bucket by using the command gsutil cp
file2 and the bucket name
gs colon forward slash forward slash bow
tie inc fw 2012 designs and as expected
the file copied over successfully as we
do have permissions to write to cloud
storage and so before i end this
demonstration i wanted to quickly go
over exactly how to create service
accounts
using the command line and so i'm going
to close down this tab and i'm going to
head up to the top right hand corner and
activate my cloud shell i'm going to
make this window a little bit bigger and
so now in order to view the service
accounts i currently have
i'm going to run the command
gcloud
iam
service dash accounts
list
and so as expected the compute engine
default service account along with the
custom service account that i created
earlier called sa bowtie demo is now
displaying and in order to just verify
that i'm going to go over to iam
under service accounts and as you can
see it is reflecting exactly the same in
the console so now in order for me to
create a new service account using the
command line i'm going to run the
command
gcloud iam service accounts create
and the name of the service account
which i'm going to call sa-tony bowtie
along with the display name as essay
tony bowtie as well and i'm going to hit
enter
and my service account has been created
so now if i run the command gcloud i am
service accounts list
i should see my new service account and
as well if i did a refresh here on the
console i can see that it is reflecting
the same so now that we've created our
new service account we need to assign
some permissions to it in order for us
to be able to use it and so if i go over
here to iam in the console i can see
here that my service account has not
been assigned any permissions and so in
order to do that i am going to simply
run the command
gcloud projects
add dash iam-policy-binding
so we're adding a policy binding and
then the name of the project catbow ties
fall 2021 we need to add the member
which is the new service account email
address along with the role of storage
object viewer i'm going to hit enter
and as you can see
my member sa tony bowtie has been
assigned the storage object viewer role
and so if i wanted to grant some other
roles to the service account i can do
that as well and so if i did a refresh
here i can see that the console reflects
exactly the same and so in order for me
to use this account in my instance i'm
going to first have to stop my instance
attach my service account and then start
up my instance again so i'm going to go
over to my cloud shell i'm just going to
clear the screen and i'm going to paste
in the command gcloud compute instances
stop the name of the instance along with
the zone and now that the instance has
stopped i can now add my surface account
to the instance and so i'm going to use
the command gcloud compute instances
set service account instance 1
along with the zone and the service
account email address i'm going to go
ahead and hit enter
and it has now been successfully added
and so now that that's done i can now
start up the instance by using the
command gcloud compute instances start
along with the instance name and the
zone and so now if i go over to my
navigation menu and go over to compute
engine and drill down on the instance if
i scroll down to the bottom
i'll be able to see that my new service
account has been added
and so this is a great demonstration for
when you want to add different service
accounts for your different applications
on different instances or even on
different resources and so that's pretty
much all i wanted to cover in this
demonstration so you can now mark this
lesson as complete and let's move on to
the next one
welcome back
in this lesson i'm going to dive into
cloud identity google's identity as a
service offering for google cloud that
maximizes end user efficiency protect
company data
and so much more
now cloud identity as i said before is
an identity as a service solution that
centrally manages users and groups this
would be the sole system for
authentication and that provides a
single sign-on experience for all
employees of an organization to be used
for all your internal and external
applications cloud identity also gives
you more control over the accounts that
are used in your organization for
example if developers in your
organization use personal accounts such
as gmail accounts those accounts are
outside of your control
so when you adopt cloud identity you can
manage access and compliance across all
the users in your domain now when you
adopt cloud identity you create a cloud
identity account for each of your users
and groups you can then use iam to
manage access to google cloud resources
for each cloud identity account and you
can also configure cloud identity to
federate identities between google and
other identity providers such as active
directory and azure active directory and
i'll be getting more into that a little
bit later
so now when it comes to cloud identity
it gives you so much more than just user
and group management it provides a slew
of features such as device management
security
single sign-on
reporting
and directory management
and i will be diving deeper into each
one of these features of cloud identity
now starting with device management
this lets people in any organization
access their work accounts from mobile
devices while keeping the organization's
data more secure in today's world
employees want to access business
applications from wherever they are
whether at home at work
or even traveling
and many even want to use their own
devices which is also known as bring
your own device or byod for short using
mobile device management there are
several ways that you can provide the
business applications employees need
on their personal devices while
implementing policies that keep the
corporate data safe you can create a
white list of approved applications
where users can access corporate data
securely through those applications
you can enforce work profiles on android
devices and requiring managed
applications on ios devices policies can
also be pushed out on these devices to
protect corporate data and identities as
well as keeping inventory of devices
with corporate data present then when
these devices are either no longer being
used for corporate use or stolen the
device can then be wiped of all its
corporate data device management also
gives organizations the power to enforce
passcodes
as well as auditing now moving into the
security component of cloud identity
this is where two-step verification
steps in now as explained earlier
two-step verification or to sv
is a security feature that requires
users to verify their identity through
something they know such as a password
plus something they have such as a
physical key or access code and this can
be anything from security keys to google
prompt
the authenticator app and backup codes
so cloud identity helps by applying
security best practices along with being
able to deploy
two-step verification for the whole
company along with enforcement controls
and can also manage passwords to make
sure they are meeting the enforced
password requirements automatically so
single sign-on is where users can access
many applications
without having to enter their username
and password for each application single
sign-on also known as sso can provide a
single point of authentication through
an identity provider also known as idp
for short you can set up sso using
google as an identity provider to access
a slew of third-party applications
as well as any on-premise or custom
in-house applications you can also
access a centralized dashboard for
conveniently accessing your applications
so now when lisa logs in with her
employee credentials she will then have
access to many cloud applications that
bowtie inc it department has approved
through a catalog of sso applications
and this will increase both security and
productivity for lisa and bowtie inc as
lisa won't have to enter
a separate username and password for
separate applications now getting into
reporting this covers audit logs for
logins groups devices and even tokens
you're even able to export these logs to
bigquery for analysis
and then you can create reports from
these logs that cover security
applications and activity
now moving on to the last component of
cloud identity is directory management
and this provides profile information
for users in your organization
email
and group addresses and shared external
contacts in the directory using google
cloud directory sync or gcds you can
synchronize the data in your google
account with your microsoft active
directory or ldap server gcds doesn't
migrate any content such as your email
your calendar events or your files to
your google account gcds is used to
synchronize all your users groups and
shared contacts to match the information
in your ldap server which could be your
active directory server or your azure
active directory domain now getting
deeper into google cloud directory sync
i'd like to touch on active directory
for just a minute now active directory
is a very common directory service
developed by microsoft and is a
cornerstone in most big corporate
on-premises environments it
authenticates and authorizes all users
and computers in a windows domain type
network signing and enforcing security
policies for all computers and
installing or updating software as
necessary now as you can see here in the
diagram the active directory forest
contains the active directory domain a
bowtieinc.co
and the active directory federation
services of bowtieinc.co where the
active directory forest is the
hierarchical structure for active
directory the active directory domain is
responsible for storing information
about members of the domain including
devices and users and it verifies their
credentials and defines their access
rights active directory federation
services or adfs
is a single sign-on service where
federation is the means of linking a
person's electronic identity and
attributes stored across multiple
distinct identity management systems so
you can think of it as a subset of sso
as it relates only to authentication
technologies used for federated identity
include some common terms that you may
hear me or others in the industry use
from time to time such as saml which
stands for security assertion markup
language oauth open id and even security
tokens such as simple web tokens json
web tokens and saml assertions and so
when you have identities already in your
on-premises environment that live in
active directory you need a way to tie
these identities to the cloud and so
here's where you would use google cloud
directory sync to automatically
provision users and groups from active
directory to cloud identity or g suite
google cloud directory sync is a free
google provided tool that implements the
synchronization process and can be run
on google cloud or in your on-premises
environment synchronization is one way
so that active directory remains the
source of truth cloud identity or g
suite uses active directory federation
services or adfs for single sign-on any
existing corporate applications and
other sas services can continue to use
your adfs as an identity provider now i
know this may be a review for some who
are advanced in this topic but for those
who aren't this is a very important
topic to know as google cloud directory
sync is a big part of cloud identity and
is a common way that is used in many
corporate environments to sync active
directory or any other ldap server to
google cloud especially when you want to
keep your active directory as the single
source of truth and so that's pretty
much all i wanted to cover
when it comes to cloud identity and
google cloud directory sync so you can
now mark this lesson as complete and
let's move on to the next one
[Music]
welcome back now i wanted to close out
this section by briefly going over the
best practices to follow when working
with identity and access management so
the phrase that was discussed in the
beginning of this lesson that will
continuously come up in the exam is the
principle of least privilege and again
this is where you would apply only the
minimal access level required for what
is needed to be done and this can be
done using predefined roles which is a
more granular level role than using
primitive roles which are very wide
scoped roles that are applied to the
whole project roles should also be
granted at the smallest scope necessary
so for instance when assigning somebody
the permissions needed
for managing pre-existing compute
instances assigning a compute instance
admin role might be sufficient for what
they need to do as opposed to assigning
them the compute instance role that has
full control of all compute engine
instance resources now when it comes to
child resources they cannot restrict
access granted on its parent
so always remember to check the policy
granted on every resource and make sure
you understand the hierarchical
inheritance you also want to make sure
that you restrict access to members
abilities to create and manage service
accounts
as users who are granted the service
account actor role for a service account
can access all the resources for which
the service account has access and
granting someone with the owner role
should be used with caution as they will
have access to modify almost all
resources
project-wide including iam policies and
billing granting an editor role might be
more sufficient for the needs of most
when using primitive roles
now when dealing with resource hierarchy
to make it easy on how to structure your
environment
you should look at mirroring your google
cloud resource hierarchy structure to
your organizational structure in other
words the google cloud resource
hierarchy should reflect how your
company is organized you should also use
projects to group resources that share
the same trust boundary as well as
setting policies at the organization
level and at the project level rather
than at the resource level now going
back to what we discussed earlier about
the principle of least privilege
you should use this guideline to grant
iam roles that is
only give the least amount of access
necessary to your resources and when
granting roles across multiple projects
it is recommended to grant them at the
folder level instead of at the project
level
now diving back into service accounts a
separate trust boundary should always be
applied for any given application in
other words create a new service account
when multiple components are involved in
your application you also want to make
sure that you don't delete any service
accounts that are in use by running
instances as your application is likely
to fail
so you will want to schedule this during
plan down time to avoid any outages now
earlier on in this section we discussed
service account keys and how they
interact with google cloud and that is
the main authentication mechanism used
for keys so you want to make sure that
any user managed keys are rotated
periodically to avoid being compromised
you can rotate a key by creating a new
key switching applications to use the
new key and then deleting the old key
but be sure to create the new key first
before deleting the old one as this will
result in parts or even your entire
application failing and also when
working with service account keys it's
always good practice to name your
service keys and this will reflect your
use for those keys and permissions for
those keys so you know what they are
used for when you're looking at them now
when you are giving access to service
accounts you want to make sure that only
those who truly need access are the ones
that have it
others in your environment should be
restricted to avoid any misuse now when
it comes to keeping your service account
keys safe i can't stress this enough you
never want to check in these keys source
code or leave them in your downloads
directory as this is a prime way of not
only getting your keys compromised but
compromising your entire environment to
be accessed publicly
now we touched a bit on auditing but we
haven't really gone into it in detail
and we'll be going into it later on in
the course but touching on best
practices
you want to be sure to check your cloud
audit logs regularly and audit all i am
policy changes whenever you edit any iam
policies a log is generated that records
that change and so you always want to
periodically check these logs to make
sure that there are no changes that are
out of your security scope you also want
to check to see
who has editing permissions on these iam
policies and make sure that those who
hold them have the rights to do so point
being is that you want to restrict who
has the ability to edit policies and
once these audit logs have been
generated you want to export them to
cloud storage so that you're able to
store them for long term retention as
these logs are typically held for weeks
and not years getting back to service
account keys
service account key access should be
periodically audited for viewing of any
misuse or unauthorized access and lastly
audit logs should also be restricted to
only those who need access and others
should have no permissions to view them
and this can be done by adding a role to
be able to view these logs now when
touching on policy management you want
to grant access to all projects in your
organization by using an organization
level policy you also want to grant
roles to a google group instead of
individual users as it is easier to add
or remove members from a google group
instead of updating an im policy and
finally when you need to grant multiple
roles to a task you should create a
google group as it is a lot easier to
grant the roles to that group and then
add the users to that group as opposed
to adding roles to each individual user
and so that's all i wanted to cover on
this short yet very important lesson on
best practices when it comes to iam now
i know this is not the most exciting
topic but will become extremely
necessary when you are dealing with
managing users groups and policies in
environments that require you to use iam
securely and so please keep this in mind
whenever you are working in any
environment as it will help you grant
the proper permissions when it comes to
these different topics so now i highly
recommend that you take a break grab a
tea or coffee before moving on into the
next section and so for now you can mark
this lesson as complete and whenever
you're ready please join me in the next
section
[Music]
welcome back
now i wanted to make this as easy as
possible for those students who do not
have a background in networking or any
networking knowledge in general which is
why i wanted to add this quick
networking refresher to kick off the
networking section of this course so
with that being said let's dive in so
before the internet computers were
standalone and didn't have the
capabilities to send emails
transfer files or share any information
fast forward some time
people started to connect their
computers together to share and be able
to do the things that modern networks
can do today part of being in this
network is being able to identify each
computer to know where to send and
receive files
this problem was solved by using an
address to identify each computer on the
network like humans use a street address
to identify where they live
so that mail and packages can be
delivered to them an ip address is used
to identify a computer or device on any
network so communication between
machines was done by the use of an ip
address
a numerical label assigned to each
device connected to a computer network
that uses the internet protocol for
communication also known as ip for short
so for this system to work a
communication system was put in place
that defined how the network would
function
this system was put together as a
consistent model of protocol layers
defining interoperability
between network devices and software in
layers
to standardize how different protocols
would communicate in this stack this
stack is referred to as the open systems
interconnection model or you may hear
many refer to it as the seven layer osi
model now this is not a deep dive
networking course but i did feel the
need to cover that which is necessary
for the understanding of the elements
taught in this course
for those wanting to learn more about
the osi model and the layers within it
please check out the links that i have
included in the lesson text below
so for this lesson and the next i will
be covering the specific layers with its
protocols that are highlighted here and
will help you understand the networking
concepts in this course with a bit
better clarity
so i'll be covering a layer 3 being the
network layer layer 4 being the
transport layer and layer 7 being the
application layer so first up i will be
covering layer 3 which is the networking
layer along with the internet protocol
now there are two versions of the
internet protocol and are managed
globally by the regional internet
registries also known as the rir the
first one which is ipv4
is the original version of the internet
protocol that first came on the scene in
1981 the second version is ipv6 which is
a newer version designed in 2017 to deal
with the problem of ipv4 address
exhaustion meaning that the amount of
usable ips were slowly being used up
and i will be covering both versions of
the internet protocol in a little bit of
depth so let's first dive into ipv
version 4. so ipv4 can be read in a
human readable notation represented in
dotted decimal notation consisting of
four numbers
each ranging from 0 to 255 separated by
dots each part between the dots
represents a group of 8 bits also known
as an octet a valid range for an ip
address starts from 0.0.0.0
and ends in 255.255.255.255.
and this would give you a total number
of over 4.2 billion ip addresses now
this range was viewed as extremely large
back then until the number of ip
addresses available were quickly
dwindling due to the many ipconnected
devices that we have today
and this is when a new addressing
architecture was introduced called
classful addressing where the address
was split into smaller ranges and this
was originally assigned to you when you
needed an ip address by one of the
registries noted before so for any given
ip address they're typically made of two
separate components the first part of
the address is used to identify the
network that the address is a part of
the part that comes afterwards is used
to specify a specific host within that
network now the first part was assigned
to you and your business by the
registries
and the second part was for you to do it
as you'd like and so these ip addresses
were assigned from the smaller ranges
explained earlier called classes the
first range of classes is class a
and it started at 0.0.0.0
and ended at 127.255
and this would give a total number of
over 2.1 billion addresses with 128
different networks class a ip addresses
can support over 16 million hosts per
network and those who were assigned
addresses in this class
had a fixed value of the first octet the
second third and fourth octet was free
for the business to assign as they
choose class a ip addresses were to be
used by huge networks like those
deployed by internet service providers
and so when ips started to dwindle many
companies return these class a network
blocks back to the registries to assist
with extending addressing capacity and
so the next range is class b and this is
half the size of the class a network the
class b network range started at one at
128.0.0.0
and end it at 191.255.255.255
and carries a total number of over 1
billion ip addresses with over 16 000
networks the fixed value in this class
is of the first and second octet the
third and fourth octet can be done with
as you like ip addresses in this class
were to be used for medium and large
size networks in enterprises and
organizations the next range is class c
and this is half the size of the class b
network the class c network range starts
at 192
and ends at 223.255.255.255
and carries a total of over half a
billion addresses with over two million
networks and can support up to
256 hosts the fixed value of this class
is the first second and third octet and
the fourth can be done with as you like
ip addresses in this class
were the most common class and were to
be used in small business and home
networks now there's a couple more
classes that were not commonly used
called class d and class e
and this is beyond the scope of this
course so we won't be discussing this
and so this was the way that was used to
assign public ip addresses to devices on
the internet and allowed communication
between devices now the problem with
classful addressing was that with
businesses that needed larger address
blocks than a class c network provided
they received a class b block which in
most cases was much larger than required
and the same thing happened with
requiring more ips than class b
and getting a class a network block this
problem introduced a lot of wasted ips
as there was no real middle ground and
so this was a way to address any
publicly routable ips now there were
certain ranges that were allocated for
private use and were designed to be used
in private networks whether on-premises
or in cloud and again they are not
designed for public use and also didn't
have the need to communicate over the
public internet and so these private ip
address spaces were standardized using
the rfc standard 1918
and again these ip addresses are
designed for private use and can be used
anywhere you like as long as they are
still kept private chances are a network
that you've come across whether it be a
cloud provider your home network or
public wi-fi will use one of these
classes to define their network and
these are split into three ranges
first one being single class a with
10.0.0
ending in 10.255.255.255.
the class b range
ranging from 172.16.0.0
to
172.31 dot
and lastly class c which was ranging
from 192.168.0.0
to 192.168.255.255.
now for those networks that use these
private ips over the public internet the
process they would use is a process
called network address translation
or nat for short
and i will be covering this in a
different lesson later on in the section
this method of classful addressing has
been replaced with something a bit more
efficient where network blocks can be
defined more granularly and was done due
to the internet running out of ipv4
addresses as we needed to allocate these
ips more efficiently now this method is
called classless inter domain routing or
cider for short now with cider based
networks you aren't limited to only
these three classes of networks class a
b and c have been removed for something
more efficient which will allow you to
create networks in any one of those
ranges cider ranges are represented by
its starting ip address called a network
address
followed by what is called a prefix
which is a slash and then a number this
slash number represents the size of the
network the bigger the number the
smaller the network and the smaller the
number the bigger the network given the
example here
192.168.0.0 is the network address
and the prefix is a slash 16. now at
this high level it is not necessary to
understand the math behind this but i
will include a link in the lesson text
for those of you who are interested in
learning more about it all you need to
keep in mind is as i said before
the bigger the prefix number the smaller
the network and the smaller the prefix
number the bigger the network so just as
an example the size of this slash 16
network is represented here by this
circle its ip range is 192.168.0.0
ending in 192.168.255.255.
and once you understand the math you
will be able to tell that a slash 16
range means that the network is the
fixed value in the first and second
octet the hosts on the network or the
range are the values of anything in the
third or fourth octets so this network
in total will provide us with 65
ip addresses now let's say you decided
to create a large network such as this
and you wanted to allocate part of it to
another part of your business you can
simply do so by splitting it in two
and be left with two slash 17 networks
so instead of one slash 16 network you
will now have 2 17 networks and each
network will be assigned 32
768 ip addresses so just to break it
down the previous network which was
192.16
forward slash 16 with the first two
octets being the network which is
192.168
it leaves the third and fourth octet to
distribute as you like and these third
and fourth octets
are what you're having to create these
two networks so looking at the blue half
the address range will start at 0.0 and
will end at 127.255.
the green half will start halfway
through the slash 16 network which will
be
128.0 and end at 255.255.
so now what if i was looking to break
this network down even further and break
it into four networks well using cider
ranges this makes things fairly easy as
i can have it again and as shown here i
would split the two slash 17 networks to
create four slash 18 networks so if i
took the blue half circle and split it
into two and then splitting the green
half circle into
this would leave me with four slash 18
networks as seen here the blue quarter
would start from 192.168.0.0
ending with the last two octets of
63.255
and the red quarter which starts from
where the blue left off
starting at the last two octets of 64.0
and ending in 127.255.
the green quarter again starting off
with the previously defined 128.0
network which is where the red quarter
left off and ending with the last two
octets being
191.255 and lastly the yellow quarter
starting off from where the green
quarter left off at 192.0 with the last
two octets ending with
255.255 and so this would leave us with
four smaller slash 18 networks broken
down from the previous two
17 networks with each of these networks
consisting of 16
384 ip addresses and we can continue
this process continuously having
networks and breaking them down into
smaller networks this process of
dividing each network into two smaller
networks is known as subnetting and each
time you subnet a network and create two
smaller networks the number in the
prefix will increase and so i know this
is already a lot to take in so this
would be a perfect time for you to grab
a coffee or a tea and i will be ending
part one here and part two will be
continuing immediately after part one so
you can now mark this lesson as complete
and i'll see you in the next one for
part two
[Music]
welcome back and in this lesson i'm
going to be covering the second part of
the networking refresher now part two of
this lesson is starting immediately from
the end of part one so with that being
said let's dive in
now i know this network refresher has
been filled with a ton of numbers
with an underlying current of math but i
wanted you to focus on the why so that
things will make sense later i wanted to
introduce the hard stuff first so that
over the length of this course you will
be able to digest this information
and understand where this fits into
when discussing the different network
parts of google cloud this will also
help you immensely in the real world as
well as the exam when configuring
networks and knowing how to do the job
of an engineer
so getting right into it i wanted to
just do a quick review on classless
inter-domain routing or cider so as
discussed in the first refresher an ipv4
address is referenced in dotted decimal
notation alongside the slash 16 is the
prefix and defines how large the network
is and so before i move on i wanted to
give you some references that i found
helpful in order to determine the size
of a network and so here i have
referenced three of the most common
prefixes
that i continuously run into that i
think would be an extremely helpful
reference for you so if you look at the
first i p address
192.168.0.0
with slash 8 as the prefix slash 8 would
fall under a class a network 192 being
the first octet
as well as being the network part of the
address would be fixed and so the host
part of it would be anything after that
so the address could be 192 dot anything
and this cider range would give you over
16 million ip addresses the second most
common network that i see is a slash 16
network and this would make this ip fall
under a class b network making the first
two octets fixed and being the network
part meaning that anything after 192.168
would be the host part meaning that the
address could be
192.168.anything and this would give you
65536 ip addresses and so for the third
ip address which is probably the most
common one that i see
is a slash 24 network which falls under
a class c network meaning that the first
three octets are fixed and the fourth
octet could be anything from zero to two
five five and this would give you
256 ip addresses and another common one
which is the smallest that you will see
is a slash 32 prefix and this is one
that i use constantly for white listing
my ip address and because a slash 32 is
one ip address this is a good one to
know when you are configuring vpn for
yourself or you're whitelisting your ip
address from home or work and for the
last reference as well as being the
biggest network is the ip address of
0.0.0.1
forward slash 0 which covers all ip
addresses and you will see this commonly
used for the internet gateway in any
cloud environment and so these are some
common prefixes that come up very
frequently and so i hope this reference
will help you now moving back to the osi
model i've covered ipv4 in the network
layer and so now it's time to discuss
ipv6 now as i noted earlier
ipv4 notation is called dotted decimal
and each number between the dots is an
octet with a value of 0 to 255. now
underneath it all each octet is made up
of an 8-bit value and having four
numbers in an ip address that would make
it a 32-bit value ipv6 is a much longer
value and is represented in hexadecimal
and each grouping is two octets which is
16 bits and is often referred to as a
hextet now as these addresses are very
long as you can see you're able to
abbreviate them by removing redundant
zeros so this example shown here is the
same address as the one above it so if
there is a sequence of zeros you can
simply replace them with one zero so in
this address each grouping of four zeros
can be represented by one zero and if
you have multiple groups of zeros in one
address
you can remove them all and replace them
with double colons so each of these ipv6
addresses that you see here are exactly
the same now each ipv6 address is 128
bits long and is represented in a
similar way to
ipv4 starting with the network address
and ending with the prefix each hextet
is 16 bits and the prefix number is the
number of bits that represent the
network with this example
slash 64 refers to the network address
underlined in green which is 2001
colon de3 each hextet is 16 bits and the
prefix is 64. so that's four groups of
16 and so this is how we know which part
is the network part of the address and
which is the host part of the address
again notice the double colon here and
as i explained previously any unneeded
zeros can be replaced by a double colon
and so this address would represent a
slew of zeros and so adding in all the
zeros the ipv6 starting network address
would look like this now because the
network address starts at 2001 colon de3
with another two hextets of zeros as the
network address that was determined by
the slash 64 prefix which is four
hextets it means a network finishes at
that network address followed by all fs
and so that's the process of how we can
determine the start and end of every
ipv6 network now as i've shown you
before with all ipv4 addresses they are
represented with a 0.0.0.0.0
and because ipv6 addresses are
represented by the same network address
and prefix we can represent ipv6
addresses as double colon slash zero and
you will see this frequently when using
ipv6 and so i know this is really
complicated but i just wanted to give
you the exposure of ipv6 i don't expect
you to understand this right away
in the end it should become a lot
clearer as we go through the course and
i promise you it will become a lot
easier i had a hard time myself trying
to understand this network concept
but after a few days i was able to
digest it and as i went back and did
some practice it started to make a lot
more sense to me and so i know as we
move along with the course
that it will start making sense to you
as well so now that we've discussed
layer 3 in the osi model i wanted to get
into layer 4 which is the transport
layer with ip packets discussing tcp and
udp and so in its simplest form a packet
is the basic unit of information in
network transmission so most networks
use tcpip as the network protocol or set
of rules for communication between
devices and the rules of tcpip require
information to be split into packets
that contain a segment of data to be
transferred along with the protocol and
its port number the originating address
and the address of where the data is to
be sent now udp is another protocol that
is sent with ip and is used in specific
applications but mostly in this course i
will be referring to tcpip and so as you
can see in this diagram of the ip packet
this is a basic datagram of what a
packet would look like again with this
source and destination ip address
the protocol port number and the data
itself now this is mainly just to give
you a high level understanding of tcpip
and udpip and is not a deep dive into
networking now moving on to layer 7 of
the osi model
this layer is used by networked
applications or applications that use
the internet and so there are many
protocols that fall under this layer now
these applications do not reside in this
layer but use the protocols in this
layer to function so the application
layer provides services for networked
applications with the help of protocols
to perform user activities and you will
see many of these protocols being
addressed as we go through this course
through resources in google cloud like
http or https for load balancing dns
that uses udp on port 53 and ssh on port
22 for logging into hosts and so these
are just a few of the many scenarios
where layer 7 and the protocols that
reside in that layer come up in this
course and we will be diving into many
more in the lessons to come and so that
about wraps up this networking refresher
lesson
and don't worry like i said before i'm
not expecting you to pick things up in
this first go
things will start to make more sense as
we go through the course and we start
putting these networking concepts into
practice also feel free to go back and
review the last couple of lessons again
if things didn't make sense to you the
first time or if you come across some
networking challenges in future lessons
and so that's everything i wanted to
cover so you can now mark this lesson as
complete and let's move on to the next
one
[Music]
welcome back in this lesson we will be
discussing the core networking service
of gcp virtual private cloud or vpc for
short it is the service that allows you
to create networks inside google cloud
with both private and public
connectivity options both for in-cloud
deployments and on-premise hybrid cloud
deployments this is a service that you
must know well as there are many
questions that come up on the exam with
regards to vpcs so with that being said
let's dive in now vpcs are what manages
the networking functionality for your
google cloud resources this is a
software defined network and is not
confined to the physical limitations of
networking in a data center this has
been abstracted for you vpc networks
including their associated routes and
firewall rules are global resources they
are not associated with any particular
region or zone they are global resources
and span all available regions across
the globe as explained earlier vpcs are
also encapsulated within projects
projects are the logical container where
your vpcs live
now these vpcs do not have ip ranges but
are simply a construct of all of the
individual ip addresses and services
within that network the ip addresses and
ranges are defined within the
subnetworks that i will be diving into a
bit later as well
traffic to and from instances can be
controlled with network firewall rules
rules are implemented on the vms
themselves so traffic can be controlled
and logged as it leaves or arrives at a
vm
now resources within a vpc network
can communicate with one another by
using internal or private ipv4 addresses
and these are subject to applicable
network firewall rules these resources
must be in the same vpc for
communication
otherwise they must traverse the public
internet with an assigned public ip or
use a vpc peering connection or
establish a vpn connection another
important thing to note is that vpc
networks only support ipv4 unicast
traffic they do not support ipv6 traffic
within the network vms in the vpc
network can only send to ipv4
destinations
and only receive traffic from ipv4
sources however it is possible to create
an ipv6 address for a global load
balancer now unless you choose to
disable it each new project starts with
a default network in a vpc the default
network is an auto mode vpc network with
predefined subnets a subnet is allocated
for each region with non-overlapping
cider blocks also each default network
has a default firewall rule
these rules are configured to allow
ingress traffic
for icmp
rdp and ssh traffic from anywhere
as well as ingress traffic from within
the default network for all protocols
and ports and so there are two different
types of vpc networks
auto mode or custom mode an auto mode
network also has one subnet per region
the default network is actually an auto
mode network as explained earlier now
these automatically created subnets use
a set of predefined ip ranges with a
slash 20 cider block that can be
expanded to a slash 16 cider block all
of these subnets
fit within the default
10.128.0.0 ford slash 9 cider block and
as new gcp regions become available
new subnets in those regions are
automatically added to auto mode
networks using an ip range on that block
now a custom owned network does not
automatically create subnets
this type of network provides you with
complete control over its subnets and ip
ranges as well as another note an auto
mode network can be converted to a
custom mode network to gain more control
but please be aware this conversion is
one way meaning that custom networks
cannot be changed to auto mode networks
so when deciding on the different types
of networks you want to use
make sure that you review all of your
considerations now custom mode vpc
networks are more flexible and better
suited to production and google
recommends that you use custom mode vpc
networks in production so here is an
example of a project that contains three
networks all of these networks span
multiple regions across the globe as you
can see here on the right hand side and
each network contains separate vms and
so this diagram is to demonstrate that
vms that are in the same network or vpc
can communicate privately even when
placed in separate regions because vms
in network a are in the same network
they can communicate over internal ip
addresses even though they're in
different regions essentially your vms
can communicate even if they exist in
different locations across the globe as
long as they are within the same network
the vms in network b and network c
are not in the same network therefore by
default these vms must communicate over
external ips even though they're in the
same region as no internal ip
communication is allowed between
networks unless you set up vpc network
peering or use a vpn connection now i
wanted to bring back the focus to the
default vpc for just a minute unless you
create an organizational policy that
prohibits it new projects will always
start with a default network that has
one subnet in each region and again this
is an auto mode vpc network in this
particular example i am showing a
default vpc with seven of its default
regions displayed along with their ip
ranges and again i want to stress that
vpc networks along with their associated
routes and firewall rules are global
resources they are not associated with
any particular region or zone so the
subnets within them are regional and so
when an auto mode vpc network is created
one subnet from each region is
automatically created within it these
automatically created subnets use a set
of predefined ip ranges that fit within
the cider block that you see here
of 10.128.0.049
and as new google cloud regions become
available
new subnets in those regions are
automatically added to auto mode vpc
networks
by using an ip range from that block in
addition to the automatically created
subnets you can add more subnets
manually to auto mode vpc networks in
regions that you choose by using ip
ranges outside of 10.128.0.049
now if you're using a default vbc or
have already created an auto mode vpc
you can switch the vpc network from auto
mode to custom mode and this is a
one-way conversion only as custom mode
vpc networks cannot be changed to auto
mode vpc networks now bringing this
theory into practice with regards to the
default vpc
i wanted to take the time to do a short
demo so whenever you're ready join me in
the console
and so here we are back in the console
and if i go here in the top right hand
corner i am logged in as tony bowties at
gmail.com and in the top drop down
project menu i'm logged in under project
tony and because this demo is geared
around the default vpc i want to
navigate to vpc networks so i'm going to
go over here to the top left hand corner
to the navigation menu
and i'm going to click on it and scroll
down
to vpc network under networking
and so as you can see here in the left
hand menu there are a bunch of different
options that i can choose from but i
won't be touching on any of these topics
as i have other lessons that will deep
dive into those topics so in this demo
i'd like to strictly touch on the
default vpc and as you can see in
project tony it has created a default
vpc for me with a one subnet in every
region having its own ip address range
and so just as a reminder whenever you
create a new project a default vpc will
be automatically created for you and
when these subnets were created each of
them have a route out to the public
internet and so the internet gateway is
listed here its corresponding firewall
rules along with global dynamic routing
and flow logs are turned off and again i
will be getting deeper into routing and
flow logs in later lessons in the
section now earlier i had pointed out
that an auto mode vpc can be converted
to a custom vpc and it's as simple as
clicking this button but we don't want
to do that just yet and what i'd like to
do is drill down into the default vbc
and show you all the different options
as you can see here the dns api has not
been enabled and so for most of you a
good idea would be to enable it and so
i'm going to go ahead and do that now as
well you can see here that i can make
adjustments to each of the different
subnets or i can change the
configuration of the vpc itself so if i
click on this edit button here at the
top i'm able to change the subnet
creation mode along with the dynamic
routing mode which i will get into in a
later lesson and the same thing with the
dns server policy and so to make this
demo a little bit more exciting i want
to show you the process on how to expand
a subnet so i'm going to go into us
central one i'm going to drill down here
and here's all the configuration
settings for the default subnet in the
us central one region and so for me to
edit this subnet i can simply click on
the edit button up here at the top and
so right below the ip address range i am
prompted with a note saying that the ip
ranges must be unique and
non-overlapping as we stated before and
this is a very important point to know
when you're architecting any vpcs or its
corresponding sub networks and so i'm
going to go ahead and change the subnet
from a cider range of 20
and i'm going to change it to 16. i'm
not going to add any secondary ip ranges
i'm going to leave private google access
off and so i'm going to leave everything
else as is
and simply click on save and so once
this has completed i'll be able to see
that my subnet range will go from a
slash 20 to a slash 16. and so here you
can see the ip address range has now
changed to a slash 16. if i go back to
the main page of the vpc network i can
see that the ip address range is
different from all the other ones now
you're probably asking why can't i just
change the ip address range on all the
subnets at once and so even though i'd
love to do that
unfortunately google does not give you
the option each subnet must be
configured one by one to change the ipa
address range now i wanted to quickly
jump into the default firewall rules and
as discussed earlier the rules for
incoming ssh
rdp
and icmp have been pre-populated
along with a default rule that allows
incoming connections for all protocols
and ports
among instances within the same network
so when it comes to routes with regards
to the vpc network the only one i really
wanted to touch on is the default route
to the internet and so without this
route any of the subnets in this vpc
wouldn't have access to route traffic to
the internet and so when the default vpc
is created the default internet gateway
is also created and so now going back to
the main page of the vpc network i
wanted to go through the process
of making the ip address range bigger
but doing it through the command line
and so i'm going to go up to the right
hand corner and open up cloud shell i'm
going to make this a little bit bigger
and so for this demo i'm going to
increase the address range for the
subnet in us west one from a slash 20 to
a slash 16 and so i'm going to paste in
the command
which is gcloud compute networks
subnets expand
ip dash range and then the name of the
network which is default as well as the
region and i'm going to do uswest1 along
with the prefix length which is going to
be 16. so i'm going to hit enter
i've been prompted to make sure that
this is what i want to do and so yes i
do want to continue so i'm going to type
in y for yes and hit enter and so within
a few seconds i should get some
confirmation and as expected my subnet
has been updated and so because i like
to verify everything i'm going to now
clear the screen and i'm going to paste
in the command gcloud compute networks
subnets describe and then the subnet
name which is default along with the
region which would be uswest1 i'm going
to click on enter and as you can see
here the ipsider range is consistent
with what we have changed and if i do a
quick refresh on the browser
i'll be able to see that the console has
reflected the same thing and as expected
the ip address range here for us west
one in the console reflects that which
we see here in cloud shell and so now to
end this demo i wanted to quickly show
you how i can delete the default vpc and
recreate it so all i need to do is to
drill into the settings
and then click on delete vpc network
right here at the top i'm going to get a
prompt to ask me if i'm sure and i'm
going to simply click on delete now just
as a note if you have any resources that
are in any vpc networks you will not be
able to delete the vpc you would have to
delete the resources first and then
delete the vpc afterwards okay and it
has been successfully deleted and as you
can see there are no local vpc networks
in this current project and so i want to
go ahead and recreate the default vpc so
i'm going to simply click on create vpc
network and so here i'm prompted to
enter in a bunch of information
for creating this new vpc network and so
keeping with the spirit of default vpcs
i'm going to name this vpc default
i'm going to put default in the
description and under subnet creation
mode i'm going to click on automatic and
as you can see a prompt came up telling
me these ip address ranges will be
assigned to each region in your vpc
network and i'm able to review the ip
address ranges for each region and as
stated before the ip address ranges for
each region will always be the same
every time i create
this default vpc or create a vpc in the
automatic subnet creation mode
now as a note here under firewall rules
if i don't select these firewall rules
none will actually be created so if
you're creating a new default vpc be
sure to check these off and so i'm going
to leave everything else as is and i'm
going to simply go to the bottom and
click on the create button and within
about a minute i should have the new
default vpc created okay and we are back
in business the default vpc has been
recreated with all of these subnets in
its corresponding regions all the ip
address ranges the firewall rules
everything that we saw earlier in the
default vpc and so that's pretty much
all i wanted to cover in this demo on
the default vpc network along with the
lesson on vpcs so you can now mark this
lesson as complete and let's move on to
the next
one welcome back and in this lesson i'm
going to be discussing vpc network
subnets now the terms subnet and sub
network are synonymous and are used
interchangeably in google cloud as
you'll hear me using either one in this
lesson yet i am referring to the same
thing now when you create a resource in
google cloud you choose a network and a
subnet and so because a subnet is needed
before creating resources some good
knowledge behind it is necessary for
both building and google cloud as well
as in the exam so in this lesson i'll be
covering subnets at a deeper level with
all of its features and functionality so
with that being said let's dive in
now each vpc network consists of one or
more useful ip range partitions
called subnets also known in google
cloud as sub networks each subnet is
associated with the region and vpc
networks do not have any ip address
ranges associated with them ip ranges
are defined for the subnets a network
must have at least one subnet before you
can use it and as mentioned earlier when
you create a project it will create a
default vpc network with subnets in each
region automatically auto mode will run
under this same functionality now custom
vpc networks on the other hand start
with no subnets giving you full control
over subnet creation and you can create
more than one subnet per region you
cannot change the name or region of a
subnet after you've created it you would
have to delete the subnet and replace it
as long as no resources are using it
primary and secondary ranges for subnets
cannot overlap with any allocated range
any primary or secondary range of
another subnet in the same network
or any ip ranges of subnets in peered
networks in other words they must be a
unique valid cider block now when it
comes to ip addresses of a subnet google
cloud vpc has an amazing feature that
lets you increase the ip space of any
subnets without any workload shutdown or
downtime as demonstrated earlier in the
previous lesson and this gives you the
flexibility and growth options to meet
your needs but unfortunately there are
some caveats the new subnet must not
overlap with other subnets in the same
vpc network in any region also the new
subnets must stay inside the rfc 1918
address space the new network range must
be larger than the original which means
the prefix length must be smaller in
number and once a subnet has been
expanded you cannot undo an expansion
now auto mode network starts with a
slash 20 range that can be expanded to a
16 ip range but not larger you can also
convert the auto mode network to a
custom mode network to increase the ip
range even further and again this is a
one-way conversion
custom mode vpc networks cannot be
changed to auto mode vpc networks
now in any network that is created in
google cloud
there will always be some ip addresses
that you will not be able to use and
these are reserved for google and so
every subnet has four reserved ip
addresses in its primary ip range and
just as a note there are no reserved ip
addresses in the secondary ip ranges and
these reserved ips can be looked at as
the first two and the last two ip
addresses in the cider range now the
first address in the primary ip range
for the subnet is reserved for the
network the second address in the
primary ip range for the subnet is
reserved for the default gateway and
allows you access to the internet the
second to last address in the primary ip
range for the subnet is reserved for
google cloud for potential future use
and the last address and the ip range
for the subnet is for broadcast
and so that about covers this short yet
important lesson on vpc network subnets
these features and functionalities of
subnets that have been presented to you
will help you make better design
decisions that will give you a bit more
knowledge and flexibility when it comes
to assigning ipspace within your vpc
networks and so that's all i have to
cover for this lesson so you can now
mark this lesson as complete and let's
move on to the next one
[Music]
welcome back and in this lesson i'm
going to be going through
routing and private google access
now although routing doesn't really show
up in the exam i wanted to give you an
inside look on how traffic is routed so
when you're building in google cloud
you'll know exactly what you will need
to do if you need to edit these routes
in any way or if you need to build new
ones to satisfy your particular need now
private google access does pop its head
in the exam but only at a high level but
i wanted to get just a bit deeper with
the service and get into the data flow
of when the service is enabled so with
that being said let's dive in now google
cloud routes define the paths that
network traffic takes from a vm instance
to other destinations these destinations
can be inside your google cloud vpc
network for example in another vm or
outside it in a vpc network a route
consists of a single destination
and a single next hop when an instance
in a vpc network sends a packet google
cloud delivers the packet to the route's
next hop if the packet's destination
address is within the route's
destination range
and so all these routes are stored in
the routing table for the vpc now for
those of you who are not familiar with a
routing table in computer networking a
routing table is a data table stored in
a router or a network host that lists
the routes to particular network
destinations and so in this case the vpc
is responsible for storing the routing
table as well each vm instance has a
controller that is kept informed of all
applicable routes
from the network's routing table each
packet leaving a vm
is delivered to the appropriate next hop
of an applicable route based on a
routing order now i wanted to take a
couple minutes to go through the
different routing types that are
available on google cloud now in google
cloud there are two types of routing
there is the system generated which
offers the default and subnet route and
then there are the custom routes which
support static routes and dynamic routes
and so i first wanted to cover system
generated routes in a little bit of
depth and so every new network whether
it be an automatic vpc or a custom vpc
has two types of system generated routes
a default route which you can remove or
replace and one subnet route for each of
its subnets now when you create a vpc
network google cloud creates a system
generated default route and this route
serves two purposes it defines the path
out of the vpc network including the
path to the internet in addition to
having this route instances must meet
additional requirements if they need
internet access the default route also
provides a standard path for private
google access and if you want to
completely isolate your network from the
internet or if you need to replace the
default route with the custom route you
can delete the default route now if you
remove the default route and do not
replace it packets destined to ip ranges
that are not covered by other routes are
dropped lastly the system generated
default route has a priority of 1000
because its destination is the broadest
possible which covers all ip addresses
in the
0.0.0.0.0 range google cloud only uses
it if a route with a more specific
destination does not apply to a packet
and i'll be getting into priorities in
just a little bit and so now that we've
covered the default route i wanted to
get into the subnet route now subnet
routes are system generated routes that
define paths to each subnet in the vpc
network each subnet has at least one
subnet route whose destination matches
the primary ip range of the subnet if
the subnet has secondary ip ranges
google cloud creates a subnet route with
a corresponding destination for each
secondary range no other route can have
a destination that matches
or is more specific than the destination
of a subnet route you can create a
custom route that has a broader
destination range that contains the
subnet route's destination range now
when a subnet is created a corresponding
subnet route for the subnet's primary
and secondary ip range is also created
auto mode vpc networks create a subnet
route for the primary ip ranges of each
of their automatically created subnets
you can delete these subnets but only if
you convert the auto mode vpc network to
custom mode and you cannot delete a
subnet route unless you modify or delete
the subnet so when you delete a subnet
all subnet routes for both primary and
secondary ranges are deleted
automatically you cannot delete the
subnet route for the subnet's primary
range in any other way and just as a
note when networks are connected by
using vpc network peering which i will
get into a little bit later some subnet
routes from one network are imported
into the other network and vice versa
and cannot be removed unless you break
the peering relationship and so when you
break the peering relationship all
imported subnet routes from the other
network are automatically removed so now
that we've covered the system generated
routes i wanted to get into custom
routes now custom routes are either
static routes that you can create
manually or dynamic routes maintained
automatically by one or more of your
cloud routers and these are created on
top of the already created system
generated routes destinations for custom
routes cannot match or be specific than
any subnet route in the network now
static routes can use any of the static
route next hops and these can be created
manually if you use the google cloud
console to create a cloud vpn tunnel
that uses policy-based routing or one
that is a route based vpn static routes
for the remote traffic selectors are
created for you and so just to give you
a little bit more clarity and a little
bit of context i've included a
screenshot here for all the different
routes that are available for the next
hop we have the default internet gateway
to define a path to external ip
addresses specify an instance and this
is where traffic is directed to the
primary internal ip address of the vm's
network interface in the vpc network
where you define the route specify ip
address is where you provide an internal
ip address assigned to a google cloud vm
as a next hop for cloud vpn tunnels that
use policy based routing and route-based
vpns you can direct traffic to the vpn
tunnel by creating routes whose next
hops refer to the tunnel by its name and
region and just as a note google cloud
ignores routes whose next hops are cloud
vpn tunnels that are down and lastly for
internal tcp and udp low balancing you
can use a load balancer's ip address as
a next hop that distributes traffic
among healthy back-end instances custom
static routes that use this next hop
cannot be scoped to specific instances
by network tags and so when creating
static routes you will always be asked
for different parameters that are needed
in order to create this route and so
here i've taken a screenshot from the
console to give you a bit more context
with regards to the information that's
needed so first up is the name and
description
so these fields identify the route a
name is required but a description is
optional and every route in your project
must have a unique name next up is the
network and each route must be
associated with exactly one vpc network
in this case it happens to be the
default network but if you have other
networks available you're able to click
on the drop down arrow and choose a
different network the destination range
is a single ipv4 cider block that
contains the ip addresses of systems
that receive incoming packets and the ip
range must be entered as a valid ipv4
cider block as shown in the example
below the field now if multiple routes
have identical destinations priority is
used to determine which route should be
used so a lower number would indicate a
higher priority for example a route with
a priority value of 100 has a higher
priority than one with a priority value
of 200 so the highest route priority
means the smallest possible non-negative
number as well another great example is
if you look back on your default routes
all your subnet routes are of a priority
of zero and the default internet gateway
is of a priority of 1000 and therefore
the subnet routes will take priority
over the default internet gateway and
this is due to the smaller number so
remember a good rule of thumb is that
the lower the number the higher the
priority the higher the number the lower
the priority now to get a little bit
more granular you can specify a list of
network tags so that the route only
applies to instances that have at least
one of the listed tags and if you don't
specify any tags then google cloud
applies the route to all instances in
the network and finally next hop which
was shown previously this is dedicated
to static routes that have next hops
that point to the options shown earlier
so now that i've covered static routes
in a bit of detail i want to get into
dynamic routes now dynamic routes are
managed by one or more cloud routers and
this allows you to dynamically exchange
routes between a vpc network and an
on-premises network with dynamic routes
their destinations always represent ip
ranges outside of your vpc network
and their next hops are always bgp peer
addresses a cloud router can manage
dynamic routes for cloud vpn tunnels
that use dynamic routing as well as
cloud interconnect and don't worry i'll
be getting into cloud routers in a bit
of detail in a later lesson now i wanted
to take a minute to go through routing
order and the routing order deals with
priorities that i touched on a little
bit earlier now subnet routes are always
considered first because google cloud
requires that subnet routes have the
most specific destinations matching the
ip address ranges of their respective
subnets if no applicable destination is
found google cloud drops the packet and
replies with a network unreachable error
system generated routes apply to all
instances in the vpc network the scope
of instances to which subnet routes
apply cannot be altered although you can
replace the default route and so just as
a note custom static routes apply to all
instances or specific instances so if
the route doesn't have a network tag the
route applies to all instances in the
network now vpc networks have special
routes that are used for certain
services and these are referred to as
special return paths in google cloud
these routes are defined outside of your
vpc network in google's production
network they don't appear in your vpc
network's routing table you cannot
remove them or override them or if you
delete or replace a default route in
your vpc network although you can
control traffic to and from these
services by using firewall rules and the
services that are covered are load
balancers internet aware proxy or iap as
well as cloud dns and so before i end
this lesson i wanted to touch on private
google access now vm instances that only
have internal ip addresses can use
private google access and this allows
them to reach the external ip addresses
of google's apis and services the source
ip address of the packet can be the
primary internal ip address of the
network interface or an address in an
alias ip range that is assigned to the
interface if you disable private google
access the vm instances can no longer
reach google apis and services and will
only be able to send traffic within the
vpc network private google access has no
effect on instances that have
external ip addresses and can still
access the internet they don't need any
special configuration to send requests
to the external ip addresses of google
apis and services you enable private
google access on a subnet by subnet
basis and it's a setting for subnets in
a vpc network and i will be showing you
this in an upcoming demo where we'll be
building our own custom vpc network now
even though the next hop for the
required routes is called the default
internet gateway
and the ip addresses for google apis and
services are external requests to google
apis and services from vms that only
hold internal ip addresses in subnet 1
where private google access is enabled
are not sent through the public internet
those requests stay within google's
network as well vms that only have
internal ip addresses do not meet the
internet access requirements
for access to other external ip
addresses
beyond those for google apis and
services now touching on this diagram
here
firewall rules in the vpc network have
been configured to allow internet access
vm1 can access google apis and services
including cloud storage because its
network interface is located in subnet 1
which has private google access enabled
and because this instance only has an
internal ip address
private google access applies to this
instance now with vm2 it can also access
google apis and services including cloud
storage because it has an external ip
address private google access has no
effect on this instance as it has an
external ip address and private google
access has not been enabled on that
subnet and because both of these
instances are in the same network they
are still able to communicate with each
other over an internal subnet route and
so this is just one way where private
google access can be applied there are
some other options for private access as
well you can use private google access
to connect to google apis and services
from your on-premises network through a
cloud vpn tunnel or cloud interconnect
without having any external ip addresses
you also have the option of using
private google access through a vpc
network peering connection which is
known as private services access and
finally the last option available for
private google access is connecting
directly from serverless google services
through an internal vpc connection now i
know this has been a lot of theory to
take in but i promise it'll become a lot
easier and concepts will become less
complicated when we start putting this
into practice coming up soon in the demo
of building our own custom vpc and so
that's pretty much all i wanted to cover
when it comes to routing and private
google access so you can now mark this
lesson as complete and let's move on to
the next one
[Music]
welcome back and in this lesson i'm
going to be discussing ip addressing now
in the network refresher lesson i went
into a bit of depth on how i p addresses
are broken down and used for
communication in computer networks in
this lesson i'll be getting into the
available types of ip addressing in
google cloud and how they are used in
each different scenario please note for
the exam a high level overview will be
needed to know when it comes to ip
addressing but the details behind it
will give you a better understanding on
when to use each type of ip address so
with that being said let's dive in
now ip addressing in google cloud holds
quite a few categories
and really start by determining whether
you are planning for communication
internally within your vpc or for
external use to communicate with the
outside world through the internet once
you determine the type of communication
that you're looking to apply between
resources some more decisions need to be
made with regards to the other options
and i will be going through these
options in just a sec now in order to
make these options a little bit more
digestible i wanted to start off with
the options available for internal ip
addresses
now internal ip addresses are not
publicly advertised they are used only
within a network now every vpc network
or on-premises network has at least one
internal ip address range resources with
internal ip addresses communicate with
other resources as if they're all on the
same private network now every vm
instance can have one primary internal
ip address that is unique to the vpc
network and you can assign a specific
internal ip address when you create a vm
instance or you can reserve a static
internal ip address for your project and
assign that address to your resources if
you don't specify an address one will be
automatically assigned to the vm in
either case the address must belong to
the ip range of the subnet and so if
your network is an auto mode vpc network
the address comes from the region subnet
if your network is a custom mode vpc
network you must specify which subnet
the ip address comes from now all
subnets have a primary sider range which
is the range of internal ip addresses
that define the subnet each vm instance
gets its primary internal ip address
from this range you can also allocate
alias ip ranges from that primary range
or you can add a secondary range to the
subnet and allocate alias ip ranges from
the secondary range use of alias ip
ranges does not require secondary subnet
ranges these secondary subnet ranges
merely provide an organizational tool
now when using ip aliasing you can
configure multiple internal ip addresses
representing containers or applications
hosted in a vm without having to define
a separate network interface and you can
assign vm alias ip ranges from either
the subnet's primary or secondary ranges
when alias ip ranges are configured
google cloud automatically installs vpc
network routes for primary and alias ip
ranges for the subnet of your primary
network interface your container
orchestrator or gke does not need to
specify vpc network connectivity for
these routes and this simplifies routing
traffic and managing your containers now
when choosing either an auto mode vpc or
a custom vpc you will have the option to
choose either an ephemeral ip or a
static ip now an ephemeral ip address is
an ip address that doesn't persist
beyond the life of the resource for
example when you create an instance or
forwarding rule without specifying an ip
address google cloud will automatically
assign the resource an ephemeral ip
address and this ephemeral ip address is
released when you delete the resource
when the ip address is released it is
free to eventually be assigned to
another resource so is never a great
option if you depend on this ip to
remain the same this ephemeral ip
address can be automatically assigned
and will be assigned from the selected
region subnet as well if you have
ephemeral ip addresses that are
currently in use
you can promote these addresses to
static internal ip addresses so that
they remain with your project until you
actively remove them and just as a note
before you reserve an existing ip
address you will need the value of the
ip address that you want to promote now
reserving a static ip address
assigns the address to your project
until you explicitly release it this is
useful if you are dependent on a
specific ip address for a specific
service and need to prevent another
resource from being able to use the same
address static addresses are also useful
if you need to move an ip address from
one google cloud resource to another and
you also have the same options when
creating an internal load balancer as
you do with vm instances and so now that
we've covered all the options for
internal ip addresses i would like to
move on to cover all the available
options for external ip addresses now
you can assign an external ip address to
an instance or a forwarding rule if you
need to communicate with the internet
with resources in another network or
need to communicate with a public google
cloud service sources from outside a
google cloud vpc network can address a
specific resource by the external ip
address as long as firewall rules enable
the connection and only resources with
an external ip address can send and
receive traffic directly to and from
outside the network and like internal ip
addresses external ip addresses have the
option of choosing from an ephemeral or
static ip address now an ephemeral
external ip address is an ip address
that doesn't persist beyond the life of
the resource and so follows the same
rules as ephemeral internal ip addresses
so when you create an instance or
forwarding rule without specifying an ip
address the resource is automatically
assigned an ephemeral external ip
address and this is something that you
will see quite often ephemeral external
ip addresses are released from a
resource if you delete the resource for
vm instances the ephemeral external ip
address is also released if you stop the
instance so after you restart the
instance it is assigned a new ephemeral
external ip address and if you have an
existing vm that doesn't have an
external ip address you can assign one
to it forwarding rules always have an ip
address whether external or internal so
you don't need to assign an ip address
to a forwarding rule after it is created
and if your instance has an ephemeral
external ip address and you want to
permanently assign the ip to your
project like ephemeral internal ip
addresses you have the option to promote
the ip address from ephemeral to static
and in this case promoting an ephemeral
external ip address to a static external
ip address now when assigning a static
ip address these are assigned to a
project long term until they are
explicitly released from that assignment
and remain attached to a resource until
they are explicitly detached for vm
instances static external ip addresses
remain attached to stopped instances
until they are removed and this is
useful if you are dependent on a
specific ip address for a specific
service like a web server or a global
load balancer that needs access to the
internet static external ip addresses
can be either a regional or global
resource
in a regional static ip address allows
resources of that region
or resources of zones within that region
to use the ip address and just as a note
you can use your own publicly routable
ip address prefixes as google cloud
external ip addresses and advertise them
on the internet the only caveat is that
you must own and bring at the minimum a
24 cider block and so now that we've
discussed internal and external ip
addressing options i wanted to move into
internal ip address reservations now
static internal ips provide the ability
to reserve internal ip addresses
from the ip range configured in the
subnet then assign those reserved
internal addresses to resources as
needed reserving an internal ip address
takes that address out of the dynamic
allocation pool and prevents it from
being used for automatic allocations
with the ability to reserve static
internal ip addresses you can always use
the same ip address for the same
resource even if you have to delete and
recreate the resource so when it comes
to internal ip address reservation you
can either reserve a static internal ip
address before creating the associated
resource or you can create the resource
with an ephemeral internal ip address
and then promote that ephemeral ip
address to a static internal ip address
and so just to give you a bit more
context i have a diagram here to run you
through it so in the first example you
would create a subnet from your vpc
network you would then reserve an
internal ip address from that subnet's
primary ip range and in this diagram is
marked as 10.12.4.3
and will be held as reserved for later
use with a resource and then when you
decide to create a vm instance or an
internal load balancer you can use the
reserved ip address that was created in
the previous step that i p address then
becomes marked as reserved and in use
now touching on the second example you
would first create a subnet from your
vpc network
you would then create a vm instance or
an internal load balancer with either an
automatically allocated ephemeral ip
address or a specific ip address that
you've chosen from within that specific
subnet and so once the ephemeral ip
address is in use you can then promote
the ephemeral ip address to a static
internal ip address and would then
become reserved and in use now when it
comes to the external ip address
reservation
you are able to obtain a static external
ip address by using one of the following
two options you can either reserve a new
static external ip address and then
assign the address to a new vm instance
or you can promote an existing ephemeral
external ip address to become a static
external ip address now in the case of
external ip addresses you can reserve
two different types
a regional ip address which can be used
by vm instances with one or more network
interfaces or by network load balancers
these ip addresses can be created either
in the console or through the command
line with the limitation that you will
only be allowed to create ipv4 ip
addresses the other type is a global ip
address which can be used for global
load balancers and can be created either
in the console or through the command
line as shown here the limitation here
is that you must choose the premium
network service tier in order to create
a global ip address
and after reserving the address you can
finally assign it to an instance during
instance creation or to an existing
instance and so as you can see there is
a lot to take in when it comes to
understanding ip addressing and i hope
this lesson has given you some better
insight as to which type of ips should
be used in a specific scenario now don't
worry the options may seem overwhelming
but once you start working with ip
addresses more often the options will
become so much clearer on what to use
and when and as i said in the beginning
only high level concepts are needed to
know for the exam but knowing the
options will allow you to make better
decisions
in your daily role as a cloud engineer
and so that's pretty much all i wanted
to cover when it comes to ip addressing
in google cloud and so now that we've
covered the theory behind ip addressing
in google cloud i wanted to bring this
into the console for a demo where we
will get hands-on with creating both
internal and external static ip
addresses so as i explained before there
was a lot to take in with this lesson so
now would be a perfect opportunity to
get up and have a stretch grab yourself
a tea or a coffee and whenever you're
ready join me back in the console so you
can now mark this lesson as complete and
i'll see you in the next
[Music]
welcome back in this demonstration i'm
going to be going over how to create and
apply both internal and external static
ip addresses i'm going to show how to
create them in both the console and the
command line as well as how to promote
ip addresses from ephemeral ips to
static ips and once we're done creating
all the ip addresses i'm going to show
you the steps on how to delete them now
there's a lot to get done here so let's
dive in now for this demonstration i'm
going to be using a project that has the
default vpc created and so in my case i
will be using project bowtieinc dev and
so before you start make sure that your
default vpc is created in the project
that you had selected so in order to do
that i'm going to head over to the
navigation menu i'm going to scroll down
to vpc network and we're going to see
here that the default vpc has been
created and so i can go ahead and start
the demonstration and so the first thing
i wanted to demonstrate is how to create
a static internal ip address and so in
order for me to demonstrate this i'm
going to be using a vm instance and so
i'm going to head over to the navigation
menu again and i'm going to scroll down
to compute engine
and so here i'm going to create my new
instance by simply clicking on create
instance and so under name i'm going to
keep it as instance 1. under region you
want to select us east one and i'm going
to keep the zone as the default selected
under machine type i'm going to select
the drop down and select e2 micro and
i'm going to leave everything else as
the default i'm going to scroll down
here to management security disks
networking and soul tenancy and i'm
going to select the networking tab from
there
and so under here i'm going to select
under network interfaces the default
network interface and here is where i
can create my static internal ip and so
clicking on the drop down under primary
internal ip you will see ephemeral
automatic ephemeral custom and reserve
static internal ip address and so you're
going to select reserve static internal
ip address and you'll get a pop-up
prompting you with some fields to fill
out to reserve a static internal ip
address and so under name i'm going to
call this
static dash internal and for the
purposes of this demo i'm going to leave
the subnet and the static ip address as
the currently selected if i wanted to
select a specific ip address i can click
on this drop down and select let me
choose and this will give me the option
to enter in a custom ip address with the
subnet range that is selected for this
specific sub network and so because i'm
not going to do that i'm going to select
assign automatically i'm going to leave
the purpose as non-shared and i'm going
to simply click on reserve and this is
going to reserve this specific ip
address and now as you can see here i
have the primary internal ip marked as
static internal and so this is going to
be my first static internal ip address
and so once you've done these steps you
can simply click on done and you can
head on down to the bottom and simply
click on create to create the instance
and when the instance finishes creating
you will see the internal static ip
address and as you can see here your
static internal ip address has been
assigned to the default network
interface on instance 1. and so in order
for me to view this static internal ip
address in the console i can view this
in vpc networks and drill down into the
specific vpc and find it under static
internal ip addresses but i wanted to
show you how to view it by querying it
through the command line and so in order
to do this i'm going to simply go up to
the menu bar on the right hand side and
open up cloud shell and once cloud shell
has come up you're going to simply paste
in the command
gcloud compute addresses list and this
will give me a list of the internal ip
addresses that are available and so now
i'm going to be prompted to authorize
this api call using my credentials and i
definitely do so i'm going to click on
authorize and as expected the static
internal ip address that we created
earlier has shown up it's marked as
internal in the region of us east one in
the default subnet and the status is in
use and so as we discussed in the last
lesson static ip addresses persist even
after the resource has been deleted and
so to demonstrate this i'm going to now
delete the instance i'm going to simply
check off the instance and go up to the
top and click on delete you're going to
be prompted to make sure if you want to
delete this yes i do so i'm going to
click on delete and so now that the
instance has been deleted i'm going to
query the ip addresses again by using
the same command gcloud compute
addresses list i'm going to hit enter
and as you can see here the ip address
static dash internal still persists but
the status is now marked as reserved and
so if i wanted to use this ip address
for another instance i can do so by
simply clicking on create instance up
here at the top menu and then i can
select static dash internal as my ip
address so i'm going to quickly close
down cloud shell
and i'm going to leave the name as
instance one the region
can select us east one and we're going
to keep the zone as the default selected
under machine type you're going to
select the e2 micro machine type going
to scroll down to management security
disks networking into soul tenancy and
i'm going to select the networking tab
from under here
and under network interfaces i'm going
to select the default network interface
and under primary internal ip
if i click on the drop down i have the
option of selecting the static dash
internal static ip address and so i
wanted to move on to demonstrate how to
promote an internal ephemeral ip address
to an internal static ip address and so
in order to do this i'm going to select
on ephemeral automatic and i'm going to
scroll down and click on done and i'm
going to go ahead and create the
instance and once the instance is ready
i'll be able to go in and edit the
network interface and so the instance is
up and ready and so i'm going to drill
down into the instance
and i'm going to go up to the top and
click on edit i'm going to scroll down
to network interfaces and i'm going to
edit the default network interface so
i'm going to scroll down a little bit
more and here under internal iptype i'm
going to click on the drop down and i'm
going to select static
and so here you are taking the current
ip address which is 10.142.0.4
and promoting it to a static internal ip
address and so you're going to be
prompted with a pop-up confirming the
reservation for that static internal ip
address and so notice that i don't have
any other options and so all i'm going
to do is type in a name and i'm going to
call this promoted
static and i'm going to click on reserve
and this will promote the internal ip
address from an ephemeral ip address to
a static ip address and so now i'm just
going to click on done
and i'm going to scroll down and click
on save and so now because i want to
verify the ip address i'm going to go
ahead and open up the cloud shell again
and i'm going to use the same command
that i used earlier which is gcloud
compute addresses list and i'm going to
hit enter
as expected the promoted static ip
address is showing as an internal ip
address in the region of us east 1 in
the default subnet and its status is in
use and so just as a recap we've created
a static internal ip address for the
first instance and for the second
instance we promoted an ephemeral
internal ip address into a static
internal ip address and we were able to
verify this through cloud shell using
the gcloud compute addresses list
command and so this is the end of part
one of this demo it was getting a bit
long so i decided to break it up and
this would be a great opportunity for
you to get up and have a stretch get
yourself a coffee or tea and whenever
you're ready join me in part two where
we will be starting immediately from the
end of part one so you can now mark this
as complete and i'll see you in the next
one
[Music]
welcome back this is part two of the
creating internal and external ip
addresses demo and we will be starting
immediately from the end of part one so
with that being said let's dive in and
so now that we've gone through how to
both create static ip addresses and
promote ephemeral ip addresses to static
ip addresses for internal ips
i want to go ahead and go through the
same with external ips and so i'm going
to first start off by deleting this
instance i'm going to go ahead and click
on delete
and so instead of doing it through the
compute engine interface i want to go
into the external ip address interface
which can be found in the vpc network
menu
so i'm going to go ahead up to the left
hand corner click on the navigation menu
and i'm going to scroll down to vpc
network
and from the menu here on the left hand
side you can simply click on external ip
addresses
and here you will see the console where
you can create a static external ip
address and so to start the process you
can simply click on reserve static
address and so here you'll be prompted
with a bunch of fields to fill out to
create this new external static ip
address and so for the name of this
static ip address you can simply call
this external dash static i'm going to
use the same in the description now here
under network service tier i can choose
from either the premium or the standard
and as you can see i'm currently using
the premium network service tier and if
i hover over the question mark over here
it tells me a little bit more about this
network service tier and as you can see
the premium tier allows me higher
performance as well as lower latency
routing but this premium routing comes
at a cost
whereas the standard network service
tier offers a lower performance compared
to the premium network service tier and
is a little bit more cost effective but
still delivering performance that's
comparable with other cloud providers
and so i'm just going to leave it as the
default selected and as we discussed in
the previous lesson ipv6 external static
ip addresses can only be used for global
load balancers and so since we're only
using it for an instance an ipv4 address
will suffice and so just as a note for
network service tier if i click on
standard ipv6 is grayed out as well as
the global selection and this is because
in order to use global load balancing
you need to be using the premium network
service tier so whenever you're creating
a global load balancer please keep this
in mind as your cost may increase so i'm
going to switch this back to premium and
so under type i'm going to keep it as
regional and under region i'm going to
select the same region that my instance
is going to be in which is us east 1 and
because i haven't created the instance
yet there is nothing to attach it to and
so i'm going to click on the drop down
and click on none and so just as another
note i wanted to quickly highlight this
caution point that the static ip
addresses
not attached to an instance or low
balancer are still billed at an hourly
rate so if you're not using any static
ip addresses
please remember to delete them otherwise
you will be charged and so everything
looks good here to create my external
static ip address so i'm going to simply
click on reserve
and this will create my external static
ip address
and put the status of it as reserved so
as you can see here the external static
ip address has been created and you will
find all of your external static ip
addresses that you create in future
right here in this menu and you will
still be able to query all these
external ip addresses from the command
line and so now in order to assign this
ip address to a network interface i'm
going to go back over to the navigation
menu and scroll down to compute engine
and create a new instance so you can go
ahead and click on create instance i'm
going to go ahead and keep the name of
this instance as instance one and in the
region i'm going to select us east one
i'm going to keep the zone as the
selected default and under machine type
i'm going to select the e2 micro machine
type i'm going to scroll down to
management security disks networking and
soul tenancy and i'm going to select the
networking tab and here under network
interfaces i'm going to select the
default network interface i'm going to
scroll down a little bit here and under
external ip
ephemeral has been selected but if i
click on the drop down i will have the
option to select the ip that we had just
created which is the external dash
static ip and so i'm going to select
that i'm going to click on done and you
can go down and click on create and so
now when the instance is created i will
see the external ip address
of external static as the assigned
external ip and as expected here it is
and because i always like to verify my
work i'm going to go ahead and open up
the cloud shell and verify it through
the command line
and so now i'm going to query all my
available static ip addresses using the
command gcloud compute addresses list
i'm going to hit enter
and as you can see here the external
static ip address of 34.75.76
in the us east one region is now in use
and this is because it is assigned to
the network interface on instance one
and so before we go ahead and complete
this demo there's one more step that i
wanted to go through and this is to
promote an ephemeral external ip address
to a static external ip address and so
i'm going to go up here to the top menu
and create a new instance i'm going to
leave the name here as instance two
under the region i'm going to select us
east one i'm going to keep the zone as
the selected default under machine type
i'm going to select the e2 micro machine
type i'm going to leave everything else
as the default and i'm going to scroll
down to management security disks
networking and soul tenancy and select
the networking tab and i'm going to
verify that i'm going to be using an
ephemeral external ip upon the creation
of this instance if i scroll down here a
little bit i can see that an external
ephemeral ip address will be used upon
creation and this will be the ip address
that i will be promoting to a static ip
through the command line so i'm going to
go ahead and scroll down click on done
and then i'm going to scroll down and
click on create and once this instance
is created then i can go ahead and
promote the ephemeral external ip
address okay and the instance has been
created along with its external
ephemeral ip address and so now i can go
ahead and promote this ephemeral ip
address so in order for me to do this
i'm going to move back to my cloud shell
and i'm going to quickly clear my screen
and i'm going to use the command gcloud
compute addresses create and then the
name that we want to use for this static
external ip address so i'm going to call
this promoted external i'm going to use
the flag dash dash addresses and so here
i will need the external ip address that
i am promoting
which is going to be 104.196.219.42
and so i'm going to copy this to my
clipboard and i'm going to paste it here
in the command line and now i'm going to
add the region flag
along with the region of us east one and
i'm going to go ahead and hit enter
and success my ephemeral external ip
address has been promoted to a static
external ip address and of course to
verify it i'm going to simply type in
the gcloud compute addresses list
command i'm going to hit enter and as
expected here it is the promoted
external ip of 104.196.219.42
marked as external in the u.s east one
region and the status is marked as in
use and so i wanted to take a moment to
congratulate you on making it through
this demonstration of creating internal
and external ip addresses as well as
promoting them so just as a recap you've
created a static internal ip address in
conjunction with creating a new instance
and assigning it to that instance you
then created another instance and used
an ephemeral ip and then promoted it to
a static internal ip address
you then created an external static ip
address using the console and assigned
it to a brand new instance you then
created another instance using an
external ephemeral ip address and
promoted it to a static external ip
address and you did this all using both
the console and the command line so i
wanted to congratulate you on a great
job now before we end this demonstration
i wanted to go through the steps of
cleaning up any leftover resources so
the first thing you want to do is delete
these instances so you can select them
all and go up to the top and click on
delete it's going to ask you if you want
to delete the two instances yes we do
click on delete and this will delete
your instances and free up the external
ip addresses so that you're able to
delete them and so now that the
instances have been deleted i'm going to
go over to the vpc network menu and i'm
going to head on over to the external ip
address console
and here i'm able to delete the external
ip addresses and so i'm going to select
all of them and i'm going to go up to
the top menu and click on release static
address and you should get a prompt
asking you if you want to delete both
these addresses the answer is yes click
on delete and within a few seconds these
external ip addresses should be deleted
and so now all that's left to delete are
the two static internal ip addresses
and as i said before because there is no
console to be able to view any of these
static internal ip addresses i have to
do it through the command line so i'm
going to go back to my cloud shell i'm
going to clear the screen and i'm going
to list the ip addresses currently in my
network and so here they are promoted
static and static internal and so the
command to delete any static ip
addresses is as follows gcloud compute
addresses delete the name of the ip
address that i want to delete which is
promoted static and then i will need the
region flag and it'll be the region of
us east one and i'm going to go ahead
and hit enter it's going to prompt me if
i want to continue with this and i'm
going to type y for yes hit enter
and success it has been deleted and so
just a double check i'm going to do a
quick verification
and yes it has been deleted and so all
that's left to delete is the static
internal ip address and so i'm going to
paste in the command
gcloud compute addresses delete the name
of the ip address that i want to delete
which is static dash internal along with
the region flag of us east one i'm going
to go ahead and hit enter
y for yes to continue
and success and one last verification to
make sure that it's all cleared up and
as you can see i have no more static i p
addresses and so this concludes this
demonstration on creating assigning and
deleting both static internal and static
external ip addresses and so again i
wanted to congratulate you on a great
job and so that's pretty much all i
wanted to cover
in this demo on creating internal and
external static ip addresses so you can
now mark this as complete and i'll see
you in the next one
[Music]
welcome back
in this lesson i will be diving into
some network security by introducing vpc
firewall rules a service used to filter
incoming and outgoing network traffic
based on a set of user-defined rules
a concept that you should be fairly
familiar with for the exam
and comes up extremely often when
working as an engineer in google cloud
it is definitely an essential security
layer that prevents unwanted access to
your cloud infrastructure
now vpc firewall rules apply to a given
project and network
and if you'd like you can also apply
firewall rules across an organization
but i will be sticking to strictly vpc
firewall rules in this lesson now vpc
firewall rules let you allow or deny
connections
to or from your vm instances
based on a configuration that you
specify
and these rules apply to either incoming
connections or outgoing connections
but never both at the same time enabled
vpc firewall rules are always enforced
regardless of their configuration and
operating system even if they have not
started up now every vpc network
functions as a distributed firewall
when firewall rules are defined at the
network level connections are allowed or
denied on a per instance basis
so you can think of the vpc firewall
rules as existing not only between your
instances and other networks
but also between individual instances
within the same network now when you
create a vpc firewall rule you specify a
vpc network and a set of components that
define what the rule does
the components enable you to target
certain types of traffic
based on the traffic's protocol ports
sources and destinations when you create
or modify a firewall rule you can
specify the instances
to which it is intended to apply
by using the target component of the
rule now in addition to firewall rules
that you create google cloud has other
rules that can affect incoming or
outgoing connections so for instance
google cloud doesn't allow certain ip
protocols
such as egress traffic on tcp port 25
within a vpc network and protocols other
than tcp udp
icmp and gre
to external ip addresses of google cloud
resources are blocked google cloud
always allows communication between a vm
instance and its corresponding metadata
server at 169.254
and this server is essential to the
operation of the instance
so the instance can access it regardless
of any firewall rules that you configure
the metadata server provides some basic
services to the instance like dhcp dns
resolution instance metadata and network
time protocol or ntp now just as a note
every network has two implied firewall
rules that permit outgoing connections
and block incoming connections firewall
rules that you create can override these
implied rules now the first implied rule
is the allow egress rule and this is an
egress rule whose action is allow and
the destination is all ips and the
priority is the lowest possible and lets
any instance send traffic to any
destination except for traffic blocked
by google cloud the second implied
firewall rule is the deny ingress rule
and this is an ingress rule whose action
is deny and the source is all ips and
the priority is the lowest possible and
protects all instances by blocking
incoming connections to them now i know
we touched on this earlier on in a
previous lesson but i felt the need to
bring it up as these are pre-populated
rules and the rules that i'm referring
to are with regards to the default vpc
network and as explained earlier these
rules can be deleted or modified as
necessary the rules as you can see here
in the table allow ingress connections
from any source to any instance on the
network when it comes to icmp rdp on
port 3389 for windows remote desktop
protocol and for ssh on port 22. and as
well the last rule allows ingress
connections for all protocols and ports
among instances in the network and it
permits incoming connections to vm
instances from others in the same
network and all of these have a rule
priority of six five five four which is
the second to lowest priority so
breaking down firewall rules there are a
few characteristics that google put in
place that help define these rules and
the characteristics are as follows each
firewall rule applies to incoming or
outgoing connections
and not both firewall rules only support
ipv4 connections so when specifying a
source for an ingress rule or a
destination for an egress rule by
address
you can only use an ipv4 address or ipv4
block insider notation as well each
firewall rules action is either allow or
deny you cannot have both at the same
time and the rule applies to connections
as long as it is enforced so for example
you can disable a rule for
troubleshooting purposes and then enable
it back again now when you create a
firewall rule you must select a vpc
network while the rule is enforced at
the instance level its configuration is
associated with a vpc network this means
you cannot share firewall rules among
vpc networks including
networks connected by vpc network
peering or by using cloud vpn tunnels
another major thing to note about
firewall rules is that they are stateful
and so that means when a connection is
allowed through the firewall in either
direction return traffic matching this
connection is also allowed you cannot
configure a firewall rule to deny
associated response traffic return
traffic must match the five tuple of the
accepted request traffic but with the
source and destination addresses and
ports reversed so just as a note for
those who may be wondering what a five
tuple is i was referring to the set of
five different values that comprise a
tcpip connection and this would be
source ip destination ip source port
destination port and protocol google
cloud associates incoming packets with
corresponding outbound packets by using
a connection tracking table google cloud
implements connection tracking
regardless of whether the protocol
supports connections if a connection is
allowed between a source and a target or
between a target and a destination all
response traffic is allowed as long as
the firewalls connections tracking state
is active and as well as a note a
firewall rules tracking state is
considered active if at least one packet
is sent every 10 minutes now along with
the multiple characteristics that make
up a firewall rule there are also
firewall rule components that go along
with it here i have a screenshot from
the console with the configuration
components of a firewall rule and i
wanted to take a moment to highlight
these components for better clarity so
now the first component is the network
and this is the vpc network that you
want the firewall rule to apply to the
next one is priority which we discussed
earlier and this is the numerical
priority which determines whether the
rule is applied as only the highest
priority rule whose other components
match traffic is applied and remember
the lower the number the higher the
priority the higher the number the lower
the priority now the next component is
the direction of traffic and these are
the ingress rules that apply to incoming
connections from specified sources to
google cloud targets and this is where
ingress rules apply to incoming
connections from specified sources to
google cloud targets
and egress rules apply to connections
going to specify destinations from
targets and the next one up is action on
match and this component either allows
or denies which determines whether the
rule permits or blocks the connection
now a target is what defines which
instances to which the rule applies and
you can specify a target by using one of
the following three options the first
option
are all instances in the network and
this is the firewall rule that does
exactly what it says it applies to all
the instances in the network the second
option is instances by target tags and
this is where the firewall rule applies
only to instances with a matching
network tag and so i know i haven't
explained it earlier but a network tag
is simply a character string added to a
tags field in a resource so let's say i
had a bunch of instances that were
considered development i can simply
throw a network tag on them using a
network tag of dev and apply the
necessary firewall rule for all the
development servers holding the network
tag dev and so the third option is
instances by target service accounts
this is where the firewall rule applies
only to instances that use a specific
service account and so the next
component is the source filter and this
is a source for ingress rules or a
destination for egress rules the source
parameter is only applicable to ingress
rules and it must be one of the
following three selections source ip
ranges and this is where you specify
ranges of ip addresses as sources for
packets either inside or outside of
google cloud the second one is source
tags and this is where the source
instances are identified by a matching
network tag and source service accounts
where source instances
are identified by the service accounts
they use you can also use service
accounts to create firewall rules that
are a bit more granular and so one of
the last components of the firewall rule
is the protocols and ports you can
specify a protocol or a combination of
protocols and their ports if you omit
both protocols and ports the firewall
rule is applicable for all traffic on
any protocol and any port and so when it
comes to enforcement status of the
firewall rule there is a drop down right
underneath all the components where you
can enable or disable the enforcement
and as i said before this is a great way
to enable or disable a firewall rule
without having to delete it and is great
for troubleshooting or to grant
temporary access to any instances and
unless you specify otherwise
all firewall rules are enabled when they
are created but you can also choose to
create a rule in a disabled state and so
this covers the vpc firewall rules in
all its entirety and i will be showing
you how to implement vpc firewall rules
along with building a custom vpc
custom routes
and even private google access
all together in a demo following this
lesson to give you some hands-on skills
of putting it all into practice and so
that's pretty much all i wanted to cover
when it comes to vpc firewall rules so
you can now mark this lesson as complete
and let's move on to the next one where
we dive in and build our custom vpc so
now is a perfect time to grab a coffee
or tea and whenever you're ready join me
in the console
welcome back
in this demonstration i want to take all
the concepts that we've learned so far
in this networking section and put it
all into practice this diagram shown
here is the architecture of exactly what
we will be building in this demo we're
going to start by creating a custom vpc
and then we're going to create two
subnets
one public and one private
in two separate regions we're then going
to create a cloud storage bucket with
some objects in it and then we will
create some instances to demonstrate
access to cloud storage as well as
communication between instances and
finally we're going to create some
firewall rules for routing traffic to
all the right places we're also going to
implement private google access
and demonstrate accessibility to the
files in cloud storage from the private
instance without an external ip so this
may be a little bit out of your comfort
zone for some
but don't worry i'll be with you every
step of the way and other than creating
the instances all the steps here have
been covered in previous lessons now
there's a lot to get done here so
whenever you're ready join me in the
console and so here we are back in the
console and as you can see up here in
the right hand corner i am logged in as
tony bowtie ace gmail.com and currently
i am logged in under project tony and so
in order to start off on a clean slate
i'm going to create a new project and so
i'm going to simply click on the project
menu drop-down and click on new project
i'm going to call this project
bowtie inc and i don't have any
organizations so i'm going to simply
click on create and as well for those of
you doing this lesson i would also
recommend for you to create a brand new
project so that you can start off anew
again i'm going to go over to the
project drop down and i'm going to
select bow tie ink as the project and
now that i have a fresh new project i
can now create my vpc network so i'm
going to go over to the left hand corner
to the navigation menu and i'm going to
scroll down to vpc network and so
because vpc networks are tied in with
the compute engine api
we need to enable it before we can
create any vpc networks so you can go
ahead and enable this api so once this
api has finished and is enabled we'll be
able to create our vpc network
ok and the api has been enabled and as
you can see the default vpc network has
been created with a subnet in every
region along with its corresponding ip
address ranges and so for this demo
we're going to create a brand new vpc
network along with some custom subnets
and so in order to do that i'm going to
go up here to the top and i'm going to
click on create vpc network and so here
i'm prompted with some fields to fill
out
so under name i'm going to think of a
creative name that i can call my vpc
network so i'm going to simply call it
custom under description i'm going to
call this custom
vpc network and i'm going to move down
here to subnets and because i'm creating
custom subnets i'm going to keep it
under custom under subnet creation mode
and so i'm going to need a public subnet
and a private subnet and you'll be able
to get the values from the text file in
the github repository within the sub
networks folder under networking
services and so i'm going to create my
public subnet first and i'm going to
simply call the public subnet public for
region i'm going to use us east one and
the ip address range will be 10.0.0.0
forward slash 24 and i'm going to leave
private google access off and i'm going
to simply click on done and now i can
create the private subnet so underneath
the public subnet you'll see add subnet
you can simply click on that and the
name of the new subnet will be as you
guessed it private under region i'm
going to use us east 4 and for the ip
address range
be sure to use 10.0.5.0.24
and we're going to leave private google
access off for now and we'll be turning
that on a little bit later in the demo
and so you can now click on done and
before we click on create we want to
enable the dns api and clicking on
enable will bring you to the dns api
home page and you can click on enable to
enable the api okay so now that we have
our network configured along with our
public and private subnets as well as
dns being enabled we can now simply
click on create but before i do that i
wanted to give you some insight with
regards to the command line so as i've
shared before everything that can be
done in the console can be done through
the command line and so if ever you
wanted to do that or you wanted to get
to know the command line a little bit
better
after filling out all the fields with
regards to creating resources in the
console you will be given the option of
a command line link that you can simply
click on and here you will be given all
the commands to create all the same
resources with all the same preferences
through the command line and i will be
providing these commands in the lesson
text so that you can familiarize
yourself with the commands to use in
order to build any networks using the
command line but this is a great
reference for you to use at any time and
so i'm going to click on close
and now i'm going to click on create
and within a minute or two the custom
vpc network will be created and ready to
use okay and the custom vpc network has
been created along with its public and
private subnet and so just to get a
little bit more insight with this custom
vpc network i'm going to drill down into
it
and as you can see here the subnets are
respectively labeled private and public
along with its region ip address range
the gateway and private google access
the routes as you can see here are the
system generated routes that i had
discussed in an earlier lesson it has
both the subnet routes to its respective
ip range along with the default route
with a path to the internet as well as a
path for private google access now we
don't have any firewall rules here yet
but we'll be adding those in just a few
minutes and so now that you've created
the vpc network with its respective
subnets we're going to head on over to
cloud storage and create a bucket along
with uploading the necessary files so
i'm going to go again over to the
navigation menu
and i'm going to scroll down to storage
and so as expected there are no buckets
present here in cloud storage and so
we're just going to go ahead and create
our first bucket by going up here to the
top menu and clicking on create bucket
and so here i've been prompted to name
my bucket and for those of you who are
here for the first time when it comes to
naming a storage bucket the name needs
to be globally unique and this means
that the name has to be unique across
all of the google cloud platform now
don't worry i'm going to get into
further detail with this in the cloud
storage lesson with all of these
specific details when it comes to names
storage classes and permissions and so
in the meantime you can come up with a
name for your bucket something that
resonates with you and so for me i'm
going to name my bucket bowtie inc dash
file dash access and so now i'm going to
simply click continue and so just as a
note for those who are unable to
continue through it is because the name
for your bucket is not globally unique
so do try to find one that is now when
it comes to location type i'm just going
to click on region and you can keep the
default location as used one and i'm
going to leave all the other options as
default and i'm going to go down to the
bottom and click create and so for those
of you who have created your bucket you
can now upload the files and those files
can be found in the github repository
in the cloud storage bucket folder under
networking services and so now i'm going
to click on upload files
and under the networking services
section under cloud storage bucket you
will find these three jpeg files and you
can simply select them and click on open
and so they are now uploaded into the
bucket and so now i'm ready to move on
to the next step so you should now have
created the vpc network with a private
and public subnet along with creating
your own bucket in cloud storage and
have uploaded the three jpeg files so
now that this is done we can now create
the instances
that will have access to these files and
so again i will go over to the
navigation menu in the top left hand
corner and scroll down to compute engine
and here i will click on create
and so again i will be prompted with
some fields to fill out and so for this
instance i'm going to first create the
public instance again i'm going to get
really creative and call this
public dash instance under labels i'm
going to add a label
under key
i'm going to type environment and under
value i'm going to type in public i'm
going to go down to the bottom and click
on save and under region i'm going to
select us east1 and you can leave the
zone as us east 1b moving down under
machine type i'm going to select the e2
micro as the machine type just because
i'm being cost conscious and i want to
keep the cost down and so i'm going to
scroll down to identity and api access
and under service account you should
have the compute engine default service
account already pre-selected now under
access scopes i want to be able to have
the proper permissions to be able to
read and write to cloud storage along
with read and write access to compute
engine and so you can click on set
access for each api and you can scroll
down to compute engine
click on the drop down menu and select
read write and this will give the public
instance the specific access that it
needs to ssh into the private instance
and so now i'm going to set the access
for cloud storage so i'm going to scroll
down to storage i'm going to click on
the drop down menu and select read write
and this will give the instance read
write access to cloud storage scrolling
down a little bit further i'm going to
go to management security disks
networking and sold tenancy and i'm
going to click on that
scroll up here just a little bit
and you can click on the networking tab
which will prompt you for a bunch of
options that you can configure for the
networking of the instance so under
network tags i want to type in public
and you can click enter you can then
scroll down to where it says network
interfaces and click on the current
interface which is the default and here
it'll open up all your options and so
under network you want to click on the
drop down and set it from default to
custom the public subnet will
automatically be propagated so you can
leave it as is and you also want to make
sure that your primary internal ip
as well as your external ip are set to
ephemeral and you can leave all the
other options as default and simply
click on done and again before clicking
on create you can click on the command
line link and it will show you all the
commands needed in order to create this
instance through the command line so i'm
going to go ahead and close this
and so i'm going to leave all the other
options as default and i'm going to
click on create and so now that my
public instance is being created i'm
going to go ahead and create my private
instance
using the same steps that i did for the
last instance so i'm going to go ahead
and click on create instance here at the
top and so the first thing i'm going to
be prompted for is the name of the
instance
and so i'm going to call this instance
private dash instance and here i'm going
to add a label the key being environment
and the value being private i'm going to
go down here to the bottom and click on
save
and under region i'm going to select us
east 4
and you can keep the zone as the default
selected under machine type we're going
to select the e2 micro and again
scrolling down to the identity and api
access under the access scopes for the
default service account i'm going to
click on the set access for each api and
i'm going to scroll down to storage i'm
going to click on the drop down menu and
i'm going to select access for read
write and for the last step i'm going to
go into the networking tab under
management security disks networking and
soul tenancy and under network tags i'm
going to give this instance a network
tag of private and under network
interfaces we want to edit this and
change it from default over to the
custom network and as expected it
selected the private subnet by default
and because this is going to be a
private instance we are not going to
give this an external ip so i'm going to
click on the drop down and select none
and with all the other options set as
default i'm going to simply click on
create
and this will create my private instance
along with having my public instance so
just as a recap we've created a new
custom vpc network
along with a private and public subnet
we've created a storage bucket and added
some files in it to be accessed and
we've created a private and public
instance and assigning the service
account on the public instance read
write access to both compute engine and
cloud storage along with a public ip
address and assigning the service
account on the private instance read
write access only for cloud storage and
no public ip and so this is the end of
part one of this demo
and this would be a great opportunity
for you to get up and have a stretch
get yourself a coffee or tea
and whenever you're ready you can join
me in part two
where we will be starting immediately
from the end of part one so you can go
ahead and complete this video and i will
see you in part two
[Music]
welcome back
this is part two of the custom vpc demo
and we will be starting exactly where we
left off from part one so with that
being said let's dive in and so now the
last thing that needs to be done is to
simply create some firewall rules and so
with these firewall rules this will give
me ssh access into the public instance
as well as allowing private
communication from the public instance
to the private instance as well as
giving ssh access
from the public instance to the private
instance and this will allow us to
access the files in the bucket from the
private instance and so in order to
create these firewall rules i need to go
back to my vpc network so i'm going to
go up to the left hand corner again to
the navigation menu
and scroll down to vpc network over here
on the left hand menu you'll see
firewall i'm going to click on that
and here you will see all the default
firewall rules for the default network
so for us to create some new ones for
the custom vpc i'm going to go up here
to the top and click on create firewall
and so the first rule i want to create
is for my public instance and i want to
give it public access as well as ssh
access and so i'm going to name this
accordingly as public dash access i'm
going to give this the same description
always a good idea to turn on logs but
for this demonstration i'm going to keep
them off under network i'm going to
select the custom network i'm going to
keep the priority at 1000 the direction
of traffic will be ingress and the
action on match will be allow and so
here is where the target tags come into
play when it comes to giving access to
the network so targets we're going to
keep it as specified target tags
and under target tags you can simply
type in public
under source filter you can keep it
under ip ranges
and the source ip range will be 0.0.0.0
forward slash 0. and we're not going to
add a second source filter here so
moving down to protocols and ports under
tcp i'm going to click that off and add
in port 22. and because i want to be
able to ping the instance i'm going to
have to add another protocol which is
icmp
and again as explained earlier the
disable rule link will bring up the
enforcement and as you can see it is
enabled but if you wanted to create any
firewall rules in future and have them
disabled you can do that right here but
we're gonna keep this enabled and we're
gonna simply click on create and this
will create the public firewall rule for
our public instance in our custom vpc
network and so we're going to now go
ahead and create the private firewall
rule and so i'm going to name this
private dash access
respectively i'm going to put the
description as the same under network
i'm going to select our custom network
keep the priority at 1000 direction of
traffic should be at ingress and the
action on match should be allow for
target tags you can type in private and
then hit enter and because i want to be
able to reach the private instance from
the public instance the source ip range
will be
10.0.0.1
forward slash 24. we're not going to add
a second source filter and under
protocols and ports we're going to
simply add tcp port 22
and again i want to add icmp
so that i'm able to ping the instance
and i'm going to click on create
and so we now have our two firewall
rules private access and public access
and if i go over to the custom vpc
network and i drill into it
i'll be able to see these selective
firewall rules under the respective
firewall rules tab and so now that we've
created our vpc network along with the
public and private subnet we've created
the cloud storage bucket with the files
that we need to access the instances
that will access those files along with
the firewall rules that will allow the
proper communication we can now go ahead
to test everything that we built and
make sure that everything is working as
expected so let's kick things off by
first logging into the public instance
so you can head on over to the
navigation menu and scroll down to
compute engine
and you can ssh into the public instance
by clicking on ssh under connect
and this should open up a new tab or a
new window logging you in with your
currently authenticated credentials okay
and we are logged into our instance and
i'm going to zoom in for better viewing
and so just to make sure that everything
is working as expected we know that our
firewall rule is correct because we are
able to ssh into the instance and now i
want to see if i have access to my files
in the bucket and so in order to do that
i'm going to run the gsutil command ls
for list and then gs colon forward slash
forward slash along with my bucket name
which is bow tie inc
hyphen file iphone access and i'm going
to hit enter and as you can see i have
access to all the files in the bucket
and the last thing i wanted to check is
if i can ping the private instance so
i'm going to first clear my screen and
i'm going to head on over back to the
console i'm going to copy the ip address
of the private instance to my clipboard
and then i'm going to head back on over
to my terminal and i'm going to type in
ping i'm going to paste the ip address
and success
i am able to successfully ping the
private instance
from the public instance
using the icmp protocol and you can hit
control c to stop the ping so now that i
know that my public instance has the
proper permissions to reach cloud
storage
as well as being able to ping my private
instance i want to be able to check if i
can ssh
into the private instance from my public
instance and so i'm going to first clear
my screen and next i'm going to paste in
this command in order for me to ssh into
the private instance g cloud compute ssh
dash dash project and my project name
which is bow tie inc dash dash zone and
the zone that my instance is in which is
us east 4c along with the name of the
instance which is private dash instance
and along with the flag dash dash
internal dash ip stating that i am using
the internal ip in order to ssh into the
instance and i'm going to hit enter and
so now i've been prompted for a
passphrase in order to secure my rsa key
pair as one is being generated to log
into the private instance now it's
always good practice when it comes to
security to secure your key pair with a
passphrase but for this demo i'm just
going to leave it blank
and so i'm just going to hit enter
i'm going to hit enter again
now i don't want to get too deep into it
but i did want to give you some context
on what's happening here so when you log
into an instance on google cloud with os
login disabled google manages the
authorized keys file
for new user accounts based on ssh keys
in metadata and so the keys that are
being generated that are being used for
the first time are currently being
stored within the instance metadata so
now that i'm logged into my private
instance i'm going to quickly clear my
screen and just as a note you'll be able
to know whether or not you're logged
into your private instance by looking
here at your prompt and so now i want to
make sure that i can ping my public
instance so i'm going to quickly type
the ping command i'm going to head on
over to the console i'm going to grab
the ip address of the public instance
i'm going to go back to my terminal and
paste it in and as expected i'm able to
ping my public instance from my private
instance i'm just going to go ahead and
hit control c to stop and i'm going to
clear the screen so now we'd like to
verify whether or not we have access to
the files in the cloud storage bucket
that we created earlier
and so now i'm going to use the same
command
that i used in the public instance to
list all the files in the cloud storage
bucket so i'm going to use the gsutil
command ls for list along with gs colon
forward slash forward slash and the
bucket name which is bow tie ink hyphen
file if an access and i'm going to hit
enter
and as you can see here i'm not getting
a response and the command is hanging
and this is due to the fact that
external access is needed in order to
reach cloud storage and this instance
only has an internal or private ip so
accessing the files in the cloud storage
bucket is not possible now in order to
access cloud storage and the set of
external ip addresses used by google
apis and services we can do this by
enabling private google access on the
subnet used by the vms network interface
and so we're going to go ahead and do
that right now so i'm going to hit
control c to stop and i'm going to go
back into the console i'm going to go to
the navigation menu and i'm going to
scroll down to vpc network
and then i'm going to drill down into
the private subnet and i'm going to edit
it under private google access i'm going
to turn it on and i'm going to go down
to the bottom and click on save and by
giving this subnet private google access
i will allow the private instance and
any instances with private ip addresses
to access any public apis
such as cloud storage so now when i go
back to my instance i'm going to clear
the screen here and i'm going to run the
gsutil command again
and success
we are now able to access cloud storage
due to enabling private google access on
the respective private subnet
so i first wanted to congratulate you on
making it to the end of this demo
and hope that this demo has been
extremely useful as this is a real life
scenario that can come up and so just as
a recap you've created a custom network
with two custom subnets you've created a
cloud storage bucket and uploaded some
files to it you've created a public
instance and a private instance and then
created some firewall rules to route the
traffic you then tested it all by using
the command line for communication you
also enable private google access for
the instance with only the internal ip
to access google's public apis so that
it can access cloud storage and so again
fantastic job on your part as this was a
pretty complex demo
and you can expect things like what
you've experienced in this demo to pop
up in your role of being a cloud
engineer at any time so before you go be
sure to delete all the resources you've
created
and again congrats on the great job so
you can now mark this as complete and
i'll see you in the next one
welcome back in this lesson i will be
going over vpc network peering and how
you can privately communicate across
vpcs in the same or different
organization vpc network peering and vpc
peering are used interchangeably in this
lesson as they are used to communicate
the same thing now for instances in one
vpc to communicate with an instance in
another vpc they would route traffic via
the public internet however to
communicate privately between two vpcs
google cloud offers a service called vpc
peering and i will be going through the
theory and concepts of vpc peering
throughout this lesson so with that
being said let's dive in
now vpc peering enables you to peer vpc
networks
so that workloads in different vpc
networks can communicate in a private
space that follows the rfc
1918 standard thus allowing private
connectivity across two vpc networks
traffic stays within google's network
and never traverses the public internet
vpc peering gives you the flexibility of
peering networks that are of the same or
different projects along with being able
to peer with other networks in different
organizations vpc peering also gives you
several advantages over using external
ip addresses or vpns to connect the
first one is reducing network latency as
all peering traffic stays within
google's high-speed network vpc peering
also offers greater network security as
you don't need to have services exposed
to the public internet and deal with
greater risks of having your traffic
getting compromised or if you're trying
to achieve compliance standards for your
organization vpc peering will allow you
to achieve the standards that you need
and finally vpc network peering reduces
network costs as you save on egress
costs for traffic leaving gcp so in a
regular network google charges you for
traffic communicating using public ips
even if the traffic is within the same
zone now you can bypass this and save
money by using internal ips to
communicate and keeping the traffic
within the gcp network
now there are certain properties or
characteristics that peered vpcs follow
and i wanted to point these out for
better understanding first off peer vpc
networks remain administratively
separate so what exactly does this mean
well it means that routes firewalls vpns
and other traffic management tools are
administered and applied separately in
each of the vpc networks so this applies
to each vpc independently which also
means that each side of a peering
association
is set up independently as well so when
you connect one vpc to the other you
have to go into each vpc that you are
connecting to both initiate and
establish the connection peering becomes
active only when the configuration from
both sides match this also means that
each vpc can delete the peering
association at any given time now during
vpc peering the vpc peers always
exchange all subnet routes you also have
the option of exchanging custom routes
subnet and static routes are global and
dynamic routes can be regional or global
a given vpc network can peer with
multiple vpc networks but there is a
limit that you can reach in which you
would have to reach out to google and
ask the limit to be increased now when
peering with vpc networks there are
certain restrictions in place that you
should be aware of first off a subnet
cider range in one peered vpc network
cannot overlap with a static route in
another peered network this rule covers
both subnet routes and static routes so
when a vpc subnet is created or a subnet
ip range is expanded google cloud
performs a check to make sure that the
new subnet range does not overlap with
ip ranges of subnets in the same vpc
network or in directly peered vpc
networks if it does the creation or
expansion will fail google cloud also
ensures that no overlapping subnet ip
ranges
are allowed across vpc networks that
have appeared network in common and
again if it does the creation or
expansion will fail now speaking of
routing when you create a new subnet in
appeared vpc network
vpc network peering doesn't provide
granular route controls to filter out
which subnet cider ranges are reachable
across pure networks these are handled
by firewall rules so to allow ingress
traffic from vm instances in a peer
network you must create ingress allow
firewall rules by default ingress
traffic to vms is blocked by the implied
deny ingress rule another key point to
note is that transitive peering is not
supported and only directly peered
networks can communicate so they have to
be peered directly in this diagram
network a is peered with network b and
network b is peered with network c and
so if one instance is trying to
communicate from network a to network c
this cannot be done unless network a is
directly peered with network c an
extremely important point to note for
vpc peering another thing to note is
that you cannot use a tag or service
account from one peered network in the
other peered network they must each have
their own as again they are each
independently operated as stated earlier
and so the last thing that i wanted to
cover is that internal dns is not
accessible for compute engine in peered
networks as they must use an ip to
communicate and so that about covers
this short yet important lesson on the
theory and concepts of vpc peering and
so now that we've covered all the theory
i'm going to be taking these concepts
into a demo where we will be pairing two
networks together and verifying the
communication between them and so you
can now mark this lesson as complete and
whenever you're ready join me in the
console
welcome back in this hands-on
demonstration
we're going to go through the steps to
create a peering connection from two
vpcs
in two separate projects as shown here
in the diagram and then to verify that
the connection works we're going to
create two instances one in each network
and ping one instance from the other
instance this demo is very similar to
the custom vpc demo that you had done
earlier but we are adding in another
layer of complexity by adding in vpc
network peering and so there's quite a
bit to do here so let's go ahead and
just dive in
okay so here we are back in the console
as you can see up in the top right hand
corner i am logged in as tony bowties
gmail.com and for this specific demo i
will be using two projects both project
tony and project bowtie inc and if you
currently do not have two projects you
can go ahead and create yourself a new
project or the two projects if you have
none and so i'm going to continue here
with project tony and the first thing i
want to do is create the two networks in
the two separate projects so i'm going
to go up to the navigation menu in the
top left hand corner and i'm going to
scroll down to vpc network
here i'm going to create my first vpc
network and i'm going to name this
bowtie ink
dash a i'm going to give it the same
description
and then under subnets i'm going to
leave the subnet creation mode under
custom under the subnet name you can
call this subnet dash a
i'm going to use the us east one region
and for the ip address range i'm going
to use 10.0 that's 0.0 forward slash 20.
and i'm going to leave all the other
options as default and i'm going to go
down to the bottom and click on create
now as this network is being created i'm
going to go over to the project bowtie
inc and i'm going to create the vpc
network there so under name i'm going to
call this bowtie inc
b and under description i'm going to use
the same under subnets i'm going to keep
subnet creation mode as custom and under
new subnet i'm going to call this subnet
subnet b the region will be used 4
and the ip address range will be
10.4.0.0
forward slash 20. you can leave all the
other options as default and scroll down
to the bottom and click on create as
this network is being created i'm going
to go back to project tony and i'm going
to create the firewall rule for bow tie
ink dash a
in this firewall rule as explained in
the last lesson we'll allow
communication from one instance to the
other and so i'm going to click on
create firewall
and under name i'm going to call this
project
tony dash a under description i'm going
to use the same
under the network i'm going to choose
the source network which will be bowtie
inc dash a priority i'm going to keep at
1000 direction of traffic should be
ingress and action on match should be
allow under targets i'm going to select
all instances in the network and under
source filter i'm going to keep ip
ranges selected and the source ip range
specifically for this demo is going to
be 0.0.0.0
forward slash 0. and again this is
specifically used for this demo and
should never be used in a
production-like environment in
production you should only use the
source ip ranges that you are
communicating with and under protocols
and ports because i need to log into the
instance to be able to ping the other
instance i'm going to have to open up
tcp on port 22. under other protocols
you can add icmp and this will allow the
ping command to be used i'm going to
leave all the other options as default
and i'm going to click on create and now
that this firewall rule has been created
i need to go back over to project bowtie
inc and create the firewall rule there
as well
i'm going to call this firewall rule
bowtie inc dash b i'm going to give it
the same description under network i'm
going to select bow tie ink dash b i'm
going to keep the priority as 1000 and
the direction of traffic should be
ingress as well the action on match
should be allow scrolling down under
targets i'm going to select all
instances in the network and again under
source filter i'm going to keep ip
ranges selected and under source ip
ranges i'm going to enter in
0.0.0.0 forward slash 0. and under
protocols and ports i'm going to select
tcp with port 22 as well under other
protocols i'm going to type in icmp i'm
going to leave everything else as
default and i'm going to click on create
now once you've created both networks
and have created both firewall rules you
can now start creating the instances so
because i'm already in project bowtie
inc i'm going to go to the left-hand
navigation menu and i'm going to scroll
down to compute engine and create my
instance so i'm just going to click on
create
and to keep with the naming convention
i'm going to call this instance instance
b i'm not going to add any labels for
now under region i'm going to choose us
east 4 and you can leave the zone as the
default selection and under machine type
i'm going to select e2 micro and i'm
going to scroll down to the bottom and
i'm going to click on management
security disks networking and sold
tenancy so that i'm able to go into the
networking tab to change the network on
the default network interface so i'm
going to click on the default network
interface and under network i'm going to
select bowtie inc b and the subnet has
already been selected for me and then
i'm going to scroll down click on done
and i'm going to leave all the other
options as default and click on create
and so as this is creating i'm going to
go over to project tony
and i'm going to create my instance
there
and i'm going to name this instance
instance a under region i am going to
select us east1 you can leave the zone
as the default selected under machine
type i'm going to select e2 micro and
scrolling down here to the bottom i'm
going to go into the networking tab
under management security disks
networking and soul
and here i'm going to edit the network
interface and change it from the default
network to bow tie ink dash a and as you
can see the subnet has been
automatically selected for me
so now i can just simply click on done
i'm going to leave all the other options
as default and i'm going to click on
create
so just as a recap we've created two
separate networks in two separate
projects along with its corresponding
subnets and the firewall rules along
with creating an instance in each
network and so now that we have both
environments set up it's now time to
create the vbc peering connection and so
because i'm in project tony i'm going to
start off with this project and i'm
going to go up to the navigation menu
and scroll down to vpc network and under
vpc network on the left hand menu you're
going to click on vpc network peering
and through the interface shown here
we'll be able to create our vpc network
peering so now you're going to click on
create connection and i'm prompted with
some information that i will need and
because we are connecting to another vpc
in another project you're going to need
the project id as well as the name of
the vpc network you want to peer with
and just as explained in the earlier
lesson the subnet ip ranges in both
networks cannot overlap so please make
sure that if you are using ip ranges
outside of the ones that are given for
this demonstration the ip ranges that
you are using do not overlap so once you
have that information you can then click
continue
and so here you will be prompted with
some fields to fill out with the
information that you were asked to
collect in the previous screen and so
since we have that information already
we can go ahead and start filling in the
fields so i'm going to call this peering
connection peering
a b and under vpc network i'm going to
select bow tie ink dash a under peered
vpc network we're going to select the
other project which should be bowtie inc
and the vpc network name will be bow tie
inc dash b and i'm going to leave all
the other options as default and so
under vpc network name you will see
exchange custom routes and here i can
select to import and export custom
routes that i have previously created so
any special routes that i have created
before the actual peering connection i
can bring them over to the other network
to satisfy my requirements and so i'm
not going to do that right now i'm going
to close this up and i'm going to simply
click on create and so this is finished
creating and is marked as inactive and
this is because the corresponding
peering connection in project bowtie has
yet to be configured the status will
change to a green check mark in both
networks and marked as active once they
are connected if this status remains as
inactive then you should recheck your
configuration and edit it accordingly so
now i'm going to head on over to project
bowtie inc and i'm going to create the
corresponding peering connection i'm
going to click on create connection once
you have your project id and the vpc
network you can click on continue and
for the name of this peering connection
i'm going to call this peering dash ba
respectively under vpc network i'm going
to select bowtie inc b and under peered
vpc network i'm going to select in
another project here you want to type in
your project id for me i'm going to
paste in my project tony project id and
under vpc network name i'm going to type
in bowtie inc
a and i'm going to leave all the other
options as default and i'm going to
click on create and so now that we've
established connections on each of the
peering connections in each vpc if the
information that we've entered is
correct then we should receive a green
check mark stating that the peering
connection is connected and success here
we have status as active and if i head
on over to project tony i should have
the same green check mark under status
for the peering connection and as
expected the status has a green check
mark and is marked as active so now in
order to do the pairing connectivity
test i'm going to need to grab the
internal ip of the instance in the other
network that resides in project bowtie
and so because it doesn't matter which
instance i log into as both of them have
ssh and ping access i'm going to simply
go over to the navigation menu i'm going
to head on over to compute engine and
i'm going to record the internal ip of
instance a and now i'm going to head
over to project bowtie and log into
instance b and ping instance a and so in
order to ssh into this instance i'm
going to click on the ssh button under
connect and it should open a new browser
tab for me logging me into the instance
okay i'm logged in here and i'm going to
zoom in for better viewing and so now
i'm going to run a ping command against
instance a using the internal ip that i
had copied earlier and i'm going to hit
enter and as you can see ping is working
and so now we can confirm that the vpc
peering connection is established and
the two instances in the different vpc
networks are communicating over their
private ips and you can go ahead and hit
control c to stop the ping and so just
as a recap you've created two separate
vpc networks with their own separate
subnets in two separate projects you've
created the necessary firewall rules in
each of these networks along with
creating instances in each of those
networks you then established a vpc
peering connection establishing the
configuration in each vpc you then did a
connectivity test by logging into one of
the instances and pinging the other
instance and so i hope this helps cement
the theory of vpc peering that you
learned in the previous lesson and has
given you some context when it comes to
configuring each end of the peering
connection so i wanted to take a moment
to congratulate you on completing this
demo and so all that's left now is to
clean up all the resources that we
created throughout this demo and you can
start by selecting the instances and
deleting them in each network as well as
the firewall rules and the networks
themselves i'm going to go over to
project tony and i'm going to do the
same thing there and so you can do
exactly what you did with the last
instance here you can select it click on
delete and delete the instance and so
next we're going to delete the peering
connection so we're going to go up to
the navigation menu we're going to
scroll down to vpc network and on the
left hand menu we're going to scroll
down to vpc network peering and so we're
going to select appearing connection
we're going to go to the top and click
on delete and then delete the peering
connection
and so now we're going to delete the
firewall rule so we're going to go up to
firewall
we're going to select the firewall rule
at the top we're going to click delete
and then delete the firewall rule and
last but not least we want to delete the
vpc network that we created so we're
going to go up to vpc networks we're
going to drill down into the custom vpc
up at the top we're going to click on
delete vpc network and then we're going
to click on delete and so now that we've
deleted all the resources in project
tony we're going to go back over to our
second project project bowtie and do the
same thing and so we're first going to
start off with the vpc peering
connection so we're going to go over to
vpc network peering we're going to
select the appearing connection we're
gonna click on delete at the top and
delete the peering connection next we're
gonna go into firewall we're gonna
select the firewall rule go up to the
top and click on delete and then delete
the firewall rule and finally we're
gonna go over to vpc networks we're
going to drill down into the custom
network we're going to click on delete
vpc network at the top and delete the
vpc network
and so now that you've successfully
deleted all your resources you can now
mark this lesson as complete and i'll
see you in the next one and congrats
again on the great job of completing
this demo
[Music]
welcome back and in this lesson i'm
going to be discussing the concepts and
terminology of shared vpcs i'm also
going to go into some detailed use cases
and how shared vpcs would be used in
different scenarios so with that being
said let's dive in
now when a vpc is created it is usually
tied to a specific project now what
happens when you want to share resources
across different projects but still have
separate billing and access within the
projects themselves
this is where shared vpcs come into play
shared vpcs allow an organization to
connect resources from multiple projects
to a common vpc network so that way they
can communicate with each other securely
and efficiently using internal ips from
that network when you use shared vpcs
you designate a project as a host
project and attach one or more other
service projects to it the vpc networks
in the host project are considered the
shared vpc networks so just as a
reminder a project that participates in
a shared vpc is either a host project or
a service project a host project can
contain one or more shared vpc networks
a service project is any project that
has been attached to a host project by a
shared vpc admin this attachment allows
it to participate in the shared vpc and
just as a note a project cannot be both
a host and a service project
simultaneously it has to be one or the
other and you can create and use
multiple host projects however each
service project can only be attached to
a single host project it is also a
common practice to have multiple service
projects administered by different
departments or teams in the organization
and so just for clarity for those who
are wondering a project that does not
participate in a shared vpc
is called a standalone project
and this is to emphasize that it is
neither a host project or a service
project now when it comes to
administering these shared vpcs we
should be adhering to the principle of
least privilege and only assigning the
necessary access needed to specific
users so here i broken down the roles
that are needed to enable and administer
the shared vpcs a shared vpc admin has
the permissions to enable host projects
attach service projects to host projects
and delegate access to some or all of
the subnets in shared vpc networks to
service project admins when it comes to
a service project admin this is a shared
vpc admin for a given host project and
is typically its project owner as well
although when defining each service
project admin a shared vpc admin can
grant permission to use the whole host
project or just some subnets and so when
it comes to service project admins there
are two separate levels of permissions
that can be applied the first is project
level permissions and this is a service
project admin that can be defined to
have permission to use all subnets in
the host project when it comes to subnet
level permissions a service project
admin can be granted a more restrictive
set of permissions to use only some
subnets now i wanted to move into some
use cases which will give you a bit more
context on how shared vpcs are used in
specific environments illustrated here
is a simple shared vpc scenario here a
host project has been created and
attached to service projects to it the
service project admin in service project
a
can be configured to access all or some
of the subnets in the shared vpc network
service project admin with at least
subnet level permissions to the 10.0.2.0
24 subnet has created vm1 in a zone
located in the us west one region this
instance receives its internal ip
address
10.0.2.15 from the 10.0.2.0
24 cider block now service project
admins in service project b can be
configured to access all or some of the
subnets in the shared vpc network a
service project admin with at least
subnet level permissions to the
10.10.4.0 forward slash 24 subnet has
created vm2 in a zone located in the us
central 1 region this instance receives
its internal ip address
10.10.4.1
from the
10.10.4.0 forward slash 24 cider block
and of course the standalone project
does not participate in the shared vpc
at all as it is neither a host nor a
service project and the last thing to
note
instances in service projects attached
to a host project using the same shared
vpc network
can communicate with one another using
either ephemeral or reserve static
internal ip addresses and i will be
covering both ephemeral and static ip
addresses in a later section under
compute engine external ip addresses
defined in the host project are only
usable by resources in that project they
are not available for use in service
projects moving on to the next use case
is a multiple hosts project for this use
case an organization is using two
separate host projects development and
production
and each host project has two service
projects attached to them both host
projects have one shared vpc network
with subnets configured to use the same
cider ranges both the testing and
production networks have been purposely
configured in the same way so this way
when you work with resources tied to a
subnet range it will automatically
translate over from one environment to
the other moving on to the next use case
is the hybrid environment now in this
use case the organization has a single
host project with a single shared vpc
network the shared vpc network is
connected via cloud vpn to an
on-premises network some services and
applications are hosted in gcp while
others are kept on premises and this way
separate teams can manage each of their
own service projects
and each project has no permissions to
the other service projects as well each
service project can also be billed
separately subnet level or project level
permissions have been granted to the
necessary service project admins
so they can create instances that use
the shared vpc network and again
instances in these service projects can
be configured to communicate with
internal services
such as database or directory servers
located on premises and finally the last
use case is a two-tier web service here
an organization has a web service that
is separated into two tiers and
different teams manage each tier the
tier one service project represents the
externally facing component behind an
http or https load balancer the tier 2
service project represents an internal
service upon which tier 1 relies on and
it is balanced using an internal tcp or
udp load balancer the shared vpc allows
mapping of each tier of the web service
to different projects so that they can
be managed by different teams while
sharing a common vpc network to host
resources that are needed for both tiers
now we cover quite a bit in this lesson
when it comes to all the concepts of
shared vpcs we covered both host and
service projects and the roles that they
play and their limitations we also went
over the different roles that are needed
to administrate these shared vpcs and we
went over different use cases on how to
use shared vpcs for different scenarios
and so that about covers everything i
wanted to discuss in this lesson
so you can now mark this lesson as
complete and let's move on to the next
one
[Music]
welcome back and in this lesson i'm
going to be discussing vpc flow logs
flow logs is an essential tool for
monitoring and analyzing traffic
coming in and going out of vpcs from vm
instances flow logs are essential to
know for the exam as you should know the
capabilities and use cases and so with
that being said let's dive in
so vpc flow logs records a sample of
network flows
sent from and received by vm instances
including instances used as google
kubernetes engine nodes these logs can
be used for network monitoring forensics
real-time security analysis and expense
optimization when you enable vpc flow
logs you enable for all vms in a subnet
so basically you would be enabling vpc
flow logs on a subnet by subnet basis
flow logs are aggregated by connection
from compute engine vms and exported in
real time these logs can be exported to
cloud logging previously known as
stackdriver for 30 days if logs need to
be stored for longer than 30 days they
can be exported to a cloud storage
bucket for longer term storage and then
read and queried by cloud logging google
cloud samples packets that leave and
enter a vm to generate flow logs now not
every packet is captured into its own
log record about one out of every 10
packets is captured but this sampling
rate might be lower depending on the
vm's load and just as a note you cannot
adjust this rate this rate is locked by
google cloud and cannot be changed in
any way and because vpc flow logs do not
capture every packet it compensates for
missed packets by interpolating from the
captured packets now there are many
different use cases for vpc flow logs
and i wanted to take a quick minute to
go over them the first one i wanted to
mention is network monitoring vpc flow
logs provide you with real-time
visibility into network throughput and
performance so you can monitor the vpc
network perform network diagnostics
understand traffic changes and help
forecast capacity
for capacity planning you can also
analyze network usage with vpc flow logs
and you can analyze the network flows
for traffic between regions and zones
traffic to specific countries on the
internet
and based on the analysis you can
optimize your network traffic expenses
now a great use case for vpc flow logs
is network forensics
so for example if an incident occurs you
can examine which ips talked with whom
and when and you can also look at any
compromised ips by analyzing all the
incoming and outgoing network flows and
lastly
vpc flow logs can be used for real-time
security analysis
you can leverage the real-time streaming
apis using pub sub and integrate them
with a sim or security information in
event management system like splunk
rapid7 or logarithm and this is a very
common way to add an extra layer of
security to your currently existing
environment as well as a great way to
meet any compliance standards that are
needed for your organization now vpc
flow logs are recorded in a specific
format log records contain base fields
which are the core fields of every log
record and meta data fields that add
additional information metadata fields
may be omitted to save storage costs but
base fields are always included and
cannot be omitted some log fields are in
a multi-field format with more than one
piece of data in a given field
for example
the connection field that you see from
the base is of the ip details format
which contains the source and
destination ip address and port
plus the protocol in a single field
flows that have an endpoint in a gke
cluster can be annotated with gke
annotations which can include details of
the cluster
pod and service of the endpoint gke
annotations are only available with a
custom configuration of metadata fields
now when you enable vpc flow logs you
can set a filter based on both base and
metadata fields that only preserves logs
that match the filter all other logs are
discarded before being written to
logging which saves you money and
reduces the time needed to find the
information you're looking for shown
here is a sample from the console in
both the classic logs viewer as well as
the logs viewer in preview and so in the
classic logs viewer you can simply
select the sub network from the first
pull down menu and from the second pull
down menu you can select the
compute.googleapis.com
forward slash vpc underscore flows and
this will give you the information that
you need to pull up all your vpc flow
logs in the logs viewer preview it is
done in a similar way but the query is
shown here in the query builder and can
be adjusted accordingly pulling up any
vpc flow logs must be done within the
console when viewing them in google
cloud and so the last thing i wanted to
show you before ending this lesson is a
sample of the log itself the log shown
here is a sample of what a vpc flow log
looks like
and as you can see here beside each
field you will see a small arrow
clicking on these arrows will expand the
field and reveal many of the subfields
that you saw on the last slide and will
give you the necessary information you
need to analyze your vpc flow logs in
this example of the connection field it
shows the five tuple that describes this
connection which you can clearly see up
here at the top and if i were to go
further down and expand more of these
fields i would find more information
that could help me better analyze more
logging info for my given problem that i
am trying to solve now i didn't want to
go too deep into logging as i will be
diving into a complete section on its
own in a later section of the course but
i did want you to get a feel for what
type of data vpc flow logs can give you
and how it can help you in your specific
use case as well as on the exam and so
that's pretty much all i wanted to cover
with regards to vpc flow logs so you can
now mark this lesson as complete and
let's move on to the next one
[Music]
welcome back in this lesson i'm going to
cover a high-level overview of a basic
foundational service that supports the
backbone of the internet as we know it
today this foundation is called dns or
the domain name system dns is used
widely in google cloud from mostly an
infrastructure perspective and is used
in pretty much any other cloud
environment or computer network on the
planet now there is quite a bit to cover
in this lesson with regards to dns so
with that being said let's dive in
now dns or domain name system is a
global decentralized distributed
database that lets you store ip
addresses and other data
and look them up by name this system
uses human readable names like
google.com and translates it into a
language that computers understand which
are numeric ip addresses for example
humans access information online through
a domain name like google.com computers
use ip addresses to access information
online like 172.217.
now whether you type google.com or the
ip address into a web browser both will
connect to google.com dns translates the
domain name to an ip address so that the
web browser knows where to connect to
and we know what to enter into the web
browser through dns you can connect a
domain name to web hosting
mail
and other services
now getting a bit deeper into it as ip
addresses are at the core of
communicating between devices on the
internet they are hard to memorize and
can change often even for the same
service to get around these problems we
gave names to ip addresses for example
when it comes to our computer
communicating with
www.google.com it will use the dns
system to do this now in the dns
database contains the information needed
to convert the www.google.com
domain name to the ip address and this
piece of information is stored in a
logical container called a zone the way
that the zone is stored is through
what's commonly known as a zone file now
within this zone file is a dns record
which links the name
www and the ip address that your laptop
needs to communicate
with the specific website and this zone
file is hosted by what's known as a name
server or ns server for short and i will
be going into further detail on this in
just a minute so in short if you can
query the zone for the record
www.google.com
then your computer can communicate with
the web server and dns is what makes it
all happen
now i wanted to go into a bit of history
of how dns came about so in early
computer networks a simple text file
called a host file was created that
mapped hostnames to ip addresses and
this enabled people to refer to other
computers by the name and their
computers translated that name to an ip
address when it needed to communicate
with it the problem is as network sizes
increased the host file approach became
impractical due to the fact that it
needed to be stored on each computer as
each computer would have to resolve the
same host names as well updates were
difficult to manage as all of the
computers would need to be given an
updated file all in all this system was
not scalable
now to overcome these and other
limitations the dns system was developed
and the dns system essentially provided
for a way to organize the names using a
domain name structure it also provided a
dynamic system for protocols services
and methods
for storing updating and retrieving ip
addresses for host computers
now that i've covered what dns is
and why we use it i wanted to dive into
the structure of the dns system now the
structure all begins with a dot the root
if you will and this can be found after
every domain name that you type into
your browser you will almost never see
it and this is because your browser will
automatically put it in without your
knowing you can try it with any domain
in any browser and you will almost
always come up with the same result this
dot is put in for you and will provide
the route for you and this is where we
start to break down the dns system
now the domain name space consists of a
hierarchical data structure like the one
you have on your computer each node has
a label and zero or more resource
records which hold information
associated with the domain name the
domain name itself consists of the label
concatenated with the name of its parent
node on the right separated by a dot so
when it comes to dns the domain name is
always assembled from right to left this
hierarchy or tree is subdivided into
zones beginning at the root zone a dns
zone may consist of only one domain or
may consist of many domains and sub
domains depending on the administrative
choices of the zone manager now getting
right into it the root server is the
first step in translating human readable
hostnames into ip addresses the root
domain is comprised of 13 dns systems
dispersed around the world known
collectively as the dns root servers
they are indicated by the letters a
through m
operated by 12 organizations such as
verisign cogent and nasa while there are
13 ip addresses that represent these
systems there are actually more than 13
servers some of the ip addresses are
actually a cluster of dns servers and so
each of these dns servers also consists
of the root zone file which contains the
address of the authoritative name server
for each top level domain and because
this is such a big undertaking to keep
updated iana or the internet assigned
numbers authority was appointed as the
authority that manages and administrates
this file and i will include a link in
the lesson text for those of you who are
looking to dive deeper into the contents
of this root zone file as well as
getting to know a little bit more about
the iana organization now while the dns
root servers establish the hierarchy
most of the name resolution process is
delegated to other dns servers so just
below the dns route in the hierarchy are
the top level domain servers
also known as tld for short the top
level domain takes the tld provided in
the user's query for example www.google
and provides details for the dot-com tld
name server the companies that
administer these domains are named
registries and they operate the
authoritative name servers for these top
level domains for example verisign is
the registry for the dot com top level
domain over a hundred million domains
have been registered in the dot com top
level domain and these top level dns
servers
handle top level domains such as com dot
org dot net and dot io and this can also
be referred to as the gtld which is the
general top level domains and the cctld
which is the country code top level
domain like dot ca for canada dot uk for
the united kingdom and dot it for italy
the top level dns servers delegate to
thousands of second level dns servers
now second level domain names are sold
to companies and other organizations and
over 900 accredited registrars register
and manage the second level domains in
the dot com domain for end users the
second level of this structure is
comprised of millions of domain names
second level dns servers can further
delegate the zone but most commonly
store the individual host records for a
domain name this is the server at the
bottom of the dns lookup chain where you
would typically find resource records
and it is these resource records that
maps services and host names to ip
addresses and will respond with the
queried resource record ultimately
allowing the web browser making the
request to reach the ip address needed
to access a website or other web
resources now there is one more concept
that i wanted to cover
before we move on and this is the sub
domain now some of you have noticed and
wondered where does the sub domain come
into play with regards to the dns
structure well this is a resource record
that falls under the second level domain
and in dns hierarchy a sub domain is a
domain that is a part of another main
domain but i wanted to put it in here
just to give you an understanding of
where subdomains would fall so now that
we understand how dns is structured i
wanted to go through the breakdown of
the data flow of dns to give you some
better contacts now there are eight
steps in a dns lookup first we start off
with the dns client which is shown here
as tony bowtie's laptop and this is a
client device which could also be a
phone or a tablet and is configured with
software to send name resolution queries
to a dns server so when a client needs
to resolve a remote host name into its
ip address in most cases it sends a
request to the dns recursive resolver
which returns the ip address of the
remote host to the client a recursive
resolver
is a dns server that is configured to
query other dns servers until it finds
the answer to the question it will
either return the answer or an error
message to the client if it cannot
answer the query and the query will
eventually be passed off to the dns
client the recursive resolver in essence
acts as the middle man between a client
and a dns name server which is usually
the internet service provider a service
carrier or a corporate network now to
make sure that a resolver is able to
properly run dns a root hints file is
supplied with almost every operating
system and this file holds the ip
addresses for the root name servers this
also includes the dns resolver but in
case it is unable to answer the query
the client will be able to still make
the query to the dns name servers now
after receiving a dns query from a
client
this recursive resolver will either
respond with cache data or send a
request to a root name server and in
this case the resolver queries a dns
root name server the root server then
responds to the resolver with the
address of a top level domain or tld dns
server such as com or dot net which
stores the information for its domains
now when searching for google.com the
request is pointed towards the dot-com
tld so naturally the resolver then makes
a request to the com tld then the tld
name server then responds with the ip
address of the domain's name server
google.com and lastly the resolver then
sends a query to the domain's name
server the ip address for google.com is
then returned to the resolver from the
name server this ip address is cache for
a period of time determined by the
google.com name server and this process
is so that a future request for this
hostname could be resolved from its
cache rather than performing the entire
process from beginning to end and so for
those of you who are unaware cache is a
component that stores data so that
future requests for that data can be
served faster the purpose of this
caching is to temporarily store data in
a location that results in improvements
in performance and reliability for data
requests dns caching involves storing
the data closer to the requesting client
so that the dns query can be resolved
earlier and additional queries further
down the dns lookup chain can be avoided
and thus improving load times dns data
can be cached in a variety of locations
down the chain each of which will store
dns records for a set amount of time
determined by a time to live also known
as ttl for short and this value is the
time to live for that domain record a
high ttl for a domain record means that
local dns resolvers will cache responses
for longer and give quicker responses
however making changes to dns records
can take longer due to the need to wait
for all cash records to expire
alternatively domain records with low
ttls can change much more quickly but
dns resolvers will need to refresh their
records more often and so in this final
step the dns resolver then responds to
the web browser with the ip address of
the domain requested initially and once
these eight steps of the dns lookup have
returned the ip address for
www.google.com
the browser is able to make the request
for the webpage and so the browser will
reach out to the ip address of the
server and request the web page which
will be loaded up in the browser now i
know this probably has been a review for
those who are a bit more advanced when
it comes to understanding dns but for
others who are fairly new to the
underpinnings of dns i hope this has
given you a basic understanding of what
it is why we use it and how it works
moving forward in the course i will be
discussing dns with regards to different
services and the needed resource records
within zones that are used by these
given services and so that's pretty much
all i wanted to cover when it comes to
the fundamentals of dns so you can now
mark this lesson as complete and let's
move on to the next one
[Music]
welcome back in this lesson i'm going to
be diving into dns record types now dns
resource records are the basic
information elements of the domain name
system they are entries in the dns
database which provide information about
hosts these records are physically
stored in the zone files on the dns
server this lesson will go through some
of the most commonly used dns records
that we will be coming across throughout
this course so with that being said
let's dive in now the first record that
i wanted to touch on are the name server
records also known as ns records for
short this record identifies which dns
server contains the current records for
a domain these servers are usually found
at a registrar internet service provider
or hosting company ns records are
created to identify the name server used
for each domain name within a given zone
in this example we have the dot co zone
that will have multiple name server
records for
bowtieinc.co now these name server
records are how the dot co delegation
happens for bowtieinc.co and they point
at servers that host the
inc.co zone that is managed by bowtie
inc and the flow shown here of the query
starts from the root zone going to the
dot co zone where the record lies for
the name servers for bowtieinc.com
and flows down to the bowtieinc.cozone
that contain all the necessary records
for bowtieinc.co
the next record that i wanted to touch
on are the a and aaa records and this is
short for address records for ipv4 and
ipv6 ip addresses respectively and this
record points a domain name to an ip
address for example when you type wwe
in a web browser the dns system will
translate that domain name
to the ip address of 52.54.92.195
using the a record information stored in
the bowtieinc.co
dns zone file the a record links a
website's domain name to an ipv4 address
that points to the server where the
website's files live now when it comes
to an aaa record this links a website's
domain to an ipv6 address that points to
the same server where the website's
files live a records are the simplest
type of dns records and one of the
primary records used in dns servers you
can do a lot with a records including
using multiple a records for the same
domain in order to provide redundancy
the same can be said
for aaa records additionally multiple
domains could point to the same address
in which case each would have its own a
or aaa record pointing to that same ip
address
moving on to cname records a c name
record short for canonical name record
is a type of resource record that maps
one domain name to another this can be
really convenient when running multiple
services like an ftp server and an
e-commerce server each running on
different ports from a single ip address
you can for example
point ftp ftp.bowtieinc.co
and shop.bowtieinc.co
to the dns entry for bowtieinc.co
which in turn has an a record which
points to the ip address so if the ip
address ever changes
you only have to change the record in
one place in the dns a record for bow
tie inc dot co and just as a note cname
records must always point to another
domain name and never directly to an ip
address next up are txt records a text
record or txt for short is a type of
resource record that provides text
information to sources outside your
domain that can be used for a number of
arbitrary purposes the records value can
be either human or machine readable text
in many cases text records are used to
verify domain ownership or even to
provide human readable information about
a server a network or a data center it
is also often used in a more structured
fashion to record small amounts of
machine readable data into the dns
system a domain may have multiple tax
records associated with it
provided the dns server implementation
supports this each record can in turn
have one or more character strings in
this example
google wants to verify the bowtieinc.co
domain so that g suite can be set up and
needs verification through the domain to
google through creating a text record
and adding it to the zone google will
then supply a text verification record
to add to the domain host's dns records
and start to scan for the text record to
verify the domain
the supplied text record is then added
by the domain administrator and behind
the scenes google is doing a
verification check at timed intervals
when google finally sees the record
exists the domain ownership is confirmed
and g suite can be enabled for the
domain and this is a typical example of
how tax records are used now moving on
to mx records a dns
mx record also known as the mail
exchange record is the resource record
that directs email to a mail server the
mx record indicates how email messages
should be routed and to which server
mail should go to like cname records an
mx record must always point to another
domain now mx records consist of two
parts the priority
and the domain name the priority are the
numbers before the domains for these mx
records and indicate the preference of
the order in which the mail server
should be used the lower the preference
number the higher the priority so in
this example
laura is emailing tony bowtie at tony at
bowtieinc.co
the mx records are part of this process
as dns needs to know where to send the
mail to and we'll look at the domain
attached to the email address which is
bowtieinc.co so the dns client will run
a regular dns query by first going to
the root then to the
cotld and finally to bowtieinc.co
it will then receive the mx record which
in this example is two of them the first
one being mail representing
mail.bowtieinc.co
and then the second one is a different
mail server outside the current domain
and in this case is a google mail server
of aspmx.l.google.com
and this is a fully qualified domain
name as the dot on the right of this
record suggests so here the server will
always try mail.bowtieinc.co
first because 5 is lower than 10. and
this will give mail.bowtieinc.co
the higher priority in the result of a
message send failure the server will
default to aspmx.l.google.com
if both values are the same then it
would be low balanced across both
servers whichever is used the server
gets the result of the query back and it
uses this to connect to the mail server
for bowtieinc.co via the smtp protocol
and it uses this protocol to deliver all
email and this is how mx records are
used for email the next record i wanted
to cover are the pointer records
also known as ptr records for short and
this provides the domain name associated
with an ip address so a dns pointer
record is exactly the opposite of the a
record which provides the ip address
associated with the domain name dns
pointer records are used in reverse dns
lookups as we discussed earlier when a
user attempts to reach a domain name in
their browser a dns lookup occurs
matching the domain name to the ip
address a reverse dns lookup is the
opposite of this process and it is a
query that starts with the ip address
and looks up the domain name while dnsa
records are stored under the given
domain name dns pointer records are
stored under the ip address reverse and
ending in dot i n
a d d r dot arpa so in this example the
pointer record for the iap address
52.54.90
would be stored under 195.92.54.52
dot in
addr dot arpa ipv6 addresses are
constructed differently from ipv4
addresses and ipv6 pointer records exist
in a different namespace
within.arpa ipv6 pointer records are
stored under the ipv6 address reversed
and converted into 4-bit sections as
opposed to 8-bit sections as in ipv4 and
as well the domain.ip6.arpa
is added at the end pointer records are
used most commonly in reverse dns
lookups for anti-spam troubleshooting
email delivery issues and logging and so
the last record that i wanted to cover
are the soa records also known as the
start of authority records and this
resource record is created for you when
you create your managed zone and
specifies the authoritative information
including global parameters about a dns
zone the soa record stores important
information about a domain or zone such
as the email address of the
administrator when the domain was last
updated and how long the server should
wait between refreshes every dns zone
registered must have an soa record as
per the rfc 1035 and there is exactly
one soa record per zone the soa record
contains the core information about your
zone so it is not possible for your zone
to work without that information and i
will include a link in the lesson text
for those who are interested in diving
deeper and understanding all the
information that is covered under these
soa records a properly optimized and
updated soa record can reduce bandwidth
between name servers increase the speed
of website access and ensure the site is
alive even when the primary dns server
is down and so that about covers
everything that i wanted to discuss when
it comes to resource records within dns
so you can now mark this lesson as
complete
and let's move on to the next one
[Music]
welcome back
in this lesson i'm going to be covering
network address translation also known
as nat for short this is a common
process
used in home business and any cloud
networks that you will encounter knowing
and understanding that will help you
achieve why you would use it and what
makes it such a necessary process
now there's quite a bit to cover here so
with that being said let's dive in
now at a high level nat is a way to map
multiple local private ip addresses to a
public ip address before transferring
the information this is done by altering
the network address data in the ip
header of the data packet while
traveling through a network towards the
destination
as packets pass through a nat device
either the source or destination ip
address is changed
then packets returning in the other
direction are translated back to the
original addresses
and this is a process that is typically
used in most home routers that are
provided by your internet service
provider now originally nat was designed
to deal with the scarcity of free ipv4
addresses increasing the number of
computers that can operate off a single
publicly routable ip address and so
because devices in the private ip space
such as 192.168.0.0
cannot traverse the public internet
that is needed for those devices to
communicate with the public internet now
ipv6 was designed to overcome the ipv4
shortage and has tons of available
addresses and therefore there is no real
need for nat when it comes to ipv6 now
nat has an additional benefit of adding
a layer of security and privacy by
hiding the ip address of your devices
from the outside world and only allowing
packets to be sent and received from the
originating private device and so this
is a high level of what nat is now there
are multiple types of not that i will be
covering
which at a high level do the same thing
which is translate private i p addresses
to public ip addresses yet different
types of nat handles the process
differently so first we have static nat
which maps a single private ip address
to a public ip address
so a one-to-one mapping that gives the
device with the private ip address
access to the public internet in both
directions
this is commonly used where one specific
device with a private address needs
access to the public internet the next
type of nat is dynamic nan and this is
similar to static nat but doesn't hold
the same static allocation a private ip
address space
is mapped to a pool of public ip
addresses and are allocated randomly as
needed when the ip address is no longer
needed the ip address is returned back
to the pool ready to be used by another
device
this method is commonly used where
multiple internal hosts with private i p
addresses
are sharing an equal or fewer amount of
public i p addresses
and is designed to be an efficient use
of public ips and finally there is port
address translation or pat
where multiple private ip addresses are
translated using a single public ip
address and a specific port
and this is probably what your home
router is using and will cover all the
devices you use in your home network
this method uses ports to help
distinguish individual devices
and is also the method that is used for
cloudnat in google cloud which i will be
covering in a later lesson and so i
wanted to get into a bit more detail on
how these methods work
starting with static not
now to set the stage for static not i'm
going to start off with a private
network here on the left
and the public ip space here on the
right
and the router or not device in the
middle in this example there is a server
on the left that needs access to
external services and for this example
the external service we are using is the
bowtress service an image sharing site
for all sorts of awesome bow ties
so the server on the left is private
with a private ip address of 192.168.0.5
and this means it has an address in the
ip version 4 private address space
meaning that it cannot route packets
over the public internet because it only
has a private ip
the beautress service on the other hand
has a public ip address which is
54.5.4.9
so the issue we run into is that the
private address can't be routed over the
public internet because it's private and
the public address of the beau trust
service
can't directly communicate with any
private address because public and
private addresses can communicate over
the public internet what we need is to
translate the private address that the
server on the left has
to a public ip that can communicate with
the service on the right and vice versa
now then that device will map the
private ip to public ip
using and maintaining a nat table and in
this case of static nat the nat device
will have a one-to-one mapping of the
private ip address to a public ip
address and can be allocated to the
device specified which in this case is
the server marked as 192.168.0.15
and so in order for the server on the
left
to communicate with the beautress
service the server will generate a
packet as normal with the source ip of
the packet being the server's private ip
address and the destination ip of the
packet being the ip of the bowtrust
service now the router in the middle is
the default gateway for any destination
so any ip packets which are destined for
anything but the local network are sent
to the router so as you can see here
with the entry in the table it will
contain the private i p address of
192.168.0.15
and mapped to the public address which
in this case is 73.6.2.33
and these are statically mapped to one
another and so as the packet passes
through the nat device the source
address of the packet is translated
from the private address to the mapped
public address and this results in a new
packet so this new packet still has
beautrest as the destination
but now it has a valid public ip address
as the source
and so this is the translation that
happens through nat now this process
works in a similar way in the other
direction
so when the beautress service receives
the packet it sees the source as this
public ip
so when it responds with data its packet
has its ip address as the source
and the previous server's public ip
address as the destination
so it sends this packet back to this
public ip so when the packet arrives at
the nat device the table is checked
it recognizes then that the ip is for
the server and so this time for incoming
traffic
the destination ip address is updated to
the corresponding private ip address and
then the packet is forwarded through to
the private server and this is how
static nat works the source i p address
is translated from the mapped private ip
to public ip
and for incoming traffic the destination
i p address is translated from the
allocated public ip to the corresponding
private ip all without having to
configure a public ip
on any private device
as they always hold their private ip
addresses
now i wanted to supply an analogy for
nat and so a very common analogy that is
used is that of a phone service so in
this example
laura is the new manager of bow tie inc
new location in montreal and has put in
a new public phone number of
514-555-8437
although as you can see here laura also
has a private extension
of one three three seven now if george
called laura at that public phone number
he would reach laura without ever
knowing her private extension so the
private extension acts as that private
ip address
and the public phone number would act as
the public ip address and this would be
the telephone analogy for static nat and
so this is the end of part one of this
lesson it was getting a bit long so i
decided to break it up this would be a
great opportunity for you to get up and
have a stretch get yourself a coffee or
a tea and whenever you're ready you can
join me in part two where we will be
starting immediately from the end of
part one so you can go ahead and
complete this video and i will see you
in part two
[Music]
welcome back this is part two of the
network address translation lesson and
we will be starting exactly where we
left off from part 1.
so with that being said let's dive in
now moving on to dynamic nat
this method is similar to static nat
except that devices are not allocated a
permanent public ip
a public ip address is allocated from a
pool of ip addresses
as they are needed and the mapping of
public to private is allocation base in
this example there are two devices on
the left and according to the nat table
there are two public ip addresses
available for use
73.6.2.33
and 73.6.2.34
so when the laptop on the left is
looking to access the beautress service
it will generate a packet where the
source ip
is the private address of 192.168.0.13
and the destination ip is 54.5.4.9
so it sends this packet and again the
router in the middle is the default
gateway for anything that isn't local as
the packet passes through the router or
the nat device
it checks if the private ip has a
current allocation of public addressing
from the pool and if it doesn't and one
is available it allocates one
dynamically and in this case
73.6.2.34
is allocated
so the packet's source i p address
is translated to this address
and the packets are sent to the
beautress service and so this process is
the same as static not thus far
but because dynamic nat allocates these
ip addresses dynamically multiple
private devices can share a single
public ip
as long as the devices are not using the
same public ip at the same time and so
once the device is finished
communication the ip is returned back to
the pool and is ready for use by another
device now just as a note if there's no
public ip addresses available
the router rejects any new connections
until you clear the nat mappings
but if you have as many public ip
addresses as hosts in your network
you won't encounter this problem and so
in this case since the lower server is
looking to access the fashion tube
service
there is an available public ip address
in the pool
of 73.6.2.33
thus giving it access to the public
internet and access to fashion tube so
in summary the nat device maps a private
ip with the public ip in a nat table and
public ips are allocated randomly and
dynamically from a pool now this type of
knot is used where multiple internal
hosts with private ip addresses
are sharing an equal or fewer amount of
public ip addresses when all of those
private devices at some time will need
public access
now an example of dynamic nat using the
telephone analogy
would be if laura and two other bow tie
inc employees
lisa and jane
had private phone numbers
and this would represent your private
ips
in this example bowtie inc has three
public phone numbers
now when any employee makes an outbound
call they are routed to whichever public
line is open at the time so the caller
id on the receiver's end
would show any one of the three public
phone numbers depending on which one was
given to the caller and this would
represent the public ips in the public
ip pool
now the last type of nat which i wanted
to talk about is the one which you're
probably most familiar with and this is
port address translation which is also
known as not overload and this is the
type of not you likely use on your home
network port address translation is what
allows a large number of private devices
to share one public ip address
giving it a many to one mapping
architecture now in this example we'll
be using three private devices on the
left
all wanting to access fashiontube on the
right
a popular video sharing website of the
latest men's fashions
shared by millions across the globe
and this site has a public ip of
62.88.44.88
and accessed using tcp port 443 now the
way that port address translation or pat
works
is to use both the ip addresses and
ports
to allow for multiple devices to share
the same public ip every tcp connection
in addition to a source and destination
ip address
has a source and destination port the
source port is randomly assigned by the
client so as long as the source port is
always unique then many private clients
can use the same public ip address and
all this information is recorded in the
nat table on the nat device
in this example let's assume that the
public ip address of this nat device is
73.6.2.33
so when the laptop in the top left
generates a packet and the packet is
going to fashion tube its destination ip
address is 62.80
and its destination port is 443. now the
source ip of this packet is the laptop's
private ip address of 192.168.6
and the source port is 35535
which is a randomly assigned ephemeral
port so the packet is routed through the
nat device
and in transit the nat device records
the source ip and the original source
private port
and it allocates a new public ip address
and a new public source port which in
this case is 8844
it records this information inside the
not table as shown here and it adjusts
the pocket so that its source ip address
is the public ip address that the nat
device is using and the source port is
this newly allocated source port and
this newly adjusted packet is forwarded
on to fashiontube now the process is
very similar with the return traffic
where the packet will verify the
recorded ips and ports
in the nat table before forwarding the
packet back to the originating source
now if the middle laptop with the ip of
192.168.0.14
did the same thing then the same process
would be followed all of this
information would be recorded in the nat
table a new public source port would be
allocated and would translate the packet
adjusting the packet's source ip address
and source port as well the same process
would happen for the laptop on the
bottom generating a packet with the
source and destination ip with the
addition of the source and destination
ports and when routed through the nat
device goes through its translation
recording the information in the nat
table and reaching its destination again
return traffic will be verified by the
recorded ips and ports in the nat table
before forwarding the packet back to its
originating source and so just as a
summary when it comes to port address
translation the nat device records the
source ip and source port in a nat table
the source ip is then replaced with a
public ip and public source port
and are allocated from a pool that
allows overloading and this is a
many-to-one architecture
and so for the telephone analogy for pat
let's use a phone operator example so in
this instance george is trying to call
laura now george only knows lark laura's
executive admin and only has lark's
phone number george does not have
laura's private line lark's public phone
number is the equivalent to having a
public ip address george calls lark who
then connects george to laura the caveat
here is that lark never gives out
laura's phone number in fact laura
doesn't have a public phone number and
can only be called by lark and here's
where nat can add an extra layer of
security by only allowing needed ports
to be accessed without allowing anyone
to connect to any port now i hope this
has helped you understand the process of
network address translation
how the translation happens
and the process of using a nat table to
achieve packet translation
along with its destination this is so
common in most environments that you
will encounter and it's very important
to fully understand the different types
of not
and how it can be used in these types of
environments and so that's pretty much
all i wanted to cover
on this lesson of network address
translation so you can now mark this
lesson as complete
and let's move on to the next one
[Music]
welcome back so now that we've covered
the fundamentals of dns along with the
different record types i wanted to focus
in on google cloud's dns service called
cloud dns now cloud dns is a fully
managed service that manages dns servers
for your specific zones and since cloud
dns shows up on the exam only on a high
level i will be giving an overview of
what this service can do so with that
being said let's dive in now cloud dns
acts as an authoritative dns server for
public zones that are visible to the
internet or for private zones that are
visible only within your network and is
commonly referred to as google's dns as
a service cloud dns has servers that
span the globe making it a globally
resilient service now while it is a
global service there is no way to select
specific regions to deploy your zones
and dns server policies you simply add
your zones records and policies and it
is distributed amongst google's dns
servers across the globe cloud dns is
also one of the few google cloud
services that offers 100
availability along with low latency
access
by leveraging google's massive global
network backbone now in order to use
cloud dns with a specific publicly
available domain a domain name must be
purchased through a domain name
registrar and you can register a domain
name through google domains or another
domain registrar of your choice cloud
dns does not provide this service and
just as a note that to create private
zones the purchasing of a domain name is
not necessary now as stated earlier
cloud dns offers the flexibility of
hosting both public zones and privately
managed dns zones now public zones are
zones that are visible to the public
internet and so when cloud dns is
managing your public domain it has
public authoritative name servers that
respond to public zone dns queries for
your specific domain now when it comes
to private zones these enable you to
manage custom domain names
for your google cloud resources without
exposing any dns data to the public
internet a private zone can only be
queried by resources in the same project
where it is defined and as we discussed
earlier a zone is a container of dns
records that are queried by dns so from
a private zone perspective these can
only be queried by one or more vpc
networks that you authorize to do so and
just as a note the vpc networks that you
authorize must be located in the same
project as the private zone to query
records hosted in manage private zones
in other projects the use of dns peering
is needed now i don't want to get too
deep into dns peering
but just know that vpc network peering
is not required for the cloud dns
peering zone to operate peering zones do
not depend on vpc network peering now
each managed zone that you create is
associated with a google cloud project
and once this zone is created it is
hosted by google's managed name servers
now these zones are always hosted on
google's manage name servers within
google cloud so you would create records
and record sets and these servers would
then become allocated to that specific
zone hosting your records and record
sets and just as a quick reminder a
record set is the collection of dns
records in a zone that have the same
name and are of the same type most
records contain a single record but it's
not uncommon to see record sets a great
example of this are a records or ns
records which we discussed earlier and
these records can usually be found in
pairs
and so now to give you a practical
example of cloud dns i wanted to bring
the theory into practice through a short
demo where i'll be creating a managed
private zone so whenever you're ready
join me in the console and so here we
are back in the console and i'm logged
in as tonybowties gmail.com and i'm
currently in project bowtie inc so now
to get to cloud dns i'm going to go over
to the navigation menu i'm going to
scroll down to network services and go
over to cloud dns
and because i currently don't have any
zones
i'm prompted with only one option which
is to create a zone and so i'm going to
go ahead and create a zone and so here
i've been prompted with a bunch of
different options in order to create my
dns zone and so the first option that i
have is zone type and because i'm
creating a private zone i'm going to
simply click on private and i need to
provide a zone name which i'm going to
call tony bowtie next i'm going to have
to provide a dns name which i will call
tony bowtie dot private and under the
description i'm just going to type in
private zone for tony bowtie and so the
next field i've been given is the
options field where it is currently
marked as default private and so if i go
over here to the right hand side and
open up the drop down menu i'm given the
options to forward queries to another
server dns peering manage reverse lookup
zones and use a service directory
namespace and so depending on your type
of scenario one of these five options in
most cases will suffice so i'm going to
keep it under default private and under
networks it says your private zone will
be visible to the selected networks
and so i'm going to click on the drop
down and i'm giving only the option of
the default network because it's the
only network that i have and so i'm
going to select it
and i'm going to click on the white
space and if i feel so inclined i can
simply click on the shortcut for the
command line and here i'm given this
specific commands if i was to use the
command line in order to create this dns
zone so i'm going to click on close here
and i'm going to click on create and as
you can see here my zone has been
created along with a couple of dns
records the first one being my name
server records as well as my start of
authority records and so as a note to
know for the exam when creating a zone
these two records will always be created
both the soa record and the ns record
and moving on to some other options here
i can add another record set if i choose
to again the dns name the record type
which i have a whole slew of record
types to choose from it's ttl and the ip
address but i'm not going to add any
records so i'm just going to cancel and
by clicking in use by i can view which
vpc network is using this zone and as
expected the default network shows up
and i also have the choice of adding
another network but since i don't have
any other networks i can't add anything
so i'm going to simply cancel i also
have the option of removing any networks
so if i click on this i can remove the
network or i can also remove the network
by clicking on the hamburger menu and so
as you can see i have a slew of options
to choose from when creating zones and
record sets and so that about covers
everything that i wanted to show you
here in cloud dns
but before i go i'm going to go ahead
and clean up and i'm just going to click
on the garbage can here on the right
hand side of the zone and i'm going to
be prompted if i want to delete the zone
yes i do so i'm going to click on delete
and so that pretty much covers
everything that i wanted to show you
with regards to cloud dns so you can now
mark this lesson as complete and let's
move on to the next one
welcome back now before we step into the
compute engine section of the course
i wanted to cover a basic foundation of
what makes these vms possible
and this is where a basic understanding
of virtualization comes into play now
this is merely an introductory lesson to
virtualization and i won't be getting
too deep into the underpinnings it
serves as just a basic foundation as to
how compute engine gets its features
under the hood and how they are possible
through the use of virtualization for
more in-depth understanding on
virtualization i will be including some
links in the lesson text for those who
are looking to learn more but for now
this will provide just enough theory to
help you understand how compute engine
works
so with that being said let's dive in so
what exactly is virtualization well
virtualization is the process of running
multiple operating systems on a server
simultaneously now before virtualization
became popular a standard model was used
where an operating system would be
installed on a server
so the server would consist of typical
hardware like cpu
memory network cards and other devices
such as video cards usb devices and
storage and then the operating system
would run on top of the hardware now
there is a middle layer of the operating
system a supervisor if you will that is
responsible for interacting with
underlying hardware and this is known as
the kernel the kernel manages the
distribution of the hardware resources
of the computer efficiently and fairly
among all the various processes running
on the computer now the kernel operates
under what is called kernel mode or
privilege mode as it runs privileged
instructions that interacts with the
hardware directly now the operating
system allows other software to run on
top of it like an application
but cannot interact directly with the
hardware it must interact with the
operating system in user mode or
non-privileged mode so when lark decides
to do something on an application that
needs to use the system hardware that
application needs to go through the
operating system it needs to make what's
known as a system call and this is the
model of running one operating system on
a single server now when passed servers
would traditionally run one application
on one server with one operating system
in the old system the number of servers
would continue to mount
since every new application required its
own server and its own operating system
as a result expensive hardware resources
were purchased but not used and each
server would use approximately under 20
of its resources on average server
resources were then known as
underutilized now there came a time when
multiple operating systems were
installed on one computer
isolated from each other with each
operating system running their own
applications this was a perfect model to
consolidate hardware and keep
utilization high but there is a major
issue that arose each cpu at this given
moment in time could only have one thing
running as privileged so having multiple
operating systems running on their own
in an unmodified state
and expecting to be running on their own
in a privileged state running privileged
instructions
was causing instability in systems
causing not just application crashes but
system crashes now a hypervisor is what
solved this problem it is a small
software layer that enables multiple
operating systems to run alongside each
other
sharing the same physical computing
resources these operating systems come
as virtual machines or vms and these are
files that mimic an entire computing
hardware environment in software the
hypervisor also known as a virtual
machine monitor or vmm
manages these vms as they run alongside
each other it separates virtual machines
from each other logically assigning each
its own slice of the underlying
computing cpu memory and other devices
like graphics network and storage this
prevents the vms from interfering with
each other so if for example one
operating system suffers a crash or a
security compromise the others will
survive and continue running now the
hypervisor was never as efficient as how
you see it here it went through some
major iterations that gave its structure
as we know it today initially
virtualization had to be done in
software or what we now refer to as the
host machine
and the operating system with its
applications put in logical containers
known as virtual machines or guests the
operating system would be installed on
the host which included additional
capabilities called a hypervisor and
allowed it to make the necessary
privileged calls to the hardware
having full access to the host the
hypervisor exposed the interface of the
hardware device that is available on the
host
and allowed it to be mapped to the
virtual machine and emulated the
behavior of this device and this allowed
the virtual machine using the operating
system drivers that were designed to
interact with the emulated device
without installing any special drivers
or tools
as well as keeping the operating system
unmodified the problem here is that it
was all emulated and so every time the
virtual machines made calls back to the
host each instruction needed to be
translated by the hypervisor
using what's called a binary translation
now without this translation the
emulation wouldn't work and would cause
system crashes bringing down all virtual
machines in the process now the problem
with this process is that it made the
system painfully slow and it was this
performance penalty that caused this
process to not be so widely adopted but
then another type of virtualization came
on the scene called para virtualization
now in this model a modified guest
operating system is able to speak
directly to the hypervisor and this
involves having the operating system
kernel to be modified and recompiled
before installation onto the virtual
machine this would allow the operating
system to talk directly with the
hypervisor without any performance hits
as there is no translation going on like
an emulation para virtualization
replaces instructions that cannot be
virtualized with hyper calls that
communicate directly with the hypervisor
so a hypercall is based on the same
concept as a system call privileged
instructions
that accept instead of calling the
kernel directly it calls the hypervisor
and due to the modification in this
guest operating system performance is
enhanced as the modified guest operating
system communicates directly with the
hypervisor and emulation overhead is
removed the guest operating system
becomes almost virtualization aware yet
there is still a process whereby
software was used to speak to the
hardware the virtual machines could
still not access the hardware directly
although
things changed in the world of
virtualization when the physical
hardware on the host became
virtualization aware and this is where
hardware assisted virtualization came
into play now hardware assisted
virtualization is an approach that
enables efficient
full virtualization using help from
hardware capabilities
on the host cpu using this model the
operating system has direct access to
resources without any hypervisor
emulation or operating system
modification the hardware itself becomes
virtualization aware the cpu contains
specific instructions and capabilities
so that the hypervisor can directly
control and configure this support it
also provides improved performance
because the privileged instructions from
the virtual machines are now trapped and
emulated in the hardware directly this
means that the operating system kernels
no longer need to be modified and
recompiled like in para virtualization
and can run as is at the same time the
hypervisor also does not need to be
involved in the extremely slow process
of binary translation now there is one
more iteration that i wanted to discuss
when it comes to virtualization and that
is kernel level virtualization
now instead of using a hypervisor
kernel level virtualization runs a
separate version of the linux kernel and
sees the associated virtual machine as a
user space process on the physical host
this makes it easy to run multiple
virtual machines on a single host a
device driver is used for communication
between the main linux kernel and the
virtual machine every vm is implemented
as a regular linux process
scheduled by the standard linux
scheduler
with dedicated virtual hardware like a
network card
graphics adapter
cpu memory and disk hardware support by
the cpu is required for virtualization a
slightly modified emulation process is
used as the display and execution
containers for the virtual machines in
many ways kernel level virtualization is
a specialized form of server
virtualization and this is the type of
virtualization platform that is used in
all of google cloud now with this type
of virtualization because of the kernel
acting as the hypervisor it enables a
specific feature called nested
virtualization now with nested
virtualization it is made possible to
install a hypervisor on top of the
already running virtual machine
and so this is what google cloud has
done now you're probably wondering after
going through all the complexities
involved with previous virtualization
models
what makes this scenario worthwhile well
using nested virtualization it makes it
easier for users to move their
on-premises
virtualized workloads to the cloud
without having to import and convert vm
images so in essence
it eases the use when migrating to cloud
a great use case for many but wouldn't
be possible on google cloud without the
benefit of running kernel level
virtualization now this is an advanced
concept that does not show up on the
exam but i wanted you to understand
virtualization at a high level
so that you can understand nested
virtualization within google cloud
as it is a part of the feature set of
compute engine and so that's pretty much
all i wanted to cover when it comes to
virtualization
so you can now mark this lesson as
complete and let's move on to the next
one
[Music]
welcome back now earlier on in the
course i discussed compute engine at a
high level to understand what it is and
what it does the goal for this section
is to dive deeper into compute engine as
it comes up heavily on the exam and so i
want to make sure i expose all the
nuances
as well it is the go-to service offering
from google cloud when looking to solve
any general computing needs with this
lesson specifically i will be going into
what makes up an instance and the
different options that are available
when creating the instance so with that
being said let's dive in
now compute engine lets you create and
run virtual machines known as instances
and host them on google's infrastructure
compute engine is google's
infrastructure as a service virtual
machine offering so it being an is
service google takes care of the
virtualization platform the physical
servers the network and storage along
with managing the data center and these
instances are available in different
sizes depending on how much cpu and
memory you might need as well compute
engine offers different family types for
the type of workload you need it for
each instance is charged by the second
after the first minute as this is a
consumption based model and as well
these instances are launched in a vpc
network in a specific zone and these
instances will actually sit on hosts in
these zones and you will be given the
option of using a multi-tenant host
where the server that is hosting your
machine is shared with others
but please note that each instance is
completely isolated from the other so no
one can see each other's instances
now you're also given the option of
running your instance on a sole tenant
node whereby your instance is on its own
dedicated hosts that is reserved just
for you and you alone you don't share it
with anyone else and this is strictly
for you only now although this option
may sound really great it does come at a
steep cost
so only if your use case requires you to
use a sole tenant node for security or
compliance purposes i recommend that you
stick with a multi-tenant host when
launching your instances and this is
usually the most common selection for
most
now compute engine instances can be
configured in many different ways and
allow you the flexibility to fulfill the
requests for your specific scenario and
as you can see here there are four
different base options when it comes to
configuration of the instance that you
are preparing to launch and so i wanted
to take time to go through them in just
a bit of detail for context starting
first with the machine type which covers
vcpu and memory now there are many
different predefined machine types that
i will be covering in great depth in a
different lesson but for now just know
that they are available in different
families depending on your needs and can
be chosen from the general
compute optimize and memory optimize
machine types they are available in
intel or amd flavors and if the
pre-defined options doesn't fit your
need you have the option of creating a
custom machine that will suit your
specific workload now when creating a vm
instance on compute engine each virtual
cpu or vcpu is implemented as a single
hardware hyper thread on one of the
available cpu processors that live on
the host now when choosing the amount of
vcpus on an instance
you must take into consideration the
desired network throughput as the amount
of vcpus will determine this throughput
as the bandwidth is determined per vm
instance not per network interface or
per ip address and so the network
throughput is determined by calculating
2 gigabits per second for every vcpu on
your instance so if you're looking for
greater network throughput then you may
want to select an instance with more
vcpus and so once you've determined a
machine type for your compute engine
instance you will need to provide it an
image with an operating system to boot
up with now when creating your vm
instances you must use an operating
system image to create boot disks for
your instances now compute engine offers
many pre-configured public images that
have compatible linux or windows
operating systems and these operating
system images can be used to create and
start instances compute engine uses your
selected image to create a persistent
boot disk for each instance by default
the boot disk for your instance is the
same size as the image that you selected
and you can use most public images at no
additional cost but please be aware that
there are some premium images that do
add additional cost to your instances
now moving on to custom images this is a
boot disk image that you own and control
access to a private image if you will
custom images are available only to your
cloud project unless you specifically
decide to share them with another
project or another organization you can
create a custom image from boot disks or
other images then use the custom image
to create an instance custom images that
you import to compute engine add no cost
to your instances but do incur an image
storage charge
while you keep your custom image in your
project now the third option that you
have is by using a marketplace image now
google cloud marketplace lets you
quickly deploy
functional software packages that run on
google cloud you can start up a software
package without having to manually
configure the software the vm instances
the storage or even the network settings
this is a all-in-one instance template
that includes the operating system and
the software pre-configured and you can
deploy a software package whenever you
like and is by far the easiest way to
launch a software package and i will be
giving you a run through on these
marketplace images in a later demo now
once you've decided on your machine type
as well as the type of image that you
wanted to use moving into the type of
storage that you want would be your next
step now when configuring a new instance
you will need to create a new boot disk
for it and this is where performance
versus cost comes into play as you have
the option to pay less and have a slower
disk speed or lower iops or you can
choose to have fast disk speed with
higher iops but pay a higher cost and so
the slowest and most inexpensive of
these options is the standard persistent
disk which are backed by standard hard
disk drives the balance persistent disks
are backed by solid state drives and are
faster and can provide higher iops than
the standard option and lastly ssd is
the fastest option which also brings
with it the highest iops available for
persistent disks now outside of these
three options for persistent disks you
also have the option of choosing a local
ssd and these are solid state drives
that are physically attached to the
server that hosts your vm instances and
this is why they have the highest
throughput and lowest latency than any
of the available persistent disks just
as a note the data that you store on a
local ssd persists only until the
instance is stopped or deleted which is
why local ssds are suited only for
temporary storage such as caches or swap
disk and so lastly moving into
networking
each network interface of a compute
engine instance is associated with a
subnet of a unique vpc network as you've
seen in the last section you can do this
with an auto a default or a custom
network each network is available in
many different regions and zones within
that region we've also experienced
routing traffic for our instance both in
and out of the vpc network
by use of firewall rules targeting ip
ranges
specific network tags or by instances
within the network now load balancers
are responsible for helping distribute
user traffic
across multiple instances either within
the network or externally using a
regional or global load balancer
and i will be getting into low balancing
in another section of the course but i
wanted to stress that load balancers are
part of instance networking that help
route and manage traffic coming in and
going out of the network
and so this is a high level overview of
the different configuration types that
go into putting together an instance and
i will be diving deeper into each
in this section as well i will be
putting a hands-on approach to this by
creating an instance in the next lesson
and focusing on the different available
features that you can use for your
specific use case and so this is all i
wanted to cover for this lesson so you
can now mark this lesson as complete and
let's move on to the next one
[Music]
welcome back now i know in previous
demonstrations we've built quite a few
compute engine instances and have
configured them accordingly in this
demonstration we're going to go through
a build of another instance but i wanted
to dig deeper into the specific
configurations that are available for
compute engine so with that being said
let's dive in and so i am now logged in
under tony bowties gmail.com as well i
am logged in under the bowtie inc
project so in order to kick off this
demo i'm going to head on over to the
compute engine console so i'm going to
go over to the navigation menu and i'm
going to scroll down to compute engine
and so here i'm prompted
to either create or import a vm instance
as well as taking the quick start and so
i'm not going to import or take the
quick start so i'm going to simply click
on create
and so i want to take a moment here to
focus on the left hand menu where there
are a bunch of different options to
create any given instance so the first
and default option allows me to create
the instance from scratch choosing the
new vm instance from template option
allows me to create a new instance from
an instance template and because i don't
have any instance templates i am
prompted here with the option to create
one and so for those of you who are
unfamiliar with instance templates
templates are used in managed instance
groups and define instance properties
for when instances are launched within
that managed instance group but don't
worry i will be covering instance groups
and instant templates in a later lesson
the next option that's available is new
vm instance from machine image and an
image is a clone or a copy of an
instance and again i will be covering
this in a separate lesson and going
through all the details of machine
images but if i did have any machine
images i would be able to create my
instance from here but since i do not i
am prompted with the option to create a
new machine image now the last option
that i wanted to show you is the
marketplace
and so the marketplace has existing
machine images that are all
pre-configured with its proper operating
system as well as the software to
accompany it so for instance if i'm
looking to create a vm with a wordpress
installation on it i can simply go up to
the top to the search bar type in
wordpress and i will be presented with
many different options and i'm just
going to choose the one here at the top
and i am presented with 49 results of
virtual machines with different types of
wordpress installations on them and
these are all different instances that
have been configured specifically for
wordpress by different companies like
lightspeed analog innovation and
cognosis inc and so for this
demonstration i'm going to choose
wordpress on centos 7
and here i'm giving an overview about
the software itself i'm also given
information about the company that
configured this as well at the top i'm
given a monthly estimated cost for this
specific instance and if i scroll down
the page i can get a little bit more
information with regards to this image
and as shown here on the right i can see
my pricing the usage fee will cost me
109 a month along with the vm instance
type that the software is configured for
the amount of disk space and the
sustained use discount i've also been
given some links here for tutorials and
documentation
and i've also been given instructions
for maintenance and support i've been
given both an email and a link to live
support and of course at the bottom we
have the terms of service and this is a
typical software package amongst many
others that's available in the google
cloud marketplace now i can go ahead and
launch this if i choose but i'm going to
choose not to launch this and i'm going
to back out and so just to give you some
context with regards to enterprise
software
software packages like f5 and jenkins
are also available in the google cloud
marketplace and again when i click on
the first option it'll give me a bunch
of available options on jenkins and its
availability from different companies on
different platforms now just as a note
to update your existing deployment of a
software package
you have to redeploy the software
package from marketplace in order to
update it but other than that caveat the
easiest way to deploy a software package
is definitely through the marketplace
and so now that we've gone through all
the different options on how to create
an instance i'm gonna go back and select
new vm instance so i can create a new vm
from scratch and so i am prompted here
at the top with a note telling me that
there was a draft that was saved from
when i started to create in my new
instance but i navigated away from it
and i have the option to restore the
configuration i was working on and so
just know that when you are in the midst
of creating an instance
google cloud will automatically save a
draft of your build so that you are able
to continue working on it later now i
don't really need this draft but i will
just hit restore
and for the name i'm going to keep it as
instance 1 and for the sake of this demo
i'm going to add a label
the key is going to be environment and
the value will be testing i'm going to
go down to the bottom click save now
when it comes to the geographic location
of the instance using regions i can
simply click on the drop down and i will
have access to deploy this instance in
any currently available region as
regions are added they will be added
here as well and so i'm going to keep it
as us east one
and under zone i have the availability
of putting it in any zone within that
region and so i'm going to keep it as us
east 1b and just as another note once
you've deployed the instance in a
specific region you will not be able to
move that instance to a different region
you will have to recreate it using a
snapshot in another region and i will be
going over this in a later lesson now
scrolling down to machine configuration
there are three different types of
families that you can choose from when
it comes to machine types the general
purpose the compute optimized and the
memory optimized the general purpose
machine family has a great available
selection of different series types that
you can choose from and is usually the
go to machine family if you're unsure
about which machine type to select so
for this demo i'm going to keep my
selection for series type as e2 and
under machine type i'm given a very
large selection of different sizes when
it comes to vcpu and memory and so i can
select from a shared core a standard
type a high memory type or a high cpu
type and i will be going over this in
greater detail in another lesson on
machine types now in case the predefined
machine types do not fit my needs
or the scope for the amount of vcpus and
memory that i need
fall in between those predefined machine
types i can simply select the custom
option and this will bring up a set of
sliders
where i am able to select both the
amount of vcpus and amount of memory
that i need for the instance that i am
creating now as i change the course
slider to either more vcpus or less my
core to memory ratio for this series
will stay the same and therefore my
memory will be adjusted automatically i
also have the option to change the
memory as i see fit to either add more
memory or to remove it and so this is
great for when you're in between sizes
and you're looking for something
specific that fits your workload and so
i'm going to change back the machine
type to an e2 micro
and as you can see in the top right
i will find a monthly estimate of how
much the instance will cost me
and i can click on this drop down and it
will give me a breakdown of the cost for
vcpu in memory the cost for my disks as
well as my sustained use discount and if
i had any other resources that i was
consuming like a static ip or an extra
attached disk those costs would show up
here as well and so if i went to a
compute optimized you can see how the
price has changed but i'm given the
breakdown so that i know exactly what
i'm paying for so i'm going to switch it
back to general purpose
and i wanted to point out here the cpu
platform and gpu as you can add gpus to
your specific machine configuration and
so just as another note
gpus can only be added to an n1 machine
type as any other type will show the gpu
selection as grayed out and so here i
can add the gpu type as well as adding
the number of gpus that i need but for
the sake of this demonstration i'm not
going to add any gpus
and i'm going to select the e2 series
and change it back to e2 micro scrolling
down a little bit here
when it comes to cpu platform depending
on the machine type you can choose
between intel or amd if you are looking
for a specific cpu but just know that
your configuration is permanent now
moving down a little bit more you will
see here display device now display
device is a feature on compute engine
that allows you to add a virtual display
to a vm for system management tools
remote desktop software and any
application that requires you to connect
to a display device on a remote server
this is an especially great feature to
have for when your server is stuck at
boot patching or hardware failure and
you can't log in and the drivers are
already included for both windows and
linux vms this feature works with the
default vga driver right out of the box
and so i'm going to keep this checked
off as i don't need it and i'm going to
move down to confidential vm service now
confidential computing is a security
feature to encrypt sensitive code and
data that's in memory so even when it's
being processed it is still encrypted
and is a great use case when you're
dealing with very sensitive information
that requires strict requirements now
compute engine also gives you the option
of deploying containers on it and this
is a great way to test your containers
instead of deploying a whole kubernetes
cluster and may even suffice for
specific use cases but just note that
you can only deploy one container per vm
instance and so now that we've covered
most of the general configuration
options for compute engine i wanted to
take a minute to dive into the options
that are available for boot disk so i'm
going to go ahead and click on change
and here i have the option of choosing
from a bunch of different public images
with different operating systems that i
can use for my boot disk so if i wanted
to load up ubuntu i can simply select
ubuntu and i can choose from each
different version that's available
as well i'm shown here the boot disk
type which is currently selected as the
standard persistent disk but i also have
the option of selecting either a
balanced persistent disk or ssd
persistent disk and i'm going to keep it
as standard persistent disk and if i
wanted to i can increase the boot disk
size so if i wanted 100 gigs i can
simply add it and if i select it and i
go back up to the top right hand corner
i can see that my price for the instance
has changed now i'm not charged for the
operating system due to it being an open
source image but i am charged more for
the standard persistent disk because i'm
no longer using 10 gigs but i'm using
100 gigabytes
now let's say i wanted to go back and i
wanted to change this image to a windows
image i'm going to go down here to
windows server and i want to select
windows server 2016 i'm going to load up
the data center version and i'm going to
keep the standard persistent disk along
with 100 gigabytes i'm going to select
it if i scroll back up i can see that
i'm charged a licensing fee for windows
server and these images with these
licensing fees are known as premium
images so please make sure that you are
aware of these licensing fees when
launching your instances and because i
want to save on money just for now i'm
going to scroll back down to my boot
disk and change it back to ubuntu
and i'm going to change the size back
down to 10 gigabytes as well before you
move on i wanted to touch on custom
images and so if i did have any custom
images i could see them here and i would
be able to create instances from my
custom images using this method i also
have the option of creating an instance
from a snapshot and because i don't have
any nothing shows up and lastly i have
the option of using existing disks so
let's say for instance i had a vm
instance and i had deleted it but i
decided to keep the attached boot disk
it would show up as unattached and i am
able to attach that to a new instance
and so now that i've shown you all the
available options when it comes to boot
disk i'm going to go ahead and select
the ubuntu operating system and move on
to the next option here we have identity
and api access which we've gone through
in great depth in a previous demo as
well i'm given an option to create a
firewall rule automatically for http and
https traffic and as for networking as
we covered it in great depth in the last
section
i will skip that part of the
configuration and simply launch it in
the default vpc and so just as a quick
note i wanted to remind you that down at
the bottom of the page you can find the
command line shortcut and when you click
on it it will give you the gcloud
command to run that you can use in order
to create your instance and so i want to
deploy this as is so i'm going to click
here on close and i'm going to click on
create
and so i'm just going to give it a
minute now so the instance can be
created and it took a few seconds but
the instance is created and this is
regarded as the inventory page to view
your instance inventory and to look up
any correlating information on any of
your instances and so this probably
looks familiar to you from the previous
instances that you've launched so here
we have the name of the instance the
zone
the internal ip along with the external
ip and a selection to connect to the
instance as well i'm also given the
option to connect to this instance in
different ways you also have the option
of adding more column information to
your inventory dashboard with regards to
your instance
and you can do this by simply clicking
on the columns button right here above
the list of instances and you can select
from creation time
machine type preserve state and even the
network and this may bring you more
insight on the information available for
that instance or even grouping of
instances with common configurations
this will also help you identify your
instances visually in the console and so
i'm just going to put the columns back
to
exactly what it was
and so now i want to take a moment to
dive right into the instance and have a
look at the instance details so as you
remember we selected the machine type of
e2 micro which has two vcpus and one
gigabyte of memory here we have the
instance id as well scrolling down we
have the cpu platform we have the
display device that i was mentioning
earlier along with the zone the labels
the creation time as well as the network
interface and scrolling down i can see
here the boot disk with the ubuntu image
as well as the name of the boot disk so
there are quite a few configurations
here and if i click on edit i can edit
some of these configurations on the fly
and with some configurations i need to
stop the instance before editing them
and there are some configurations like
the network interface where i would have
to delete the instance in order to
recreate it so for instance if i wanted
to change the machine type i need to
stop the instance in order to change it
and the same thing goes for my display
device as well the network interface in
order for me to change it from its
current network or subnetwork i'm going
to have to stop the instance in order to
change it as well and so i hope this
general walkthrough of configuring an
instance has given you a sense of what
can be configured on launch
and allowed you to gain some insight on
editing features of an instance after
launch a lot of what you've seen here in
this demo will come up in the exam and
so i would recommend that before going
into the exam to spend some time
launching instances knowing exactly how
they will behave and what can be edited
after creation that can be done on the
fly edits that need the instance to be
shut down and edits that need the
instance to be recreated and so that's
pretty much all i wanted to cover when
it comes to creating an instance so you
can now mark this as complete and let's
move on to the next one
welcome back now in this lesson i'm
going to be discussing compute engine
machine types now a machine type is a
set of virtualized hardware resources
that's available to a vm instance
including the system memory size
virtual cpu count
and persistent disks in compute engine
machine types are grouped and curated by
families for different workloads you
must always choose a machine type when
you create an instance and you can
select from a number of pre-defined
machine types in each machine type
family if the pre-defined machine types
don't meet your needs then you can
create your own custom machine types in
this lesson i will be going through all
the different machine types their
families and their use cases so with
that being said let's dive in
now each machine type family displayed
here includes different machine types
each family is curated for specific
workload types the following primary
machine types are offered on compute
engine which is general purpose compute
optimized and memory optimized and so i
wanted to go through each one of these
families in a little bit of detail now
before diving right into it
defining what type of machine type you
are running can be overwhelming for some
but can be broken down to be understood
a bit better they are broken down into
three parts and separated by hyphens the
first part in this example shown here
is the series so for this example the
series is e2 and the number after the
letter is the generation type in this
case it would be the second generation
now the series come in many different
varieties and each are designed for
specific workloads now moving on to the
middle part of the machine type this is
the actual type and types as well can
come in a slew of different flavors and
is usually coupled with a specific
series so in this example the type here
is standard and so moving on to the
third part of the machine type this is
the amount of vcp use
in the machine type and so with vcpus
they can be offered anywhere from one
vcpu up to 416 vcpus and so for the
example shown here this machine type has
32 vcpus and so there is one more aspect
of a machine type
which is the gpus
but please note that gpus are only
available for the n1 series and so
combining the series the type and the
vcpu
you will get your machine type and so
now that we've broken down the machine
types in order to properly define them
i wanted to get into the predefined
machine type families
specifically starting off with the
general purpose predefined machine type
and all the general purpose machine
types are available in the standard type
the high memory type and the high cpu
type so the standard type
is the balance of cpu and memory and
this is the most common general purpose
machine type general purpose also comes
in high memory and this is a high memory
to cpu ratio so very high memory a lower
cpu
and lastly we have the high cpu machine
type and this is a high cpu to memory
ratio so this would be the opposite of
the high memory so very high cpu to
lower memory so now digging into the
general purpose machine family i wanted
to start off with the e2 series and this
is designed for day-to-day computing at
a low cost so if you're looking to do
things like web serving
application serving
back office applications
small to medium databases microservices
virtual desktops or even development
environments the e2 series would serve
the purpose perfectly
now the e2 machine types are cost
optimized machine types that offer
sizing between 2 to 32 vcpus and half a
gigabyte to 128 gigabytes of memory so
small to medium workloads that don't
require as many vcpus and applications
that don't require local ssds or gpus
are an ideal fit for e2 machines e2
machine types do not offer sustained use
discounts however they do provide
consistently
low on-demand and committed use pricing
in other words they offer the lowest
on-demand pricing across the general
purpose machine types as well the e2
series machines are available in both
pre-defined and custom machine types
moving on i wanted to touch on all the
machine types available in the n-series
and these are a balanced machine type
with price and performance across a wide
range of vm flavors and these machines
are designed for web servers application
servers back office applications medium
to large databases as well as caching
and media streaming and they are offered
in the standard high memory and high cpu
types
now the n1 machine types are compute
engines first generation general purpose
machine types now this machine type
offers up to 96 vcpus and 624 gigabytes
of memory and again as i mentioned
earlier this is the only machine type
that offers both gpu support and tpu
support the n1 type is available as both
pre-defined machine types and custom
machine types and the n1 series offers a
larger sustained use discount than n2
machine types speaking of which
the n2 machine types are the second
generation general purpose machine types
and these offer flexible sizing between
two 280 vcpus and half a gigabyte of
memory to 640 gigabytes of memory and
these machine types also offer an
overall performance improvement over the
n1 machine types workloads that can take
advantage of the higher clock frequency
of the cpu
are a good choice for n2 machine types
and these workloads can get higher per
thread performance while benefiting from
all the flexibility that a general
purpose machine type offers and two
machine types also offer the extended
memory feature and this helps control
per cpu software licensing costs now
getting into the last n series machine
type the n2d machine type is the largest
general purpose machine type with up to
224 vcpus and
896 gigabytes of memory this machine
type is available in predefined and
custom machine types and this machine
type as well has the extended memory
feature which i discussed earlier that
helps you avoid per cpu software
licensing the n2d machine type supports
the committed use and sustain use
discounts now moving on from the general
purpose machine type family i wanted to
move into the compute optimize machine
family now this series
offers ultra high performance for
compute intensive workloads such as high
performance computing
electronic design automation
gaming and single threaded applications
so anything that is designed for compute
intensive workloads this will definitely
be your best choice
now compute engine optimized machine
types are ideal for as i said earlier
compute intensive workloads and these
machine types offer the highest
performance per core
on compute engine compute optimized
types are only available as predefined
machine types and so they are not
available for any custom machine types
the c2 machine types offer a maximum of
60 vcpus and a maximum of 240 gigabytes
of memory now although the c2 machine
type works great for compute intensive
workloads it does come with some caveats
and so you cannot use regional
persistent disks with compute optimized
machine types and i will be getting into
the details of persistent disks in a
later lesson and they are only available
in select zones and regions on select
cpu platforms and so now moving into the
last family is the memory optimize
machine family and this is for ultra
high memory workloads this family is
designed for large in memory databases
like sap hana as well as in memory
analytics
now the m series comes in two separate
generations
m1 and m2 the m1 offering a maximum of
160 vcpus and a maximum memory of
3844 gigabytes whereas the m2 offering
again a maximum of 160 vcpus but
offering a whopping 11
776 gigabytes of maximum memory and as i
said before these machine types they're
ideal for tasks that require intensive
use of memory so they are suited for
in-memory databases and in memory
analytics data warehousing workloads
genomics analysis and sql analysis
services memory optimized machine types
are only available as predefined machine
types and the caveats here is that you
cannot use regional persistent disks
with memory optimized machine types as
well they're only available in specific
zones now i wanted to take a moment to
go back
to the general purpose machine type so
that i can dig into the shared cord
machine type and this is spread amongst
the e2 and n1 series and these shared
core machine types are used for
burstable workloads are very cost
effective as well they're great for
non-resource intensive applications
shared core machine types use context
switching to share a physical core
between vcpus for the purpose of
multitasking different shared core
machine types sustain different amounts
of time on a physical core which allows
google cloud to cut the price in general
share core instances can be more cost
effective for running small
non-resource intensive applications than
standard high memory or high cpu machine
types now when it comes to cpu bursting
these shared core machine types offer
bursting capabilities that allow
instances to use additional physical cpu
for short periods of time bursting
happens automatically when your instance
requires more physical cpu than
originally allocated during these spikes
your instance will take advantage of
available physical cpu in bursts and the
e2 shared core machine type is offered
in micro small and medium while the n1
series is offered in the f1 micro and
the g1 small and both of these series
have a maximum of two vcpus with a
maximum of four gigabytes of memory now
i wanted to take a moment to touch on
custom machine types and these are
available for any general purpose
machine and so this is customer defined
cpu and memory designed for custom
workloads
now if none of the general purpose
predefined machine types cater to your
needs
you can create a custom machine type
with a specific number of vcpus and
amount of memory that you need for your
instance these machine types are ideal
for workloads that are not a good fit
for the pre-defined machine types that
are available they're also great for
when you need more memory or more cpu
but the predefined machine types don't
quite fit exactly what you need for your
workload just as a note it costs
slightly more to use a custom machine
type than a pre-defined machine type and
there are limitations in the amount of
memory and vcpu you can select and as i
stated earlier when creating a custom
machine type you can choose from the e2
n2
and 2d and n1 machine types and so the
last part i wanted to touch on are the
gpus that are available and these are
designed for the graphic intensive
workloads and again are only available
for the n1 machine type and gpus come in
five different flavors from nvidia
showing here as the tesla k80 the tesla
p4 the tesla t4 the tesla v100 and the
tesla p100 and so these are all the
families and machine types that are
available for you in google cloud and
will allow you to be a little bit more
flexible with the type of workload that
you need them for and so for the exam
you won't have to memorize each machine
type but you will need to know an
overview of what each machine type does
now i know there's been a lot of theory
presented here in this lesson but i hope
this is giving you a better
understanding of all the available
pre-defined machine types in google
cloud and so that's pretty much all i
wanted to cover in this lesson on
compute engine machine types so you can
now mark this lesson as complete and
let's move on to the next one
[Music]
welcome back in this lesson i'm going to
be reviewing managing your instances now
how you manage your instances is a big
topic in the exam
as well it's very useful to know for
your work as a cloud engineer in the
environments you are responsible for
knowing both the features that are
available as well as the best practices
will allow you to make better decisions
with regards to your instances and allow
you to keep your environment healthy
this lesson will dive into the many
features that are available in order to
better manage your instances using the
specific features within google cloud so
with that being said let's dive in
now i wanted to start off this lesson
discussing the life cycle of an instance
within google cloud every instance has a
predefined life cycle from its starting
provisioning state to its deletion an
instance can transition through many
instant states as part of its life cycle
when you first create an instance
compute engine provisions resources to
start your instance next the instance
moves into staging where it prepares the
first boot and then it finally boots up
and is considered running during its
lifetime a running instance can be
repeatedly stopped and restarted or
suspended and resumed so now i wanted to
take a few minutes to go through the
instance life cycle in a bit of detail
starting with the provisioning state
now this is where resources are being
allocated for the instance the instance
is not yet running and the instance is
being allocated its requested amount of
cpu and memory along with its root disk
any additional disks that are attached
to it and as well some additional
feature sets that are assigned to this
instance and when it comes to the cost
while in the provisioning state there
are no costs that are being incurred
moving right along to the staging state
after finishing the provisioning state
the life cycle continues with the
staging state and this is where
resources have been acquired and the
instance is being prepared for first
boot both internal and external ips are
allocated and can be either static or
ephemeral in the system image that was
originally chosen for this instance
is used to boot up the instance and this
can be either a public image or a custom
image costs in the state are still not
incurred as the instance is still in the
pre-boot state
now once the instance has left staging
it will move on to the running state and
this is where the instance is booting up
or running and should allow you to log
into the instance either using ssh or
rdp within a short waiting period due to
any startup scripts or any boot
maintenance tasks for the operating
system now during the running state you
can reset your instance and this is
where you would wipe the memory contents
of the vm instance and reset the virtual
machine to its initial state resetting
an instance
causes an immediate hard reset of the vm
and therefore the vm does not do a
graceful shutdown for the guest
operating system however
the vm retains all persistent disk data
and none of the instance properties
change the instance remains in running
state through the reset now as well in
the running state a repair can happen
due to the instance encountering an
internal error or the underlying machine
is unavailable due to maintenance during
this time the instance is unusable and
if the repair is successful the instance
returns back to the running state paying
attention to costs
this state is where the instance starts
to occur them and is related to the
resources assigned to the instance like
the cpu and memory any static ips and
any disks that are attached to the
instance and i will be going into a bit
of detail in just a bit with regards to
this state
and finally we end the life cycle with
the stopping suspended and terminated
states now when you are suspending an
instance it is like closing the lid of
your laptop suspending the instance will
preserve the guest operating system
memory and application state of the
instance otherwise it'll be discarded
and from this state you can choose
either to resume or to delete it when it
comes to stopping either a user has made
a request to stop the instance or there
was a failure and this is a temporary
status and the instance will move to
terminated touching on costs for just a
second when suspending or stopping an
instance you pay for resources that are
still attached to the vm instance
such as static ips and persistent disk
data you do not pay the cost of a
running vm instance ephemeral external
ip addresses are released from the
instance and will be assigned a new one
when the instance is started now when it
comes to stopping suspending or
resetting an instance you can stop or
suspend an instance if you no longer
need it but want to keep the instance
around for future use compute engine
waits for the guest to finish shutting
down and then transitions the instance
to the terminated state so touching on
the terminated state this is where a
user either shuts down the instance or
the instance encounters a failure you
can choose to restart the instance or
delete it as well as holding some reset
options within the availability policy
in this state you still pay for static
ips and disks
but like the suspending or stopping
state you do not pay for the cpu and
memory resources allocated to the
instance
and so this covers a high level overview
of the instance lifecycle in google
cloud and all of the states that make up
this lifecycle now to get into some
detail with regards to some feature sets
for compute engine i wanted to revisit
the states where those features apply
now when creating your instance you have
the option of using shielded vms for
added security and when using them the
instance would instantiate them as the
instance boots and enters into the
running state
so what exactly is a shielded vm
well shielded vms offer verifiable
integrity of your compute engine vm
instances so you can be sure that your
instances haven't been compromised by
boot or kernel level malware or rootkits
and this is achieved through a four-step
process
which is covered by secure boot virtual
trusted platform module also known as
vtpm measure boot which is running on
vtpm and integrity monitoring so i
wanted to dig into this for just a sec
to give you a bit more context
now the boot process for shielded vms
start with secure boot and this helps
ensure that the system only runs
authentic software by verifying the
digital signature for all boot
components and stopping the boot process
if signature verification fails so
shielded vm instances run firmware
that's signed and verified using
google's certificate authority and on
each and every boot any boot component
that isn't properly signed or isn't
signed at all is not allowed to run and
so the first time you boot a vm instance
measure boot creates the integrity
policy baseline from the first set of
these measurements and then securely
stores this data each time the vm
instance boots after that these
measurements are taken again and stored
in secure memory until the next reboot
having these two sets of measurements
enables integrity monitoring which is
the next step and allows it to determine
if there have been changes to a vm
instance's boot sequence and this policy
is loaded onto a virtualized trusted
platform module again known as the vtpm
for short which is a specialized
computer chip that you can use to
protect objects like keys and
certificates that you use to
authenticate access to your system with
shielded vms vtpm enables measured boot
by performing the measurements needed to
create a known good boot baseline and
this is called the integrity policy
baseline the integrity policy baseline
is used for comparison
with measurements from subsequent vm
boots to determine if anything has
changed integrity monitoring relies on
the measurements created by measured
boot for both the integrity policy
baseline and the most recent boot
sequence integrity monitoring compares
the most recent boot measurements
to the integrity policy baseline and
returns a pair of pass or failed results
depending on whether they match or not
one for the early boot sequence and one
for the late boot sequence and so in
summary this is how shielded vms help
prevent data exfiltration so touching
now on the running state when you start
a vm instance using google provided
public images a guest environment is
automatically installed on the vm
instance a guest environment is a set of
scripts daemons and binaries that read
the content of the metadata server to
make a virtual machine run properly on
compute engine a metadata server is a
communication channel for transferring
information from a client to the guest
operating system vm instances created
using google provided public images
include a guest environment that is
installed by default creating vm
instances
using a custom image will require you to
manually install the guest environment
this guest environment is available for
both linux and windows systems and each
supported operating system that is
available on compute engine requires
specific guest environment packages
either google or the owner of the
operating system builds these packages
now when it comes to the linux guest
environment it is either built by google
or the owner of the operating system
and there are some key components that
are applicable to all builds which can
be found in the link that i have
included in the lesson text the base
components of a linux guest environment
is a python package that contains
scripts daemons and packages for the
supported linux distributions when it
comes to windows a similar approach
applies where a package is available
with main scripts and binaries as a part
of this guest environment
now touching back on the metadata server
compute engine provides a method for
storing and retrieving metadata in the
form of the metadata server this service
provides a central point to set metadata
in the form of key value pairs which is
then provided to virtual machines at
runtime and you can query this metadata
server programmatically from within the
instance and from the compute engine api
this is great for use with startup and
shutdown scripts or gaining more insight
with your instance metadata can be
assigned to projects as well as
instances and project metadata
propagates to all instances within the
project while instance metadata only
impacts that instance and you can access
the metadata using the following url
with the curl command you see here on
the screen so if you're looking for the
metadata for a project you would use the
first url that ends in project and for
any instance metadata you can use the
second url that ends in instance now
please note that when you make a request
to get information from the metadata
server your request and the subsequent
metadata response never leaves the
physical host running the virtual
machine instance now once the instance
has booted and has gone through the
startup scripts you will then have the
ability to login to your instance using
ssh or rdp now there are some different
methods that you can use to connect and
access both your linux instances and
your windows instances that i will be
going over
now when it comes to linux instances
we've already gone through accessing
these types of instances in previous
lessons and demos but just as a
refresher you would typically connect to
your vm instance via ssh access on port
22. please note that you will require a
firewall rule as we have done in
previous demos to allow this access and
you can connect to your linux instances
through the google cloud console or the
cloud shell using the cloud sdk now i
know that the use of ssh keys are the
defacto when it comes to logging into
linux instances now in most scenarios on
google cloud google recommends using os
login over using ssh keys the os login
feature lets you use compute engine iam
roles to manage ssh access to linux
instances and then if you'd like you can
add an extra layer of security by
setting up os login with two-step
verification and manage access at the
organization level by setting up
organizational policies os login
simplifies ssh access management by
linking your linux user account to your
google identity administrators can
easily manage access to instances
at either an instance or project level
by setting iam permissions now if you're
running your own directory service for
managing access or are unable to set up
os login you can manually manage ssh
keys and local user accounts in metadata
by manually creating ssh keys and
editing the public ssh key metadata now
when it comes to windows instances you
would typically connect to your vm
instance via rdp access on port 3389 and
please note that you will also require a
firewall rule as shown here to allow
this access you can connect to your
windows instances through the rdp
protocol or through a powershell
terminal now when logging into windows
this requires setting a windows password
and can be done either through the
console or the gcloud command line tool
and then after setting your password you
can then log in from the recommended rdp
chrome extension or using a third-party
rdp client and i will provide a link to
this rdp chrome extension in the lesson
text now once the instance has booted up
and your instance is ready to be logged
into you always have the option of
modifying your instance and you can do
it manually by either modifying it on
the fly or you can take the necessary
steps to edit your instance like i
showed you in a previous lesson by
stopping it editing it and then
restarting it although when it comes to
google having to do maintenance on a vm
or you merely want to move your instance
to a different zone in the same region
this has all become possible without
shutting down your instance
using a feature called live migration
now when it comes to live migration
compute engine migrates your running
instances to another host
in the same zone instead of requiring
your vms to be rebooted this allows
google to perform maintenance reliably
without interrupting any of your vms
when a vm is scheduled to be live
migrated google provides a notification
to the guest that a migration is coming
soon live migration keeps your instances
running during compute engine hosts that
are in need of regular infrastructure
maintenance and upgrades replacement of
failed hardware and system configuration
changes when google migrates a running
vm instance from one host to another
it moves the complete instance state
from the source to the destination in a
way that is transparent to the guest os
and anyone communicating with it google
also gives you the option of doing live
migration manually from one zone to
another within the same region either
using the console or running the command
line you see here gcloud compute
instances move the name of the vm with
the zone flag and the zone that it's
currently in and then the destination
zone flag with the zone that you wanted
to go to and just as a note with some
caveats instances with gpus attached
cannot be live migrated and you can't
configure a preemptable instance to live
migrate and so instance lifecycle is
full of different options and
understanding them can help better
coordinate moving editing and repairing
vm instances no matter where they may
lie in this life cycle now i hope this
lesson has given you the necessary
theory that will help better use the
discuss feature sets and giving you some
ideas on how to better manage your
instances now there is a lot more to
know than what i've shown you here to
manage your instances but topics shown
here are what shows up in the exam as
well are some really great starting
points to begin managing your instances
and so that's pretty much all i wanted
to cover when it comes to managing
instances so you can now mark this
lesson as complete and join me in the
next one where i will cement the theory
in this lesson with the hands-on demo
[Music]
welcome back in this demonstration i'm
going to be cementing some of the theory
that we learned in the last lesson with
regards to the different login methods
for windows and linux instances how to
implement these methods are extremely
useful to know both for the exam and for
managing multiple instances in different
environments now there's a lot to cover
here so with that being said let's dive
in so as you can see i am logged in here
under tony bowtie ace
gmail.com as well i am in the project of
bowtie inc and so the first thing that i
want to do is create both a linux
instance and a windows instance and this
is to demonstrate the different options
you have for logging into an instance
and so in order for me to do that i need
to head on over to compute engine so i'm
going to go over to the navigation menu
and i'm going to scroll down to compute
engine and so just as a note before
creating your instances please make sure
that you have a default vpc created
before going ahead and creating these
instances if you've forgotten how to
create a default vpc please go back to
the networking services section and
watch the vpc lesson for a refresher and
so i'm going to go ahead and create my
first instance and i'm going to start
with the windows instance so i'm going
to simply click on create
and so for the name of this instance you
can simply call this windows dash
instance
and i'm not going to add any labels and
for the region you should select us
east1 and you can keep the zone as the
default for us east 1b and scrolling
down to the machine configuration for
the machine type i'm going to keep it as
is as it is a windows instance and i'm
going to need a little bit more power
scrolling down to boot disk we need to
change this from debian over to windows
so i'm going to simply click on the
change button and under operating system
i'm going to click on the drop down and
select windows server for the version
i'm going to select the latest version
of windows server which is the windows
server 2019 data center and you can keep
the boot disk type and the size as its
default and simply head on down and
click on select and we're going to leave
everything else as the default and
simply click on create
and success our windows instance has
been created and so the first thing that
you want to do is you want to set a
windows password for this instance and
so i'm going to head on over to the rdp
button and i'm going to click on the
drop-down and here i'm going to select
set windows password and here i'm going
to get a pop-up to set a new windows
password the username has been
propagated for me as tony bowties i'm
going to leave it as is and i'm going to
click on set
and i'm going to be prompted with a new
windows password that has been set for
me so i'm going to copy this and i'm
going to paste it into my notepad so be
sure to record it somewhere either write
it down
or copy and paste it into a text editor
of your choice i'm going to click on
close and so now for me to log into this
i need to make sure of a couple things
the first thing is i need to make sure
that i have a firewall rule open for
port 3389 the second is i need to make
sure that i have an rdp client and so in
order to satisfy my first constraint i'm
going to head on over to the navigation
menu and go down to vpc network
here i'm going to select firewall and as
expected the rdp firewall rule has been
already created due to the fact that
upon creation of the default vpc network
this default firewall rule is always
created and so now that i've gotten that
out of the way i'm going to head back on
over to compute engine
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
record the external ip so that i'll be
able to log into it now i'm going to be
logging into this instance
from both a windows client and a mac
client so starting with windows i'm
going to head on over to my windows
virtual machine and because i know
windows has a default rdp client already
built in i'm going to simply bring it up
by hitting the windows key and typing
remote desktop connection
i'm going to click on that i'm going to
paste in the public ip for the instance
that i just recorded and i'm going to
click on connect you should get a pop-up
asking for your credentials i'm going to
type in my username as tony bowtie ace
as well i'm going to paste in the
password and i'm going to click on ok
i'm prompted to accept the security
certificate and i'm going to select yes
and success
i'm now connected to my windows server
instance and it's going to run all its
necessary startup scripts you may get a
couple of prompts that come up
asking you if you want to connect to
your network
absolutely i'm going to close down
server manager just for now
and another thing that i wanted to note
is that when you create a windows
instance there will automatically be
provisioned a google cloud shell with
the sdk pre-installed and so you'll be
able to run all your regular commands
right from this shell without having to
install it and this is due to the guest
environment that was automatically
installed on the vm instance upon
creation and this is a perfect example
of some of the scripts that are
installed with the guest environment i'm
going to go ahead and close out of this
and i'm going to go ahead and close out
of my instance
hit ok and so being here in windows i
wanted to show you an alternate way of
logging into your instance through
powershell so for those of you who are
quite versed in windows and use
powershell in your day-to-day there is
an easy way to log into your instance
using powershell now in order for me to
do that i need to open another firewall
rule covering tcp port 5986 so i'm going
to head on over back to the google cloud
console i'm going to head over to the
navigation menu and i'm going to scroll
down to vpc network
i'm going to go into firewall and i'm
going to create a new firewall rule and
under name i'm going to name this as
allow
powershell i'm going to use the same for
the description i'm going to scroll down
to targets and i'm going to select all
instances in the network and under
source ip ranges for this demonstration
i'm going to use
0.0.0.0 forward slash 0. and again this
should not be used in a production
environment but is used merely for this
demo i'm going to leave everything else
as is and i'm going to go down to
protocols and ports i'm going to click
on tcp and i'm going to type in 5986 for
the port and i'm going to click on
create i'm going to give it a second
just to create and it took a couple
seconds but our firewall rule is now
created and so now i'm gonna head over
to my windows vm and i'm gonna open up a
powershell command prompt and hit the
windows key and type in powershell
and so in order for me to not get
constantly asked about my username and
password i'm going to use a variable
that will keep my password for me and so
every time i connect to my windows
instance i won't need to type it in all
the time and so the command for that is
dollar sign credentials equals get dash
credential i'm going to hit enter and
i'm going to get a prompt to type in my
username and password so i'm going to
simply type that in now along with my
password and hit ok and if you don't get
a prompt with any errors then chances
are that you've been successful at
entering your credentials and so now in
order to connect to the instance you're
going to need the public ip address
again so i'm going to head on over back
to the console i'm going to head on over
to the navigation menu and back to
compute engine here i'm going to record
the external ip and i'm going to head on
over back to my windows virtual machine
and so you're going to enter this
command which i will include in the
lesson text and you'll also be able to
find it in the github repository beside
computer name you're going to put in
your public ip address of your windows
instance and make sure at the end you
have your credentials variable i'm going
to simply click enter and success i'm
now connected to my windows instance in
google cloud so as you can see here on
the left
is the public ip of my windows instance
and so these are the various ways that
you can connect to your windows instance
from a windows machine and so now for me
to connect to my windows instance on a
mac i'm going to head on over there now
and like i said before i need to satisfy
the constraint of having an rdp client
unfortunately mac does not come with an
rdp client and so the recommended tool
to use is the chrome extension but i
personally like microsoft's rdp for mac
application and so i'm going to go ahead
and do a walkthrough of the installation
so i'm going to start off by opening up
safari and i'm going to paste in this
url which i will include in the lesson
text
and microsoft has made available a
microsoft remote desktop app available
in the app store i'm going to go ahead
and view it in the app store and i'm
going to simply click on get and then
install and once you've entered your
credentials and you've downloaded and
installed it you can simply click on
open i'm going to click on not now and
continue and i'm going to close all
these other windows for better viewing
i'm going to click on add pc i'm going
to paste in the public ip address of my
windows instance and under user account
i'm going to add my user account type in
my username paste in my password you can
add a friendly name here i'm going to
type in windows dash gc for google cloud
and i'm going to click on add and then
once you've pasted in all the
credentials and your information you can
then click on add and i should be able
to connect to my windows instance by
double clicking on this window it's
asking me for my certificates i'm going
to hit continue
and success i'm connected to my windows
instance and so this is how you would
connect to a windows instance from a
windows machine as well as from a mac as
well there are a couple of other options
that i wanted to show you over here on
the drop down beside rdp i can download
an rdp file which will contain the
public ip address of the windows
instance along with your username if i
need to reset my password i can view the
gcloud command to do it or i can set a
new windows password if i forgotten my
old one and so that's everything i had
to show you with regards to connecting
to a windows instance and so since this
demo was getting kind of long i decided
to split it up into two parts
and so this is the end of part one of
this demo and this would be a great
opportunity to get up and have a stretch
grab yourself a tea or a coffee and
whenever you're ready you can join me in
part two where we will be starting
immediately from the end of part 1 so
you can complete this video and i'll see
you in part 2.
[Music]
welcome back this is part 2 of the
connecting to your instances demo and we
will be starting exactly where we left
off in part one so with that being said
let's dive in and so now that we've
created our windows instance and went
through all the methods of how to
connect to it let's go ahead and create
a linux instance i'm going to go up to
the top menu here and click on create
instance and i'm going to name this
instance
linux instance i'm not going to give it
any labels under region i'm going to
select the us east one region and the
zone i'm going to leave it as its set
default as us east 1b the machine
configuration i'm going to leave it as
is under boot disk i'm going to leave
this as is with the debian distribution
and i'm going to go ahead and click on
create
okay and our linux instance has been
created and in order for me to connect
to it
i am going to ssh into it but first i
need to satisfy the constraint of having
a firewall rule with tcp port 22 open so
i'm going to head on over to the
navigation menu
and i'm going to scroll down to vpc
network i'm going to head on over to
firewall and as expected the allow ssh
firewall rule has been created alongside
the default vpc network and so since
i've satisfied that constraint i can
head back on over to compute engine and
so here i have a few different options
that i can select from for logging into
my linux instance i can open in a
browser window if i decided i wanted to
put it on a custom port i can use this
option here if i provided a private ssh
key to connect to this linux instance i
can use this option here i have the
option of viewing the gcloud command in
order to connect to it
and i've been presented with a pop-up
with the command to use within the
gcloud command line in order to connect
to my instance i can run it now in cloud
shell but i'm going to simply close it
and so whether you are on a mac a
windows machine or a linux machine you
can simply click on ssh and it will open
a new browser window connecting you to
your instance
now when you connect to your linux
instance for the first time
compute engine generates an ssh key pair
for you this key pair by default is
added to your project or instance
metadata and this will give you the
freedom of not having to worry about
managing keys now if your account is
configured to use os login compute
engine stores the generated key pair
with your user account
now when connecting to your linux
instance in most scenarios google
recommends using os login this feature
lets you use iam roles to manage ssh
access to linux instances and this
relieves the complexity of having to
manage multiple key pairs and is the
recommended way to manage many users
across multiple instances or projects
and so i'm going to go ahead now and
show you how to configure os login for
your linux instance and the way to do
this will be very similar on all
platforms so i'm going to go ahead and
go back to my mac vm and i'm going to
open up my terminal
make this bigger for better viewing
and i'm going to start by running the
gcloud init command in order to make
sure i'm using the right user and for
the sake of this demonstration i'm going
to re-initialize this configuration so
i'm going to click on one hit enter
number two for tony bowtie ace and i'm
going to use project bow tie ink so 1
and i'm not going to configure a default
compute region in zone and so if i run
the gcloud config list command i can see
that the account that i'm using is tony
bowties gmail.com in project bowtie inc
and so because os login requires a key
pair i'm going to have to generate that
myself so i'm going to go ahead and
clear the screen and i'm going to use
the command ssh keygen and this is the
command to create a public and private
key pair i'm going to use the default
path to save my key and i'm going to
enter a passphrase
i'm going to enter it again and i
recommend that you write down your
passphrase so that you don't forget it
as when you lose it you will be unable
to use your key pair and so if i change
directory to dot ssh and do an ls for
list i can see that i now have my public
and private key pair the private key
lying in id underscore rsa and the
public key lying in id underscore
rsa.pub and so another constraint that i
have is i need to enable os login for my
linux instance so i'm going to go ahead
and go back to the console and i'm going
to go ahead and go into my linux
instance
i'm going to click on edit and if you
scroll down you will come to some fields
marked as custom metadata and under key
you will type in enable dash os login
and under value you will type in all
caps true now i wanted to take a moment
here to discuss this feature here under
ssh keys for block project wide ssh keys
now project wide public ssh keys are
meant to give users access to all of the
linux instances in a project that allow
project project-wide public ssh keys so
if an instance blocks project-wide
public ssh keys as you see here
a user can't use their project-wide
public ssh key to connect to the
instance
unless the same public ssh key is also
added to the instance metadata this
allows only users whose public ssh key
is stored in instance level metadata to
access the instance
and so this is an important feature to
note for the exam and so we're going to
leave this feature checked off for now
and then you can go to the bottom and
click on save now if i wanted to enable
os login for all instances in my project
i can simply go over to the menu on the
left and click on metadata and add the
metadata here with the same values so
under key i type in enable dash os login
and under value i type in in all caps
true but i don't want to enable it for
all my instances
only for that one specific instance so
with regards to project-wide public keys
these keys can be managed through
metadata and should only be used as a
last resort if you cannot use the other
tools such as ssh from the console or os
login these are where the keys are
stored and so you can always find them
here when looking for them here as you
can see there are a couple of keys for
tony bowtie ace that i have used for
previous instances and so i'm going to
go back to metadata just to make sure
that my key value pair for os login has
not been saved and it is not and i'm
going to head back on over to my
instances and so now that my constraint
has been fulfilled where i've enabled
the os login feature by adding the
unnecessary metadata i'm going to head
on over back to my mac vm
i'm going to go ahead and clear the
screen so now i'm going to go ahead and
log into my instance using os login by
using the command gcloud compute os dash
login ssh dash keys add and then the
flag key dash file and then the path for
my public key which is dot ssh forward
slash id underscore rsa.pub i'm gonna
hit enter
and so my key has been successfully
stored with my user account i'm gonna go
ahead and make this a little bigger for
better viewing and so in order to log
into my instance i'm going to need my
username which is right up here under
username i'm going to copy that and i'm
just going to clear my screen for a
second here for better viewing and so in
order for me to ssh into my instance i'm
going to type in the command ssh minus i
i'm going to have to provide my private
key which is in dot ssh forward slash id
underscore rsa and then my username that
i had recorded earlier at and then i'm
going to need my public ip address of my
linux instance so i'm going to head back
over to the console for just a sec
i'm going to copy the ip address head
back over to my mac vm paste it in and
hit enter it's asking if i want to
continue yes i do
enter the passphrase for my key
and success i am connected and so there
is one caveat that i wanted to show you
with regards to permissions for os login
so i'm going to head back over to the
console and i'm going to go up to the
navigation menu and head over to i am an
admin now as you can see here tony
bowties gmail.com has the role of owner
and therefore i don't need any granular
specific permissions i have the access
to do absolutely anything now in case i
was a different user and i didn't hold
the role of owner i would be looking for
specific permissions
that would be under compute
os login and this would give me
permissions as a standard user now if i
wanted super user access or root access
i would need to be given the compute os
admin login role and as you can see it
would allow me administrator user
privileges so when using os login and
the member is not an owner one of these
two roles are needed so i'm going to
exit out of here i'm going to hit cancel
and so that about covers everything that
i wanted to show you with regards to all
the different methods that you can use
for connecting to vm instances for both
windows and linux instances now i know
this may have been a refresher for some
but for others
knowing all the different methods of
connecting to instances can come in very
useful especially when coordinating many
instances in bigger environments i want
to congratulate you on making it to the
end of this demo and gaining a bit more
knowledge on this crucial part of
managing your instances so before you go
be sure to delete any resources that
you've created and again congrats on the
great job so you can now mark this as
complete and i'll see you in the next
one
welcome back in this demonstration i'll
be discussing metadata and how it can
pertain to a project as well as an
instance as well i'm going to touch on
startup and shutdown scripts and it's
real world use cases in the last lesson
we touched the tip of the iceberg when
it came to metadata and wanted to go a
bit deeper on this topic as i personally
feel that it holds so much value
and give you some ideas on how you can
use it i'm also going to combine the
metadata using variables in a startup
script and i'm going to bring to life
something that's dynamic in nature so
with that being said let's dive in so i
am currently logged in as tony at bowtie
ace gmail.com
under the project of bow tie inc and so
in order to get right into the metadata
i'm going to head on over to my
navigation menu and go straight to
compute engine and over here on the left
hand menu you will see metadata and you
can drill down into there now as i
explained in a previous lesson
metadata can be assigned to both
projects and instances while instance
metadata
only impacts a specific instance so here
i can add and store metadata which will
be used on a project-wide basis as well
as mentioned earlier metadata is stored
in key value pairs and can be added at
any time now this is a way to add custom
metadata but there is a default set of
metadata entries that every instance has
access to and again this applies for
both project and instance metadata so
here i have the option of setting my
custom metadata for the entire project
and so i'm going to dive into where to
store custom metadata on an instance and
so in order for me to show you this i'm
going to first head over to vm instances
and create my instance and so just as a
note before creating your instance make
sure that you have the default vpc
created and so because i like to double
check things i'm going to head over to
the navigation menu i'm going to scroll
down to vpc network and as expected i
have the default vpc already created and
so this means i can go ahead and create
my instance so i'm going to head back on
over to compute engine
and i'm going to create my instance and
i'm going to name this instance
bowtie dash web server i'm not going to
add any labels and under the region i'm
going to select us east one and you can
keep the zone as the default as us east
1b under machine type i want to keep
things cost effective so i'm going to
select the e2 micro i'm going to scroll
down and under identity and api access i
want to set access for each api
and scroll down to compute engine i want
to select it and i want to select on
read write and i'm going to leave the
rest as is and scrolling down to the
bottom i want to click on management
security disks networking and sold
tenancy
and under here you will find the option
to add any custom metadata and you can
provide it right here under metadata as
a key value pair but we're not going to
add any metadata right now so i'm just
going to scroll down to the bottom i'm
going to leave everything else as is and
simply click on create
and it should take a few moments for my
instance to be created okay and now that
my instance is up i want to go ahead and
start querying the metadata now just as
a note metadata must be queried from the
instance itself and can't be done from
another instance or even from the cloud
sdk on your computer so i'm going to go
ahead and log into the instance using
ssh
okay and now that i'm logged into my
instance i want to start querying the
metadata now normally you would use
tools like wget or curl to make these
queries
in this demo i will use curl and for
those who don't know curl is a command
line tool to transfer data to or from a
server using supported protocols like
http ftp scp and many more this tool is
fantastic for automation since it's
designed to work without any user
interaction and so i'm going to paste in
the url that i am going to use to query
the instance metadata and this is the
default url that you would use to query
any metadata on any instance getting a
little deeper into it a trailing slash
shown here shows that the instance value
is actually a directory and will have
other values that append to this url
whether they are other directories or
just endpoint values now when you query
for metadata you must provide the
following header in all of your requests
metadata dash flavor colon google and
should be put in quotations if you don't
provide this header the metadata server
will deny your request so i'm going to
go ahead and hit enter and as you can
see i've been brought up a lot of
different values that i can choose from
in order to retrieve different types of
metadata and as stated before anything
with a trailing slash is actually a
directory and will have other values
underneath it so if i wanted to query
the network interfaces
and because it's a directory i need to
make sure that i add the trailing slash
at the end and as you can see here i
have the network interface of 0 and i'm
going to go ahead and query that
and here i will have access to all the
information about the network interface
on this instance so i'm going to go
ahead and query the network on this
interface and as expected the default
network is displayed i'm going to
quickly go ahead and clear my screen and
i'm going to go ahead and query some
more metadata this time i'm going to do
the name of the server and as expected
bowtie dash web server showed up and
because it's an endpoint i don't need
the trailing slash at the end i'm going
to go ahead and do one more this time
i'm going to choose machine type
and again as expected the e2 micro
machine type is displayed and so just as
a note for those who haven't noticed any
time that you query metadata it will
show up to the left of your command
prompt now what i've shown you here is
what you can do with instance metadata
and so how about if you wanted to query
any project metadata well instead of
instance at the end you would use
project with the trailing slash i'm
going to simply click on enter and as
you can see here project doesn't give me
a whole lot of options but it does give
me some important values like project id
so i'm going to simply query that right
now and as expected bowtie inc is
displayed and so this is a great example
of how to query any default metadata for
instances and for projects now you're
probably wondering how do i query my
custom metadata well once custom
metadata has been set you can then query
it from the attributes directory in the
attributes directory can be found in
both the instance and project metadata
so i'm going to go ahead and show you
that now but first i wanted to add some
custom metadata and this can be set in
either the console the gcloud command
line tool or using the api and so i'm
going to run the command here gcloud
compute instances add dash metadata the
name of your instance and when you're
adding custom metadata you would add the
flag dash dash metadata with the key
value pair which in this example is
environment equals dev and then i'm also
going to add the zone of the instance
which is us east 1a and i'm going to hit
enter
and because i had a typo there i'm going
to go ahead and try that again using us
east 1b
i'm going to hit on enter
and success and so to verify that this
command has worked
i'm going to go ahead and query the
instance and i'm going to go under
attributes
i'm going to hit on enter and as you can
see here the environment endpoint has
been populated so i'm going to query
that and as expected dev is displaying
as the environment value now if i wanted
to double check that in the console i
can go over to the console i can drill
down into bowtie web server
and if i scroll down to the bottom under
custom metadata you can see the key
value pair here has m as the key and dev
being the value and so these are the
many different ways that you can query
metadata for any instances or projects
now i wanted to take a quick moment to
switch gears and talk about startup and
shutdown scripts now compute engine lets
you create and run your own startup and
shutdown scripts on your vm instance and
this allows you to perform automation
that can perform actions when starting
up such as installing software
performing updates or any other tasks
that are defined in the script and when
shutting down you can allow instances
time to clean up on perform tasks such
as exporting logs to cloud storage or
bigquery or syncing with other systems
and so i wanted to go ahead and show you
how this would work while combining
metadata into the script so i'm going to
go ahead and drill down into bow tie web
server
i'm going to click on edit and i'm going
to scroll down here
to custom metadata i'm going to click on
add item and under key i'm going to type
in
startup dash script and under value i'm
going to paste in my script i'm going to
just enlarge this here for a second and
i will be providing the script in the
github repository now just to break it
down this is a bash script i'm pulling
in a variable called name which will
query the instance name as well i have a
variable called zone which will query
the instance zone i'm going to be
installing an apache web server and it's
going to display on a web browser both
the server name and the zone that it's
in and so in order for me to see this
web page i also need to open up some
firewall rules and so an easy way to do
this would be to scroll up to firewalls
and simply click on allow http and allow
https traffic this will tag the instance
with some network tags as http server
and https server and create two separate
firewall rules that will allow traffic
for port 80 and port 443 so i'm going to
leave everything else as is i'm going to
scroll down to the bottom and click on
save okay and it took a few seconds
there but it did finish saving i'm going
to go ahead and go up to the top and
click on reset and this will perform a
hard reset on the instance and will
allow the startup script to take effect
so i'm going to click on reset it's
going to ask me if i really want to do
this and for the purposes of this
demonstration i'm going to click on
reset please note you should never do
this in production as it doesn't do a
clean shutdown on the operating system
but as this is an instance with nothing
on it i'm going to simply click on reset
now i'm going to head on back to the
main console for my vm instances and i'm
going to record my external ip i'm going
to open up a new browser i'm going to
zoom in for better viewing and i'm going
to paste in my ip address and hit enter
and as you can see here
i've used my startup script to display
not only this web page but i was able to
bring in metadata that i pulled using
variables and was able to display it
here in the browser and so before i end
this demonstration i wanted to show you
another way of using a startup script
but being able to pull it in from cloud
storage so i'm going to go back to the
navigation menu and i'm going to scroll
down to storage
here i will create a new bucket
and for now find a globally unique name
to name your bucket and i'm going to
call my bucket bowtie web server site
and i'm going to leave the rest as its
default and i'm going to simply click on
create
and if you have a globally unique name
for your bucket you will be prompted
with this page without any errors and
i'm going to go ahead and upload the
script
and you can find this script in the
github repository so i'm going to go
into my repo and i'm going to look for
bow tie start up final sh i'm going to
open it
and now that i have the script uploaded
i'm going to drill into this file so i
can get some more information that i
need for the instance and what i need
from here is to copy the uri so i'm
going to copy this to my clipboard and
i'm going to head back on over to
compute engine i'm going to drill down
into my instance
i'm going to click on edit at the top
and i'm going to scroll down to where it
says custom metadata and here i'm going
to remove the startup script metadata
and i'm going to add a new item and i'm
going to be adding startup dash script
dash url and in the value i'm going to
paste in the uri that i had just copied
over and this way on startup my instance
will use this startup script that's in
cloud storage so i'm going to scroll
down to the bottom click on save
and now i'm going to click on reset i'm
going to reset here i'm going to go back
to the main page for my vm instances and
i can see that my external ip hasn't
changed so i'm going to go back to my
open web browser and i'm going to click
on refresh and success and as you can
see here i've taken a whole bunch of
different variables including the
machine name
the environment variable the zone as
well as the project and i've displayed
it here in a simple website and although
you may not find this website
specifically useful in your production
environment this is just an idea to get
creative using default and custom
metadata along with a startup script
i've seen in some environments where
people have multiple web servers and
create a web page to display all the
specific web servers in their different
environments along with their ips their
data and their configurations and so
just as a recap we've gone through the
default and custom metadata and how to
query it in an instance we also went
through startup scripts and how to apply
them both locally and using cloud
storage and so i hope you have enjoyed
having fun with metadata and using them
in startup scripts such as this one i
also hope you find some fascinating use
cases in your current environments and
so before you go just a quick reminder
to delete any resources that you've
created to not incur any added costs and
so that's pretty much all i wanted to
cover with this demonstration so you can
now mark this as complete and let's move
on to the next one
[Music]
welcome back and in this lesson i'm
going to be discussing compute engine
billing now when it comes to pricing
with regards to compute engine i've only
gone over the fact that instances are
charged by the second after the first
minute but i never got into the depths
of billing and the various ways to save
money when using compute engine in this
lesson i will be unveiling how both
costs and discounts are broken down in
google cloud as it refers to the
resource based billing model and the
various savings that can be had when
using compute engine so with that being
said let's dive in
now each vcpu and each gigabyte of
memory on compute engine is built
separately rather than as part of a
single machine type you are still
creating instances using pre-defined
machine types but your bill shows them
as individual cpus and memory used per
hour and this is what google refers to
as resource-based billing which i will
get into in just a bit the billing model
applies to all vcpus gpus and memory
resources and are charged a minimum of
one minute for example if you run your
virtual machine for 30 seconds you will
be billed for one minute of usage after
one minute instances are charged in one
second increments instance up time is
another determining factor for cost and
is measured as the number of seconds
between when you start an instance and
when you stop an instance in other words
when your instance is in the terminated
state if an instance is idle but still
has a state of running it will be
charged for instance uptime but again
you will not be charged if your instance
is in a terminated state
now getting into reservations these are
designed to reserve the vm instances you
need so after you create a reservation
the reservation ensures that those
resources are always available for you
to use during the creation process you
can choose how a reservation is to be
used for example you can choose for a
reservation to be automatically applied
to any new or existing instances that
match the reservation's properties which
is the default behavior or you can
specify that reservation to be consumed
by a specific instance in all cases a vm
instance can only use a reservation if
its properties exactly match the
properties of the reservation after you
create a reservation you begin paying
for the reserved resources immediately
and they remain available for your
project to use indefinitely until the
reservation is deleted reservations are
great to ensure that your project has
resources for future increases in demand
including planned or unplanned spikes
backup and disaster recovery or for a
buffer when you're planning growth when
you no longer need a reservation you can
simply delete the reservation to stop
incurring charges each reservation like
normal vms are charged based on existing
on-demand rates which include sustained
use discounts and are eligible for
committed use discounts which i will be
getting into in just a bit now
purchasing reservations do come with
some caveats
reservations apply only to compute
engine data proc
and google kubernetes engine as well
reservations don't apply to shared core
machine types preemptable vms sole
tenant nodes
cloud sql and data flow now as i
explained before each vcpu and each
gigabyte of memory on compute engine is
built separately rather than as a part
of a single machine type and is billed
as individual cpus and memory used per
hour resource-based pricing allows
compute engine to apply sustained use
discounts
to all of your pre-defined machine type
usage in a region collectively
rather than to individual machine types
and this way vcpu and memory usage for
each machine type can receive any one of
the following discounts sustained use
discounts committed use discounts and
preemptable vms and i'd like to take a
moment to dive into a bit of detail on
each of these discount types starting
with sustained use discounts
now sustained use discounts are
automatic discounts for running specific
compute engine resources a significant
portion of the billing month for example
when you run one of these resources for
more than 25 percent of a month compute
engine automatically gives you a
discount for every incremental minute
that you use for that instance now the
following tables show the discounts
applied for the specific resources
described here now for the table on the
left for general purpose n2 and n2d
predefined and custom machine types and
for compute optimized machine types you
can receive a discount of up to 20
percent the table on the right shows
that for general purpose n1 predefined
and custom machine types as well as sole
tenant nodes and gpus you can get a
discount of up to 30 percent sustained
use discounts are applied automatically
to usage within a project separately for
each region so there is no action
required on your part to enable these
discounts now some notes that i wanted
to cover here is that sustained use
discounts automatically apply to vms
created by both google kubernetes engine
and compute engine as well they do not
apply to vms created using the app
engine flexible environment as well as
data flow and the e-2 machine types
sustained use discounts are applied on
incremental use after you reach certain
usage thresholds this means that you pay
only for the number of minutes that you
use an instance and compute engine
automatically gives you the best price
google truly believes that there's no
reason to run an instance for longer
than you need it
now sustained use discounts are applied
on incremental use after you reach
certain usage thresholds this means that
you pay only for the number of minutes
that you use an instance and compute
engine automatically gives you the best
price now consider a scenario where you
have two instances or sole tenant nodes
in the same region that have different
machine types and run at different times
of the month
compute engine
breaks down the number of vcpus and
amount of memory used across all
instances that use predefined machine
types and combines the resources to
qualify for the largest sustained usage
discounts possible now in this example
assume you run the following two
instances
in the us east one region during a month
for the first half you run an n1
standard four instance with four vcpus
and 15 gigabytes of memory for the
second half of the month you run a
larger and one standard 16 instance with
16 vcpus and 60 gigabytes of memory in
this scenario compute engine reorganizes
these machine types into individual vcpu
and memory resources and combines their
usage to create the following resources
for vcpus so because four vcpus were
being used for the whole month the
discount here would be thirty percent
the additional twelve vcpus were added
on week two in the month and so for
those 12 vcpus they would receive a 10
discount and this is how discounts are
applied when it comes to sustained use
discounts now moving on to the next
discount type is committed use discounts
so compute engine lets you purchase
committed use contracts in return for
deeply discounted prices for vm usage so
when you purchase a committed use
contract you purchase compute resource
which is comprised of vcpus memory
gpus and local ssds and you purchase
these resources at a discounted price in
return for committing to paying for
those resources for one year or three
years committed use discounts are ideal
for workloads with predictable resource
needs so if you know exactly what you're
going to use committed use discounts
would be a great option for this and the
discount is up to 57
for most resources like machine types or
gpus when it comes to memory optimized
machine types the discount is up to 70
percent now when you purchase a
committed use contract you can purchase
it for a single project and applies to a
single project by default or you can
purchase multiple contracts which you
can share across many projects by
enabling shared discounts once purchased
your billed monthly for the resources
you purchased for the duration of the
term you selected whether you use the
services or not if you have multiple
projects that share the same cloud
billing account you can enable committed
use discount sharing so that all of your
projects within that cloud billing
account share all of your committed use
discount contracts your sustained use
discounts are also pooled at the same
time now some caveats when it comes to
committed use discounts shared core
machines are excluded on this as well
you can purchase commitments only on a
per region basis if a reservation is
attached to a committed use discount the
reservation can't be deleted for the
duration of the commitment so please be
aware now to purchase a commitment for
gpus or local ssds you must purchase a
general purpose and one commitment and
lastly after you create a commitment you
cannot cancel it you must pay the agreed
upon monthly amount for the duration of
the commitment now committed use
discount recommendations give you
opportunities to optimize your compute
costs by analyzing your vm spending
trends with and without a committed use
discount contract by comparing these
numbers you can see how much you can
save each month with a committed use
contract and this can be found under the
recommendations tab on the home page in
the console and so i wanted to move on
to the last discount type which are
preemptable vms now preemptable vms are
up to eighty percent cheaper than
regular instances pricing is fixed and
you never have to worry about variable
pricing these prices can be found on the
link to instance pricing that i have
included in the lesson text a
preemptable vm is an instance that you
can create and run at a much lower price
than normal instances however compute
engine might stop or preempt these
instances if it requires access to those
resources for other tasks as preemptable
instances our access compute engine
capacity so their availability varies
with usage now generally compute engine
avoids preempting instances
but compute engine does not use an
instant cpu usage or other behavior to
determine whether or not to preempt it
now a crucial characteristic to know
about preemptable vms is that compute
engine always stops them after they run
for 24 hours and this is something to be
aware of for the exam preemptable
instances are finite compute engine
resources so they might not always be
available and if you happen to
accidentally spin up a preemptable vm
and you want to shut it down there is no
charge if it's running for less than 10
minutes now another thing to note is
that preemptable instances can't live
migrate to a regular vm instance or be
set to automatically restart when there
is a maintenance event due to the
limitations preemptable instances are
not covered by any service level
agreement and when it comes to the
google cloud free tier credits for
compute engine this does not apply to
preemptable instances so you're probably
asking when is a great time to use
preemptable vms well if your apps are
fault tolerant and can withstand
possible instance preemptions then
preemptable instances can reduce your
compute engine costs significantly for
example batch processing jobs can run on
preemptable instances if some of those
instances stop during processing the job
slows down but does not completely stop
preemptable instances create your batch
processing tasks without placing any
additional workload on your existing
instances and without requiring for you
to pay full price for additional normal
instances and since containers are
naturally stateless and fault tolerant
this makes containers an amazing fit for
preemptable vms so running preemptable
vms for google kubernetes engine is
another fantastic use case now it's
really critical that you have an
understanding for each different
discount type and when is a good time to
use each as you may be presented
different cost-effective solutions in
the exam and understanding these
discount types will prepare you to
answer them understanding the theory
behind this resource-based pricing model
all the available discount types along
with the types of workloads that are
good for each will guarantee that you
will become familiar with what types of
questions are being asked in the exam
and will also make you a better cloud
engineer as you will be able to spot
where you can save money and be able to
make the appropriate changes and so
that's pretty much all i wanted to cover
when it comes to compute engine billing
and its discount types so you can now
mark this lesson as complete and let's
move on to the next one
welcome back in this lesson i'm going to
be covering the fundamentals as it
pertains to storage these concepts are
needed to know in order to fully
understand the different google cloud
storage options that i will be diving
into later as well the exam expects that
you know the different types of storage
that's available for all the various
services
and so before i get into the different
types of storage i wanted to cover the
underlying theory behind it so with that
being said let's dive in
so i wanted to start off by going
through the three types of storage and
how data is presented to a user or to
the server there is block storage file
storage and object storage these types
of storage tie into the available
services that are available in google
cloud and they offer different options
for different types of workloads and i
will be going over each of these in a
bit of depth and so the first one i
wanted to touch on is block storage
now block storage is sometimes referred
to as block level storage and is a
technology that is used to store data
files on storage systems or cloud-based
storage environments block storage is
the fastest available storage type and
it is also efficient and reliable with
block storage files are split into
evenly sized blocks of data each with
its own unique identifier it is
presented to the operating system as
structureless raw data in the form of a
logical volume or a hard drive and the
operating system structures it with a
file system like ext3 or ext4 on linux
and ntfs for windows it would then mount
this volume or drive as the root volume
in linux or a c or d drive in windows
block storage is usually delivered on
physical media in the case of google
cloud it is delivered as either spinning
hard drives or solid state drives so in
google cloud you're presented with block
storage that consists of either
persistent disks or local ssd
which can both be mountable and bootable
block storage volumes can then be used
as your boot volumes for compute
instances in google cloud
installed with your operating system of
choice and structured so that your
operating system database or application
will then be able to consume it now
moving on to the second type of storage
is file storage
now file storage is also referred to as
file level or file based storage and is
normally storage that is presented to
users and applications as a traditional
network file system in other words the
user or application receives data
through directory trees folders and
files file storage also allows you to do
the same this functions similarly to a
local hard drive however a structure has
already been applied and cannot be
adjusted after the fact this type of
structure only has the capabilities of
being mountable but not bootable you
cannot install an operating system on
file storage as i said before the
structure has already been put in place
for you and is ready for you or your
application to consume due to this
structure the service that is serving
the file system has some underlying
software that can handle access rights
file sharing file locking and other
controls related to file storage in
google cloud this service that serves
this type of storage is known as cloud
file store and is usually presented over
the network to users in your vpc network
using the nfs protocol or in this case
nfs version 3. but i'll be diving into
that a little bit later and the last
storage type that i wanted to cover is
object storage
now object storage also referred to as
object-based storage
is a general term that refers to the way
in which we organize and work with units
of storage called objects and this is a
storage type that is a flat collection
of unstructured data and this type of
storage holds no structure like the
other two types of storage and is made
up of three characteristics the first
one is the data itself and this could be
anything from movies songs and even
photos of men in fancy bow ties the data
could also be binary data as well the
second characteristic is the metadata
and this is usually related to any
contextual information about what the
data is or anything that is relevant to
the data and the third characteristic is
a globally unique identifier and this
way it's possible to find the data
without having to know the physical
location of the data and this is what
allows object storage to be infinitely
scalable as it doesn't matter where the
object is stored this type of storage
can be found in google cloud and is
known as cloud storage cloud storage is
flat storage with a logical container
called a bucket that you put objects
into now although this type of storage
is not bootable using an open source
tool called fuse this storage type can
be mounted in google cloud and i will be
covering that a little bit later in the
cloud storage lesson but in most cases
object store is designed as the type of
storage that is not bootable or
mountable and because of the
characteristics of this storage
it allows object storage again to be
infinitely scalable and so these are the
three main types of storage that you
will need to know and understand as each
has its use cases so if you're looking
for high performance storage you will
always look to block storage to satisfy
your needs if you're looking to share
files across multiple systems or have
multiple applications
that need access to the same files and
directories then file storage might be
your best bet if you're looking to store
terabytes of pictures for a web
application and you don't want to worry
about scaling object storage will allow
you to read and write an infinite amount
of pictures that will meet your
requirements so now that we've covered
these storage types let's take a few
moments to discuss storage performance
terms now when discussing storage
performance there are some key terms to
understand that when used together
define the performance of your storage
first there is io which stands for input
output
and is a single read write request and
can be measured in block size and this
block size can vary anywhere from one
kilobyte to four megabytes and beyond
depending on your workload now q depth
when it comes to storage is the number
of pending input output requests
waiting to be performed on a disk io
requests become queued when reads or
writes are requested faster than they
can be processed by the disk when io
requests are queued the total amount of
time it takes to read or write data to
disk becomes significantly higher this
is where performance degradation can
occur and queue depth must be adjusted
accordingly now the next term is a
common touch point when it comes to
discussing storage performance on gcp
and on the exam which is iops and this
is a metric that stands for input output
operations per second this value
indicates how many different input or
output operations a device or group of
devices can perform in one second more
value in the iops signifies the
capability of executing more operations
per second and again this is a common
touch point that i will be diving into a
little bit later now next up is
throughput and this is the speed at
which the data is transferred in a
second and is most commonly measured in
megabytes per second this is going to be
another common topic that comes up
frequently when discussing storage on
gcp as well
latency is the measurement of delay
between the time data is requested when
the data starts being returned and is
measured in milliseconds so the time
each io request will take to complete
results in being your average latency
and the last two terms i wanted to bring
up is sequential and random access
sequential would be a large single file
like a video and random access would be
loading an application or an operating
system so lots of little files that are
all over the place it's obvious that
accessing data randomly is much slower
and less efficient than accessing it
sequentially and this can also affect
performance now why i bring up all these
terms is not about calculating the
average throughput but to give you a
holistic view on storage performance
as all these characteristics play a part
in defining the performance of your
storage
there is not one specific characteristic
that is responsible for disk performance
but all have a role in achieving the
highest performance possible
for your selected storage now i know
this is a lot of theory to take in but
this will all start to make more sense
when we dive into other parts of the
course where we will discuss disk
performance with all these
characteristics as it relates to compute
engine and other services that use
storage it is crucial to know the
storage types as well as the performance
characteristics as it will bring clarity
to questions in the exam and also give
you a better sense on how to increase
your storage performance in your work
environment and so that's pretty much
all i wanted to cover when it comes to
storage types and storage performance as
it pertains to storage as a whole so you
can now mark this lesson as complete and
let's move on to the next one
[Music]
welcome back and in this lesson i'm
going to be covering persistent disks
and local ssds i'm going to be getting
into the detail with the most commonly
used storage types for instances which
are both persistent disks and local ssds
this lesson will sift through all the
different types of persistent disks and
local ssds along with the performance of
each knowing what type of disk to use
for your instance and how to increase
disk performance shows up on the exam
and so i want to make sure to cover it
in detail and leave no stone unturned so
with that being said let's dive in now
persistent disks and local ssds are the
two available types of block storage
devices
available in google cloud and the
determining factor of what you will use
for your particular scenario will depend
on your use case and the specific
characteristics that you require from
each storage medium now by default each
compute engine instance has a single
boot persistent disk that contains the
operating system when you require
additional storage space you can add one
or more additional persistent disks or
local ssds to your instance and i will
be going through these storage options
along with their characteristics now as
you can see here persistent disks and
local ssds come in a slew of different
types as well with persistent disks they
are available in both zonal and regional
options so starting off with persistent
disks you have three different types you
can choose from as well you have the
flexibility of choosing from two
different geographic options when it
comes to the redundancy of your
persistent disks and i will be covering
the zonal and regional options in detail
in just a bit now persistent disks are
durable network storage devices
that your instances can access like
physical disks in a computer so these
are not physically attached disks but
network disks that are connected over
google's internal network persistent
disks are independent of your instance
and can persist after your instance has
been terminated and this can be done by
turning on this flag upon creation you
can even detach your disk and move it to
other instances when you need to scaling
persistent disks can be done
automatically and on the fly by using
the disk resize feature and this gives
you the flexibility to resize your
current persistent disks with no
downtime and even add additional disks
to your instance for additional
performance and storage persistent disks
are also encrypted by default and google
also gives you the option of using your
own custom keys each persistent disk can
be up to 64 terabytes in size and most
instances can have up to 128 persistent
disks and up to 257 terabytes of total
persistent disk space attached and just
as a note share core machine types are
limited to 16 persistent disks and 3
terabytes of total persistent disk space
and so now that i've gone through the
details of persistent disks i wanted to
dive into the two geographic options
that's available for persistent disks
first starting with zonal now zonal
persistent disks are disks that are
available in one zone in one region
these disks are the most commonly used
persistent disks for general day-to-day
usage and used for those whose workloads
are not sensitive to specific zone
outages they are redundant within the
zone you've created them in but cannot
survive an outage of that zone and may
be subjected to data loss if that
specific zone is affected and this is
where snapshots should be a part of your
high availability strategy when using
zonal persistent disks snapshots are
incremental and can be taken even if you
snapshot disks that are attached to
running instances and i'll be going into
detail about snapshots in a later lesson
zonal persistent disks can also be used
with any machine type including
pre-defined shared core and custom
machine types now when it comes to
regional persistent disks they have
storage qualities that are similar to
zonal persistent disks however regional
persistent disks provide durable storage
and replication of data between two
zones in the same region if you are
designing systems that require high
availability on compute engine you
should use regional persistent disks
combined with snapshots for durability
regional persistent disks are also
designed to work with regional managed
instance groups in the unlikely event of
a zonal outage you can usually fail over
your workload running on regional
persistent disks to another zone by
simply using the force attached flag
regional persistent disks are slower
than zonal persistent disks and should
be taken into consideration when write
performance is less critical than data
redundancy across multiple zones now
noting a couple of caveats here when it
comes to disk limits regional persistent
disks are similar to zonal persistent
disks however regional standard
persistent disks have a 200 gigabyte
size minimum and may be a major factor
when it comes to cost so please be aware
as well you can't use regional
persistent disks with memory optimized
machine types or compute optimized
machine types now these two geographic
options are available for all three
persistent disk types whose
characteristics i will dive into now
starting off with the standard
persistent disk type also known in
google cloud as pd standard now these
persistent disks are backed by standard
hard disk drives and these are your
standard spinning hard disk drives and
allows google cloud to give a cost
effective solution for your specific
needs standard persistent disks are
great for large data processing
workloads that primarily use sequential
ios now as explained earlier sequential
access would be accessing larger files
and would require less work by the hard
drive thus decreasing latency as there
are physical moving parts in this hard
drive this would allow the disc to do
the least amount of work as possible and
therefore making it the most efficient
as possible and therefore sequential ios
are best suited for this type of
persistent disk and again this is the
lowest price persistent disks out of all
the persistent disk types now stepping
into the performance of standard
persistent disks for just a second
please remember that iops and throughput
performance depends on disk size
instance vcpu count and i o block size
among other factors and so this table
here along with the subsequent tables
you will see later are average speeds
that google has deemed optimum for these
specific disk types they cover the
maximum sustained iops as well as the
maximum sustained throughput along with
the granular breakdown of each here you
can see the differences between both the
zonal and regional standard pd and as
you can see here in the table the zonal
standard pd and the regional standard pd
are pretty much the same when it comes
to most of these metrics but when you
look closely at the read iops per
instance this is where they differ where
the zonal standard pd has a higher read
iops per instance than the regional
standard pd and this is because the
regional standard pd is accessing two
different disks in two separate zones
and so the latency will be higher the
same thing goes for right throughput per
instance and so this would be a decision
between high availability versus speed
moving on to the next type of persistent
disk is the balanced persistent disk in
google cloud known as pd balance this
disk type is the alternative to the ssd
persistent disks that balance both
performance and cost as this disk type
has the same maximum iops as the ssd
persistent disk type but holds a lower
iops per gigabyte and so this disk is
designed for general purpose use the
price for this disk also falls in
between the standard and the ssd
persistent disks so this is basically
your middle of the road disk when you're
trying to decide between price and speed
moving straight into performance i put
the standard pd metric here so that you
can see a side-by-side comparison
between the balance pd and the standard
pd and as you can see here when it comes
to the metrics under the maximum
sustained iops the balance pd is
significantly higher than the standard
pd in both the zonal and regional
options as well looking at the maximum
sustained throughput the read write
throughput per gigabyte is a little over
two times faster and the right
throughput per instance is three times
faster so quite a bit of jump from the
standard pd to the balance pd and moving
on to the last persistent disk type is
the ssd persistent disk type also known
in google cloud as a pd ssd and these
are the fastest persistent disks that
are available
and are great for enterprise
applications and high performance
databases that demand lower latency and
more iops so this would be great for
transactional databases or applications
that require demanding and near
real-time performance the pd ssds have a
single digit millisecond latency and
because of this comes at a higher cost
and therefore is the highest price
persistent disk moving on to the
performance of this persistent disk this
disk type is five times faster when it
comes to read iops per gigabyte than the
balance pd as well as five times faster
for the right iops per gigabyte and so
the table here on the left shows the
performance for the pd ssd and the table
on the right shows the performance of
both the standard pd and the balance pd
and so here you can see the difference
moving from the standard pd over to the
ssd pd the read write throughput per
instance stays the same from the
standard pd all the way up to the ssd pd
but where the ssd outperforms all the
other ones is through the read write
throughput per gigabyte it's one and a
half times faster than the balance pd
and four times faster than the standard
pd and again you will also notice a drop
in performance from the zonal option to
the regional option and so this is the
end of part one of this lesson as it
started to get a little bit long and so
whenever you're ready you can join me in
part two where i will be starting
immediately from the end of part one so
you can complete this video and i will
see you in the next
[Music]
welcome back this is part two of the
persistent disks and local ssds lesson
and we will be starting exactly where we
left off in part one so with that being
said let's dive in and so now that i've
covered all the persistent disk types i
wanted to move into discussing the
characteristics of the local ssd local
ssds are physically attached to the
server that hosts your vm instance local
ssds have higher throughput and lower
latency than any of the available
persistent disk options and again this
is because it's physically attached and
the data doesn't have to travel over the
network now the crucial thing to know
about local ssds is that the data you
store on a local ssd persists only until
the instance is stopped or deleted once
the instance is stopped or deleted your
data will be gone and there is no chance
of getting it back now each local ssd is
375 gigabytes in size but you can attach
a maximum of 24 local ssd partitions for
a total of 9 terabytes per instance
local ssds are designed to offer very
high iops and very low latency and this
is great for when you need a fast
scratch disk or a cache and you don't
want to use instance memory local ssds
are also available in two flavors scuzzy
and mvme now for those of you who are
unaware
scuzzy is an older protocol and made
specifically for hard drives it also
holds the limitation of having one queue
for commands nvme on the other hand also
known as non-volatile memory express is
a newer protocol and is designed for the
specific use of flash memory and
designed to have up to 64 000 qs as well
each of those queues in turn can have up
to 64 000 commands running at the same
time and thus making nvme infinitely
faster now although nvme comes with
these incredible speeds it does come at
a cost and so when it comes to the
caveats of local ssd although compute
engine automatically encrypts your data
when it's written to local ssd storage
space you can't use customer supplied
encryption keys with local ssds as well
local ssds are only available for the n1
n2 and compute optimized machine types
now moving on to the performance of
local ssds throughput is the same
between scuzzy and nvme but the read
write iops per instance is where nvme
comes out on top and as you can see here
the read iops per instance is a whopping
two million four hundred thousand read
iops per instance as well the right iops
per instance is 1.2 million over the 800
000 for local ssd now before i end this
lesson i wanted to cover a few points on
performance scaling
as it pertains to block storage on
compute engine now persistent disk
performance scales with the size of the
disk and with the number of vcpus on
your vm instance persistent disk
performance scales linearly until it
reaches either the limits of the volume
or the limits of each compute engine
instance whichever is lower now this may
seem odd that the performance of your
disk scales with cpu count but you have
to remember persistent disks aren't
physically attached to your vm they are
independently located as such i o on a
pd is a network operation and thus it
takes cpu to do i o which means that
smaller instances run out of cpu to
perform disk io at higher rates so in
order for you to get better performance
you can increase the iops for your disk
by resizing them to their maximum
capacity but once that size has been
reached you will have to increase the
number of cpus on your instance in order
to increase your disk performance a
recommendation by google is that you
have one available vcpu for every 2000
to
iops of expected traffic so to sum it up
performance scales until it reaches
either the limits of the disk or the
limits of the vm instance to which the
disk is attached the vm instance limits
are determined by the machine type and
the number of vcpus of the instance now
if you want to get more granular with
regards to disk performance i've
included a few links in the lesson text
that will give you some more insight but
for most general purposes and for the
exam remember that persistent disk
performance is based on the total
persistent disk capacity
attached to an instance and the number
of vcpus that the instance has and so
that's pretty much all i wanted to cover
when it comes to persistent disks and
local ssds so you can now mark this
lesson as complete and let's move on to
the next one
welcome back in this demo i'm going to
be covering how to manage and interact
with your disks on compute engine this
demo is designed to give you both
experience and understanding on working
with persistent disks and how you would
interact with them we're going to start
the demo off by creating an instance
we're then going to create a separate
persistent disk and attach it to the
instance we're going to then interact
with the disk and then resize the disk
while afterwards we will delete it and
we're going to do this all by both using
the console and the command line so with
that being said let's dive in so here i
am in the console i'm logged in as tony
bowties gmail.com and i am in project
bowtie inc and so the first thing we
need to do to kick off this demo is to
create an instance that we can attach
our disk to but first i always like to
make sure that i have a vpc to deploy my
instance into with its corresponding
default firewall rules so i'm going to
head on over to the navigation menu
and i'm going to go down to vpc network
and as expected my default vpc has been
created and just to make sure that i
have all my necessary firewall rules i'm
going to drill down into the vpc and
head on over to firewall rules i'm going
to click on firewall rules and the
necessary firewall rule that i need for
ssh is created and so i can go ahead and
create my instance so i'm going to go
back up to the navigation menu and i'm
going to go over to compute engine so
i'm going to go ahead and click on
create and i'm going to name this
instance bowtie dash instance and for
the sake of this demo i'll add in a
label here the key is going to be
environment and the value will be
testing i'm going to go down to the
bottom click on save with regards to the
region i'm going to select us east 1 and
i'm going to keep the zone as the
default for us east 1b and under machine
type to keep things cost effective i'm
going to use an e2 micro shared core
machine and i'm going to scroll down to
service account and under service
account you want to select the set
access for each api
you want to scroll down to compute
engine and here you want to select read
write and this will give us the
necessary permissions in order to
interact with our disk that we will be
creating later so i'm going to scroll
down to the bottom here and i'm going to
leave everything else set at its default
and just before creating the instance
please do remember you can always click
on the command line link where you can
get the gcloud command to create this
instance through the command line i'm
going to close this up and i'm going to
simply click on create i'm just going to
wait a few seconds here for my instance
to come up okay and my instance is up
and so now what we want to do is we want
to create our new disk so i'm going to
go over here to the left hand menu and
i'm going to click on disks and as you
can see here the disk for the instance
that i had just created has 10 gigabytes
in us east 1b and we want to leave that
alone and we want to create our new disk
so i'm going to go up to the top here
and simply click on create disk
and so for the name of the disk i'm
going to call this disk new pd for
persistent disk and i'm going to give it
the same description i'm going to keep
the type as standard persistent disk and
for the region i want to select us east
one i'm going to keep the zone as its
default in us east 1b and as the disk is
in us east 1b i'll be able to attach it
to my instance and so just as a note
here there is a selection where you can
replicate this disk within the region if
i click that off i've now changed this
from a zonal persistent disk to a
regional persistent disk and over here
in zones it'll give me the option to
select any two zones that i prefer and
so if you're looking at creating some
regional persistent disks these are the
steps you would need to take in order to
get it done in the console now in order
to save on costs i'm going to keep this
as a zonal persistent disk so i'm going
to click on cancel i'm going to uncheck
the option and make sure your region is
still set at us east 1 and your zone is
selected as us east 1b we're going to
leave the snapshot schedule alone and
i'll be diving into snapshot schedules
in a later lesson i'm going to scroll
down here to source type i'm going to
keep it as blank disk and the size here
is set at 500 gigabytes and we want to
set it to 100 gigabytes but before we do
that i wanted to bring your attention to
the estimated performance here you can
see the sustain random iops limits as
well as the throughput limit and so
depending on the size of the disk that
you want to add these limits will change
accordingly so if i change this to 100
my sustained random iops limit on read
went from 375 iops to 75 iops and so
this is a great demonstration that the
larger your disc the better your
performance and so this is a great way
to figure out on what your performance
will be before you create your disk and
i've also been prompted with a note here
saying that because my disk is under 200
gigabytes that i will have reduced
performance and so for this demo that's
okay i'm going to keep my encryption as
the google manage key and under labels i
will add environment as the key and
value is testing
and so now that i've entered all my
options i'm going to simply click on
create
and i'm going to give it a few seconds
and my new disk should be created okay
and my new disk has been created and you
can easily create this disk through the
command line and i will be supplying
that in the lesson text i merely want to
go through the console setup so that you
are aware of all the different options
and so now that i've created my disk and
i've created my instance i want to now
log into my instance and attach this new
disk so i'm going to go back to vm
instances and here i want to ssh into
the bowtie instance and i'm going to
give it a few seconds here to connect
and i'm going to zoom in for better
viewing i'm going to clear my screen
and so the first thing i want to do is i
want to list all my block devices that
are available to me on this instance and
the linux command for that is ls blk
and as you can see my boot disk has been
mounted
and is available to me and so now i want
to attach the new disk that we just
created and just as a note i could as
easily have done this in the console but
i wanted to give you an idea of what it
would look like doing it from the
command line and so i'm going to paste
in the command to attach the disk which
is gcloud compute instances attach dash
disk the name of the instance which is
bow tie dash instance along with the
flag dash dash disk the disk name which
is new pd and the zone of the disk using
the zone flag with us east 1b so i'm
going to go ahead and hit enter
and no errors came up so i'm assuming
that this had worked and so just to
double check i'm gonna run the lsblk
command again and success as you can see
here my block device sdb has been
attached to my instance and is available
to me with the size of 100 gigabytes and
so now i want to look at the state that
this roblox device is in and so the
command for that will be sudo
file dash s followed by the path of the
block device which is forward slash dev
forward slash sdb i'm going to hit on
enter and as you can see it is showing
data which means that it is just a raw
data device and so in order for me to
interact with it i need to format the
drive with a file system that the
operating system will be able to
interact with and so the command to
format the drive would be sudo mkfs
which is make file system i'm going to
use ext4 as the file system minus
capital f along with the path of the new
disk so i'm going to hit on enter and no
errors so i'm assuming that it was
successful so just to verify i'm going
to run the sudo file minus s command and
as you can see here because the disk now
has a file system i've been given the
information with regards to this disk
whereas before it was simply raw data
and so now that we've created our disk
and we've formatted our disk to a file
system that the operating system is able
to read we need to now mount the disk
and so in order to do that we need to
create a mount point so i'm going to
first clear the screen and i'm going to
run the command sudo mkdir and the new
mount point i'm going to call it slash
new pd i'm going to hit enter and now
i'm going to mount the disk and the
command for that is sudo mount the path
for the block device which is forward
slash dev forward slash sdb and then the
mount point which is forward slash new
pd i'm going to hit enter no errors so
i'm assuming that it had worked but just
to verify i'm going to run the command
lsblk
and success as you can see sdb has now
been mounted as new pd and so now i can
interact with this disk so the first
thing i want to do is i want to change
directories to this mount point i'm in
now new pd i'm going to do an ls and so
just as a note for those of you who are
wondering the lost and found directory
is found on each linux file system and
this is designed to place orphaned or
corrupted files or any corrupted bits of
data from the file system to be placed
here and so it's not something that you
would interact with but always a good to
know so i'm going to now create a file
in new pd so i'm going to run the
command sudo nano file a bow ties dot
text so file a bow ties is the file that
i'm going to create nano is my text
editor and so i'm going to hit on enter
and so in this file i'm going to type in
bow ties are so classy
because after all they are i'm going to
hit ctrl o to save i'm going to hit
enter to verify it and ctrl x to exit so
if i do another ls i can see the file of
bow ties has been created also by
running the command df minus k i'll be
able to see the file system here as well
and so this is the end of part one of
this demo it was getting a bit long so i
decided to break it up this would be a
great opportunity for you to get up have
a stretch get yourself a coffee or tea
and whenever you're ready you can join
me in the next one where part two will
be starting immediately from the end of
part one
[Music]
welcome back this is part two of this
demo and we're gonna continue
immediately from the end of part one so
with that being said let's dive in and
so what i want to do now is i want to
reboot the instance in order to
demonstrate the mounting of this device
and i'm going to do that by using the
command sudo reboot it's going to
disconnect me i'm going to click on
close and i'm going to wait about a
minute for it to reboot okay and it's
been about a minute so i'm going to now
ssh into my instance
okay and here i am back again logged
into my instance i'm going to quickly
clear the screen and i'm going to run
the lsblk command now what i wanted to
demonstrate here is that although i
mounted the new device it did not stay
mounted through the reboot and this is
because there is a configuration file in
linux that points to which partitions
get mounted automatically upon startup
that i need to edit in order to make
sure that this device is mounted every
time the instance reboots and so in
order to do that i need to edit a file
called fstab and i'm going to have to
add the unique identifier for this
partition also known as the device sdb
and this will mount the partition
automatically every time there happens
to be a reboot so in order to do that
i'm going to run the command sudo blk id
and the path of the block device forward
slash dev forward slash sdb i'm going to
hit on enter and here is the identifier
also known as the uuid that i need to
append to the fstab file so i'm going to
copy the uuid
and i'm going to use the command
sudo nano
etc
fs tab and i'm going to hit on enter and
here you will find the uuid for your
other partitions and so you're going to
be appending a line here right at the
end so i'm going to move my cursor down
here i'm going to type in uuid equals
and then the uuid that i had copied
earlier the amount point which is going
to be forward slash new pd the type of
file system which is ext4 along with
defaults
comma no fail i'm going to hit control o
to save hit enter to verify and control
x to exit and so now i'm going to mount
this device by running the command sudo
mount dash a and hit enter and this
command will mount all the partitions
that are available in the fstab file and
so when i run a lsblk
i can see here that my block device sdb
is now mounted on forward slash new pd
now i know this may be a refresher for
some but this is a perfect demonstration
of the tasks that need to be done when
creating and attaching a new disk to an
instance and is a common task for many
working on linux instances and working
in cloud this can definitely be scripted
but i wanted to show you the steps that
need to be taken in order to get a new
disk in a usable state okay so great we
have created a new disk we had attached
the disk created a file system and had
mounted the disk along with editing the
configuration file to make sure that the
device mounts whenever the instance
starts up so now that we've done all
that i wanted to demonstrate resizing
this disk from 100 gigabytes to 150
gigabytes and so just to show you where
it is in the console i'm going to
quickly go back to my console tab and so
here i'm going to go to the left hand
menu i'm going to click on disks i'm
going to drill down into new pd and at
the top i'm going to click on edit and
so here i'm able to adjust the disk
space size and simply click on save not
much that i really need to do here but i
did want to show you how to do this in
the command line so i'm going to go back
to the tab of my instance and i'm going
to quickly clear the screen and i'm
going to paste in the command gcloud
compute disks
resize the name of the disk which is new
pd and the new size in gigabytes using
the dash dash size flag 150 which is the
new size of the disc along with the dash
dash zone flag of us east 1b i'm going
to hit enter it's going to ask me if i
want to do this as this is not
reversible and please remember when you
resize a disk you can only make it
bigger and never smaller so i'm going to
hit y to continue
and it took a few seconds there but it
was successful so if i run a df minus k
you can see here that i only have 100
gigabytes available to me and this is
because i have to extend the file system
on the disk so i've made the disk larger
but i haven't allocated those raw blocks
to the file system so in order for the
file system to see those unallocated
blocks that's available to it i need to
run another command so i'm going to
quickly clear my screen again
and i'm going to run the command sudo
resize to fs along with the block device
i'm going to hit enter and as you can
see it was successful showing the old
blocks as 13 and the new blocks as 19.
so if i run a df minus k i can now see
my 150 gigabytes that's available to me
and so just to demonstrate after
resizing the disk along with mounting
and then remounting the disk that the
file that i've created still exists i'm
going to run an ls minus al but first i
will need to
change directories into new pd clear my
screen and run an ls and phyla bow ties
is still there and so this is a great
example demonstrating how the data on
persistent disks persist through the
lifetime of a disk even when mounting
unmounting rebooting and resizing and so
as you can see we've done a lot of work
here and so just as a recap where we've
created a new disk we attached this disk
to an instance we formatted the disk
into an ext4 file system we've mounted
this disk we've written a file to it
added its unique identifier to the
configuration file so that it mounts on
startup and then we've resized the disk
along with extending the file system on
the disk and so this is the end of the
demo and i wanted to congratulate you on
making it to the end and i hope this
demo has been extremely useful and again
fantastic job on your part now before
you go i wanted to quickly walk through
the steps of deleting all the resources
you've created and so the first thing
that i want to do is delete the disk
that was created for this demo and so
before i can delete the disk i'm going
to first detach the disk from the
instance and the easiest way to do that
is through the command line so i'm going
to quickly clear my screen and so i'm
going to show you how to detach the disk
from the instance and so i'm going to
paste in this command gcloud compute
instances detach disk the instance name
which is bow tie dash instance along
with the disc with the flag dash dash
disc the name of the disc which is new
pd along with the zone i'm going to hit
enter
and it's been successfully detached and
so now that it's detached i can actually
delete the disk and so i'm going to head
on over back to the console and i'm
going to go ahead and delete the new pd
disk i'm going to click on delete i'm
going to get a prompt asking me if i'm
sure yes i am if i go back to the main
menu for my disks and this should just
take a moment and once it's deleted you
will no longer see it here and i'm going
to go back over to vm instances and i'm
going to delete this as well
and so there's no need to delete your
default vpc unless you'd like to
recreate it again but don't worry for
those who decide to keep it you will not
be charged for your vpc as we will be
using it in the next demo and so that's
pretty much all i wanted to cover when
it comes to managing disks with compute
engine so you can now mark this as
complete and let's move on to the next
one
[Music]
welcome back in this lesson i'll be
discussing persistent disk snapshots now
snapshots are a great way to backup data
from any running or stopped instances
from unexpected data loss
snapshots are also a great strategy for
use in a backup plan for any and all
instances no matter where they are
located and so as cloud engineers and
architects this is a great tool for
achieving the greatest uptime for your
instances so diving right into it
snapshots as i mentioned before are a
great way for both backing up and
restoring the data of your persistent
disks you can create snapshots from
disks even while they are attached to
running instances snapshots are global
resources so any snapshot is accessible
by any resource within the same project
you can also share snapshots across
projects as well snapshots also support
both zonal and regional persistent disks
snapshots are incremental and
automatically compressed so you can
create regular snapshots on a persistent
disk
faster and at a much lower cost than if
you regularly created a full image of a
disk now when you create a snapshot you
have the option of choosing a storage
location snapshots are stored in cloud
storage
and can be stored in either a
multi-regional location or a regional
cloud storage bucket a multi-regional
storage location provides higher
availability but will drive up costs
please be aware that the location of a
snapshot affects its availability and
can incur
networking costs when creating the
snapshot or restoring it to a new disk
if you do not specify storage location
for a snapshot google cloud uses the
default location which stores your
snapshot in a cloud storage
multi-regional location closest to the
region of your source disk if you store
your snapshot in the same region as your
source disk there is no network charge
when you access that snapshot from the
same region if you access the snapshot
from a different region you will incur a
network cost compute engine stores
multiple copies of each snapshot across
multiple locations as well you cannot
change the storage location of an
existing snapshot once a snapshot has
been taken it can be used to create a
new disk in any region and zone
regardless of the storage location of
the snapshot now as i explained earlier
snapshots are incremental and i wanted
to take a moment to dive into that for
just a minute so when creating snapshots
the first successful snapshot of a
persistent disk is a full snapshot that
contains all the data on the persistent
disk the second snapshot only contains
any new data or modify data since the
first snapshot data that hasn't changed
since snapshot 1 isn't included instead
snapshot 2 contains references to
snapshot 1 for any unchanged data as
shown here snapshot 3 contains any new
or changed data since snapshot 2 but
won't contain any unchanged data from
snapshot 1 or 2. instead snapshot 3
contains references to blocks in
snapshot 1 and snapshot 2 for any
unchanged data this repeats for all
subsequent snapshots of the persistent
disk snapshots are always created based
on the last successful snapshot taken
and so now you're probably wondering
what happens when you decide to delete a
snapshot are they dependent on each
other well when you delete a snapshot
compute engine immediately marks the
snapshot as deleted in the system if the
snapshot has no dependent snapshots it
is deleted outright however if the
snapshot does have dependent snapshots
then there are some steps that happen
behind the scenes so shown here in this
diagram snapshot 2 is deleted the next
snapshot from the full snapshot no
longer references the snapshot for
deletion in this example snapshot 1 then
becomes the reference for snapshot 3 and
any data that is required for restoring
other snapshots is moved into the next
snapshot increasing its size shown here
blocks that were unique to snapshot 2
are moved to snapshot 3 and the size of
snapshot 3 increases any data that is
not required for restoring other
snapshots is deleted so in this case
blocks that are already in snapshot 3
are deleted from snapshot 2 and the size
of all snapshots are lower now because
subsequent snapshots might require
information stored in a previous
snapshot
please be aware that deleting a snapshot
does not necessarily delete all the data
on the snapshot if you're looking to
make sure that your data has indeed been
deleted from your snapshots you should
delete all snapshots if your disk has a
snapshot schedule you must detach the
snapshot schedule from the disk before
you can delete the schedule
removing the snapshot schedule from the
disk prevents further snapshot activity
from occurring
now touching on the topic of scheduled
snapshots by far the best way to backup
your data on compute engine is to use
scheduled snapshots this way you will
never have to worry about manually
creating snapshots or even worry about
using other tools to kick off those
snapshots you can simply use this
built-in tool by google which is why
snapshot schedules are considered best
practice to backup any compute engine
persistent disks now in order to create
any snapshot schedules you must create
your snapshot schedule in the same
region where your persistent disk
resides now there are two ways to create
a snapshot schedule the first one is to
create a snapshot schedule and then
attach it to an existing persistent disk
the other way is to create a new
persistent disk with a snapshot schedule
you also have the option of setting up a
snapshot retention policy that defines
how long you want to keep your snapshots
some options when creating snapshot
schedules are both retention policies
and source disk deletion rules now if
you choose to set up a snapshot
retention policy you must do it as part
of your snapshot schedule when you
create a snapshot schedule is when you
can also set a source disk deletion rule
the source disk deletion rule controls
what happens to your snapshots if the
source disk is deleted now a few caveats
here on the scheduled snapshots is that
a persistent disk can only have one
snapshot schedule attached to it at a
time also you cannot delete a snapshot
schedule if it is attached to a disk you
must detach the schedule from all disks
then delete the schedule as well after
you create a snapshot schedule you
cannot edit it to update a snapshot
schedule you must delete it and create a
new one now before i end this lesson i
wanted to touch on managing snapshots
for just a minute so when managing
snapshots there's a few things to
remember in order to use snapshots to
manage your data efficiently you can
snapshot your disks at most once every
10 minutes you are unable to snapshot
your disks at intervals less than 10
minutes so please keep that in mind when
creating your schedules also you should
create snapshots on a regular schedule
to minimize data loss if there was an
unexpected failure if you have existing
snapshots of a persistent disk the
system automatically uses them as a
baseline for any subsequent snapshots
that you create from that same disk
so in order to improve performance you
can eliminate excessive snapshots by
creating an image and reusing it using
this method would not only be ideal for
storage and management of snapshots but
also help to reduce costs and if you
schedule regular snapshots for your
persistent disks you can reduce the time
that it takes to complete each snapshot
by creating them during off-peak hours
when possible and lastly for those of
you who use windows for most situations
you can use the volume shadow copy
service to take snapshots of persistent
disks that are attached to windows
instances you can create vss snapshots
without having to stop the instance or
detach the persistent disk and so that's
pretty much all i wanted to cover when
it comes to the theory of persistent
disk snapshots their schedules and how
to manage them in the next lesson i'll
be doing a hands-on demo
demonstrating snapshots and putting this
theory into practice and get a feel for
how snapshots work and how they can be
applied to persistent disks so you can
now mark this lesson as complete and
whenever you're ready join me in the
console
[Music]
welcome back
in this demonstration we're going to
dive into snapshots and snapshot
schedules this demo will give you the
hands-on knowledge you need to create
and delete snapshots along with how to
manage snapshot schedules we're going to
start the demo off by creating an
instance we're going to interact with it
and then take a snapshot of the disk
we're going to then create another
instance from the snapshot and then
create some snapshot schedules for both
of these instances by using both the
console and the command line so there's
a lot to do here so with that being said
let's dive in and so i'm currently
logged in as tony bowties gmail.com as
well i'm in project bowtie inc so the
first thing that we need to do to kick
off this demo is to create an instance
but first as always i like to make sure
that i have a vpc to deploy my instance
into with its corresponding default
firewall rules and so i'm going to head
on over to the navigation menu and
scroll down to vpc network
and because i didn't delete my default
vpc from the last demo i still have it
here i'm just going to drill down and
make sure that i have my firewall rules
i'm gonna go over to firewall rules and
as expected the ssh firewall rule that i
need has already been created and so now
that i have everything in order i'm
gonna go back over to the navigation
menu and head on over to compute engine
to create my instance now i figure for
this demo i'd switch it up a little bit
and create the instance by the command
line so i'm going to head on over to
cloud shell i'm going to open that up
and it took a minute to provision and so
what i'm going to do now is i'm going to
open it up in a new tab i'm going to
zoom in for better viewing and i'm going
to paste in my command to create my
instance and this gcloud command to
create these instances will be available
in the github repository and you will
find all the instructions and the
commands
under managing snapshots in compute
engine so i'm going to hit enter
and you may get a prompt to authorize
this api call and i'm going to click on
authorize
and success our instance has been
created and is up and running and so now
what i want to do is ssh into the
instance and so i'm just going to run
the command from here which is gcloud
compute ssh dash dash zone the zone that
i'm in which is used 1b and the instance
which is bowtie dash instance i'm going
to hit enter it's going to prompt me if
i want to continue i'm going to say yes
and i'm going to enter my passphrase and
enter it again
it's going to update my metadata and
it's going to ask me again for my
passphrase and i'm in so i'm going to
just quickly clear my screen and so the
first thing i want to do is i want to
verify the name of my instance so i'm
going to type in the command hostname
and as expected bowtie dash instance
shows up and so now i want to create a
text file and so i'm going to run the
command
sudo nano file a
text i'm going to hit enter and it's
going to open up my nano text editor and
you can enter a message of any kind that
you'd like for me i'm going to enter
more bow tie needed because you can
never get enough bow ties i'm going to
hit ctrl o to save press enter to verify
the file name to write and then ctrl x
to exit i'm going to run the command ls
space minus al to list my files so i can
verify that my file has been created and
as you can see here file a bowties.txt
has been created and so now that i've
created my instance and i've written a
file to disk i'm going to now head on
over to the console and take a snapshot
of this disk and because my session was
transferred to another tab i can now
close the terminal and you want to head
over to the left-hand menu and go to
disks and so now i want to show you two
ways on how you can create this snapshot
the first one is going to disks and
choosing the disk that you want for me
it's bowtie instance and under actions
i'm going to click on the hamburger menu
and here i can create snapshot and this
will bring me straight to my snapshot
menu but for this demo i'm going to go
over to the left hand menu and i'm going
to click on snapshots and here i'm going
to click on create snapshot and so for
the name of the snapshot i'm going to
type in bowtie snapshot and i'm going to
use the same for the description moving
down on the source disk the only one
that i can select is bow tie instance
and that's the one that i want anyways
so i'm going to click on that the
location in order to cut down on costs
we don't need multi-regional we're going
to just select regional and if you
select on the location i'm able to
select any other locations like tokyo
and i can create my snapshot in tokyo
but i want to keep my snapshot in the
same region so i'm going to go back and
select us east one where it is based on
the source disk location and i'm going
to add a label here with the key
environment and the value of testing i'm
going to leave my encryption type as
google managed and i'm going to simply
click on create and this will create a
snapshot of the boot disk on bow tie
instance and that took about a minute
there and so just as a note if you have
any bigger discs they will take a little
bit longer to snapshot okay and now that
i've created my snapshot i'm going to go
back up to vm instances and i'm going to
create a new instance from that snapshot
and so i'm going to name this instance
bowtie dash instance dash 2 and i'm
going to give this a label i'm going to
add a label here the key of environment
and the value of testing and hit save
the region is going to be used 1 and you
can leave the zone as its default as us
east 1b and under machine type you can
select the e2 micro and you want to go
down to boot disk and select the change
button and here i'm going to select
snapshots instead of using a public
image so i'm going to click on snapshots
and if i select the snapshot drop down
menu i will see here my bowtie snapshot
so i'm going to select this i'm going to
leave the rest as default and i'm going
to go down to select and i'm going to
leave everything else as its default and
i'm going to click on create i'm going
to just give it a minute here so bowtie
instance 2 can be created okay and it
took a minute there so now i'm going to
ssh into this instance
and i'm going to zoom in for better
viewing and even though i know the
instance is named bowtie.instance2
i'm still going to run the hostname
command and as expected the same name
pops up but what i was really curious
about is if i run the command ls space
dash al i can see here my file of file
of bowties.text
and if i cat the file
[Music]
i'll be able to see the text that i
inputted into that file and so although
it was only one file and a text file at
that i was able to verify that my
snapshot had worked as there will be
times where your snapshot can get
corrupted and so doing some various spot
checks on your snapshots is some good
common practice and so now i want to
create a snapshot schedule for both of
these instances and so i'm going to go
back to the console and on the left hand
menu i'm going to head down to snapshots
and if i go over to snapshot schedules
you can see that i have no snapshot
schedules so let's go ahead and create a
new one by clicking on create snapshot
schedule and so as mentioned in the last
lesson we need to create this schedule
first before we can attach it to a disk
and so i'm going to name this snapshot
schedule as bow tie dash disk schedule
i'm going to use the same for the
description the region i'm going to
select it as us east one and i'm going
to keep the snapshot location as
regional under us east one you scroll
down here and under schedule options you
can leave the schedule frequency as
daily and just as a note for start time
this time is measured in utc so please
remember this when you're creating your
schedule in your specific time zone and
so i'm going to put the start time as o
600 and this will be 1 am eastern
standard time as backups are always best
done when there is the least amount of
activity and i'm going to keep the auto
delete snapshots after 14 days i'm going
to keep the deletion rule as keep
snapshots as well i can enable the
volume shadow copy service for windows
but since we're running linux i don't
need to enable this and since we labeled
everything else i might as well give
this a label i'm going to use the key as
environment and the value of testing and
once you've filled everything out then
you can simply click on create and it
took a minute there but the schedule was
created and so now that i have my
snapshot schedule i need to attach it to
a disk so i'm going to head on over to
the left hand menu and click on disks
and here i'm going to drill down into
bow tie instance i'm going to go up to
the top and click on edit and under
snapshot schedule i'm going to click on
the drop down and here i will find bow
tie disk schedule i'm going to select
that i'm going to click on save and so
now that i have my snapshot schedule
attached to my disk for the bowtie
instance instance i now want to create a
snapshot schedule for my other instance
and so instead of using the console i'm
going to go ahead and do it through the
command line so i'm going to go up to
the top to my open shell and i'm going
to quickly clear the screen and so in
order to create my schedule i'm going to
run this command gcloud compute resource
policies create snapshot schedule the
name of the snapshot schedule which is
bow tie disk schedule 2 the region the
maximum retention days the retention
policy and the schedule followed by the
storage location and like i said before
these commands you will find in the
github repository so i'm going to go
ahead and hit enter
and so i wanted to leave this error in
here to show you that i needed the
proper permissions in order to create
this snapshot schedule a great reminder
to always check if you have the right
role for the task at hand and so i have
two options i can either change users
from my service account user to tony
bowtie or i can simply head on over to
my instance and edit the service account
permissions and so the easiest way to do
it would be to just switch users and so
i'm going to go ahead and do that so i'm
going to go ahead and run the command
gcloud auth login and remember that this
is something that you don't have to do i
merely wanted to show you that you
require the proper permissions on
creation of specific resources okay and
i quickly went through the
authentication process i'm gonna just
clear my screen and i'm going to go
ahead and run the command again
and as expected the snapshot schedule
was created with no errors and so now
that my schedule has been created i can
now attach it to the disk so i'm going
to run the command gcloud compute disks
add resource policies the instance name
which is bowtie instance 2 and the
resource policy which is the snapshot
schedule named as bowtie disk schedule 2
in the zone of us east 1b i'm going to
hit enter
and success and so just to verify that
the snapshot schedule has been attached
to my disk i'm going to go back to the
console i'm going to head back on over
to the main page of disks i'm going to
drill down into bow tie instance 2 and
here it is the snapshot schedule has
been attached and so i want to
congratulate you on making it to the end
of this demo and i hope this demo has
been useful as snapshots in the role of
an engineer is a common task that can
save you from any data loss once set
into place and so just as a recap you've
created an instance you created a file
on that instance and then you've created
a snapshot of the disk of that instance
and used it to create another instance
you then verified the snapshot and then
created a snapshot schedule for both
boot disks of the instances using the
console and the command line well done
on another great job now before you go i
wanted to take a moment to clean up any
resources we've used so we don't
accumulate any costs and so the first
thing we want to do is we want to detach
the snapshot schedules from the disks
and so since we're in bow tie instance 2
i'm going to go ahead and click on edit
under snapshot schedule i'm going to
select the no schedule hit save and i'm
going to do the same thing with my other
disk
now i'm going to head back on over to
snapshots i'm going to delete this
snapshot and i'm going to head back on
over to snapshot schedules i'm going to
select all the snapshot schedules and
i'm going to click on delete
and now that everything's cleaned up
with regards to snapshots and snapshot
schedules i can now go over to vm
instances and delete the instances
i'm going to select them all and simply
click on delete
and so that's pretty much all i wanted
to cover in this demo when it comes to
snapshots and snapshot schedules
so you can now mark this as complete and
let's move on to the next one
welcome back in this lesson we're going
to switch gears and take an automated
approach to deployment by diving into
google's tool for infrastructure as code
called deployment manager now deployment
manager allows you to deploy
update and tear down resources from
within google cloud using yaml jinja and
python code templates it allows you to
automate the deployment of all the
resources that are available in google
cloud and deploy it in a fast easy and
repeatable way for consistency and
efficiency in this lesson we're going to
explore the architecture of deployment
manager and dive into all the different
components that gives it its flexibility
and the features that make this tool an
easy solution for deploying complex
environments so with that being said
let's dive in
now breaking down the components that i
mentioned earlier i wanted to start off
with the first component being the
configuration now a configuration
defines the structure of your deployment
as you must specify a configuration to
create a deployment a configuration
describes all the resources you want for
a single deployment and is written in
yaml syntax that lists each of the
resources you want to create and its
respective resource properties a
configuration must contain a resources
section followed by the list of
resources to create and so each resource
must contain these three components the
name the type and properties without
these three components a deployment will
not instantiate and so i wanted to take
a moment to go over these three
components in a bit of depth so the
first component of the configuration is
the name and the name is a user defined
string to identify this resource and can
be anything you choose from names like
instance one my-vm
bowtie dash instance and you can even go
as far to use larks dash instance dash
don't dash touch and the syntax can be
found here and must not contain any
spaces or invalid characters next
component in a configuration is type and
there are a couple of different types
that you can choose from a type can
represent a single api source known as a
base type
or a set of resources known as a
composite type and either one of these
can be used to create part of your
deployment the type of the resource
being deployed here in this diagram is
shown as a base type of
compute.v1.instance
and there are many other api resources
that can be used such as compute.v1.disk
app engine dot v1 as well as
bigquery.v2 and the syntax is shown here
as api dot version dot resource now a
composite type contains one or more
templates that are pre-configured to
work together these templates expand to
a set of base types when deployed in a
deployment composite types are
essentially hosted templates that you
can add to deployment manager the syntax
is shown here as gcp dash types forward
slash provider colon resource and to
give you an example of what a composite
type looks like
here is shown the creation of a reserved
ip address using the compute engine v1
api and you could also use composite
types with other apis in the same way
such as gcp dash types forward slash app
engine dash v1 colon apps or bigquery
v2 colon data sets and for the last
component in a configuration is
properties and this is the parameters
for the resource type this includes all
the parameters you see here in this
example including the zone
machine type the type of disk along with
its parameters pretty much everything
that gives detail on the resource type
now just as a note they must match the
properties for this type so what do i
mean by this so let's say you entered a
zone but that particular zone doesn't
exist or that compute engine machine
type doesn't exist in that zone you will
end up getting an error as deployment
manager will not be able to parse this
configuration and thus failing
deployment so make sure when you add
your properties that they match those of
the resource now a configuration can
contain templates which are essentially
parts of the configuration file that
have been abstracted into individual
building blocks a template is a separate
file that is imported and used as a type
in a configuration and you can use as
many templates as you want in a
configuration and allow you to separate
your configuration out into different
pieces that you can use and reuse across
different deployments templates can be
as generalized or specific as you need
and they also allow you to take
advantage of features like template
properties environment variables and
modules to create dynamic configuration
as shown here templates can be written
in a couple of different ways they can
be written in either ginger 2.1 or
python 3. the example shown on the left
has been written in ginger and is very
similar to the yaml syntax so if you're
familiar with yaml this might be better
for you the example on the right has
been written in python and is pretty
amazing as you can take advantage of
programmatically generating parts of
your templates if you are familiar with
python this might be a better format for
you now one of the advantages of using
templates is the ability to create and
define custom template properties
template properties are arbitrary
variables that you define in template
files any configuration file or template
file that uses the template in question
can provide a value for the template
property without changing the template
directly this lets you abstract the
property so that you can change the
property's value for each unique
configuration without updating the
underlying template and just as a note
deployment manager creates predefined
environment variables that you can use
in your deployment in this example the
project variable will use the project id
for this specific project and so
combining all these components together
will give you a deployment and so a
deployment is a collection of resources
that are deployed and managed together
using a configuration you can then
deploy update or delete this deployment
by merely changing some code or at the
click of a button now when you deploy
you provide a valid configuration in the
request to create the deployment a
deployment can contain a number of
resources across a number of google
cloud services when you create a
deployment deployment manager creates
all of the described resources to deploy
a configuration it must be done through
the command line and cannot be done
through the console you can simply use
the syntax shown here and a deployment
will be instantiated from the
configuration file that you have entered
where bow tie deploy is the name of the
deployment and the file after the dash
dash config is your configuration file
google cloud also offers pre-defined
templates that you can use to deploy
from the gcp marketplace and can be
found right in the console of deployment
manager this way all the configuration
and template creation is handled for you
and you just deploy the solution through
the console now after you've created a
deployment you can update it whenever
you need to you can update a deployment
by adding or removing resources from a
deployment or updating the properties of
existing resources in a deployment a
single update can contain any
combination of these changes so you can
make changes to the properties of
existing resources and add new resources
in the same request you update your
deployment by first making changes to
your configuration file or you can
create a configuration file with the
changes you want you will then have the
option to pick the policies to use for
your updates or you can use the default
policies and finally you then make the
update request to deployment manager and
so once you've launched your deployment
each deployment has a corresponding
manifest as the example shown here a
manifest is a read-only property that
describes all the resources in your
deployment and is automatically created
with each new deployment manifests
cannot be modified after they have been
created as well it's not the same as a
configuration file but is created based
on the configuration file and so when
you delete a deployment all resources
that are part of the deployment are also
deleted if you want to delete specific
resources from your deployment and keep
the rest delete those resources from
your configuration file and update the
deployment instead
and so as you can see here deployment
manager gives you a slew of different
options to deploy update or delete
resources simultaneously in google cloud
now like most services in gcp there are
always some best practices to follow
note that there are many more best
practices to add to this and can be
found in the documentation which i will
be providing the link to in the lesson
text but i did want to point out some
important ones to remember so the first
one i wanted to bring up is to break
your configurations up into logical
units so for example you should create
separate configurations for networking
services security services and compute
services so this way each team will be
able to easily take care of their own
domain without having to sift through a
massive template containing the code to
the entire environment another best
practice to follow is to use references
and references should be used for values
that are not defined until a resource is
created such as resources self-link ip
address or system generated id without
references deployment manager creates
all resources in parallel so there's no
guarantee that dependent resources are
created in the correct order using
references would enforce the order in
which resources are created the next one
is to preview your deployments using the
preview flag so you should always
preview your deployments to assess how
making an update will affect your
deployment deployment manager does not
actually deploy resources when you
preview a configuration but runs a mock
deployment of those resources instead
this gives you the opportunity to see
the changes to your deployment before
committing to it you also want to
consider automating the creation of
projects as well as automating the
creation of resources contained within
the projects and this enables you to
adopt an infrastructure as code approach
for project provisioning this will allow
you to provide a series of predefined
project environments that can be quickly
and easily provisioned it will also
allow you to use version control to
manage your base project configuration
and it will also allow you to deploy
reproducible and consistent project
configurations and lastly using a
version control system as part of the
development process for your deployments
is a great best practice to follow as it
allows you to fall back to a previous
known good configuration it provides an
audit trail for changes as well it uses
the configuration as part of a
continuous deployment system now as
you've seen here in this lesson
deployment manager can be a powerful
tool in your tool belt when it comes to
implementing infrastructure as code and
it has endless possibilities that you
can explore on your own it can also
provide a massive push
towards devops practices and head down
the path of continuous automation
through continuous integration
continuous delivery and continuous
deployment and so that's pretty much all
i wanted to cover when it comes to
deployment manager and so whenever
you're ready join me in the next one
where we will go hands-on in a
demonstration to deploy a configuration
in deployment manager so you can now
mark this lesson as complete and
whenever you're ready join me in the
console
[Music]
welcome back in this demonstration we're
gonna go hands-on with deployment
manager and deploy a small web server
we're gonna first use the google cloud
editor to copy in our code and we're
gonna then do a dry run and then finally
deploy our code we're gonna then do a
walkthrough of deployment manager in the
console and go through the manifest as
well as some of the other features we're
then going to verify all the deployed
resources and we get to do an easy
cleanup in the end by hitting the delete
button and taking care of removing any
resources that were created so there's
quite a bit to go through here and so
with that being said let's dive in and
so as you can see here i am logged in as
tonybowties gmail.com in the project of
bowtie inc now since we're going to be
doing most of our work in code the first
thing that we want to do is go to the
google cloud editor so i'm going to go
up here to the top and open up cloud
shell and i'm going to then click on the
button open editor i'm going to make
this full screen for better viewing and
so in order to get the terminal in the
same viewing pane as the editor i'm
going to simply go up to the top menu
and click on terminal and select new
terminal now for better viewing and this
is totally optional for you i'm going to
change the color theme into a dark mode
and so i'm going to go up to the menu
click on file go down to settings and go
over to color theme and i'm going to
select dark visual studio and for those
of you who are working in visual studio
code this may look very familiar to you
and i'm also going to increase the font
size by again going back up to file over
to settings and then over to open
preferences here under workspace and
then scroll down to terminal
and if you scroll down to integrated
font size i'm going to adjust the font
size to 20 for better viewing and my
cloud shell font size is a little bit
easier to see and so once you've done
that you can then close the preferences
tab and we're now ready to create files
in our editor okay so next up i want to
create a folder for all my files to live
in so i'm going to go up to the menu
here i'm going to select on file and
select new folder and i'm going to
rename this folder as templates and hit
ok and so now that we have the folder
that all of our files are going to live
in the next step is to open up the
github repository in your text editor
and have your files ready to copy over
and so just as a note for those who are
fluent in how to use git
you can use this new feature in the
cloud shell editor to clone the course
repo without having to recreate the
files so i'm going to go over my text
editor and make sure that you've
recently done a git pull we're going to
open up the files under compute engine
deployment manager and you'll see
templates with a set of three files and
i've already conveniently opened them up
i'm going to go up to bow tie
deploy.yaml and this is going to be the
configuration file that i'm going to be
copying over and once i finish copying
all these files over i'll be going
through this in a little bit of detail
just so you can understand the format of
this configuration and so i'm going to
select all of this i'm going to copy
this head back on over to the editor and
here i'm going to select file new file
so i'm going to rename this as bow tie
dash deploy dot yaml hit okay and i'm
going to paste in my code and so this
configuration file is showing that i'm
going to be importing two templates by
the name of bowtie.webserver.jinja
as well as
bowtie.network.jinja so i'm going to
have a template for my web server and a
template for the network and under
resources as you can see this code here
will create my bow tie dash web server
the type is going to be the template the
properties will have the zone the
machine type as well as a reference for
the network as well underneath the
bowtie web server is the bowtie network
and again this is pulling from type
bowtie.network.jinja
so this is a another template file and
under the properties we have the region
of us east one and so we're going to
copy over these two templates bowtie web
server and bowtie network as we need
both of these templates in order to
complete this deployment and so i'm
going to go ahead and do that now head
back on over to my code editor i'm going
to go to bowtie web server i'm going to
copy everything here back to my editor
and i'm going to create the new file
called bowtie
web server it's going to be dot jinja
hit enter i'm going to paste the code in
and just to do a quick run through of
the template the instance name is going
to be bow tie dash website the type is
compute.v1.instance
and as you can see here we are using a
bunch of different properties here under
zone we have property zone which is
going to reference back to the yaml
template here under zone you will see us
east 1b and so this way if i have to
create another web server
i can enter whatever zone i like here in
the configuration file and leave the bow
tie dash web server template just the
way it is under machine type i have
variables set for both the zone and
machine type under disks i'm going to
have the device name as an environment
variable and it's going to be a
persistent disk and the source image is
going to be debian9 i also put in some
metadata here that will bring up the web
server and lastly i have a network tag
of http server as well as the
configuration for the network interface
the network referring to bowtie dash
network and a sub network called public
which i will be showing to you in just a
moment and as well the access configs of
the type one to one nat and this will
give the instance a public ip address
and so now that we've gone through that
template we need to create one last
template which is the bowtie dash
network so i'm going to head back on
over to my code editor and open up
bowtie network select the code copy it
back over to cloud editor and i'm going
to create a new file call this bowtie
network dot jinja hit enter paste in my
code and to quickly walk you through
this we're going to be creating a new
custom network called bow tie dash
network the type is going to be
compute.v1.network
as the vpc uses the compute engine api
it's going to be a custom network so the
value of the auto create sub networks is
going to be false the name is going to
be public here we have the custom
ipcider range and you can also use this
as a variable but for this demo i
decided to just leave it under network i
have a reference to the bowtie network
the value for private google access is
false and the region variable is
fulfilled through the configuration file
moving right along i have two firewall
rules here one for ssh access and the
other for web server access one opening
up port 22 to the world as well as port
80. as well the web server access
firewall rule has a target tag of http
server referencing back to the network
tag of the bowtie web server instance
okay and so now we've finished creating
the configuration file along with the
templates so i'm going to head back on
up to the menu click on file and select
save all and since we've finished
creating all of our files the next thing
to do is to execute a mock deploy using
the bowtie deploy configuration but
first i know that we haven't used
deployment manager before and so i need
to go in and turn on the api and so i'm
just going to go up here to the top to
the search bar and i'm going to type in
deployment and you should see deployment
manager as the first result and bring
this down a little bit and as expected
the deployment manager api has not been
enabled yet so i'm going to click on
enable and after a few moments we should
be good to go
okay and as you can see here deployment
manager is pretty empty
as most of it is done through the
command line but if you're looking to
deploy a marketplace solution you can do
that right here at the top and this will
bring you right to the marketplace and
will allow you to deploy from a large
selection of pre-configured templates
but i don't want to do that and so i'm
just going to bring this up a little bit
and i'm going to head on over to the
terminal i'm going to run an ls i'm
going to run the command ls and you
should be able to see the templates
folder i'm going to change my directory
into the templates folder do another ls
and here are all my files and so before
we do a mock deploy of this
configuration we want to make sure that
we're deploying to the correct project i
can see here that i am currently in bow
tie inc but if you are ever unsure about
the project that you're in you can
always run the gcloud config list
command in order to confirm so i'm going
to quickly clear my screen and i'm going
to run the command gcloud config list
it's going to prompt me to authorize
this api call and i'm going to authorize
and as expected my project is set to
deploy in project bowtie inc and so now
that i've verified it i'm going to
quickly clear my screen again and so i'm
going to paste in my command gcloud
deployment dash manager deployments
create bowtie deploy which is the name
of the deployment along with the
configuration file flag dash dash config
and then the name of the configuration
file which is bowtie
deploy.yaml and the preview flag as
we're only doing a mock deploy and so if
there are any errors i'll be able to see
this before i actually deploy all the
resources so i'm going to go ahead and
hit enter and in just a minute we'll
find out exactly what happens
and as you can see here the mock
deployment was a success and there are
no errors and if i do a quick refresh up
here in the console i'll be able to see
my deployment which i can drill down
into and here i will see my manifest
file with my manifest name and i can
view the config as well as my templates
that it imported the layout as well as
the expanded config so if i click on
view of the config it'll show me here in
the right hand panel exactly what this
deployment has used for the config and i
can do the same thing with my template
files so i'm going to open up my network
template and i can quickly go through
that if i'd like as well i also have the
option to download it and if i really
want to get granular i can go over here
to the left hand pane i can select on vm
instance and it'll show me all the
resource properties everything from the
disks to the machine type to the
metadata the network interfaces the zone
that it's in and the network tag same
thing if i go over here to the network
and again because this is a custom
network the value for the autocreate
subnetworks is false i can check on the
public sub network as well as the
firewall rules and so because this is a
preview it has not actually deployed
anything now taking a look at compute
engine instances in a new tab you can
see here that i have no instances
deployed and so the same goes for any of
the other resources and so what we want
to do now is we want to deploy this
deployment and we can do that one of two
ways we can simply click on the button
here that says deploy or we can run the
command in the command line and so i'm
looking to show you how to do it in the
command line so i'm going to move down
to the command line i'm going to quickly
clear my screen
i'm going to paste in the code which is
gcloud deployment dash manager
deployments update bowtie deploy now
you're probably wondering why update and
this is because the configuration has
been deployed even though it's a preview
deployment manager still sees it as a
deployment and has created what google
cloud calls a shell and so by using
update you can fully deploy the
configuration using your last preview to
perform that update and this will deploy
your resources exactly how you see it in
the manifest and so anytime i make an
adjustment to either the configuration
or the templates i can simply run the
update command instead of doing the
whole deployment again so i want to get
this deployed now and so i'm going to
hit enter
and i'll be back in a minute once it's
deployed all the resources and success
my deployment is successful and as you
can see here there are no errors and all
the resources are in a completed state
so i'm going to select my bow tie
website in my manifest and i'll have
access to the resource with a link up
here at the top that will bring me to
the instance as well i can ssh into the
instance and i have all the same options
that i have in the compute engine
console and so in order to verify that
all my resources have been deployed i'm
going to go back over to the tab that i
already have open and as you can see my
instance has been deployed and i want to
check to see if my network has been
deployed so i'm going to go up to the
navigation menu and i'm going to head on
down to vpc network and as you can see
here bowtie network has been deployed
with its two corresponding firewall
rules i'm going to drill down into
bowtie network and check out the
firewall rules and as you can see here
ssh access and web server access have
been created with its corresponding
protocols and ports and so now that i
know that all my resources have been
deployed i want to head back on over to
compute engine to see if my instance has
been configured properly so i'm going to
click on ssh to see if i can ssh into
the instance and success with ssh so i
know that this is working properly and
so i'm going to close this tab down and
i also want to see whether or not my web
server has been configured properly with
the metadata that i provided it and so i
can directly open up the webpage by
simply clicking on this link and success
my you look dapper today why thank you
tony bowtie and so as you can see the
web server has been configured properly
using the metadata that i provided so i
wanted to congratulate you on making it
to the end of this demo and hope it has
been extremely useful and gave you an
understanding of how infrastructure is
code is used in google cloud using their
native tools i hope this also triggered
some possible use cases for you that
will allow you to automate more
resources and configurations in your
environment and allow you to start
innovating on fantastic new ways for
cicd for those of you who are familiar
with infrastructure as code this may
have been a refresher but will give you
some insight for questions on the exam
that cover deployment manager and just
as a quick note for those of you who are
looking to learn more about
infrastructure as code i have put a few
links in the lesson text going into
depth on deployment manager and another
tool that google recommends called
terraform and so now before you go we
want to clean up all the resources that
we've deployed to reduce any incurred
costs and because deployment manager
makes it easy we can do it in one simple
step so i'm going to head back on over
to my open tab where i have my console
open to deployment manager and i'm going
to head on over to the delete button and
simply click on delete now deployment
manager gives me the option of deleting
all the resources it created or simply
deleting the manifest but keeping the
resources untouched and so you want to
select delete bowtie deploy with all of
its resources and simply click on delete
all and this will initiate the teardown
of all the resources that have been
deployed from the bowtie deploy
configuration and this will take a few
minutes to tear down but if you ever
have a larger configuration to deploy
just as a note it may take a little bit
longer to both deploy and to tear down
and so just as a recap you've created a
configuration file and two templates in
the cloud shell editor you then deployed
your configuration using deployment
manager through the command line in
cloud shell you then verified each
individual resource that was deployed
and verified the configuration of each
resource congratulations again on a job
well done and so that's pretty much all
i wanted to cover in this demo when it
comes to deploying resources using
deployment manager so you can now mark
this as complete and let's move on to
the next one
[Music]
welcome back and in this lesson we're
going to learn about google cloud load
balancing and how it's used to
distribute traffic within the google
cloud platform google cloud load
balancing is essential when using it
with instance groups kubernetes clusters
and is pretty much the defacto when it
comes to balancing traffic coming in as
well as within your gcp environment
knowing the differences between the
types of load balancers and which one to
use for specific scenarios is crucial
for the exam as you will be tested on it
and so there's a lot to cover here so
with that being said let's dive in now i
wanted to start off with some basics
with regards to what is low balancing
and so when it comes to the low balancer
itself a low balancer distributes user
traffic across multiple instances of
your application so by spreading the
load you reduce the risk of your
applications experiencing performance
issues a load balancer is a single point
of entry with either one or multiple
back ends and within gcp these back ends
could consist of either instance groups
or negs and i'll be getting into any g's
in just a little bit low balancers on
gcp are fully distributed and software
defined so there is no actual hardware
load balancer involved in low balancing
on gcp it is completely software defined
and so there's no need to worry about
any hardware any pre-warming time as
this is all done through software now
depending on which low balancer you
choose google cloud gives you the option
of having either a global load balancer
or a regional load balancer the load
balancers are meant to serve content as
close as possible to the users so that
they don't experience increased latency
and gives the users a better experience
as well as reducing latency on your
applications when dealing with low
balancers in between services google
cloud also offers auto scaling with
health checks in their load balancers to
make sure that your traffic is always
routed to healthy instances and by using
auto scaling able to scale up the amount
of instances you need in order to handle
the load automatically now as there are
many different low balancers to choose
from it helps to know what specific
aspects you're looking for and how you
want your traffic distributed and so
google has broken them down for us into
these three categories the first
category is global versus regional
global load balancing is great for when
your back ends are distributed across
multiple regions
and your users need access to the same
applications and content
using a single anycast ip address
as well when you're looking for ipv6
termination global load balancing will
take care of that now when it comes to
regional load balancing this is if
you're looking at serving your back ends
in a single region and handling only
ipv4 traffic now once you've determined
whether or not you need global versus
regional low balancing the second
category to dive into is external versus
internal external load balancers are
designed to distribute traffic coming
into your network from the internet
and internal load balancers are designed
to distribute traffic within your
network and finally the last category
that will help you decide on what type
of load balancer you need is the traffic
type and shown here are all the traffic
types that cover http https tcp and udp
and so now that we've covered the
different types of load balancing that's
available on google cloud i wanted to
dive into some more depth on the low
balancers themselves here you can see
that there are five load balancers
available and i will be going through
each one of these in detail now before
diving into the low balancers themselves
i wanted to introduce you to a concept
using gcp
for all load balancers called back end
services how a low balancer knows
exactly what to do is defined by a
backend service and this is how cloud
load balancing knows how to distribute
the traffic the backend service
configuration contains a set of values
such as the protocol used to connect to
back ends various distribution in
session settings health checks and
timeouts these settings provide fine
grain control over how your load
balancer behaves an external http or
https load balancer must have at least
one backend service and can have
multiple backend services the back ends
of a backend service can be either
instance groups or network endpoint
groups also known as negs but not a
combination of both and so just as a
note you'll hear me refer to negs over
the course of this lesson and so a
network endpoint group also known as neg
is a configuration object that specifies
a group of back-end endpoints or
services and a common use case for this
configuration is deploying services into
containers now moving on to the values
themselves i wanted to first start with
health checks and google cloud uses the
overall health state of each back end to
determine its eligibility for receiving
new requests or connections back ends
that respond successfully for the
configured number of times are
considered healthy back-ends that fail
to respond successfully for a separate
number of times are considered unhealthy
and when a back-end is considered
unhealthy traffic will not be routed to
it next up is session affinity and
session affinity sends all requests from
the same client to the same back end if
the back end is healthy and it has
capacity service timeout is the next
value and this is the amount of time
that the load balancer waits for a
backend to return a full response to a
request next up is traffic distribution
and this comprises of three different
values the first one is a balancing mode
and this defines how the load balancer
measures back-end readiness for the new
requests or connections the second one
is target capacity and this defines a
target maximum number of connections a
target maximum rate or target maximum
cpu utilization and the third value for
traffic distribution is capacity scalar
and this adjusts overall available
capacity without modifying the target
capacity and the last value for back-end
services are back-ends and a back-end is
a group of endpoints that receive
traffic from a google cloud load
balancer and there are several types of
back-ends but the one that we are
concentrating on for this section and
for the exam is the instance group now
backend services are not critical to
know for the exam but i wanted to
introduce you to this concept to add a
bit more context for when you are
creating low balancers in any
environment
and will help you understand other
concepts in this lesson and so this is
the end of part one of this lesson it
was getting a bit long so i decided to
break it up this would be a great
opportunity for you to get up and have a
stretch get yourself a coffee or tea and
whenever you're ready join me in part
two where we will be starting
immediately from the end of part one so
you can now complete this video and i
will see you in part two
this is part two of the cloud load
balancers lesson and we'll be starting
exactly where we left off in part one so
with that being said let's dive in now
before jumping right into the first load
balancer that i wanted to introduce
which is http and https low balancer
there's a couple of different concepts
that i wanted to introduce and these are
the methods of how an http and https
load balancer distributes traffic using
forwarding rules and these are cross
region low balancing and content based
load balancing now touching on cross
region load balancing when you configure
an external http or https load balancer
in premium tier it uses a global
external ip address and can
intelligently route requests from users
to the closest backend instance group or
neg based on proximity for example if
you set up instance groups in north
america and europe and attach them to a
low balancers back-end service user
requests around the world are
automatically sent to the vms closest to
the users assuming that the vms pass
health checks and have enough capacity
if the closest vms are all unhealthy or
if the closest instance group is at
capacity and another instance group is
not at capacity the load balancer
automatically sends requests to the next
closest region that has available
capacity and so here in this diagram a
user in switzerland hits the low
balancer by going to bowtieinc.co and
because there are vms that are able to
serve that traffic in europe west 6
traffic is routed to that region and so
now getting into content based load
balancing http and https low balancing
supports content based load balancing
using url maps to select a backend
service based on the requested host name
request path or both for example you can
use a set of instance groups or negs to
handle your video content and another
set to handle static as well as another
set to handle any images you can also
use http or https low balancing with
cloud storage buckets and then after you
have your load balancer set up you can
add cloud storage buckets to it now
moving right along when it comes to http
and https load balancer this is a global
proxy based layer 7 low balancer which
is at the application layer and so just
as a note here with all the other low
balancers that are available in gcp the
http and https low balancer is the only
layer 7 load balancer all the other low
balancers in gcp are layer 4 and will
work at the network layer and so this
low balancer enables you to serve your
applications worldwide behind a single
external unicast ip address external
http and https load balancing
distributes http and https traffic to
back ends hosted on compute engine and
gke external http and https load
balancing is implemented on google front
ends or gfes as shown here in the
diagram gfes are distributed globally
and operate together using google's
global network and control plane in the
premium tier gfes offer cross-regional
low balancing directing traffic to the
closest healthy backend that has
capacity and terminating http and https
traffic as close as possible to your
users with the standard tier the load
balancing is handled regionally and this
load balancer is available to be used
both externally and internally that
makes this load balancer global external
and internal this load balancer also
gives support for https and ssl which
covers tls for encryption in transit as
well this load balancer accepts all
traffic whether it is ipv4 or ipv6
traffic and just know that ipv6 traffic
will terminate at the low balancer and
then it will forward traffic as ipv4 so
it doesn't really matter which type of
traffic you're sending the load balancer
will still send the traffic to the back
end using ipv4 this traffic is
distributed by location or by content as
shown in the previous diagram forwarding
rules are in place to distribute defined
targets to each target pool for the
instance groups again defined targets
could be content based and therefore as
shown in the previous diagram video
content could go to one target whereas
static content could go to another
target url maps direct your requests
based on rules so you can create a bunch
of rules depending on what type of
traffic you want to direct and put them
in maps for requests ssl certificates
are needed for https and these can be
either google managed or self-managed
and so just as a quick note here the
ports used for http are on 80 and 8080
as well on https the port that is used
is port 443 now moving into the next low
balancer is ssl proxy an ssl proxy low
balancing is a reverse proxy load
balancer that distributes ssl traffic
coming from the internet to your vm
instances when using ssl proxy load
balancing for your ssl traffic user ssl
connections are terminated at the low
balancing layer and then proxied to the
closest available backend instances by
either using ssl or tcp with the premium
tier ssl proxy low balancing can be
configured as a global load balancing
service with the standard tier the ssl
proxy load balancer handles low
balancing regionally this load balancer
also distributes traffic by location
only ssl proxy low balancing lets you
use a single ip address for all users
worldwide and is a layer 4 load balancer
which works on the network layer this
load balancer shows support for tcp with
ssl offload and this is something
specific to remember for the exam this
is not like the http or https load
balancer where we can use specific rules
or specific configurations in order to
direct traffic ssl proxy low balancer
supports both ipv4 and ipv6 but again it
does terminate at the load balancer and
forwards the traffic to the back end as
ipv4 traffic and forwarding rules are in
place to distribute each defined target
to its proper target pool and encryption
is supported by configuring back-end
services to accept all the traffic over
ssl now just as a note it can also be
used for other protocols that use ssl
such as web sockets and imap over ssl
and carry a number of open ports to
support them moving on to the next load
balancer is tcp proxy now the tcp proxy
load balancer is a reverse proxy load
balancer that distributes tcp traffic
coming from the internet to your vm
instances when using tcp proxy load
balancing traffic coming over a tcp
connection is terminated at the load
balancing layer and then forwarded to
the closest available backend using tcp
or ssl so this is where the low balancer
will determine which instances are at
capacity and send them to those
instances that are not like ssl proxy
load balancing tcp proxy load balancing
lets you use a single ip address for all
users worldwide the tcp proxy load
balancer automatically routes traffic to
the back ends that are closest to the
user this is a layer 4 load balancer and
again can serve traffic both globally
and externally tcp proxy distributes
traffic by location only and is intended
for specifically non-http traffic
although you can decide if you want to
use ssl between the proxy and your back
end and you can do this by selecting a
certificate on the back end again this
type of load balancer supports ipv4 and
ipv6 traffic and ipv6 traffic will
terminate at the low balancer and
forwards that traffic to the back end as
ipv4 traffic now tcp proxy low balancing
is intended for tcp traffic and supports
many well-known ports such as port 25
for simple mail transfer protocol or
smtp next up we have the network load
balancer now the tcp udp network load
balancer is a regional pass-through load
balancer a network load balancer
distributes tcp or udp traffic among
instances in the same region network
load balancers are not proxies and
therefore responses from the back end
vms go directly to the clients
not back through the load balancer the
term known for this is direct server
return as shown here in the diagram this
is a layer 4 regional load balancer and
an external load balancer as well that
can serve to regional locations it
supports either tcp or udp but not both
although it can low balance udp tcp and
ssl traffic on the ports that are not
supported by the tcp proxy and ssl proxy
ssl traffic can still be decrypted by
your back end instead of the load
balancer itself traffic is also
distributed by incoming protocol data
this being protocols scheme and scope
there is no tls offloading or proxying
and forwarding rules are in place to
distribute and define targets to their
target pools and this is for tcp and udp
only now with other protocols they use
target instances as opposed to instance
groups lastly a network load balancer
can also only support
self-managed ssl certificates as opposed
to the google managed certificates as
well and so the last low balancer to
introduce is the internal load balancer
now an internal tcp or udp load balancer
is a layer 4 regional load balancer that
enables you to distribute traffic behind
an internal load balancing ip address
that is accessible only to your internal
vm instances internal tcp and udp load
balancing distributes traffic among vm
instances in the same region this load
balancer supports tcp or udp traffic but
not both and as i said before this type
of load balancer is used to balance
traffic within gcp across instances this
low balancer cannot be used for
balancing internet traffic as it is
internal only traffic is automatically
sent to the back end as it does not
terminate client connections and for
forwarding rules this load balancer
follows specific specifications where
you need to specify at least one and up
to five ports by number as well you must
specify all to forward traffic to all
ports now again like the network load
balancer you can use either tcp or udp
and so that's pretty much all i had to
cover with this lesson on low balancing
please remember that for the exam you
will need to know the differences
between them all
in my experience there are a few
questions that come up on the exam where
you will need to know what low balancer
to use and so a good idea might be to
dive into the console and have a look at
the options as well as going back
through this lesson as a refresher to
understand each use case this is also a
crucial component in any environment
that is used especially when serving
applications to the internet for any
three-tier web application or kubernetes
cluster and so that pretty much sums up
this lesson on low balancing so you can
now mark this lesson as complete and
let's move on to the next one
welcome back in this lesson i will be
going into depth on instance groups
along with instance templates instance
groups are a great way to set up a group
of identical servers used in conjunction
with instance groups instance templates
handles the instance properties to
deploy the instance groups into your
environment this lesson will dive into
the details of the features use cases
and how instance groups and instance
templates work together to create a
highly scalable and performing
environment now there's a lot to cover
here so with that being said let's dive
in now an instance group is a collection
of vm instances that you can manage as a
single entity compute engine offers two
kinds of vm instance groups managed and
unmanaged manage instance groups or migs
let you operate applications on multiple
identical vms you can make your workload
scalable and highly available by taking
advantage of automated mig services like
auto scaling auto healing regional and
zonal deployments and automatic updating
and i'll be getting into these services
in just a sec now when it comes to
unmanaged instance groups they also let
you low balance across a fleet of vms
but this is something that you need to
manage and i'll be going deeper into
unmanaged instance groups a bit later
right now i wanted to take some time to
go through the features and use cases of
migs in a bit more detail for some more
context starting off with its use cases
now migs are great for stateless serving
workloads such as website front ends web
servers and website applications as the
application does not preserve its state
and saves no data to persistent storage
all user and session data stays with the
client and makes scaling up and down
quick and easy migs are also great for
stateless batch workloads and these are
high performance or high throughput
compute workloads such as image
processing from a queue and lastly you
can build highly available stateful
workloads using stateful managed
instance groups or stateful migs
stateful workloads include applications
with stateful data or configuration such
as databases
legacy monolith type applications and
long running batch computations with
checkpointing you can improve uptime and
resiliency of these types of
applications with auto healing
controlled updates and multi-zone
deployments while preserving each
instance's unique state including
instance names persistent disks and
metadata now that i've covered the type
of workloads that are used with migs i
wanted to dive into the features
starting with auto healing
now when it comes to auto healing
managed instance groups maintain high
availability of your applications by
proactively keeping your instances in a
running state a mig automatically
recreates an instance that is not
running and managed instance groups also
take care of application-based auto
healing and this improves application
availability by relying on a health
check that detects things like freezing
crashing or overloading if a health
check determines that an application has
failed on a vm the mig auto healer
automatically recreates that vm instance
the health check used to monitor the
migs are similar to the health checks
used for low balancing with a few little
differences low balancing health checks
help direct traffic away from
unresponsive instances and towards
healthy ones these health checks cannot
recreate instances whereas mig health
checks proactively signal to delete and
recreate instances that become unhealthy
moving on to managed instance groups
regional or multi-zone feature now you
have the option of creating regional
migs or zonal migs
regional migs provide higher
availability compared to zonal migs
because the instances in a regional mig
are spread across multiple zones in a
single region google recommends regional
migs over zonal migs as you can manage
twice as many migs as zonal migs so you
can manage 2 000 migs instead of 1000
you can also spread your application
load across multiple zones instead of a
single zone or managing multiple zonal
migs across different zones and this
protects against zonal failures and
unforeseen scenarios where an entire
group of instances in a single zone
malfunctions in the case of a zonal
failure or if a group of instances in a
zone stops responding a regional mig
continues supporting your instances by
continuing to serve traffic to the
instances in the remaining zones now
cloud low balancing can use instance
groups to serve traffic so you can add
instance groups to a target pool or to a
back end an instance group is a type of
back end and the instances in the
instance group respond to traffic from
the load balancer the back end service
in turn knows which instances it can use
and how much traffic they can handle and
how much traffic they are currently
handling in addition the back-end
service monitors health checking and
does not send new connections to
unhealthy instances now when your
applications require additional compute
resources migs support auto scaling that
dynamically add or remove instances from
the mig in response to an increase or
decrease in load you can turn on auto
scaling and configure an auto scaling
policy to specify how you want the group
to scale not only will auto scaling
scale up to meet the load demands but
will also shrink and remove instances as
the load decreases to reduce your costs
auto scaling policies include scaling
based on cpu utilization load balancing
capacity and cloud monitoring metrics
and so when it comes to auto updating
you can easily and safely deploy new
versions of software to instances in a
mig the rollout of an update happens
automatically based on your
specifications you can also control the
speed and scope of the deployments in
order to minimize disruptions to your
application you can optionally perform
rolling updates as well as partial
rollouts for canary testing and for
those who don't know rolling updates
allow updates to take place with zero
downtime by incrementally updating
instances with new ones as well canary
testing is a way to reduce risk and
validate new software by releasing
software to a small percentage of users
with canary testing you can deliver to
certain groups of users at a time and
this is also referred to as stage
rollouts and this is a best practice in
devops and software development now
there are a few more things that i
wanted to point out that relate to migs
you can reduce the cost of your workload
by using preemptable vm instances in
your instance group and when they are
deleted auto healing will bring the
instances back when preemptable capacity
becomes available again you can also
deploy containers to instances in
managed instance groups when you specify
a container image in an instance
template and is used to create a mig
each vm is created with the container
optimized os that includes docker and
your container starts automatically on
each vm in the group and finally when
creating migs you must define the vpc
network that it will reside in although
when you don't define the network google
cloud will attempt to use the default
network now moving on into unmanaged
instance groups for just a minute
unmanaged instance groups can contain
heterogeneous instances and these are
instances that are of mixed sizes of cpu
ram as well as instance types and you
can add and remove these instances from
the group whenever you choose there's a
major downside to this though unmanaged
instance groups do not offer auto
scaling auto healing rolling update
support multi-zone support or the use of
instance templates and are not a good
fit for deploying highly available and
scalable workloads you should only use
unmanaged instance groups if you need to
apply load balancing to groups of these
mixed types of instances or if you need
to manage the instances yourself so
unmanaged instance groups are designed
for very special use cases where you
will need to mix instance types in
almost all cases you will be using
managed instance groups as they were
intended to capture the benefits of all
the features they have to offer
now in order to launch an instance group
into any environment you will need
another resource to do this and this is
where instance templates come into play
an instance template is a resource that
you can use to create vm instances and
managed instance groups instance
templates define the machine type boot
disk image or container image as well as
labels and other instance properties you
can then use an instance template to
create a mig or vm instance instance
templates are an easy way to save a vm
instances configuration so you can use
it later to recreate vms or groups of
vms an instance template
is a global resource that is not bound
to a zone or region although you can
restrict a template to a zone by calling
out specific zonal resources now there
is something to note for when you are
ever using migs if you want to create a
group of identical instances you must
use an instance template to create a mig
and is something you should always keep
in the front of mind when using migs
these two resources both instance
templates and managed instance groups go
hand in hand now some other things to
note is that instance templates are
designed to create instances with
identical configurations so you cannot
update an existing instance template or
change an instance template after you
create it if you need to make changes to
the configuration
create a new instance template you can
create a template based on an existing
instance template or based on an
existing instance to use an existing vm
to make a template you can save the
configuration using the gcloud command
gcloud instance dash templates create or
to use the console you can simply go to
the instance templates page click on the
template that you want to update and
click on create similar the last thing
that i wanted to point out is that you
can use custom or public images in your
instance templates and so that's pretty
much all i had to cover when it comes to
instance groups and instance templates
managed instance groups are great for
when you're looking at high availability
as a priority and letting migs do all
the work of keeping your environment up
and running and so you can now mark this
lesson as complete and whenever you're
ready join me in the next one where we
go hands-on with instance groups
instance templates and load balancers in
a demo
welcome back in this demo we're going to
put everything that we've learned
together in a hands-on demo called
managing bow ties we're going to create
an instance template and next we're
going to use it to create an instance
group we're then going to create a low
balancer with a new back end and create
some health checks along the way we're
then going to verify that all instances
are working by browsing to the load
balancer ip and verifying the website
application we're then going to stress
test one of the instances to simulate a
scale out using auto scaling and then
we're going to simulate scaling the
instance group back in now there's quite
a bit to do here so with that being said
let's dive in so here i am logged in as
tony bowties at gmail.com under project
bowtie inc and so the first thing that
you want to do is you want to make sure
that you have a default vpc network
already created and so just to double
check i'm going to go over to the
navigation menu i'm going to scroll down
to vpc network
and yes i do have a default vpc network
so i'm going to go ahead and start
creating my resources and so now what i
want to do is i want to create my
instance template and so in order to do
that i'm going to go back up to the
navigation menu i'm going to go down to
compute engine and go up to instance
templates as you can see i currently
have no instance templates and yours
should look the same and so you can go
ahead and click on create instance
template and so just as a note there are
no monthly costs associated with
instance templates but this estimate
here on the right is to show you the
cost of each instance you will be
creating with this template okay so
getting right into it i'm going to name
this instance template
bowtie template and since we're spinning
up a lot of vms you want to be conscious
on costs and so under series you're
going to click on the drop down and
you're going to select n1 and under
machine type you're going to select f1
micro and this is the smallest instance
type as well as the cheapest within
google cloud you can go ahead and scroll
down right to the bottom here under
firewall you want to check off allow
http traffic next you want to select
management security disks networking and
sold tenancy you scroll down a little
bit and under startup script you're
going to paste in the script that's
available in the repo and you will find
a link to this script and the repo in
the lesson text and so you can leave all
the other options as its default and
simply click on create it's going to
take a couple minutes here okay and the
instance template is ready and so the
next step that you want to do is create
an instance group and as i said in a
previous lesson in order to create an
instance group you need an instance
template hence why we made the instance
template first okay and our instance
template has been created and so now
that you've created your instance
template you can head on over to
instance groups here in the left hand
menu and as expected there are no
instance groups and so you can go ahead
and click on the big blue button and
create an instance group you're going to
make sure that new managed instance
group stateless is selected and here you
have the option of choosing a stateful
instance group as well as an unmanaged
instance group and so we're going to
keep things stateless and so for the
name of the instance group you can
simply call this bowtie group i'm going
to use the same name in the description
and under location you want to check off
multiple zones in under region you want
to select us east one and if you click
on configure zones you can see here that
you can select all the different zones
that's available in that region that you
choose to have your instances in and so
i'm going to keep it under all three
zones i'm going to scroll down here a
little bit and under instance template
you should see bow tie template you can
select that you can scroll down a little
bit more and here under minimum number
of instances you want to set the minimum
number of instances to 3 and under
maximum number of instances you want to
set that to 6 and so this is going to be
double the amount of the minimum number
of instances so when you're scaled out
you should have a maximum of 6 instances
and when you're scaled in or you have
very low traffic you should only have
three instances so you can scroll down
some more and under auto healing you
want to select the health check and
you're going to go ahead and create a
new health check under name you can call
this healthy bow ties i'm going to use
the same for the description and i'm
going to leave the rest as its default
and go down and click on save and
continue i'm going to scroll down some
more and i'm going to leave the rest as
is and simply click on create and it's
going to take a couple minutes here and
so i'm going to pause the video and i'll
be back in a flash okay and my instance
group has been created and so to get a
better look at it i'm going to click on
bow tie group and i can see here that
three instances have been created if i
go up to vm instances you can see here
that i have three instances but under
instance groups because i have health
check enabled it shows that my instances
are unhealthy and this is because i
still need to create a firewall rule
that will allow google's health check
probes to reach my vm instances and so
you're going to go ahead and create that
firewall rule so you can bring the
health check status up to healthy so i'm
going to go over to the navigation menu
and scroll down to vpc network and go
over to firewall here under firewall as
expected you have the default firewall
rules from the default created vpc
network and so i'm going to go up to
create firewall and you can name this
firewall rule allow health check i'm
going to use the same for the
description i'm going to scroll down
here a little bit and under targets i'm
going to select all instances in the
network source filter i'm going to leave
as i p ranges and so here under source i
p ranges i want to enter in the ip
addresses for the google cloud health
check probes and you can find these in
the documentation and i will also be
supplying them in the instructions and
there are two sets of ip addresses that
need to be entered and just as a note
you don't need to know this for the exam
but it's always a good to know if you're
ever adding health checks to any of your
instances i'm going to scroll down a
little bit to protocols and ports and
under tcp i'm going to check it off and
put in port 80. that's pretty much all
you have to do here so whenever you
entered all that information in you can
simply click on create and so now i have
a firewall rule that will allow health
checks to be done and so it may take a
minute or two but if i head back on over
to my compute engine instances and go
over to my instance groups
i'll be able to see that all my
instances are now healthy and so
whenever you're creating instance groups
and you're applying health checks this
firewall rule is necessary so please be
aware okay so now that we've created our
instance templates we've created our
instance groups and we created a
firewall rule in order to satisfy health
checks we can now move on to the next
step which is creating the load balancer
so i'm going to go back up to the
navigation menu and i'm going to scroll
down to network services and over to
load balancing and as expected there are
no load balancers created and so
whenever you're ready you can click on
the big blue button and create a new low
balancer here you have the option of
creating an http or https load balancer
along with a tcp load balancer or a udp
load balancer and because we're serving
external traffic on port 80 we're going
to use the http load balancer so you can
click on start configuration and i'm
being prompted to decide between
internet facing or internal only and
you're going to be accepting traffic
from the internet to your load bouncer
so make sure that from internet to my
vms is checked off and simply click
continue and so next you will be
prompted with a page with a bunch of
configurations that you can enter and so
we'll get to that in just a second but
first we need to name our load balancer
and so i'm going to call this
bowtie dash lb for low balancer and so
next step for your load balancer is you
need to configure a back end so you can
click on back end configuration and here
you have the option of selecting from
back-end services or back-end buckets so
you're going to go ahead and click on
back-end services and create a back-end
service and here you will be prompted
with a bunch of fields to fill out in
order to create your back-end service
and you can go ahead and name the
backend service as bowtie backend
service back-end type is going to be
instance group and you can leave the
protocol named port and timeout as is as
we're going to be using http under
instance group in new back-end if you
select the drop-down you should see your
available bow tie group instance group
select that
scroll down a little bit and under port
numbers you can enter in port 80 and you
can leave all the other options as
default and simply click on done and so
if you're ever interested you can always
add a cache using cloud cdn now i know
we haven't gone through cloud cdn in
this course but just know that this is
google's content delivery network and it
uses google's global edge network to
serve content closer to users and this
accelerates your websites and your
applications and delivers a better user
experience for your user okay and moving
on here under health check if i click on
the drop down you should see healthy bow
ties you can select that for your health
check and so just as a note here under
advanced configurations you can set your
session affinity your connection
draining timeout as well as request and
response headers and so we don't need
any of that for this demo and so i'm
going to go ahead and collapse this and
once you've finished filling in all the
fields you can simply click on create
okay and so you should now have your
back end configuration and your host and
path rules configured and so the only
thing that's left to configure is the
front end so you can go up and click on
front-end configuration and you can name
your front-end bowtie front-end service
gonna keep the protocols http and here
is where you would select the network
service tier choosing either premium or
standard and if you remember in the load
balancing lesson in order to use this as
a global load balancer i need to use a
premium tier okay and we're going to
keep this as ipv4 with an ephemeral ip
address on port 80 so once you've
finished configuring the front end you
can simply click on done and you can go
and click on review and finalize and
this will give you a summary on your
configuration and so i'm happy with the
way everything's configured and if you
are as well you can simply click on
create and this may take a minute or two
but it will create your low balancer
along with your back end and your front
end so again i'm going to pause the
video here for just a minute and i'll be
back before you can say cat in the hat
okay and my load balancer has been
created and to get a little bit more
details i'm going to drill down into it
and i can see here the details of my
load balancer along with my monitoring
and any caching but i don't have any
caching enabled and therefore nothing is
showing so going back to the details i
can see here that i have a new ip
address for my load balancer and i'll be
getting into that in just a minute i'm
going to go back here and i'm going to
check out my back ends click on bow tie
back end service and here i can see the
requests per second as well as my
configuration and if you do see this
caution symbol here showing that some of
your instances are unhealthy it's only
because the low balancer needs time to
do a full health check on all the
instances in the instance group and so
this will take some time okay and so i'm
going to go back over and check out my
front end and there's nothing to drill
down into with the front end service but
it does show me my scope the address the
protocol
network tier and the low balancer itself
so this is the end of part one of this
demo it was getting a bit long so i
decided to break it up this would be a
great opportunity for you to get up have
a stretch get yourself a coffee or tea
and whenever you're ready part two will
be starting immediately from the end of
part one so you can now mark this as
complete and i'll see you in part two
this is part two of the managing bow
ties demo and we will be starting
exactly where we left off in part one so
with that being said let's dive in and
so before you move forward you want to
make sure that all your instances are
considered healthy by your load balancer
and as i can see here all my instances
in my instance group are considered
healthy by the load balancer and so just
to verify this i'm going to go ahead and
copy the i p address and you can open up
a new tab in your browser and simply
paste it in
and success as you can see here managing
the production of many bow ties can be
automated but managing the wearer of
them definitely cannot another fine
message from the people at bow tie inc
now although this is a simple web page i
used a couple variables just to show you
the low balancing that happens in the
background and traffic will be load
balanced in between all of the instances
in the instance group so if you click on
refresh then you should see the machine
name and the data center change so every
time i click refresh the traffic will be
routed to a different instance in a
different zone and so a simple
simulation on how traffic is low balance
between the different instances in their
different zones okay so now that we've
verified the website application i'm
going to close down this tab and so now
that we've created our instance template
we've created our instance group and
we've created our low balancer with the
back end and front end service and it
looks like everything seems to be
working together nicely we're going to
go ahead and simulate a scale out using
auto scaling and so in order to simulate
this we're going to do a stress test on
one of the instances so i'm going to
head back on over to the navigation menu
scroll down to compute engine and here
you can ssh into any one of these
instances and run the stress test from
there so i'm going to pick here the one
at the top and so whenever you're logged
in you can simply paste in the command
that i've included in the instructions
that will run the stress test and so
this is a stress test application called
stress that was included in the startup
script and this again will put stress on
the server itself and trigger a scale
out to handle the load and it'll do this
for 30 seconds so you can go ahead and
hit enter and head back over to the
console and in about a minute or two you
should see some new instances that will
be created by your instance group in
order to handle the load okay and after
about a couple minutes it's showing here
that instances are being created and it
will be scaling out to the maximum
amount of instances that i've set it to
which is six i'm going to drill down
into this
and yes a scale out is happening and
some new instances are being created to
handle the load so i'm going to give it
just a minute here okay and as you can
see here all the instances have been
created they've been added to the
instance group and all of them are
marked as healthy and so just to verify
that all the instances are working i'm
going to go ahead and open up a new tab
i'm going to plug in the ip address on
my load balancer and i'm going to simply
cycle through all these instances to
make sure that all them are working and
it looks like i have no issues and so
now that you've simulated a scale out i
wanted to go ahead and run a scale in
and so i'm first going to close up these
tabs now with regards to scaling there
is a 10 minute stabilization period that
cannot be adjusted for scaling and this
is a built-in feature into google cloud
now because i respect your time as a
student i'm going to show you a work
around to trigger a scale in sooner
strictly for this demo and i also wanted
to caution that this should never be
done in a production or production-like
environment you should always wait for
the scaling to happen on its own and
never force it this method is being used
strictly for learning purposes to save
you some time and so i'm going to go
ahead to the top menu and click on
rolling restart and replace and this
will bring up a new page where you will
have the option to either restart or
replace any instances in your instance
group and so for your purposes under
operation make sure that you have
restart checked off and this will
restart all of your instances and only
bring up the ones that are needed so i'm
going to go ahead and click on restart
i'm going to go back to my instance
group console and i'm just going to give
this a few minutes to cook and i'll be
right back in a flash okay so it looks
like the instance group has scaled in
and we are now down left to three
instances the minimum that we configured
for our instance group and so that
pretty much covers the managing bow ties
demo so i wanted to congratulate you on
making it through this demo and i hope
that this has been extremely useful in
excelling your knowledge on managing
instance templates managed instance
groups and creating load balancers with
back-end and front-end services now this
was a jam-packed demo and there was a
lot to pack in with everything you've
learned from the last few lessons and so
just as a recap you created an instance
template with your startup script you
then created a new instance group with a
health check to go with it configuring
auto scaling for a minimum of three
instances you then created a firewall
rule so that the health check probes
were able to connect to the application
and you then created a load balancer
with its back end and front-end service
and verified that the website
application was indeed up and running
you then ran a stress test to allow a
simulation of a scale out of your
instance group and then simulated a
scale in of your instance group great
job and so now that we've completed this
demo you want to make sure that you're
not accumulating any unnecessary costs
and so i'm going to go ahead and walk
you through the breakdown of deleting
all these resources so first you're
going to go ahead and delete the load
balancer go back up to the navigation
menu and scroll down to network services
and go over to load balancing so i'm
going to go ahead and check off bow tie
lb and simply go up to the top and click
on delete it's going to ask me if i'm
sure i want to do this i'm also going to
select bow tie back end service and i
can delete my load balancer and my back
end service all at once i'm going to go
ahead and delete load balancer and the
selected resources
and this should clear up within a few
seconds okay and our load balancer has
been deleted i'm going to just go up
here to the back end make sure
everything's good yeah we're all clean
same thing with front end and so now you
can move on to instance groups so i'm
going to head back up to the navigation
menu go down a compute engine and go up
to instance groups and here you can just
simply check off bow tie group and
simply click on delete
you're going to be prompted with a
notification to make sure you want to
delete bow tie group yes i want to
delete and again this should take about
a minute okay it actually took a couple
minutes but my instance group has been
deleted and so now i'm going to go over
to instance templates and i'm going to
delete my template and check off bow tie
template and simply click delete you're
going to get a prompt to make sure you
want to delete your instance template
yes you want to delete
and success you've now deleted all your
resources although there is one more
resource that you will not be billed for
but since we're cleaning everything up
we might as well clean that up as well
and this is the firewall rule that we
created and go over to the navigation
menu and scroll down to vpc network
i'm going to go to firewall here on the
left hand menu and here i'm going to
check off the allow health check
firewall rule and simply click on delete
i'm going to get a prompt to make sure
that i want to delete it yes you want to
delete i'm going to quickly hit refresh
and yes we've deleted it and so this
concludes the end of this demo so you
can now mark this as complete and i'll
see you in the next one
welcome back in this next section we
will be focusing on google cloud's
premier container orchestration service
called kubernetes but before we can dive
right into kubernetes and the benefits
that it gives to containers you'll need
an understanding as to what containers
are and what value containers provide in
this lesson i will be covering the
difference between virtual machines and
containers what containers are how they
work and the value proposition they
bring so with that being said let's dive
in
now for those of you who didn't know
container technology gets its name from
the shipping industry products get
placed into standardized shipping
containers which are designed to fit
into the ship that accommodates the
container's standard size instead of
having various sizes of packaging now by
standardizing this process and keeping
the items together the container can be
moved as a unit and it costs less to do
it this way as well the standardization
allows for consistency when packing and
moving the containers placing them on
ships and docks as well as storage no
matter where the container is it always
stays the same size and the contents
stay isolated from all the other
containers that they are stacked with
and so now before we get into the
details of containers i wanted to cover
how we got here and why
so a great way to discuss containers is
through their comparison to virtual
machines now as we discussed in a
previous lesson when it comes to vms the
systems are virtualized through a
hypervisor that sits on top of the
underlying host infrastructure the
underlying hardware is virtualized so
that multiple operating system instances
can run on the hardware each vm runs its
own operating system and has access to
virtualized resources representing the
underlying hardware due to this process
vms come with the cost of large overhead
in cpu memory and disk as well can be
very large due to the fact that each vm
needs its own individual operating
system there also lacks standardization
between each vm making them unique due
to the os configuration the software
installed and the software libraries
thus not making it very portable to be
able to run in any environment now when
dealing with containers things are run
very differently the underlying host
infrastructure is still there but
instead of just using a hypervisor and
abstracting the underlying hardware
containerization takes it one step
further and abstracts the operating
system
thus
leaving the application with all of its
dependencies in a neatly packaged
standardized container this is done by
installing the operating system on top
of the host infrastructure
and then a separate layer on top of the
host operating system called the
container engine now instead of having
their own operating system the
containers share the operating system
kernel with other containers
while operating independently
running just the application code and
the dependencies needed to run that
application this allows each container
to consume very little memory or disk
making containers very lightweight
efficient and portable containerized
applications can start in seconds and
many more instances of the application
can fit onto the machine compared to a
vm environment this container can now be
brought over to other environments
running docker and able to run without
having the worries of running into
issues of compatibility now although
there are a few different container
engines out there the one that has
received the most popularity is docker
and this is the engine that we will be
referring to for the remainder of this
course now a docker image is a
collection or stack of layers that are
created from sequential instructions on
a docker file so each line in the
dockerfile is run line by line and a
unique read-only layer is written to the
image what makes docker images unique is
that each time you add another
instruction in the docker file a new
layer is created now going through a
practical example here shown on the
right is a docker file and we will be
able to map each line of code to a layer
shown on the docker image on the left
the line marked from
shows the base image that the image will
be using the example shown here shows
that the ubuntu image version 12.04
will be used next the run instruction is
used which will perform a general update
install apache 2 and output a message to
be displayed that is written to the
index.html file next up is the working
directories and these are the
environment variables set by using an
env instruction and this will help run
the apache runtime next layer is the
expose instruction and this is used to
expose the container's port on 8080 and
lastly the command layer is an
instruction that is executing the apache
web server from its executable path and
so this is a great example of how a
docker file is broken down from each
line to create the layers of this image
and so just as a note here each docker
image starts with a base image as well
each line in a docker file creates a new
layer that is added to the image and
finally all the layers in a docker image
are read only and cannot be changed
unless the docker file is adjusted to
reflect that change
so now how do we get from a docker image
to a container well a running docker
container is actually an instantiation
of an image so containers using the same
image are identical to each other in
terms of their application code and
runtime dependencies so i could use the
same image for multiple copies of the
same container that have different tasks
what makes each individual container
different
is that running containers include a
writable layer on top of the read-only
content runtime changes including any
rights and updates to data and files are
saved in this read write layer so in
this example when using the command
docker run fashionista a docker
container will be instantiated from the
docker image and a read write layer is
always added on top of the read-only
layers when a container is created
writing any necessary files that's
needed for the application and so just
as a note here docker containers are
always created from docker images and
containers can use the same image yet
will always have a different read write
layer no matter the amount of containers
running on a given host so now when your
containers have been created you need a
place to store them and so this is where
a container registry comes into play now
a container registry is a single place
for you to store and manage docker
images now when you create your docker
file and then build your image
you want to store that image in a
central image repository whether it be a
private one or a public one a popular
public container registry is docker hub
and this is a common registry where many
open source images can be found
including those used for the base layer
images like the ubuntu example that i
showed you earlier and so once you have
your containers in a container registry
you need to be able to run these
containers so in order to run these
containers you need docker hosts and
these can consist of any machine running
the docker engine and this could be your
laptop
server or you can run them in provided
hosted cloud environments now this may
have been a refresher for some but for
those of you who are new to containers i
hope this has given you a lot more
clarity on what containers are what they
do and the value that they bring to any
environment and so that's pretty much
all i wanted to cover on this short
lesson of an introduction to containers
so you can now mark this lesson as
complete and let's move on to the next
one
welcome back so now that you've gotten
familiar with what containers are and
how they work i wanted to dive into
google cloud's platform as a service
offering for containers called google
kubernetes engine also known as short as
gke now although the exam goes into a
more operational perspective with
regards to gke knowing the foundation of
kubernetes and the different topics of
kubernetes is a must in order to
understand the abstractions that take
place with gke from regular kubernetes
in this lesson i will be getting into
key topics with regards to kubernetes
and we'll be touching on the
architecture
components and how they all work
together to achieve the desired state
for your containerized workloads now
there's a lot to get into so with that
being said let's dive in now before i
can get into gke i need to set the stage
on explaining what kubernetes is put
simply kubernetes is an orchestration
platform for containers which was
invented by google and eventually open
source it is now maintained by the cncf
short for the cloud native computing
foundation and has achieved incredible
widespread adoption kubernetes provides
a platform to automate schedule and run
containers on clusters of physical or
virtual machines
thus eliminating many of the manual
processes involved in deploying and
scaling containerized applications
kubernetes manages the containers that
run the applications and ensure that
there is no downtime in a way that you
the user can define
for example if you define that when a
container goes down and another
container needs to start kubernetes
would take care of that for you
automatically and seamlessly kubernetes
provides you with the framework to run
distributed systems resiliently it takes
care of scaling and failover for your
application provides deployment patterns
and allows you to manage your
applications with tons of flexibility
reliability and power it works with a
range of container tools including
docker now although this adoption was
widespread it did come with its various
challenges this included scaling at cd
load balancing availability auto scaling
networking
rollback on faulty deployments and so
much more
so now google cloud has since developed
a managed offering for kubernetes
providing a managed environment for
deploying managing and scaling your
containerized applications using google
infrastructure the gke environment
consists of compute engine instances
grouped together to form a cluster and
it provides all the same benefits as
on-premises kubernetes yet has
abstracted the complexity of having to
worry about the hardware and to top it
off it has the benefits of advanced
cluster management features that google
cloud provides
with things like cloud load balancing
and being able to spread traffic amongst
clusters and nodes node pools to
designate subnets of nodes within a
cluster for additional flexibility
automatic scaling of your cluster's node
instance count and automatic upgrades
for your clusters node software it also
allows you to maintain node health and
availability with node auto repair and
takes care of logging and monitoring
with google cloud's operation suite for
visibility into your cluster so as you
can see here gke holds a lot of benefits
when it comes to running kubernetes in
google cloud so i wanted to take a
moment now to dive into the cluster
architecture and help familiarize you
with all the components involved in a
cluster so a cluster is the foundation
of google kubernetes engine and
kubernetes as a whole the kubernetes
objects that represent your
containerized applications all run on
top of the cluster in gke a cluster
consists of at least one control plane
and multiple worker machines called
nodes the control plane and node
machines run the kubernetes cluster the
control plane is responsible to
coordinate the entire cluster and this
can include scheduling workloads like
containerized applications and managing
the workload's life cycle scaling and
upgrades the control plane also manages
network and storage resources for those
workloads and most importantly it
manages the state of the cluster and
make sure it is at the desired state now
the nodes are the worker machines that
run your containerized applications and
other workloads the nodes are compute
engine vm instances that gke creates on
your behalf when you create a cluster
each node is managed from the control
plane which receives updates on each
node's self-reported status a node also
runs the services necessary to support
the docker containers that make up your
cluster's workloads these include the
docker runtime and the kubernetes node
agent known as the cubelet which
communicates with the control plane and
is responsible for starting and running
docker containers scheduled on that node
now diving deeper into the architecture
there are components within the control
plane and nodes that you should
familiarize yourself with as these
components are what ties the cluster
together and helps manage the
orchestration as well as the state now
the control plane is the unified
endpoint for your cluster the control
plane's components make global decisions
about the cluster for example scheduling
as well as detecting and responding to
cluster events all interactions with the
cluster are done via kubernetes api
calls and the control plane runs the
kubernetes api server process to handle
those requests you can make kubernetes
api calls directly via http or grpc or
can also be done indirectly by running
commands from the kubernetes command
line client called cubectl and of course
you can interact with the ui in the
cloud console the api server process is
the hub for all communications for the
cluster moving on to the next component
is cube scheduler the cube scheduler is
a component that discovers and assigns
newly created pods to a node for them to
run on so any new pods that are created
will automatically be assigned to its
appropriate node by the cube scheduler
taking into consideration any
constraints that are in place next up is
the cube controller manager and this is
the component that runs controller
processes and is responsible for things
like noticing and responding when nodes
go down
maintaining the correct number of pods
populating the services and pods as well
as creating default accounts and api
access tokens for new namespaces it is
these controllers that will basically
look to make changes to the cluster when
the current state does not meet the
desired state now when it comes to the
cloud controller manager this is what
embeds cloud-specific control logic the
cloud controller manager lets you link
your cluster into any cloud providers
api
and separates out the components that
interact with that cloud platform from
components that just interact with your
cluster the cloud controller manager
only runs controllers that are specific
to your cloud provider in this case
google cloud and lastly we have fcd and
this component is responsible to store
the state of the cluster at cd is a
consistent and highly available key
value store that only interacts with the
api server it saves all the
configuration data along with what nodes
are part of the cluster and what pods
they are running so now the control
plane needs a way to interact with the
nodes of the cluster thus the nodes
having components themselves for this
communication to occur this component is
called a cubelet and this is an agent
that runs on each node in the cluster
that communicates with the control plane
it is responsible for starting and
running docker containers scheduled on
that node it takes a set of pod specs
that are provided to it and ensures that
the containers described in those pod
specs are running and healthy and i will
be diving into pod specs in a later
lesson next up is cube proxy and this is
the component that maintains network
connectivity to the pods in a cluster
and lastly the container runtime is the
software that is responsible for running
containers kubernetes supports container
runtimes like docker and container d and
so these are the main components in a
cluster covering the control plane and
nodes with regards to communication
within the cluster now before i end this
lesson there is one more topic i wanted
to touch on with regards to the
architecture of a gke cluster and that
is the abstraction that happens and what
exactly does gke manage with regards to
kubernetes well gke manages all the
control plane components the endpoint
exposes the kubernetes api server that
cubectl uses to communicate with your
cluster control plane the endpoint
exposes the kubernetes api server that
cubectl uses to communicate with your
cluster control plane the endpoint ip is
displayed in cloud console and this ip
will allow you to interact with the
cluster when you run the command gcloud
container clusters get dash credentials
you see that the command gets the
cluster endpoint as part of updating
cubeconfig an ip address for the cluster
is then exposed to interact with and is
responsible for provisioning and
managing all the infrastructure that is
needed for the control plane gke also
automates the kubernetes nodes by
launching them as compute engine vms
under the hood but still allows the user
to change the machine type and access
upgrade options by default google
kubernetes engine clusters and node
pools are upgraded automatically by
google but you can also control when
auto upgrades can and cannot occur by
configuring maintenance windows and
exclusions and just as a note a clusters
control plane and nodes do not
necessarily run the same version at all
times and i will be digging more into
that in a later lesson and so i know
this is a lot of theory to take in but
is as i said before a necessity to
understanding kubernetes and gke and as
we go further along into kubernetes and
get into demos i promise that this will
start to make a lot more sense and you
will start becoming more comfortable
with gke and the underlying components
of kubernetes knowing kubernetes is a
must when working in any cloud
environment as it is a popular and
growing technology that is not slowing
down so knowing gke will put you in a
really good position for your career as
an engineer in google cloud as well will
give you a leg up on diving into other
cloud vendors implementation of
kubernetes and so that's pretty much all
i wanted to cover when it comes to
google kubernetes engine and kubernetes
so you can now mark this lesson as
complete and let's move on to the next
one
welcome back in this lesson i will be
covering cluster and node management in
gke as it refers to choosing different
cluster types for your workloads cluster
versions
node pools as well as upgrades and the
many different options to choose from it
is good to familiarize yourself with
these options as they may be the
deciding factor of having to keep your
workloads highly available and your
tolerance to risk within your
environment so with that being said
let's dive in now in the last lesson we
touched on nodes and how they are the
workers for the kubernetes cluster so
now that you are familiar with nodes i
wanted to touch on a concept that builds
on it called node pools now a node pool
is a group of nodes within a cluster
that all have the same configuration and
using node config specification to
achieve this a node pool can also
contain one or multiple nodes when you
first create a cluster the number and
type of nodes that you specify becomes
the default node pool as shown here in
the diagram then you can add additional
custom node pools of different sizes and
types to your cluster all nodes in any
given node pool are identical to one
another now custom node pools are really
useful when you need to schedule pods
that require more resources than others
such as more memory more disk space or
even different machine types you can
create upgrade and delete node pools
individually without affecting the whole
cluster and just as a note you cannot
configure a single node in any node pool
any configuration changes affect all
nodes in the node pool and by default
all new node pools run the latest stable
version of kubernetes existing node
pools can be manually upgraded or
automatically upgraded you can also run
multiple kubernetes node versions on
each node pool in your cluster update
each node pool independently and target
different node pools for specific
deployments in that node now with gke
you can create a cluster tailored to
your availability requirements and your
budget the types of available clusters
include zonal both single zone or
multi-zonal and regional zonal clusters
have a single control plane in a single
zone depending on what kind of
availability you want you can distribute
your nodes for your zonal cluster in a
single zone or in multiple zones now
when you decide to deploy a single zone
cluster it again has a single control
plane running in one zone this control
plane manages workloads on nodes running
in the same zone a multi-zonal cluster
on the other hand has a single replica
of the control plane running in a single
zone and has nodes running in multiple
zones during an upgrade of the cluster
or an outage of the zone where the
control plane runs
workloads still run however the cluster
its nodes and its workloads cannot be
configured until the control plane is
available multi-zonal clusters are
designed to balance availability and
cost for consistent workloads and just
as a note the same number of nodes will
be deployed to each selected zone and
may cost you more than budgeted so
please be aware and of course when
you're looking to achieve high
availability for your cluster regional
clusters are always the way to go a
regional cluster has multiple replicas
of the control plane running in multiple
zones within a given region nodes also
run in each zone where a replica of the
control plane runs because a regional
cluster replicates the control plane and
nodes it consumes more compute engine
resources than a similar single zone or
multi-zonal cluster the same number of
nodes will be deployed to each selected
zone and the default when selecting
regional clusters is three zones now if
you're dealing with more sensitive
workloads that require more strict
guidelines private clusters give you the
ability to isolate nodes from having
inbound and outbound connectivity to the
public internet this isolation is
achieved as the nodes have internal ip
addresses only if you want to provide
outbound internet access for certain
private nodes you can use cloudnat or
manage your own nat gateway by default
private google access is enabled in
private clusters and their workloads
with limited outbound access to google
cloud apis and services over google's
private network in private clusters the
control plane's vpc network is connected
to your clusters vpc network with vpc
network peering your vpc network
contains the cluster nodes and a
separate google cloud vpc network
contains your cluster's control plane
the control plane's vpc network is
located in a project controlled by
google traffic between nodes and the
control plane is routed entirely using
internal ip addresses the control plane
for a private cluster has a private
endpoint in addition to a public
endpoint the control plane for a
non-private cluster only has a public
endpoint the private endpoint is an
internal ip address in the control
plane's vpc network the public endpoint
is the external ip address of the
control plane and you can control access
to this endpoint using authorized
networks or you can disable access to
the public endpoint as shown here in the
diagram you can disable the public
endpoint and connect to your network
using an internal ip address using cloud
interconnect or cloud vpn and you always
have the option of enabling or disabling
this public endpoint now when you create
a cluster you can choose the cluster
specific kubernetes version or you can
mix the versions for flexibility on
features either way it is always
recommended that you enable auto upgrade
for the cluster and its nodes now when
you have auto upgrade enabled you are
given the choice to choose from what are
called release channels when you enroll
a new cluster in a release channel
google automatically manages the version
and upgrade cadence for the cluster and
its node pools all channels offer
supported releases of gke and are
considered in general availability you
can choose from three different release
channels for automatic management of
your cluster's version and upgrade
cadence as shown here the available
release channels are rapid regular and
stable release channels the rapid
release channel gets the latest
kubernetes release as early as possible
and be able to use new gka features the
moment that they go into general
availability with the regular release
channel you have access to gke and
kubernetes features reasonably soon
after they are released but on a version
that has been qualified two to three
months after releasing in the rapid
release channel and finally we have the
stable release channel where stability
is prioritized over new functionality
changes and new versions in this channel
are rolled out last after being
validated two to three months in the
regular release channel and so if you're
looking for more direct management of
your cluster's version choose a static
version when you enroll a cluster in a
release channel that cluster is upgraded
automatically when a new version is
available in that channel now if you do
not use a release channel or choose a
cluster version the current default
version is use the default version is
selected based on usage and real world
performance and is changed regularly
while the default version is the most
mature one
other versions being made available are
generally available versions that pass
internal testing and qualification
changes to the default version are
announced in a release note now if you
know that you need to use a specific
supported version of kubernetes for a
given workload you can specify it when
creating the cluster if you do not need
to control the specific patch version
you use consider enrolling your cluster
in a release channel instead of managing
its version directly now when it comes
to upgrading the cluster please be aware
that control plane and nodes do not
always run the same version at all times
as well a control plane is always
upgraded before its nodes when it comes
to zonal clusters you cannot launch or
edit workloads during that upgrade and
with regional clusters each control
plane is upgraded one by one as well
with control planes auto upgrade is
enabled by default and this is google
cloud's best practice now again if you
choose you can do a manual upgrade but
you cannot upgrade the control plane
more than one minor version at a time so
please be aware as well with any cluster
upgrades maintenance windows and
exclusions are available and so this way
you can choose the best times for your
upgrades and so like cluster upgrades by
default a clusters nodes have auto
upgrade enabled and it is recommended
that you do not disable it again this is
best practice by google cloud and again
like the cluster upgrades a manual
upgrade is available and maintenance
windows and exclusions are available for
all of these upgrades now when a no pool
is upgraded gke upgrades one node at a
time
while a node is being upgraded gke stops
scheduling new pods onto it and attempts
to schedule its running pods onto other
nodes the node is then recreated at the
new version but using the same name as
before this is similar to other events
that recreate the node such as enabling
or disabling a feature on the node pool
and the upgrade is only complete when
all nodes have been recreated and the
cluster is in the desired state when a
newly upgraded node registers with the
control plane gke marks the node as
schedulable upgrading a no pool may
disrupt workloads running in that pool
and so in order to avoid this you can
create a new node pool with the desired
version and migrate the workload then
after migration you can delete the old
node pool now surge upgrades let you
control the number of nodes gke can
upgrade at a time and control how
disruptive upgrades are to your
workloads you can change how many nodes
gke attempts to upgrade at once by
changing the surge upgrade parameters on
a no pool surge upgrades reduce
disruption to your workloads during
cluster maintenance and also allow you
to control the number of nodes upgraded
in parallel surge upgrades also work
with the cluster auto scaler to prevent
changes to nodes that are being upgraded
now surge upgrade behavior is determined
by two settings max surge upgrade and
max unavailable upgrade
now with max surge upgrade this is the
number of additional nodes that can be
added to the no pool during an upgrade
increasing max surge upgrade raises the
number of nodes that can be upgraded
simultaneously and when it comes to the
max unavailable upgrade this is the
number of nodes that can be
simultaneously unavailable during an
upgrade increasing max unavailable
upgrade raises the number of nodes that
can be upgraded in parallel so with max
surge upgrade the higher the number the
more parallel upgrades which will end up
costing you more money with max
unavailable upgrade the higher the
number the more disruptive it is and so
the more risk you are taking and so
during upgrades gke brings down at most
the sum of the max surge upgrade added
with the max unavailable upgrade so as
you can see here there are a slew of
options when it comes to deciding on the
type of cluster you want as well as the
type of upgrades that are available
along with when you want them to occur
and so your deciding factor in the end
will be the workload that you are
running and your risk tolerance and this
will play a big factor in keeping up
time for your cluster as well as saving
money in any type of environment and so
that's pretty much all i wanted to cover
when it comes to gke cluster and node
management so you can now mark this
lesson as complete and let's move on to
the next one
[Music]
welcome back and in this lesson i will
be diving into some more theory within
kubernetes and gke this time touching on
objects and how objects are managed pods
are only one type of object but there
are many other parts that are involved
in the management of these objects and
this is what this lesson is set out to
teach you now there's quite a bit to
cover here so with that being said let's
dive in
now kubernetes objects are persistent
entities in kubernetes kubernetes uses
these entities to represent the state of
your cluster for example it can describe
things like what containerized
applications are running and on which
nodes and what resources are available
to those applications a kubernetes
object is a record of intent once you
create the object kubernetes will
constantly work to ensure that object
exists by creating an object you're
effectively telling kubernetes what you
want your cluster's workload to look
like and this is your cluster's desired
state and you've heard me speak about
this many times before and this is what
i was referring to now almost every
kubernetes object includes two nested
object fields that govern the object's
configuration the object spec and the
object's status for objects that have a
spec you have to set this when you
create the object providing a
description of the characteristics you
want the resource to have its desired
state the status describes the current
state of the object supplied and updated
by kubernetes and its components the
kubernetes control plane continually and
actively manages every object's actual
state to match the desired state you
supplied now each object in your cluster
has a name that is unique for that type
of resource every kubernetes object also
has a uid that is unique across your
whole cluster only one object of a given
kind can have a given name at a time
however if you delete the object you can
make a new object with that same name
every object created over the whole
lifetime of a kubernetes cluster has a
distinct uid these distinct uids are
also known as uuids which we discussed
earlier on in the course now when
creating updating or deleting objects in
kubernetes this is done through the use
of a manifest file where you would
specify the desired state of an object
that kubernetes will maintain when you
apply the manifest each configuration
file can contain multiple manifests and
is common practice to do so when
possible a manifest file is defined in
the form of a yaml file or a json file
and it is recommended to use yaml now in
each yaml file for the kubernetes object
that you want to create there are some
required values that need to be set the
first one is the api version and this
defines which version of the kubernetes
api you're using to create this object
the kind described in this example as a
pod is the kind of object you want to
create next up is the metadata and this
is the data that helps uniquely identify
the object including a string name
a uid and an optional namespace and the
last required value is the spec
and this is what state you desire for
the object and the spec in this example
is a container by the name of bow tie
dash web server and is to be built with
the latest nginx web server image as
well as having port 80 open on the
container now when it comes to objects
pods are the smallest most basic
deployable objects in kubernetes a pod
represents a single instance of a
running process in your cluster pods
contain one or more containers such as
docker containers and when a pod runs
multiple containers the containers are
managed as a single entity and share the
pods resources which also includes
shared networking and shared storage for
their containers generally one pod is
meant to run a single instance of an
application on your cluster which is
self-contained and isolated
now although a pod is meant to run a
single instance of your application on
your cluster
it is not recommended to create
individual pods directly instead you
generally create a set of identical pods
called replicas to run your application
a set of replicated pods are created and
managed by a controller such as a
deployment controllers manage the life
cycle of their pods as well as
performing horizontal scaling changing
the number of pods is necessary now
although you might occasionally interact
with pods directly to debug troubleshoot
or inspect them it's recommended that
you use a controller to manage your pods
and so once your pods are created they
are then run on nodes in your cluster
which we discussed earlier the pod will
then remain on its node until its
process is complete the pot is deleted
the pod is evicted from the node due to
lack of resources or the node fails if a
node fails pods on the node are
automatically scheduled for deletion now
a single gke cluster should be able to
satisfy the needs of multiple users or
groups of users and kubernetes
namespaces help different projects teams
or customers to share a kubernetes
cluster you can think of a namespace as
a virtual cluster inside of your
kubernetes cluster and you can have
multiple namespaces logically isolated
from each other they can help you and
your teams with organization and
security now you can name your
namespaces whatever you'd like but
kubernetes starts with four initial
namespaces the first one is the default
namespace and this is for objects with
no other namespace
so when creating new objects without a
namespace your object will automatically
be assigned to this namespace cube dash
system is the next one and these are for
objects created by kubernetes
cube-public is created automatically and
is readable by all users but is mostly
reserved for cluster usage in case that
some resources should be visible and
readable publicly throughout the whole
cluster and finally cube node lease is
the namespace for the lease objects
associated with each node which improves
the performance of the node heartbeats
as the cluster scales and so like most
resources in google cloud labels are key
value pairs that help you organize your
resources in this case kubernetes
objects labels can be attached to
objects at creation time and can be
added or modified at any time each
object can have a set of key value
labels defined and each key must be
unique for a given object and labels can
be found under metadata in your manifest
file and so the one thing to remember
about pods is that they are ephemeral
they are not designed to run forever and
when a pod is terminated it cannot be
brought back in general pods do not
disappear until they are deleted by a
user or by a controller pods do not heal
or repair themselves for example if a
pod is scheduled on a node which later
fails the pod is deleted as well if a
pod is evicted from a node for any
reason the pod does not replace itself
and so here is a diagram of a pod life
cycle that shows the different phases of
its running time to give you some better
clarity of its ephemeral nature when
first creating the pod the pod will
start impending and this is the pod's
initial phase and is waiting for one or
more of the containers to be set up and
made ready to run this includes the time
a pod spends waiting to be scheduled as
well as the time spent downloading
container images over the network once
the pod has completed the pending phase
it is moved on to be scheduled and once
it is scheduled it will move into the
running phase and this is the phase
where the pod has been bound to a node
and all of the containers have been
created the running phase has at least
one container in the pod running or is
in the process of starting or restarting
and once the workload is complete the
pod will move into the succeeded phase
and this is where all the containers in
the pod have terminated in success and
will not be restarted now if all the
containers in the pod have not
terminated successfully the pod will
move into a failed phase and this is
where all the containers in the pod have
terminated and at least one container
has terminated in failure now there's
one more phase in the pod life cycle
that i wanted to bring up which is the
unknown phase and this is the state of
the pod that could not be obtained this
phase typically occurs due to an error
in communicating with the node where the
pod should be running so now when you're
creating pods using a deployment is a
common way to do this a deployment runs
multiple replicas of your application
and automatically replaces any instances
that fail or become unresponsive
deployments help ensure that one or more
instances of your application are
available to serve user requests
deployments use a pod template which
contains a specification for its pods
the pod specification determines how
each pod should look like for instance
what applications should run inside its
containers which volumes the pods should
mount its labels and more and so when a
deployments pod template is changed new
pods are automatically created one at a
time now i wanted to quickly bring up
replica sets for just a moment you'll
hear about replica sets and i wanted to
make sure that i covered it replica sets
ensures that a specified number of pod
replicas are running at any given time
however a deployment is a higher level
concept that manages replica sets and
provides updates to pods along with
other features and so using deployments
is recommended over using replica sets
unless your workload requires it and i
will be including a link to replica sets
in the lesson text so speaking of
workloads in kubernetes workloads are
objects that set deployment rules four
pods based on these rules kubernetes
performs the deployment and updates the
workload with the current state of the
application workloads let you define the
rules for application scheduling scaling
and upgrading now deployments which we
just discussed is a type of workload and
as we've seen a deployment runs multiple
replicas of your application and
automatically replaces any instances
that fail or become unresponsive
deployments are best used
for stateless applications another type
of workload is stateful sets and in
contrast to deployments these are great
for when your application needs to
maintain its identity and store data so
basically any application that requires
some sort of persistent storage daemon
sets is another common workload that
ensures every node in the cluster runs a
copy of that pod and this is for use
cases where you're collecting logs or
monitoring node performance now jobs is
a workload that launches one or more
pods and ensures that a specified number
of them successfully terminate jobs are
best used to run a finite task to
completion as opposed to managing an
ongoing desired application state and
cron jobs are similar to jobs however
cron jobs runs to completion on a
cron-based schedule and so the last
workload that i wanted to cover are
config maps and these store general
configuration information and so after
you upload a config map any workload can
reference it as either an environment
variable or a volume mount and so just
as a note config maps are not meant to
store sensitive data if you're planning
to do this please use secrets now i know
this lesson has been extremely heavy in
theory but these are fundamental
concepts to know when dealing with
kubernetes and gke as well as the
objects that it supports so i recommend
that if you need to go back and review
this lesson if things aren't making
sense so that you can better understand
it as these concepts all tie in together
and will come up in the exam and so
that's pretty much all i wanted to cover
in this lesson on pods and object
management within gke so you can now
mark this lesson as complete
and let's move on to the next one
[Music]
welcome back and in this lesson i'm
going to be diving into kubernetes
services now services are a major
networking component when it comes to
working in kubernetes and can play a
major factor when it comes to deciding
on how you want to route your traffic
within your kubernetes cluster as well
in my experience services show up on the
exam and so an understanding of how they
work and the different types to use are
essential to understanding the big
picture of kubernetes this lesson will
cover an overview on what services are
what they do and the different types
that are available along with their use
cases now there's a lot to cover here so
with that being said let's dive in now
as i had discussed earlier kubernetes
pods are ephemeral pods are created and
destroyed to match the state of your
cluster so these resources are never
permanent a perfect example of this is
by using a deployment object so you can
create and destroy pods dynamically now
when it comes to networking in
kubernetes each pod gets its own ip
address however in a deployment a pod
that is running once destroyed will be
recreated with a new ip address and
there is no real way to keep track of
these i p addresses for communication as
they change very frequently and this is
where services come into play now a
service is an abstraction in the sense
that it is not a process that listens on
some network interface
a service can be defined as a logical
set of pods an abstraction on top of the
pod which provides a single persistent
ip address and dns name by which pods
can be accessed it allows for routing
external traffic into your kubernetes
cluster and used inside your cluster for
more intelligent routing with services
it is also very easy to manage load
balancing configuration for traffic
between replicas it helps pods scale
quickly and easily as the service will
automatically handle the recreation of
pods and their new ip addresses the main
goal of services in kubernetes is to
provide persistent access to its pods
without the necessity to look for a
pod's ip
each time when the pod is recreated and
again services also allow for external
access from users to the applications
inside the cluster without having to
know the ip address of the individual
pod in order to reach that application
now in order for a service to route
traffic to the correct pod in the
cluster there are some fields in the
manifest file that will help determine
the end points on where traffic should
be routed shown here on the right is the
deployment manifest for reference and on
the left is the services manifest now as
you can see here in the service manifest
on the left the kind is clearly defined
as service under metadata is the name of
the service and this will be the dns
name of the service when it is created
so when it comes to the spec there is a
field here called a selector and this is
what defines what pods should be
included in the service and it is the
labels under the selector that define
which pods and labels are what we
discussed in the last lesson as
arbitrary key value pairs so any pod
with these matching labels is what will
be added to the service as shown here in
the deployment file this workload will
be a part of the service and its labels
match that of the selector in the
services file for type this is the type
of service that you will want to use in
this example type cluster ip is used but
depending on the use case you have a few
different ones to choose from now at the
bottom here is a list of port
configurations protocol being the
network protocol to use with the port
port being the port that incoming
traffic goes to and finally the target
port which is the port on the pod that
traffic should be sent to and this will
make more sense as we go through the
upcoming diagrams so touching on
selectors and labels for a moment
kubernetes has a very unique way of
routing traffic and when it comes to
services it's not any different services
select pods based on their labels now
when a selector request is made to the
service it selects all pods in the
cluster matching the key value pair
under the selector it chooses one of the
pods if there are more than one with the
same key value pair and forwards the
network request to it and so here in
this example you can see that the
selector specified for the service has a
key value pair of app inventory you can
see the pod on node 1 on the left holds
the label of app inventory as well which
matches the key value pair of the
selector and so traffic will get routed
to that pod because of it if you look at
the label for the pod in node 2 on the
right the label does not match that of
the selector and so it will not route
traffic to that pod and so to sum it up
the label on the pod matching the
selector in the service determines where
the network request will get routed to
and so now i will be going through the
many different service types that are
available for routing network traffic
within gke starting with cluster ip
now a cluster ip service is the default
kubernetes service it gives you a
service inside your cluster that other
apps inside your cluster can access the
service is not exposed outside the
cluster but can be addressed from within
the cluster when you create a service of
type cluster ip kubernetes creates a
stable ip address that is accessible
from nodes in the cluster clients in the
cluster call the service by using the
cluster ip address and the port value
specified in the port field of the
service manifest the request is
forwarded to one of the member pods on
the port specified in the target port
field and just as a note this ip address
is stable for the lifetime of the
service so for this example a client
calls the service at 10.176
on tcp port 80. the request is forwarded
to one of the member pods on tcp port
80. note that the member pod must have a
container that is listening on tcp port
80. if there is no container listening
on port 80 clients will see a message
like fail to connect or this site can't
be reached think of the case when you
have a dns record that you don't want to
change and you want the name to resolve
to the same ip address or you merely
want a static ip address for your
workload this would be a great use case
for the use of the cluster ip service
now although the service is not
accessible by network requests outside
of the cluster
if you need to connect to the service
you can still connect to it with the
cloud sdk or cloud shell by using the
exposed ip address of the cluster and so
i wanted to take a moment to show you
what a cluster ip manifest actually
looks like and i will be going through
the manifest for each service type for
you to familiarize yourself with we
first have the name of the service which
is cluster ip dash service
we then have the label used for the
selector which is the key value pair of
app inventory and then we have the
service type which is cluster ip and we
have the port number exposed internally
in the cluster which is port 80 along
with the target port that containers are
listening on which again is port 80. and
so the next service type we have is node
port
so when you create a service of type
node port you specify a node port value
the node port is a static port and is
chosen from a pre-configured range
between 30 000 and 32
you can specify your own value within
this range but please note that any
value outside of this range will not be
accepted by kubernetes as well if you do
not choose a value a random value within
the range specified will be assigned
once this port range has been assigned
to the service then the service is
accessible by using the ip address of
any node along with the no port value
the service is then exposed on a port on
every node in the cluster the service
can then be accessed externally at the
node ip along with the node port when
using node port services you must make
sure that the selected port is not
already open on your nodes and so just
as a note the no port type is an
extension of the cluster i p type so a
service of type node port naturally has
a cluster i p address and so this method
isn't very secure as it opens up each
node to external entry as well this
method relies on knowing the ip
addresses of the nodes which could
change at any time and so going through
the manifest of type node port service
we start off with the name of the
service which is node port dash service
the label used for the selector which
uses the key value pair of app inventory
the type which is node port and notice
the case sensitivity here which you will
find in most service types along with
the port number exposed internally in
the cluster which is port 80 and again
the port that the containers are
listening on which is the target port
which is port 80 as well and lastly and
most importantly we have the no port
value which is marked as you saw in the
diagram earlier as port
32002 the next service type we have up
is low balancer and this service is
exposed as a load balancer in the
cluster low balancer services will
create an internal kubernetes service
that is connected to a cloud provider's
load balancer and in this case google
cloud this will create a static publicly
addressable ip address and a dns name
that can be used to access your cluster
from an external source the low balancer
type is an extension of the no port type
so a service of type load balancer
naturally has a cluster ip address if
you want to directly expose a service
this is the default method all traffic
on the port you specify
will be forwarded to the service there
is no filtering or routing and it means
you can send many different types of
traffic to it like http https tcp or udp
and more the downside here is that for
each service you expose with a low
balancer you pay for that load balancer
and so you can really rack up your bill
if you're using multiple load balancers
and shown here is the manifest for type
load balancer it shows the name of the
service load balancer dash service the
label which is used for the selector
which is the key value pair of app
inventory
the service type which is low balancer
again notice the case sensitivity along
with the port and the target port which
are both port 80. and so this is the end
of part one of this lesson it was
getting a bit long so i decided to break
it up this would be a great opportunity
for you to get up and have a stretch get
yourself a coffee or tea and whenever
you're ready part two will be starting
immediately from the end of part one so
go ahead and mark this as complete and
i'll see you in the next one
[Music]
welcome back this is part two of the
kubernetes services lesson and we're
going to continue immediately from the
end of part one so whenever you're ready
let's dive in and so the next service
type we have is multiport services
now for some services there is the need
to expose more than one port kubernetes
lets you configure multiple port
definitions on a service object so when
using multiple ports for a service you
must give all your ports names and if
you have multiple service ports these
names must be unique in this example if
a client calls the service at 10.176.1
on tcp port 80 the request is forwarded
to a member pod on tcp port 80 on either
node 1 or node 2. but if a client calls
the service at 10.176.133.7
on tcp port 9752 the request is
forwarded to the pod on tcp port 9752
that resides on node 1. each member pod
must have a container listening on tcp
port 80 and a container listening on tcp
port 9752 this could be a single
container with two threads or two
containers running in the same pod and
of course as shown here is a manifest
showing the multi-port services
the name of the service
the label used for the selector
as well as the service type the port
node exposed internally for each
separate workload as well as the port
that containers are listening on for
each workload as well and as you saw
before nginx was using target port 80
where appy was using port 9752 moving on
to another service type is external name
now a service of type external name
provides an internal alias for an
external dns name internal clients make
requests using the internal dns name and
the requests are redirected to the
external name when you create a service
kubernetes creates a dns name that
internal clients can use to call the
service in this example the internal dns
name is bowtie.sql when an internal
client makes a request to the internal
dns name of bowtie.sql the request gets
redirected to bowtie.sql2
dot bow tie inc dot private the external
name service type is a bit different
than other service types as it's not
associated with a set of pods or an ip
address it is a mapping from an internal
dns name to an external dns name this
service does a simple cname redirection
and is a great use case for any external
service that resides outside of your
cluster and again here is a view of a
manifest for type external name here
showing the internal dns name along with
the external dns name redirect and
moving on to the last service type we
have the headless service type now
sometimes you don't need or want low
balancing and a single service ip in
this case you can create headless
services by specifying none as the
service type in the manifest file this
option also allows you to choose other
service discovery mechanisms without
being tied to kubernetes implementation
applications can still use a
self-registration pattern with this
service and so a great use case for this
is when you don't need any low balancing
or routing you only need the service to
patch the request to the back end pod no
ips needed headless service is typically
used with stateful sets where the name
of the pods are fixed this is useful in
situations like when you're setting up a
mysql cluster where you need to know the
name of the master and so here is a
manifest for the headless service again
the service type is marked as none and
so to sum it up kubernetes services
provides the interfaces through which
pods can communicate with each other
they also act as the main gateway for
your application services use selectors
to identify which pods they should
control they expose an ip address and a
port that is not necessarily the same
port at which the pod is listening and
services can expose more than one port
and can also route traffic to other
services external ip addresses or dns
names services make it really easy to
create network services in kubernetes
each service can be backed with as many
pods as needed without having to make
your code aware of how each service is
backed also please note that there are
many other features and use cases within
the services that have been mentioned
that i've not brought up i will also
include some links in the lesson text
for those who are interested in diving
deeper into services this lesson was to
merely summarize the different service
types and knowing these service types
will put you in a great position on the
exam for any questions that cover
services within gke now i know this has
been another lesson that's been
extremely heavy in theory and has been a
tremendous amount to take in but not to
worry next up is a demo that will put
all this theory into practice and we'll
be going ahead and building a cluster
along with touching on much of the
components discussed within the past few
lessons and so that's pretty much all i
wanted to cover when it comes to
kubernetes service types so you can now
mark this lesson as complete and
whenever you're ready join me in the
console
[Music]
welcome back
in this lesson i'll be going over
ingress for gke
an object within gke that defines rules
for routing traffic to specific services
ingress is a well-known topic that comes
up in the exam
as well as being a common resource that
is used in many gke clusters that you
will see in most environments
something that you will get very
familiar with while diving deeper into
more complex environments
so whenever you're ready let's dive in
now in gke an ingress object defines
rules for routing http and https traffic
to applications running in a cluster
an ingress object is associated with one
or more service objects
each of which is associated with a set
of pods
when you create an ingress object the
gke ingress controller
creates a google cloud
http or https load balancer and
configures it according to the
information in the ingress and its
associated services
gke ingress is a built-in
and managed ingress controller
this controller implements ingress
resources as google cloud load balancers
for http and https workloads in gke
also the load balancer is given a stable
ip address that you can associate with a
domain name each external http
and https load balancer or internal http
or https load balancer uses a single url
map
which references one or more back-end
services
one back-end service corresponds to each
service referenced by the ingress in
this example assume that you have
associated the load balancers ip address
with the domain name bowtieinc.co
when a client sends a request to
bowtieinc.co
the request is routed to a kubernetes
service named products on port 80. and
when a client sends a request to
bowtieinc.co
forward slash discontinued the request
is routed to a kubernetes service named
discontinued on port 21337
ingress is probably the most powerful
way to expose your services but can also
be very complex
as there are also many types of ingress
controllers to choose from
along with plugins for ingress
controllers
ingress is the most useful and cost
effective if you want to expose
multiple services under the same ip
address
as you only pay
for one load balancer if you are using
the native gcp integration
and comes with a slew of features
and so shown here is the ingress
manifest which is a bit different from
the other manifest that you've seen
as it holds rules for different paths
explain in the previous diagram in the
manifest shown here one path directs all
traffic
to the product's service name
while the other path redirects traffic
from discontinued to the back end
service name of discontinued
and note that each of these service
names have their own independent
manifest
as it is needed to create the service
and are referenced within the ingress
manifest
so the more rules you have for different
paths or ports the more services you
will need
now i wanted to touch on network
endpoint groups or any g's for short for
just a second
now this is a configuration object that
specifies a group of back-end endpoints
or services
negs are useful
for container native load balancing
where each container can be represented
as an endpoint to the load balancer the
negs are used to track pod endpoints
dynamically so the google low balancer
can route traffic to its appropriate
back ends
so traffic is low balanced from the load
balancer directly to the pod ip
as opposed to traversing the vm ip and
coupe proxy networking in these
conditions
services will be annotated automatically
indicating that a neg
should be created to mirror the pod ips
within the service the neg is what
allows compute engine load balancers to
communicate directly with pods the
diagram shown here is the ingress to
compute engine resource mappings of the
manifest that you saw earlier where the
gke ingress controller
deploys and manages compute engine low
balancer resources based on the
ingressed resources
that are deployed in the cluster
now touching on health checks for just a
minute if there are no specified health
check parameters for a corresponding
service
using a back-end custom resource
definition
a set of default and inferred parameters
are used health check parameters for a
back-end service should be explicitly
defined by creating a back-end config
custom resource definition for the
service and this should be done if
you're using anthos
a backend config custom resource
definition should also be used if you
have more than one container in the
serving pods as well if you need control
over the port that's used for the low
balancers health checks now you can
specify the backend services health
check parameters
using the health check parameter of a
back-end config custom resource
definition referenced by the
corresponding service
this gives you more flexibility and
control
over health checks for a google cloud
external http or https load balancer or
internal http or https load balancer
created by an ingress
and lastly i wanted to touch on ssl
certificates and there are three ways to
provide ssl certificates to an http or
https load balancer the first way is
google managed certificates
and these are provisioned deployed
renewed
and managed for your domains and just as
a note
managed certificates do not support
wildcard domains the second way to
provide ssl certificates is through
self-managed certificates that are
shared with google cloud you can
provision your own ssl certificate
and create a certificate resource
in your google cloud project you can
then list the certificate resource in an
annotation on an ingress to create an
http or https load balancer that uses
the certificate and the last way to
provide ssl certificates is through
self-managed certificates as secret
resources so you can provision your own
ssl certificate and create a secret to
hold it you can then refer to the secret
as an ingress specification to create an
http or https load balancer that uses
this certificate and just as a note you
can specify multiple certificates in an
ingress manifest the load balancer
chooses a certificate if the common name
in the certificate
matches the host name
used in the request and so that pretty
much covers
all the main topics in this short lesson
on ingress for gke
so you can now mark this lesson as
complete
and let's move on to the next one
[Music]
welcome back
in this lesson i'll be going over gke
storage options now kubernetes currently
offers a slew of different storage
options
and is only enhanced by the added
features available in google cloud for
gke we'll also be getting into the
different abstractions that kubernetes
offers to manage storage
and how they can be used for different
types of workloads
now there's quite a bit to go over here
so with that being said let's dive in
now as i stated before there are several
storage options for applications running
on gke
the choices vary in terms of flexibility
and ease of use
google cloud offers several storage
options that can be used for your
specific workload
kubernetes also provides storage
abstractions which i will be getting
into in just a bit the easiest storage
options are google cloud's managed
storage products if you need to connect
a database to your cluster you can
consider
using cloud sql datastore or cloud
spanner and when it comes to object
storage cloud storage would be an
excellent option to fill the gap file
store is a great option for when your
application requires
managed network attached storage and if
your application requires block storage
the best option is to use persistent
disks
and can be provisioned manually or
provisioned dynamically through
kubernetes now i wanted to first start
off with kubernetes storage abstractions
but in order to understand kubernetes
storage abstractions i wanted to take a
moment to explain how storage is mounted
in the concept of docker now docker has
a concept of volumes
though it is somewhat looser and less
managed than kubernetes
a docker volume is a directory on disk
or in another container
docker provides volume drivers but the
functionality is somewhat limited a
docker container has a writable layer
and this is where the data is stored by
default
making the data ephemeral and so data is
not persisted when the container is
removed so storing data inside a
container is not always recommended now
there are three ways to mount data
inside a docker container the first way
is a docker volume and sits inside the
docker area within the host's file
system and can be shared amongst other
containers
this volume is a docker object and is
decoupled from the container
they can be attached and shared across
multiple containers as well bind
mounting is the second way to mount data
and is coming directly from the host's
file system
bind mounts are great for local
application development
yet cannot be shared across containers
and the last way to mount data is by
using temp-fs
and is stored in the host's memory this
way is great for ephemeral data and
increases performance as it no longer
lies in the container's writable layer
now with kubernetes storage abstractions
file system and block based storage are
provided to your pods but are different
than docker in nature volumes are the
basic storage unit in kubernetes that
decouples the storage from the container
and tie it to the pod and not the
container like in docker a regular
volume simply called volume is basically
a directory that the containers in a pod
have access to the particular volume
type used is what will determine its
purpose
some volume types are backed by
ephemeral storage
like empty dir
config map and secrets and these volumes
do not persist after the pod ceases to
exist
volumes are useful for caching temporary
information
sharing files between containers
or to load data into a pod other volume
types are backed by durable storage and
persist beyond the lifetime of a pod
like persistent volumes and persistent
volume claims a persistent volume is a
cluster resource
that pods can use for durable storage a
persistent volume claim
can be used to dynamically provision a
persistent volume
backed by persistent disks persistent
volume claims can also be used to
provision other types of backing storage
like nfs
and i will be getting more into
persistent volumes and persistent volume
claims in just a bit
now as you saw in docker on disk files
in a container are the simplest place
for an application to write data but
files are lost when the container
crashes or stops for any other reason
as well as being unaccessible to other
containers running in the same pod in
kubernetes the volume source declared in
the pod specification determines how the
directory is created
the storage medium used
and the directory's initial contents
a pod specifies what volumes it contains
and the path where containers mount the
volume ephemeral volume types
live the same amount of time as the pods
they are connected to these volumes are
created when the pod is created and
persist through container restarts only
when the pod terminates or is deleted
are the volumes terminated as well other
volume types are interfaces to durable
storage that exist independently of a
pod like ephemeral volumes data in a
volume backed by durable storage
is preserved when the pod is removed
the volume is merely unmounted and the
data can be handed off to another pod
now volumes differ in their storage
implementation
and their initial contents you can
choose the volume source that best fits
your use case
and i will be going over some common
volume sources
that are used and you will see
in many gke implementations the first
volume that i want to bring up is empty
dir
now an empty dir volume provides an
empty directory that containers in the
pod can read and write from when the pod
is removed from a node for any reason
the data in the empty dir is deleted
forever an empty dir volume is stored on
whatever medium is backing the node
which might be a disk
ssd or network storage
empty der volumes are useful for scratch
space and sharing data between multiple
containers in a pod
the next type of volume that i wanted to
go over is config map
and config map is a resource that
provides a way to inject configuration
data into pods
the data stored in a config map object
can be referenced in a volume of type
config map
and then consumed through files running
in a pod the next volume type is secret
and a secret volume is used to make
sensitive data such as passwords oauth
tokens and ssh keys
available to applications
the data stored in a secret object can
be referenced in a volume of type secret
and then consumed through files running
in a pod
next volume type is downward api and
this volume makes downward api data
available to applications
so this data includes information
about the pod and container in which an
application is running in
an example of this would be to expose
information about the pods namespace and
ip address to applications and the last
volume type that i wanted to touch on is
persistent volume claim now a persistent
volume claim volume can be used to
provision durable storage so that they
can be used by applications a pod uses a
persistent volume claim
to mount a volume that is backed by this
durable storage and so now that i've
covered volumes i wanted to go into a
bit of detail about persistent volumes
persistent volume resources are used to
manage durable storage in a cluster in
gke a persistent volume
is typically backed by a persistent disk
or file store can be used as an nfs
solution unlike volumes the persistent
volume life cycle is managed by
kubernetes and can be dynamically
provisioned
without the need to manually create and
delete the backing storage persistent
volume resources are cluster resources
that exist independently of pods and
continue to persist as the cluster
changes and as pods are deleted and
recreated moving on to persistent volume
claims this is a request for
and claim to
a persistent volume resource persistent
volume claim objects request a specific
size
access mode and storage class for the
persistent volume if an existing
persistent volume can satisfy the
request or can be provisioned the
persistent volume claim is bound to that
persistent volume and just as a note
pods use claims
as volumes the cluster inspects the
claim to find the bound volume and
mounts that volume for the pod
now i wanted to take a moment to go over
storage classes and how they apply to
the overall storage in gke
now these volume implementations
such as gce persistent disk are
configured through storage class
resources
gke creates a default storage class for
you which uses the standard persistent
disk type of ext4 as shown here the
default storage class is used when a
persistent volume claim doesn't specify
a storage class name
and can also be replaced with one of
your choosing you can even create your
own storage class resources to describe
different classes of storage
and is helpful when using windows node
pools
now as i stated before persistent volume
claims can automatically provision
persistent disks for you
when you create this persistent volume
claim object
kubernetes dynamically creates a
corresponding persistent volume object
due to the gke default storage class
this persistent volume
is backed by a new empty compute engine
persistent disk you use this disk in a
pod by using the claim as a volume when
you delete a claim the corresponding
persistent volume object and the
provision compute engine persistent disk
are also deleted now to prevent deletion
you can set the reclaim policy of the
persistent disk resource
or its storage class resource to retain
now deployments as shown here in this
diagram are designed for stateless
applications
so all replicas of a deployment
share the same persistent volume claim
which is why stateful sets are the
recommended method of deploying stateful
applications
that require a unique volume per replica
by using stateful sets with persistent
volume claim templates
you can have applications that can scale
up automatically
with unique persistent volume claims
associated to each replica pod
now lastly i wanted to touch on some
topics that will determine the storage
access that is available for any gke
cluster in your environment now i first
wanted to start off with access modes
and there are three supported modes for
your persistent disks that allow read
write access and are listed here read
write once is where the volume can be
mounted as read write by a single node
read only many is where the volume can
be mounted as a read only by many nodes
and lastly read write many is where the
volume can be mounted as read write by
many nodes and just as a note
read write once is the most common use
case for persistent disks
and works as the default access mode for
most applications next i wanted to touch
on the type of persistent disks that are
available and the benefits and caveats
of access for each now going through the
persistent disks lesson of this course
you probably know by now about the
available persistent disks when it comes
to zonal versus regional availability
and so this may be a refresher for some
now going into regional persistent disks
these are multi-zonal resources that
replicate data between two zones in the
same region and can be used similarly to
zonal persistent disks in the event of a
zonal outage kubernetes can fail over
workloads using the volume to the other
zone regional persistent disks are great
for highly available solutions for
stateful workloads on gke now zonal
persistent disks
are zonal resources
and so unless a zone is specified
gke assigns the disk to a single zone
and chooses the zone at random once a
persistent disk is provisioned
any pods referencing the disk are
scheduled to the same zone as the disk
and just as a note
using anti-affinity on zones
allows stateful set pods to be spread
across zones
along with the corresponding disks and
the last point that i wanted to cover
when it comes to persistent volume
access
is the speed of access
now as stated in an earlier lesson the
size of persistent disks determine the
iops and throughput of the disk gke
typically uses persistent disks
as boot disks and to back kubernetes
persistent volumes
so whenever possible use larger and
fewer disks
to achieve higher iops and throughput
and so that pretty much covers
everything that i wanted to go over
in this lesson on gke storage options
so you can now mark this lesson as
complete
and let's move on to the next one
[Music]
welcome back in these next few demos i'm
going to be doing a complete walkthrough
and putting all the theory we learned
into practice through building and
interacting with gke clusters and you'll
be building and deploying your own
containerized application on this
cluster called box of bowties so in this
demo we're going to be setting up our
own gke cluster in the console along
with going through all the options that
are available when deploying it we're
also going to use the command line to
configure the cubectl command line tool
so that we can interact with the cluster
so with that being said let's dive in
and so here in the console i am logged
in as tonybowties gmail.com
under the project of bow tie inc and so
before launching the cluster i need to
make sure that my default vpc has been
created so i'm going to go over to the
navigation menu and i'm going to scroll
down to vpc network
and as expected the default network is
here so i can go ahead and create my
cluster and so in order to get to my
kubernetes engine console i'm going to
go up to the navigation menu and i'm
going to scroll down under compute and
you will find here kubernetes engine and
you'll see a few different options to
choose from and over here on the left
hand menu i will be going through these
options in the upcoming demos but for
now i want to concentrate on creating
our cluster now gk makes things pretty
easy
as i have the option to create a cluster
to deploy a container or even taking the
quick start and so we're going to go
ahead and click on create our cluster
and so here we are prompted with our
cluster basics now if i really wanted to
i can simply fill out all the fields
that you see here and click on create
and it will use all the defaults to
build my cluster but we're going to
customize it a little bit so we're going
to go ahead and go through all these
options so first under name we're going
to name this cluster bowtie dash cluster
and so under location type we want to
keep things as zonal and if i check off
the specify default node locations i'll
be able to make this a multi-zonal
cluster as i have the option of
selecting from multiple zones where i
can situate my nodes and so i can select
off a bunch of different zones if i
choose but we want to keep it as a
single zonal cluster and so i'm going to
check these all off
and under zone i'm going to click on the
drop down menu and i'm going to select
us east 1b and just as a note for each
zone that you select this is where the
control plane will live so if i was to
create a multi-zonal cluster as you can
see the master zone is the zone where
the control plane will be created and is
selected as us east 1b as that is the
zone that i had selected and so if i
change this
to let's say us east 1d you can see that
the control plane will change with it so
i'm going to change it back to us east
1b and you also have the option of
creating a regional cluster and the
location selection will change from zone
to region and here you will have to
specify at least one zone to select but
please also remember that the same
number of nodes will be deployed to each
selected zone so if i have three nodes
in this cluster and i decide to select
three zones then i will have nine nodes
in this cluster and so doing something
like this could get quite pricey when
you're looking to be cost conscious okay
so moving on i'm going to uncheck
specify default node locations i'm going
to change the location type back to
zonal and make sure that my zone is at
us east 1b moving down to the master
version this is where we would select
either a static version or opt-in to a
release channel for the version of
kubernetes that you want for your
cluster and so with the static version i
can choose from a bunch of different
versions here all the way back from
1.14.10
all the way to the latest version and so
with the release channel i have the
release channel selection here and i can
choose from the rapid channel the
regular channel or the stable channel
and so i'm going to keep things as the
default with the regular channel as well
i'm going to keep the default version as
the version of my choice now i could go
ahead and simply click on create here
but as this demo is a walkthrough i'm
going to go ahead and go through all the
available options so i'm going to start
by going over to the left hand menu and
clicking on default pool under no pools
now here i have one node pool already
with three nodes and this is the default
node pool that comes with any cluster
but if i was doing something specific i
could add another node pool and
configure it from here but because i
don't have a need for two node pools i'm
gonna go ahead and remove nodepool1 so
i'm going to go up here to remove
nodepool and as you can see gke makes it
really easy for me to add or remove node
pools so i'm going to go back to the
default pool and i'm going to keep the
name as is i'm gonna keep my number of
nodes as three and if i wanted to change
the number of nodes i can simply select
this i can choose six or however many
nodes you need for your workload and so
because we're not deploying a large
workload i'm gonna keep this number at 3
and moving right along we do want to
check off enable auto scaling and so
this way we don't have to worry about
scaling up or scaling down and here i'm
going to put the minimum number of nodes
as one and i'm going to keep my maximum
number of nodes at 3. and so here i'm
given the option to select the zone
location for my nodes but again for each
zone that i select it will run the same
amount of nodes so basically i have
another option in order to choose from
having a zonal or multi-zonal cluster
and because we're creating our cluster
in a single zone i'm going to uncheck
this and under automation as you can see
enable auto upgrade and enable auto
repair are both checked off and this is
due to the fact that the auto upgrade
feature is always enabled for the
release channel that i selected but as i
pointed out in a previous lesson that
this is google's best practice
to have auto upgrade and auto repair
enabled and so moving down to the bottom
are some fields to change the surge
upgrade behavior and so just as a
refresher surge upgrades allow you to
control the number of nodes gke can
upgrade at a time and control how
disruptive those upgrades are to your
workloads so max surge being the number
of additional nodes that can be added to
the node pool during an upgrade and max
unavailable being the number of nodes
that can be simultaneously unavailable
during that upgrade and because we're
not worried about disruptions we'll just
leave it set as the default and so
moving on we're going to move back over
to the left hand menu and under no pools
we're going to click on nodes and here
is where i can choose the type of
instance that i want to be using for my
nodes and so i'm going to keep the image
type as container optimize os and this
is the default image type but i also
have the option of choosing from others
like ubuntu or windows and so i'm going
to keep it as the default and under
machine configuration i'm going to keep
it under general purpose
with series e2 but i do want to change
the machine type to e2 micro just to be
cost conscious and under boot disk size
i want to keep it as 10 gigabytes as we
don't really need 100 gigabytes for what
we're doing here and you also have the
option of choosing from a different boot
disk type you can change it from
standard persistent disk to ssd but i'm
going to keep things as standard as well
i also have the option here to use
customer manage keys for encryption on
my boot disk as well as selecting from
preemptable nodes for some cost savings
and so i'm going to now move down to
networking and here if i wanted to get
really granular i can add a maximum pods
per node as well as some network tags
but our demo doesn't require this so i'm
going to leave it as is and i'm going to
go back over to the left hand menu and
click on security and under node
security you have the option of changing
your service account along with the
access scopes and so for this demo we
can keep things as the default service
account and the access scopes can be
left as is i'm going to go back over to
the left hand menu and click on metadata
and here i can add kubernetes labels as
well as the instance metadata and so i
know i didn't get into node taints but
just to fill you in on no taints when
you submit a workload to run in a
cluster the scheduler determines where
to place the pods associated with the
workload and so the scheduler will place
a pod on any node that satisfies the
resource requirements for that workload
so no taints will give you some more
control over which workloads can run on
a particular pool of nodes and so they
let you mark a node so that the
scheduler avoids or prevents using it
for certain pods so for instance if you
had a node pool that is dedicated to
gpus you'd want to keep that node pool
specifically for the workload that
requires it and although it is in beta
this is a great feature to have and so
that pretty much covers no pools as we
see it here and so this is the end of
part one of this demo it was getting a
bit long so i decided to break it up
this would be a great opportunity for
you to get up and have a stretch get
yourself a coffee or a tea and whenever
you're ready part two will be starting
immediately from the end of part one so
you can now mark this as complete and
i'll see you in the next one
[Music]
this is part two of creating a gke
cluster part 2 will be starting
immediately from the end of part 1. so
with that being said let's dive in and
so i'm going to go back over to the left
hand menu and under cluster i'm going to
click on automation and here i have the
option of enabling a maintenance window
for aligning times when auto upgrades
are allowed i have the option of adding
the window here and i can do it at
specified times during the week or i can
create a custom maintenance window and
so we don't need a maintenance window
right now so i'm going to uncheck this
and as well you have the option of doing
maintenance exclusions for when you
don't want maintenance to occur ngk
gives you the option of doing multiple
maintenance exclusions for whenever you
need them and because we don't need any
maintenance exclusions i'm going to
delete these and here you have the
option to enable vertical pod auto
scaling and this is where gke will
automatically schedule pods onto other
nodes that satisfy the resources
required for that workload as well here
i can enable my node auto provisioning
and enabling this option allows gke to
automatically manage a set of node pools
that can be created and deleted as
needed and i have a bunch of fields that
i can choose from the resource type the
minimum and maximum for cpu and memory
the service account
as well as adding even more resources
like gpus but our workload doesn't
require anything this fancy so i'm going
to delete this and i'm going to uncheck
enable auto provisioning and lastly we
have the auto scaling profile and i have
the option from choosing the balance
profile which is the default as well as
the optimize utilization which is still
in beta and so i'm going to keep things
as the default and i'm going to move
back on over to the left hand menu over
to networking and so here i can get
really granular with my cluster when it
comes to networking i have the option of
choosing from a public or a private
cluster as well i can choose from a
different network and since we only have
the default that's what shows up but if
you had different networks here you can
choose from them as well as the subnets
i can also choose from other networking
options like pod address range maximum
pods per node and there's a bunch of
other options which i won't get into any
detail with but i encourage you if
you're very curious to go through the
docs and to check out these different
options now the one thing that i wanted
to note here is the enable http low
balancing and this is a add-on that is
required in order to use google cloud
load balancer and so as we discussed
previously in the services lesson when
you enable service type load balancer a
load balancer will be created for you by
the cloud provider and so google
requires you to check this off so that a
controller can be installed in the
cluster upon creation and will allow a
load balancer to be created when the
service is created and so i'm going to
leave this checked as we will be
deploying a load balancer a little bit
later and so moving back over to the
left hand menu i'm going to now click on
security and there are many options here
to choose from that will allow you to
really lock down your cluster and again
this would all depend on your specific
type of workload now i'm not going to go
through all these options here but i did
want to highlight it for those who are
looking to be more security focused with
your cluster and so moving down the list
in the menu i'm going to click on
metadata and so here i can enter a
description for my cluster as well as
adding labels and so the last option on
the cluster menu is features and here i
have the option of running cloud run for
anthos which will allow you to deploy
serverless workloads to anthos clusters
and runs on top of gke and here you can
enable monitoring for gke and have it be
natively monitored by google cloud
monitoring and if i was running a
third-party product to monitor my
cluster i can simply uncheck this and
use my third-party monitoring and
there's a whole bunch of other features
that i won't dive into right now but if
you're curious you can always hover over
the question mark and get some more
information about what it does and so
now i've pretty much covered all the
configuration that's needed for this
cluster and so now i'm going to finally
head down to the bottom and click on
create and so it may take a few minutes
to create this cluster so i'm going to
go ahead and pause this video here and
i'll be back faster than you can say cat
in the hat okay and the cluster has been
created as you can see it's in the
location of us east 1b with three nodes
six vcpus and three gigabytes of memory
and i can drill down and see exactly the
details of the cluster as well if i
wanted to edit any of these options i
can simply go up to the top click on
edit and make the necessary changes and
so now you're probably wondering what
will i need to do in order to create
this cluster through the command line
well it's a bit simpler than what you
think and i'm going to show you right
now i'm going to simply go over to the
right hand menu and activate cloud shell
and bring this up for better viewing and
i'm going to paste in my command gcloud
container clusters create bow tie dash
cluster with the flag num nodes and the
number of nodes that i choose which is
three and so like i said before if i
wanted to simply create a simple cluster
i can do so like this but if i wanted to
create the cluster exactly how i built
my last cluster then i can use this
command which has all the necessary
flags that i need to make it customize
to my liking a not so very exciting
demonstration but at the same time shows
you how easy yet powerful gke really is
and so i'm not going to launch this
cluster as i already have one and so now
i wanted to show you how to interact
with your new gke cluster so i'm going
to simply clear my screen and so now in
order for me to interact with my cluster
i'm going to be using the cube ctl
command line tool and this is the tool
that is used to interact with any
kubernetes cluster no matter the
platform now i could use the gcloud
container commands but they won't allow
me to get very granular as the cubectl
tool and so a caveat of creating your
cluster through the console is that you
need to run a command in order to
retrieve the cluster's credentials and
configure the cubectl command line tool
and i'm going to go ahead and paste that
in now and the command is gcloud
container clusters get dash credentials
and the name of my cluster which is bow
tie dash cluster along with the zone
flag dash dash zone followed by the zone
itself which is us east 1b i'm going to
go ahead and hit enter and as you can
see cubectl has now been configured and
so now i'm able to interact with my
cluster so just to verify i'm going to
run the command cubectl
getpods and naturally as no workloads
are currently deployed in the cluster
there are no pods so i'm going to run
the command cube ctl get nodes
and as you can see the cubectl command
line tool is configured correctly and so
now this cluster is ready to have
workloads deployed to it and is also
configured with the cubectl command line
tool so that you're able to manage the
cluster and troubleshoot if necessary
now i know that there has been a ton of
features that i covered but i wanted to
give you the full walkthrough so that
you are able to tie in some of the
theory from the last few lessons and get
a feel for the gke cluster as we will be
getting more involved with it over the
next couple of demos and so that's
pretty much all i wanted to cover when
it comes to creating and setting up a
gke cluster so you can now mark this as
complete and whenever you're ready join
me in the console in the next one where
you will be building your box a bow ties
container to deploy to your new cluster
but if you are not planning to go
straight into the next demo i do
recommend that you delete your cluster
to avoid any unnecessary costs and
recreate it when you are ready to go
into the next demo
[Music]
welcome back now in the last lesson you
built a custom gke cluster and
configured the cube ctl command line
tool to interact with the cluster in
this lesson you're going to be building
a docker image for a box of bow ties
using cloud build which will then be
pushed over to google cloud container
registry so that you can deploy it to
your current gke cluster and so as you
can see there's a lot to do here so with
that being said let's dive in so now the
first thing that you want to do is to
clone your repo within cloud shell so
you can run the necessary commands to
build your image so i'm going to go up
here to the top right and i'm going to
open up cloud shell i'm going to make
sure that i'm in my home directory so
i'm going to run the command cd space
tilde
hit enter and i'm in my home directory
if i run the command ls i can see that i
only have cloud shell.txt and so now i'm
going to clone my github repository and
i'll have a link in the instructions in
the github repo as well as having it in
the lesson text below and so the command
would be git clone along with the https
address of the github repo and i'm going
to hit enter
and it's finished cloning my repo i'm
going to quickly clear my screen
and i'm going to run the command ls and
i can see my repo here and now i'm going
to drill down into the directory by
running cd google cloud associate cloud
engineer if i run an ls i can see all my
clone files and folders and so now the
files that we need are going to be found
in the box of bowties folder under
kubernetes engine and containers so i'm
going to change directories to that
location and run ls and under box of bow
ties is a folder called container which
will have all the necessary files that
you need in order to build your image we
have the jpeg for box of bow ties we
have the docker file and we have our
index.html and so these are the three
files that we need in order to build the
image and so as i said before we are
going to be using a tool called cloud
build which we have not discussed yet
cloudbuild is a serverless ci cd
platform that allows me to package
source code into containers and you can
get really fancy with cloud build but
we're not going to be setting up any ci
cd pipelines we're merely using cloud
build to build our image and to push it
out to container registry as well
container registry is google cloud's
private docker repository where you can
manage your docker images and integrates
with cloud build gke app engine cloud
functions
and other repos like github or bitbucket
and it allows for an amazing build
experience with absolutely no heavy
lifting and because you're able to build
images without having to leave google
cloud i figured that this would be a
great time to highlight these services
so getting back to it we've cloned the
repo and so we have our files here in
cloud shell and so what you want to do
now is you want to make sure the cloud
build api has been enabled as this is a
service that we haven't used before now
we can go through the console and enable
the api there but i'm going to run it
here from cloud shell and i'm going to
paste in the command gcloud services
enable cloudbuild.googleapis.com
i'm going to hit enter and you should
get a prompt asking you to authorize the
api call you definitely want to
authorize
should take a few seconds all right and
the api has been enabled for cloud build
so now i'm going to quickly clear my
screen and so because i want to show you
exactly what cloud build is doing i want
to head on over there through the
console and so i'm going to go over to
the navigation menu and i'm going to
scroll down to tools until you come to
cloud build
and as expected there is nothing here in
the build history as well not a lot here
to interact with and so now you're going
to run the command that builds the image
and so you're going to paste that
command into the cloud shell which is
gcloud builds submit dash dash tag
gcr.io which is the google cloud
container registry our variable for our
google cloud project along with the
image name of box bow ties version 1.0.0
and please don't forget the trailing dot
at the end i'm going to go ahead and hit
enter cloud build will now compress the
files and move them to a cloud storage
bucket and then cloud build takes those
files from the bucket and uses the
docker file to execute the docker build
process and so i'm going to pause the
video here till the build completes and
i'll be back in a flash okay and the
image is complete and is now showing up
in the build history in the cloud build
dashboard and so if i want to drill down
into the actual build right beside the
green check mark you will see the hot
link so you can just simply click on
that and here you will see a build
summary with the build log
the execution details along with the
build artifacts and as well the
compressed files are stored in cloud
storage and it has a hot link right here
if i wanted to download the build log i
can do so here and i conveniently have a
hot link to the image of box of bow ties
and this will bring me to my container
registry so you can go ahead and click
on the link
it should open up another tab and bring
you right to the page of the image that
covers a lot of its details now the
great thing i love about container
registry is again it's so tightly
coupled with a lot of the other
resources within google cloud that i am
able to simply deploy right from here
and i can deploy to cloud run to gke as
well as compute engine now i could
simply deploy this image right from here
but i wanted to do it from gke so i'm
going to go back over to gke in the
other tab i'm going to go to the
navigation menu go down to kubernetes
engine
and i'm going to go up to the top menu
and click on deploy it's going to ask
for the image you want to deploy and you
want to click on select to select a new
container image and you should have a
menu pop up from the right hand side of
your screen and under container registry
you should see box of bow ties you can
expand the node here and simply click on
the image and then hit select
and so now the container image has been
populated into my image path and you
want to scroll down and if i wanted to i
could add another container and even add
some environment variables and so we're
not looking to do that right now so you
can simply click on continue and you're
going to be prompted with some fields to
fill out for your configuration on your
deployment and so the application name
is going to be called box of bow ties
i'm going to keep it in the default
namespace as well i'm going to keep the
key value pair as app box of bow ties
for my labels and because this
configuration will create a deployment
file for me you can always have a look
at the manifest by clicking on the view
yaml button before it's deployed and
this is always good practice before you
deploy any workload so as you can see
here at the top i have the kind as
deployment the name as well as the
namespace my labels
replicas of three as well as my selector
and my spec down here at the bottom as
well this manifest also holds another
kind
of horizontal pod auto scaler and is
coupled with the deployment in this
manifest due to the reference of the
deployment itself and so it's always
common practice to try and group the
manifest together whenever you can and
so this is a really cool feature to take
advantage of on gke so i'm going to
close this now and i'm actually going to
close cloud shell as i don't need it
right now as well you can see here that
it's going to deploy to my kubernetes
cluster of bow tie cluster in us east 1b
and if i wanted to i can deploy it to a
new cluster and if i had any other
clusters in my environment they would
show up here and i'd be able to select
from them as well but bow tie cluster is
the only one that i have and so now that
you've completed your configuration for
your deployment you can simply click on
deploy this is just going to take a
couple minutes so i'm just going to
pause the video here and i'll be back as
soon as the deployment is done okay the
workload has been deployed and i got
some default messages that popped up i
can set an automated pipeline for this
workload but we're not going to do that
for this demo but feel free to try it on
your own later if you'd like and we will
want to expose our service as we want to
see if it's up and running and we're
going to take care of that in just a bit
and so if i scroll through some of the
details here i can see that i have some
metrics here for cpu memory and disk the
cluster
namespace
labels and all the pods that it's
running on basically a live visual
representation of my deployment if i
scroll back up to the top i can dive
into some details events
and even my manifest i can also copy my
manifest and download it if i'd like so
as you can see a lot of different
options and so now i want to verify my
deployment and so i'm going to use the
cube ctl command line tool to run some
commands to verify the information so
i'm going to open back up my cloud shell
and make this a little bit bigger for
better viewing and i'm going to run the
command cubectl get all
and as you can see here i have a list of
all the pods that are running the name
of the service the deployment the
replica set everything about my cluster
and my deployment and you should be
seeing the same when running this
command and so next you want to pull up
the details on your deployments in the
cluster and so the command for that is
cube ctl get deployments and it came out
kind of crammed at the bottom so i'm
going to simply clear my screen and run
that command again
and as you can see the box of bowties
deployment is displayed how many
replicas that are available how many of
those replicas achieve their desired
state and along with how long the
application has been running and so now
i want to dive into my pods and in order
to do that i'm going to run the command
cube ctl get pods and here i can see all
my pods now if i wanted to look at a
list of events
for a specific pod the command for that
would be cubectl describe pod and then
the name of one of the pods so i'm going
to pick this first one copy that i'm
going to paste it and i'm going to hit
enter and here i can see all the events
that have occurred for this pod as well
i also have access to some other
information with regards to volumes
conditions and even the container and
image ids and this is a great command to
use for when you're troubleshooting your
pods and you're trying to get to the
bottom of a problem and so now the final
step that you want to do is you want to
be able to expose your application so
you can check to see if it's running
properly and so we're going to go ahead
and do that through the console so i'm
going to close down cloud shell and i'm
going to go to overview and scroll down
to the bottom click on the button that
says expose and if i wanted to i can do
it from up here in the top right hand
corner where it says expose deployment
so i'm going to click on expose and this
probably looks very familiar to you as
this is a graphical representation of
the services manifest and so the port
mapping here will cover the ports
configuration of the services manifest
starting here with port target port as
well as protocol for target port i'm
going to open up port 80. here under
service type you have the option of
selecting cluster ip
node port or load balancer and the
service type you want to use is going to
be low balancer and we can keep the
service name as box of bowties service
and again you can view the manifest file
for this service and you can copy or
download it if you need to but we don't
need this right now so i'm going to
close it in a pretty simple process
so all i need to do is click on expose
and within a minute or two you should
have your service up and running with
your shiny new low balancer okay and the
service has been created and as you can
see we're under the services and ingress
from the left hand menu and if i go back
to the main page of services in ingress
you can see that box a bow tie service
is the only one that's here i also have
the option of creating a service type
ingress but we don't want to do that
right now so i'm going to go back to
services and here you will see your
endpoint and this is the hot link that
should bring you to your application so
you can click on it now you'll get a
redirect notice as it is only http and
not https so it's safe to click on it so
i'm going to click on it now and success
and here is your box of bow ties
what were you expecting and so i wanted
to congratulate you on deploying your
first application box of bow ties on
your gke cluster and so just as a recap
you've cloned your repo into your cloud
shell environment you then built a
container image using cloud build and
pushed the image to container registry
you then created a deployment using this
image and verified the deployment using
the cube ctl command line tool you then
launched a service of type low balancer
to expose your application and verified
that your application was working so
fantastic job on your part and that's
pretty much all i wanted to cover in
this part of the demo
so you can now mark this as complete and
whenever you're ready join me in the
console for the next part of the demo
where you will manage your workload on
the gke cluster so please be aware of
the charges incurred on your currently
deployed cluster if you plan to do the
next demo at a later date again you can
mark this as complete and i'll see you
in the next
welcome back in the last couple of demo
lessons you built a custom gke cluster
and deployed the box of bowties
application in this lesson you will be
interacting with this workload on gke by
scaling the application editing your
application and rebuilding your docker
image so you can do a rolling update to
the current workload in your cluster now
there's a lot to do here so with that
being said let's dive in so continuing
where we left off you currently have
your box of bow ties workload deployed
on your gke cluster and so the first
thing you want to do is scale your
deployment and you are looking to scale
down your cluster to one pod and then
back up again to three and this is just
to simulate scaling your workload so
whether it be ten pods or one the action
is still the same so now we can easily
do it through the console by drilling
down into the box of bowties workload
going up to the top menu and clicking on
actions and clicking on scale and here i
can indicate how many replicas i'd like
and scale it accordingly and so i wanted
to do this using the command line so i'm
going to cancel out of here and then i'm
going to open up cloud shell instead
okay and now that you have cloud shell
open up you want to run the command cube
ctl get pods to show the currently
running available pods for the box of
bowties workload and you may get a
pop-up asking you to authorize the api
call using your credentials and you
definitely want to authorize and here
you will get a list of all the pods that
are running your box of bow ties
workload and so now since you want to
scale your replicas down to one you can
run this command cube ctl scale
deployment and your workload which is
box of bowties dash dash replicas is
equal to one you can hit enter and it is
now scaled
and in order to verify that i'm going to
run cube ctl get pods and notice that
there is only one pod running with my
box of bow ties workload and in order
for me to scale my deployment back up to
three replicas i can simply run the same
command but change the replicas from 1
to 3. hit enter it's been scaled i'm
going to run cube ctl get pods and
notice that i am now back up to 3
replicas and so as you can see
increasing or decreasing the number of
replicas in order to scale your
application is pretty simple to do okay
so now that you've learned how to scale
your application you're gonna learn how
to perform a rolling update but in order
to do that you need to make changes to
your application and so what you're
going to do is edit your application
then rebuild your docker image and apply
a rolling update and in order to do that
we can stay here in cloud shell as
you're going to edit the file in cloud
shell editor i'm going to first clear my
screen i'm going to change directory
into my home directory and now you want
to change directories to your container
folder where the files are that i need
to edit i'm going to run ls and here's
the files that i need and so what you're
going to do now is edit the
index.html file and the easiest way to
do that is to simply type in edit
index.html and hit enter and this will
open up your editor so you can edit your
index.html file and if you remember when
we launched our application it looked
exactly like this and so instead of what
were you expecting we're going to
actually change that text to something a
little different and so i'm going to go
back to the editor in my other tab and
where it says what were you expecting
i'm going to actually change this to
well i could always use something to eat
then i'm going to go back up to the menu
click on file and click on save and so
now in order for me to deploy this i
need to rebuild my container and so i'm
going to go back to my terminal i'm
going to clear the screen and i'm going
to run the same command that i did the
last time which is gcloud build submit
dash dash tag gcr dot io with the
variable for your google cloud project
followed by the image box of bowties
colon
1.0.1 and so this will be a different
version of the image also don't forget
that trailing dot at the end and you can
hit enter and again this is the process
where cloud build compresses the files
moves them to a cloud storage bucket and
then takes the files from the bucket and
uses the docker file to execute the
docker build process and this will take
a couple minutes so i'm going to pause
the video here and i'll be back before
you can say cat in the hat okay and my
new image has been created and so i want
to head over to cloud build just to make
sure that there are no errors so i'm
going to close down cloud shell because
i don't need it right now i'm going to
head back up to the navigation menu and
scroll down to cloud build and under
build history you should see your second
build and if you drill down into it you
will see that the build was successful
and heading over to build artifacts you
should now see your new image as version
1.0.1 and so now i'm going to head over
to the registry and verify the image
there and it seems like everything looks
okay so now i'm gonna head back on over
to my gke cluster
i'm gonna go to the navigation menu down
to kubernetes engine and here i'm gonna
click on workloads i'm gonna select box
of bowties and up at the top menu you
can click on actions and select a
rolling update and here you are prompted
with a pop-up where you can enter in
your minimum seconds ready your maximum
search percentage as well as your
maximum unavailable percentage and so
here under container images i am
prompted to enter in the sha-256 hash of
this docker image now a docker image's
id is a digest which contains a sha-256
hash of the image's configuration and if
i go back over to the open tab for
container registry you can see here the
digest details to give you a little bit
more context along with the sha 256 hash
for the image that i need to deploy and
so you can copy this digest by simply
clicking on the copy button and then you
can head back on over to the gke console
head over to the container images
highlight the hash and paste in the new
hash and so when you copy it in make
sure it's still in the same format of
gcr dot io forward slash your project
name forward slash box of bow ties the
at symbol followed by the hash and so
once you've done that you can click on
the update button and this will schedule
an update for your application and as
you can see here at the top it says that
pods are pending
as well if i go down to active revisions
you can see here that there is a summary
and the status that pods are pending and
so just as a note
rolling updates allow the deployments
update to take place with zero downtime
by incrementally updating pods instances
with new ones so the pods will be
scheduled on nodes with available
resources and if the nodes do not have
enough resources the pods will stay in a
pending state but i don't think we're
going to have any problems with these
nodes as this application is very light
in resources and if i open up cloud
shell
and run a cube ctl get pods command
you will see that new pods have started
and you can tell this by the age of the
pod as well if you ran the command keep
ctl describe pod along with the pod name
you could also see the event logs when
the pod was created and if i close cloud
shell i can see up here at the top of my
deployment details it shows that my
replicas have one updated four ready
three available and one unavailable and
if i click on refresh i can see now that
my replicas are all updated and
available and so now in order to check
your new update you can simply go down
to exposing services and click on the
endpoints link you'll get that redirect
notice you can simply click on the link
and because the old site may be cached
in your browser you may have to refresh
your web page
and success and you have now completed a
rolling update in gke so i wanted to
congratulate you on making it to the end
of this multi-part demo and hope that
it's been extremely useful in excelling
your knowledge in gke and so just as a
recap you scaled your application to
accommodate both less and more replicas
you edited your application in the cloud
shell editor and rebuilt your container
image using cloud build you then applied
the new digest to your rolling update
and applied that rolling update to your
deployment while verifying it all in the
end fantastic job on your part as this
was a pretty complex and long multi-part
demo and you can expect things like what
you've experienced in this demo to pop
up in your role of being a cloud
engineer when dealing with gke and so
that's pretty much all i wanted to cover
with this multi-part demo working with
gke so before you go i wanted to take a
few moments to delete all the resources
you've created one by one so i'm going
to go up to the top i'm going to close
all my tabs i'm going to head on over to
clusters and so i don't want to delete
my cluster just yet but the first thing
that i want to do is delete my container
images so i'm going to head up to the
top and open up cloud shell
and i'm going to use the command gcloud
container images delete gcr dot io
forward slash your google cloud project
variable forward slash along with your
first image of box of bow ties colon
1.0.0
hit enter it's going to prompt you if
you want to continue you want to hit y
for yes and it has now deleted the image
as well you want to delete your latest
image which is
1.0.1 so i'm going to change the zero to
one hit enter it's going to ask if you
want to continue yes and so the
container images have now been deleted
and so now along with the images you
want to delete the artifacts as well and
those are stored in cloud storage so i'm
going to close down cloud shell i'm
going to head on up to the navigation
menu and i'm going to head down to
storage and you want to select your
bucket that has your project name
underscore cloud build select the source
folder and click on delete and you're
going to get a prompt asking you to
delete the selected folder but in order
to do this you need to type in the name
of the folder so i'm going to type it in
now
you can click on confirm and so now the
folder has been deleted along with the
artifacts and so now that we've taken
care of the images along with the
artifacts we need to clean up our gke
cluster so i'm going to head back on up
to the navigation menu and i'm going to
head on over to kubernetes engine and
the first thing that i want to delete is
the low balancer so i'm going to head on
up to services and ingress and you can
select box of bow tie service and go up
to the top and click on delete you're
going to get a confirmation and you want
to click on delete and it's going to
take a couple minutes you do quick
refresh and the service has finally been
deleted i now want to delete my workload
so i'm going to go over to the left hand
menu click on workloads select the
workload box of bowties and go up to the
top and click on delete and you want to
delete all resources including the
horizontal pod auto scaler so you can
simply click on delete and it may take a
few minutes to delete gonna go up to the
top and hit refresh and my workload has
been deleted and so now all that's left
to delete is the gke cluster itself so
i'm going to go back to clusters so
you're going to select the cluster and
go up to the top and click on delete and
you're going to get a prompt asking you
if you want to delete these storage pods
and these are default storage pods that
are installed with the cluster as well
you can delete the cluster while the
workload is still in play but i have
this habit of being thorough so i wanted
to delete the workload before deleting
the cluster and so you want to go ahead
and click on delete and so that's pretty
much all i have for this demo
and this section on google kubernetes
engine and again congrats on the great
job you can now mark this as complete
and i'll see you in the next one
[Music]
welcome back and in this lesson i will
be covering the features of cloud vpn an
essential service for any engineer to
know about when looking to connect
another network to google cloud whether
it be your on-premises network another
cloud provider
or even when connecting to vpcs
this service is a must know for any
engineer and for the exam so with that
being said let's dive in
now cloudvpn securely connects your peer
network to your vpc network through an
ipsec vpn connection when i talk about a
peer network this is referring to an
on-premises vpn device or vpn service a
vpn gateway hosted by another cloud
provider such as aws or azure or another
google cloud vpn gateway and so this is
an ipsec or encrypted tunnel from your
peer network to your vpc network that
traverses the public internet and so for
those who don't know ipsec being short
for internet security protocol and this
is a set of protocols using algorithms
allowing the transport of secure data
over an ip network ipsec operates at the
network layer so layer 3 of the osi
model which allows it to be independent
of any applications although it does
come with some additional overhead so
please be aware and so when creating
your cloud vpn
traffic traveling between the two
networks is encrypted by one vpn gateway
and then decrypted by the other vpn
gateway now moving on to some details
about cloud vpn this is a regional
service and so please take that into
consideration when connecting your
on-premises location to google cloud for
the least amount of latency it also
means that if that region were to go
down you would lose your connection
until the region is back up and running
now cloud vpn is also a site-to-site vpn
only and therefore it does not support
site-to-client so this means that if you
have a laptop or a computer at home you
cannot use this option with a vpn client
to connect to google cloud cloudvpn can
also be used in conjunction with private
google access for your on-premises hosts
so if you're using private google access
within gcp you can simply connect to
your data center with vpn and have
access as if you were already in gcp so
if you're looking to extend private
google access to your on-premises data
center cloud vpn would be the perfect
choice and so when it comes to speeds
each cloud vpn tunnel can support up to
three gigabits per second total for
ingress and egress as well routing
options that are available are both
static and dynamic but are only
available as dynamic for aha vpn and
lastly cloudvpn supports ik version 1
and ike version 2 using shared secret
and for those of you who are unaware ike
stands for internet key exchange and
this helps establish a secure
authenticated communication channel by
using a key exchange algorithm to
generate a shared secret key to encrypt
communications so know that when you
choose cloudvpn that your connection is
both private and secure so now there are
two types of vpn options that are
available in google cloud one being the
classic vpn and the other being h a vpn
and i'm going to take a moment to go
through the differences now with classic
vpn this provides a service level
agreement of 99.9 percent also known as
an sla of three nines while h a vpn
provides a four nines sla when
configured with two interfaces and two
external ips now when it comes to
routing classic vpn supports both static
and dynamic routing whereas havpn
supports dynamic routing only and this
must be done through bgp using cloud
router classic vpn gateways have a
single interface
and a single external ip address and
support tunnels using static routing as
well as dynamic routing and the static
routing can be either route based or
policy based whereas with havpn it can
be configured for two interfaces and two
external ips for true ha capabilities
and as mentioned earlier when it comes
to routing for havpn dynamic routing is
the only available option now the one
thing about classic vpn is that google
cloud is deprecating certain
functionality on october 31st of 2021
and is recommending all their customers
to move to h a vpn and so know that this
has not been reflected in the exam and
not sure if and when it will be but know
that when you are creating a cloud vpn
connection in your current environment h
a vpn is the recommended option and so
now i wanted to dive into some
architecture of how cloud vpn is set up
for these two options starting with
classic vpn
now as i said before classic vpn is a
cloud vpn solution
that lets you connect your peer network
to your vpc network through an ipsec vpn
connection in a single region now unlike
h a vpn classic vpn offers no redundancy
out of the box you would have to create
another vpn connection and if the
connection were to go down you would
have to manually switch over the
connection from one to the other now as
you can see here when you create a vpn
gateway google cloud automatically
chooses only one external ip address for
its interface and the diagram shown here
shows that of a classic vpn network
connected from the bowtie dash network
vpc in bowtie project to an on-premises
network configured using a static route
to connect now moving on to h-a-v-p-n
again this is a highly available cloud
vpn solution that lets you connect your
peer network to your vpc network using
an ipsec vpn connection in a single
region exactly like classic vpn where
havpn differs is that it provides four
nines sla and as you can see here it
supports double the connections so when
you create an h a vpn gateway google
cloud automatically chooses two external
ip addresses
one for each of its fixed number of two
interfaces each ip address is
automatically chosen from a unique
address pool to support high
availability each of these ha vpn
gateway interfaces supports multiple
tunnels which allows you to create
multiple h a vpn gateways and you can
configure an h a vpn gateway with only
one active interface and one public ip
address however this configuration does
not provide a four nines sla now for h a
vpn gateway you configure an external
peer vpn gateway resource that
represents your physical peer gateway in
google cloud you can also create this
resource as a standalone resource and
use it later in this diagram the two
interfaces of an h a vpn gateway in the
bowtie network vpc living in bowtie
project are connected to two peer vpn
gateways in an on-premises network and
this connection is using dynamic routing
with bgp connecting to a cloud router in
google cloud now when it comes to the
times when using cloudvpn makes sense
one of the first things you should think
about is whether or not you need public
internet access so when you're sharing
files or your company needs a specific
sas product that's only available on the
internet vpn would be your only option
as well when you're looking to use
interconnect and your peering location
is not available so you're not able to
connect your data center to the
colocation facility of your choice vpn
would be the only other option that you
have as well if budget constraints come
into play when deciding on connecting to
your peer network vpn would always be
the way to go as cloud interconnect is
going to be the more expensive option
and lastly if you don't need a high
speed network and low latency is not
really a concern for you and you only
have regular outgoing traffic coming
from google cloud then vpn would suffice
for your everyday needs and so the
options shown here are also the deciding
factors to look for when it comes to
questions in the exam that refer to
cloudvpn or connecting networks and so
that's pretty much all i have for this
short lesson on cloudvpn so you can now
mark this lesson as complete and let's
move on to the next one
[Music]
welcome back and in this lesson i'm
going to go over another connection type
that allows for on-premises connectivity
to your google cloud vpcs which is cloud
interconnect other than vpn this is the
other connection type that allows
connectivity from your on-premises
environment to your google cloud vpc
cloud interconnect is the most common
connection for most larger organizations
and are for those that demand fast low
latency connections this lesson will
cover the features of cloud interconnect
and the different types that are
available so with that being said let's
dive in so getting right into it cloud
interconnect is a low latency highly
available connection between your
on-premises data center and google cloud
vpc networks also cloud interconnect
connections provide internal ip address
connection which means internal ip
addresses are directly accessible from
both networks and so on premises hosts
can use internal ip addresses and take
advantage of private google access
rather than external ip addresses to
reach google apis and services traffic
between your on-premises network and
your vpc network doesn't traverse the
public internet traffic traverses a
dedicated connection or through a
service provider with a dedicated
connection your vpc network's internal
ip addresses are directly accessible
from your on-premises network now unlike
vpn this connection is not encrypted if
you need to encrypt your traffic at the
ip layer you can create one or more
self-managed vpn gateways in your vpc
network and assign a private ip address
to each gateway now although this may be
a very fast connection it also comes
with a very high price tag now unlike
vpn this connection type is not
encrypted if you need to encrypt your
traffic at the ip layer you can create
one or more self-managed vpn gateways in
your vpc network and assign a private ip
address to each gateway now although
this may be a very fast connection it
also comes with a very high price tag
and is the highest price connection type
cloud interconnect offers two options
for extending your on-premises network
dedicated interconnect which provides a
direct physical connection between your
on-premises network and google's network
as well as partner interconnect which
provides connectivity between your
on-premises and vpc networks through a
supported service provider and so i
wanted to take a moment to highlight the
different options for cloud interconnect
starting with dedicated interconnect now
dedicated interconnect provides a direct
physical connection between your
on-premises network and google's network
dedicated interconnect enables you to
transfer large amounts of data between
your network and google cloud which can
be more cost effective than purchasing
additional bandwidth over the public
internet for dedicated interconnect you
provision a dedicated interconnect
connection between the google network
and your own router in a common location
the following example shown here shows a
single dedicated interconnect connection
between a vpc network and an on-premises
network for this basic setup a dedicated
interconnect connection is provisioned
between the google network and the
on-premises router in a common
co-location facility when you create a
vlan attachment you associate it with a
cloud router this cloud router creates a
bgp session for the vlan attachment and
its corresponding on-premises peer
router these routes are added as custom
dynamic routes in your vpc network and
so for dedicated interconnect connection
capacity is delivered over one or more
10 gigabits per second or 100 gigabits
per second ethernet connections with the
follow-on maximum capacity supported per
interconnect connection so with your 10
gigabit per second connections you can
get up to eight connections totaling a
speed of 80 gigabits per second with the
100 gigabit per second connection you
can connect two of them together to have
a total speed of 200 gigabits per second
and so for dedicated interconnect your
network must physically meet google's
network in a supported co-location
facility also known as an interconnect
connection location this facility
is where a vendor the co-location
facility provider provisions a circuit
between your network and a google edge
point of presence also known as a pop
the setup shown here is suitable for
non-critical applications that can
tolerate some downtime but for sensitive
production applications at least two
interconnect connections in two
different edge availability domains are
recommended now partner interconnect
provides connectivity between your
on-premises network and your vpc network
through a supported service provider so
this is not a direct connection from
your on-premises network to google as
the service provider provides a conduit
between your on-premises network and
google's pop now a partner interconnect
connection is useful if a dedicated
interconnect co-location facility is
physically out of reach or your
workloads don't warrant an entire 10
gigabit per second connection for
partner interconnect 50 megabits per
second to 50 gigabits per second vlan
attachments are available with the
maximum supported attachment size of 50
gigabits per second now service
providers have existing physical
connections to google's network that
they make available for their customer
to use so in this example shown here you
would provision a partner interconnect
connection with a service provider and
connecting your on-premises network to
that service provider after connectivity
is established with the service provider
a partner interconnect connection is
requested from the service provider and
the service provider configures your vln
attachment for use once your connection
is provisioned you can start passing
traffic between your networks by using
the service providers network now there
are many more detailed steps involved to
get a connection established along with
traffic flowing but i just wanted to
give you a high level summary of how a
connection would be established with a
service provider now as well to build a
highly available topology you can use
multiple service providers as well you
must build redundant connections for
each service provider in each
metropolitan and so now there's a couple
more connection types that run through
service providers that are not on the
exam but i wanted you to be aware of
them if ever the situation arises in
your role as a cloud engineer so the
first one is direct peering and direct
peering enables you to establish a
direct peering connection between your
business network and google's edge
network and exchange high throughput
cloud traffic this capability is
available at any of more than 100
locations in 33 countries around the
world when established direct peering
provides a direct path from your
on-premises network to google services
including google cloud products that can
be exposed through one or more public ip
addresses traffic from google's network
to your on-premises network also takes
that direct path
including traffic from vpc networks in
your projects now you can also save
money and receive direct egress pricing
for your projects after they have
established direct peering with google
direct peering exists outside of google
cloud unless you need to access google
workspace applications the recommended
methods of access to google cloud are
dedicated interconnect or partner
interconnect establishing a direct
peering connection with google is free
and there are no costs per port and no
per hour charges you just have to meet
google's technical peering requirements
and can then be considered for the
direct peering service
and moving on to the last connection
type is cdn interconnect now i know we
haven't gotten into cdns in the course
as the exam does not require you to know
it but cdn standing for content delivery
network is what caches content at the
network edge to deliver files faster to
those requesting it one of the main ways
to improve website performance now
moving on to cdn interconnect this
connection type enables select
third-party cdn providers like akamai
and cloudflare along with others to
establish and optimize your cdn
population costs by using direct peering
links with google's edge network and
enables you to direct your traffic from
your vpc networks to the provider's
network and so your egress traffic from
google cloud through one of these links
benefits from the direct connectivity to
the cdn provider and is billed
automatically with reduced pricing
typical use cases for cdn interconnect
is if you're populating your cdn with
large data files from google cloud or
you have frequent content updates stored
in different cdn locations and so
getting into the use cases of when to
use cloud interconnect a big purpose for
it would be to prevent traffic from
traversing the public internet it is a
dedicated physical connection right to
google's data centers so when you need
an extension of your vpc network to your
on-premises network interconnect is
definitely the way to go now in speed
and low latencies of extreme importance
interconnect is always the best option
and will support up to 200 gigabits per
second as well when you have heavy
outgoing traffic or egress traffic
leaving google cloud cloud interconnect
fits the bill perfectly and lastly when
it comes to private google access this
travels over the backbone of google's
network and so when you are connected
with interconnect this is an extension
of that backbone and therefore your
on-premises hosts will be able to take
advantage of private google access and
so i hope this has given you some
clarity on the differences between the
different connection types and how to
extend your google cloud network to a
peer or on-premises network so that's
pretty much all i had to cover when it
comes to cloud interconnect so you can
now mark this lesson as complete and
let's move on to the next one
[Music]
welcome back in this lesson i'm going to
be covering an overview of app engine
now this is not a deep dive lesson for
app engine as there is so much to cover
with this service but i will be listing
a lot of the features of app engine to
give you a good feel for what it can do
and what you will need to know for the
exam so with that being said let's dive
in now app engine is a fully managed
serverless platform for developing and
hosting web applications at scale this
is google's platform as a service
offering that was designed for
developers so that they can develop
their application and let app engine do
all the heavy lifting by taking care of
provisioning the servers and scaling the
instances needed based on demand app
engine gives you the flexibility of
launching your code as is or you can
launch it as a container and uses
runtime environments of a variety of
different programming languages like
python java node.js go ruby php or net
applications deployed on app engine that
experience regular traffic fluctuations
or newly deployed applications where
you're simply unsure about the load are
auto scaled accordingly and
automatically your apps scale up to the
number of instances that are running to
provide consistent performance or scale
down to minimize idle instances and
reduces costs app engine also has the
capabilities of being able to deal with
rapid scaling for sudden extreme spikes
of traffic having multiple versions of
your application within each service
allows you to quickly switch between
different versions of that application
for rollbacks testing or other temporary
events you can route traffic to one or
more specific versions of your
application by migrating or splitting
traffic and you can use traffic
splitting to specify a percentage
distribution of traffic across two or
more of the versions within a service
and allows you to do a b testing or blue
green deployment between your versions
when rolling out new features app engine
supports connecting to back-end storage
services such as cloud firestore cloud
sql and cloud storage along with
connecting to on-premises databases and
even external databases that are hosted
on other public clouds app engine is
available in two separate flavors
standard and flexible environments and
each environment offers their own set of
features that i will get into in just a
sec
now as i mentioned before app engine is
available in standard and flexible
environments and depending on your
application needs either one will
support what you need for your workload
or you could even use both
simultaneously the features shown here
will give you a feel for both types of
environments and i'm going to be doing a
quick run through summarizing the
features of each starting with the
standard environment now with the
standard environment applications run in
a secure sandboxed environment allowing
app engine standard to distribute
requests across multiple servers and
scaling servers to meet traffic demands
your application runs with its own
secure reliable environment that is
independent of the hardware
operating system or physical location of
the server the source code is written in
specific versions
of the supported programming languages
and with app engine standard it is
intended to run for free or at a very
low cost where you pay only for what you
need and when you need it with app
engine standard your application can
scale to zero instances when there is no
traffic app engine standard is designed
for sudden and extreme spikes of traffic
which require immediate scaling and
pricing for standard app engine is based
on instance hours and so when it comes
to features for app engine flexible the
application instances run within docker
containers that includes a custom
runtime or source code written in other
programming languages these docker
containers are then run on compute
engine vms app engine flexible will run
any source code that is written in a
version of any of the supported
programming languages for app engine
flexible and unlike the standard
environment unfortunately there is no
free quota for app engine flexible as
well app engine flexible is designed for
consistent traffic or for applications
that experience regular traffic
fluctuations and pricing is based on the
vm resources and not on instance hours
like app engine standard and so where
app engine flexible really shines over
app engine standard are how the vms are
managed so instances are health checked
healed as necessary and co-located with
other services within the project the
vm's operating system is updated and
applied automatically as well vms are
restarted on a weekly basis to make sure
any necessary operating system and
security updates are applied ssh along
with root access are available to the vm
instances running your containers now
deploying applications to app engine is
as simple as using the gcloud app deploy
command
this command automatically builds a
container image from your configuration
file by using the cloud build service
and then deploys that image to app
engine now an app engine application is
made up of a single application resource
that consists of one or more services
each service can be configured to use
different runtimes and to operate with
different performance settings
services and app engine are used to
factor your large applications into
logical components
that can securely share app engine
features and communicate with one
another these app engine services become
loosely coupled behaving like
microservices now within each service
you deploy versions of that service and
each version then runs within one or
more instances depending on how much
traffic you configured it to handle
having multiple versions of your
application within each service allows
you to quickly switch between different
versions of that application for
rollbacks testing or other temporary
events you can route traffic to one or
more specific versions of your
application by migrating traffic to one
specific version
or splitting your traffic between two
separate versions and so the versions
within your services run on one or more
instances by default app engine scales
your application to match the load your
applications will scale up the number of
instances that are running to provide
consistent performance or scale down to
minimize idle instances and reduce costs
now when it comes to managing instances
app engine can automatically create and
shut down instances as traffic
fluctuates or you can specify a number
of instances to run
regardless of the amount of traffic you
can also configure how and when new
instances are created by specifying a
scaling type for your application and
how you do this is you specify the
scaling type in your application's
app.yaml file now there are three
different types of scaling choices to
choose from and the first one being
automatic scaling and this scaling type
creates instances based on request rate
response latencies and other application
metrics you can specify thresholds for
each of these metrics as well as a
minimum number instances to keep running
at all times if you use automatic
scaling each instance in your
application has its own queue for
incoming requests before the queues
become long enough to have a visible
effect on your app's latency app engine
automatically creates one or more new
instances to handle the load the second
type is basic scaling and this creates
instances when your application receives
requests each instance is shut down when
the application becomes idle basic
scaling is fantastic for intermittent
workloads or if you're looking to drive
your application by user activity app
engine will try to keep your costs low
even though it might result in higher
latency as the volume of incoming
requests increase and so the last
scaling type is manual scaling and this
is where you specify the number of
instances that continuously run
regardless of the load so these are
instances that are constantly running
and this allows complex startup tasks on
the instances to have already been
completed when receiving requests and
applications that rely on the state of
the memory over time so this is ideal
for instances whose configuration
scripts require some time to fully run
their course so now that i've gone over
managing the instances i wanted to take
a few moments to go over how app engine
manages traffic starting with traffic
migration now traffic migration switches
the request routing between the versions
within a service of your application
moving traffic from one or more versions
to a single new version so when
deploying a new version with the same
name of an existing version it causes an
immediate traffic migration all
instances of the old version are
immediately shut down in app engine
standard you can choose to route
requests to the target version either
immediately or gradually you can also
choose to enable warm-up requests if you
want the traffic gradually migrated to a
version gradual traffic migration is not
supported in app engine flexible and
traffic is migrated immediately now one
thing to note is that when you
immediately migrate traffic to a new
version without any running instances
then your application will have a spike
in latency for loading requests
while instances are being created and so
another way to manage traffic on app
engine is through traffic splitting now
you can use traffic splitting to specify
a percentage distribution of traffic
across two or more of the versions
within a service so in this example if
i'm deploying a new version of my
service i can decide on how i want to
distribute traffic to each version of my
application and so i decide that i want
to keep my current version in play but
roll out the new version of my
application to 10 of my users leaving
the old version was still 90 of the
traffic going to that version and so
splitting traffic allows you to conduct
a b testing between your versions and
provides control over the pace when
rolling out features and just as a note
when you've specified two or more
versions for splitting you must choose
whether to split traffic by either by
either ip address http cookie or do it
randomly now again this has not been a
deep dive lesson on app engine but i
hope this has given you an overview of
the features that are available as the
exam touches on these features i also
wanted to give you some familiarity with
the service itself as coming up next i
will be going into a demo where we will
be launching an application using app
engine and trying on some of these
features for yourself and so that's
pretty much all i wanted to cover
when it comes to app engine so you can
now mark this lesson as complete and
whenever you're ready join me in the
console where you will deploy an
application on app engine and try out
some of these features for yourself
[Music]
welcome back and in this demo you're
going to build another application to
deploy on app engine called serverless
bowties this demo will run you through
the ins and outs of deploying a website
application on app engine along with
managing it while experiencing no
downtime so there's quite a bit of work
to do here so with that being said let's
dive in and so here in my console i am
logged in as tonybowtieace gmail.com
under project bowtie inc and so the
first thing i want to do here is i want
to head on over to app engine so in
order to do that i'm going to go to the
top left-hand navigation menu and i'm
going to go down to app engine and
because i haven't created any
applications i'm going to be brought to
this splash page now in order to deploy
this application we're not going to be
doing it through the console but we will
be doing it through the command line and
so to get started with that i'm going to
go up to the top and open up cloud shell
i'm going to make this bigger for better
viewing and so in order for me to get
the code to launch this application i'm
going to be cloning my github repository
into cloud shell and so for those of you
who haven't deleted your repository from
the last demo you can go ahead and skip
the cloning step for those of you who
need to clone your repository you will
find a link to the instructions in the
lesson text and there you'll be able to
retrieve the command which will be git
clone along with the address of the repo
i'm going to hit enter and because i've
already cloned this repo i'm receiving
this error i'm going to do an ls and as
you can see here the google cloud
associate cloud engineer repo has
already been cloned so i'm going to cd
into that directory and in order to get
the code i'm going to simply run the
command git pull
to get the latest and i'm going to
simply clear my screen and so now that
i've retrieved all the code that i need
in order to deploy it i need to go to
that directory and that directory is
going to be 11 serverless services
forward slash 0 1 serverless bowties and
hit enter you're going to run ls and
here you will find two versions of the
website application site v1 and site v2
along with the instructions if you want
to follow straight from here and so i
want to go ahead and deploy my first
website application so i'm going to cd
into site v1 ls and here you will see
the app.yaml which is the configuration
file that you will need in order to run
the application on app engine and so
before i go ahead and deploy this i
wanted to take a moment to show you the
application configuration so i'm going
to go ahead and open it up in cloud
shell editor so i'm going to type in
edit app.yaml enter and as you can see
here my runtime is python 3.7 and as you
can see i have a default expiration of
two seconds along with an expiration
underneath each handler and this is due
to the caching issue that happens with
app engine and so in order to simulate
traffic splitting between the two
website applications in order to make
things easy i needed to expire the cash
and this is an easy way to do it now
there may be applications out there that
do need that caching and so the
expiration may be a lot higher but for
the purposes of this demo two seconds
expiration should suffice as well
explain the two handlers here the first
one showing the files that will be
uploaded to the cloud storage bucket as
well as the second stating what static
files will be presented and so i'm going
to go ahead back over to my terminal and
i'm going to go ahead and clear my
screen and i'm going to go ahead and run
the command gcloud app deploy with the
flag dash dash version and this is going
to be version one so i'm going to go
ahead and hit enter and you may get a
pop-up asking you to authorize this api
call using your credentials and you want
to click on authorize and you're going
to be prompted to enter in a region that
you want to deploy your website
application to we want to keep this in
us east one so i'm going to type in 15
hit enter
and you're going to be prompted to
verify your configuration for your
application before it's deployed you're
also going to be prompted if you want to
continue definitely yes so i'm going to
hit y enter and so now as you've seen
the files have been uploaded to cloud
storage and app engine is going to take
a few minutes to create the service
along with the version so i'm going to
let it do the needful and i'll be back
before you know it okay and my
application has been deployed now
although you don't see it here in the
console it has been deployed all i need
to do is refresh my screen but i wanted
to just point out a couple things that
is shown here in the terminal the first
one being the default service now the
first time you deploy a version of your
application it will always deploy to the
default service initially and only then
will you be able to deploy another named
service to app engine now here where it
says setting traffic split for service
this is referring to the configuration
for traffic splitting being applied in
the background which i will be getting
into a little bit later and lastly the
url shown for the deployed service will
always start with the name of your
project followed by.ue.r.appspot.com
which is why in production google
recommends to run app engine in a
completely separate project
before this demo running it in the same
project that we've been using will
suffice okay so let's go ahead and take
a look at the application so i'm going
to go back up to the top here to the
navigation menu and i'm gonna go down to
app engine and go over to services and
so here you will see the default service
with version one and if i go over to
versions i will see here my version the
status
the traffic allocation along with any
instances that it needs the run time the
specific environment and i'll have some
diagnostic tools here that i could use
and so because this is a static website
application we won't be using any
instances and so this will always show a
zero so now i want to head back on over
to services and i'm going to launch my
application by simply clicking on this
hot link
and success serverless bow ties for all
and so it looks like my application has
been successfully deployed so i'm going
to close down this tab now there's a
couple of things that i wanted to run
through here on the left hand menu just
for your information so here i can click
on instances and if i was running any
instances i am able to see a summary of
those instances and i can click on the
drop down here and choose a different
metric and find out any information that
i need as well i can click on this drop
down and select a version if i had
multiple versions which i do not
clicking on task queues here is where i
can manage my task queues but this is a
legacy service that will soon be
deprecated clicking on cron jobs here i
can schedule any tasks that i need to
run at a specific time on a recurring
basis i can edit or add any firewall
rules if i need to and as you can see
the default firewall rule is open to the
world now you probably noticed memcache
as being one of the options here in the
menu but this is a legacy service that
will soon be deprecated
memcache is a distributed in-memory data
store that is bundled into the python to
runtime acting as a cache for specific
tasks and google recommends moving to
memory store for redis if you're
planning on applying caching for your
app engine application and so i'm not
sure how much longer this will be here
and lastly under settings here is where
you can change your settings for your
application i can add any custom domains
any ssl certificates as well as setting
up email for any applications that want
to send email out to your users okay and
now that we've done that walkthrough i
want to go ahead and deploy my second
version of the application and so i'm
going to go ahead back down to cloud
shell i'm going to quickly clear my
screen and i want to move into the site
v2 directory so i'm going to hit cd dot
dot which will bring you back one
directory you do an ls and i'm going to
change directories into site v2 and do
an ls just to verify and yes you will
see serverless bow ties too i'm going to
quickly clear my screen and i'm going to
run the same command as before which is
gcloud app deploy with the version flag
dash dash version and instead of one i'm
going to launch version 2. so i'm going
to hit enter i'm going to be prompted if
i want to continue yes i do and as you
can see the files have been uploaded to
cloud storage for version 2 of the
website application and app engine is
going to take a few minutes to create
the service along with the version so
i'm going to let it cook here for a
couple minutes and i'll be back before
you can say cat in the hat okay so
version 2 has been deployed and so if i
go up here to the console and i click on
refresh you should see version 2 of your
service and as you can see 100 of the
traffic has been allocated to version 2
automatically and this is the default
behavior for whenever you launch a new
version of your service the only way to
avoid this is to deploy your new version
with the no promote flag and so if i go
back to services here on the left and i
click on the default service
you should see success for version two
and so i know that my website
application for version 2 has been
deployed successfully so i'm going to
close down this tab again and i'm going
to go back to versions and so what i
want to do now is i want to simulate an
a b test or blue green deployment by
migrating my traffic back to the old
version in this case being version one
so in production let's say that you
would release a new version and the
version doesn't go according to plan you
can always go back to the previous
version and app engine allows you to do
that very easily and so i'm going to
click on version 1 and i'm going to go
up to the top menu and click on migrate
traffic you'll be prompted if you want
to migrate traffic yes i do so i'm going
to click on migrate and it should take a
minute here and traffic should migrate
over to version one and success traffic
has been migrated and so we want to
verify that this has happened i'm gonna
go back to services i'm gonna click on
the default service and yes the traffic
has been allocated to version one okay
so i'm going to shut down this tab i'm
going to go back to versions and so now
what i want to do is i want to simulate
splitting the traffic between the two
versions and so in order for you to do
this you can go up to the top menu
click on split traffic and you'll be
prompted with a new menu here and here i
can choose from different versions and
because i only have two versions i'm
going to add version 2 and in order to
allocate the traffic between the two i
can either use this slider
and as you can see the allocation
percentage will change or i can simply
just type it in and so i'm going to
leave this at 50 percent so fifty
percent of version one fifty percent of
version two i'm going to split traffic
randomly i'm gonna move this down just a
little bit and so that's exactly how you
wanna allocate your traffic and so once
you've completed that you can simply
click on save it's going to take a
moment to update the settings and it's
been successful so if i head back on
over to the previous page you can see
here that traffic has been allocated to
both versions and so now in order to
verify this what you're going to do is
go over to services and click on the
default hot link and you'll see version
one but if i continuously refresh my
screen i can see that here i have
version two so because it's random i
have a 50 chance of getting version 1
and a 50 chance of getting version 2.
and so this is a simulation of splitting
traffic to different versions and
usually with a b testing only a small
percentage of the traffic is routed to
the new version until verification can
be made that the new version deployed
has indeed been successful and this can
be done by receiving feedback from the
users and so now i wanted to take a
quick moment to congratulate you on
making it through this demo and hope
that it has been extremely useful in
excelling your knowledge in deploying
and managing applications on app engine
so just as a recap you've cloned the
repo to cloud shell you then deployed
version one of your application into app
engine you verified its launch and then
you deployed version two of the
application and verified its launch as
well you then migrated traffic from
version two over to version one and then
you went ahead and split traffic between
both versions and allotted 50 of the
traffic allocation to each version and
so now before you go i want to make sure
that we clean up any resources that
we've deployed so that we don't incur
any unnecessary costs and so the way to
do this is very simple so first step you
want to go over to the left hand menu
and click on settings and simply click
on disable application you're going to
be prompted to type in the app's id for
me it's bowtie inc so i'm going to type
that in and i'm going to click on
disable now unfortunately with app
engine you can't actually delete the
application it can only be disabled and
so now here i'm going to hit the hot
link to go over to the cloud storage
bucket and as you can see here i have no
files but i'm going to move back to my
buckets
and i'm going to move into the staging
bucket which is appended with your
project id.appspot.com
and as you can see here there's a whole
bunch of different files as well if i
drill down into the directory marked as
ae for app engine i can see here that i
have some more directories along with
the manifest and so now if you want to
keep your application in order to run it
later you don't need to delete this
bucket but because i don't need it i'm
going to go ahead and delete the bucket
hit delete paste in my bucket name hit
delete as well under us.artifacts
you will find a directory called
containers and as explained in the last
lesson code build builds a container for
your application before deploying it to
app engine so i'm going to drill down
into images so here's all the container
digests and i don't need any of these so
i'm gonna go ahead and delete this
bucket as well and so this is the last
step in order to delete all the
directories and files that we use to
deploy our application in an app engine
okay and so i'm gonna head back on over
to app engine and so now that cleanup
has been taken care of that's pretty
much all i wanted to cover in this demo
for deploying and managing applications
on app engine so you can now mark this
as complete and i'll see you in the next
one and again congrats on a job well
done
[Music]
welcome back in this lesson i will be
diving into another serverless product
from google cloud by the name of cloud
functions an extremely useful and
advanced service that can be used with
almost every service on the platform now
there's quite a bit to cover here so
with that being said let's dive in now
cloud functions as i said before are a
serverless execution environment and
what i mean by this is like app engine
there is no need to provision any
servers or updating vms as the
infrastructure is all handled by google
but unlike app engine you will never see
the servers so the provisioning of
resources happens when the code is
executed now cloud functions are a
function as a service offering and this
is where you upload code that is
purposefully written in a supported
programming language and when your code
is triggered it is executed in a fully
managed environment and your billed for
when that code is executed cloud
functions run in a runtime environment
and support many different runtimes like
python java node.js go and net core
cloud functions are event driven so when
something happens in your environment
you can choose whether or not you'd like
to respond to this event if you do then
your code can be executed in response to
the event these triggers can be one of a
few different types such as http
pub sub cloud storage and now firestore
and firebase which are in beta and have
yet to be seen in the exam cloud
functions are priced according to how
long your function runs and how many
resources you provision for your
function if your function makes an
outbound network request there are also
additional data transfer fees cloud
functions also include a perpetual free
tier which allows you 2 million
invocations or executions of your
function now cloud functions themselves
are very simple but have a few steps to
execute before actually running so i
wanted to give you a walkthrough on
exactly how cloud functions work now
after selecting the name and region you
want your function to live in you would
then select the trigger you wish to use
and you can choose from the many i
listed earlier being http cloud storage
pub sub cloud firestore and firebase a
trigger is a declaration that you are
interested in a certain event or set of
events binding a function to a trigger
allows you to capture and act on these
events authentication configuration is
the next step and can be selected with
public access
or configured through iam now there are
some optional settings that can be
configured where you would provide the
amount of memory the function will need
to run
networking preferences and even
selection for a service account now once
all the settings have been solidified
your written code can then be put into
the function now the functions code
supports a variety of languages as
stated before like python java node.js
or go now when writing your code there
are two distinct types of cloud
functions that you could use http
functions and background functions with
http functions you invoke them from
standard http requests these http
requests wait for the response and
support handling of common http request
methods like get put
post delete and options when you use
cloud functions a tls certificate is
automatically provisioned for you so all
http functions can be invoked via a
secure connection now when it comes to
background functions
these are used to handle events from
your gcp infrastructure such as messages
on a pub sub topic or changes in a cloud
storage bucket now once you have put all
this together you are ready to deploy
your code now there are two things that
will happen when deploying your code the
first one is the binding of your trigger
to your function once you bind a trigger
you cannot bind another one to the same
function
only one trigger can be bound to a
function at a time now the second thing
that will happen when you deploy your
function's source code to cloud
functions is that source code is stored
in a cloud storage bucket as a zip file
cloud build then automatically builds
your code into a container image that
pushes that image to container registry
cloud functions accesses this image when
it needs to run the container to execute
your function the process of building
the image is entirely automatic and
requires no manual intervention and so
at this point of the process the
building of your function is now
complete now that the function has been
created we now wait for an event to
happen and events are things that happen
within your cloud environment that you
might want to take action on these might
be changes to data in cloud sql files
added to cloud storage or a new vm being
created currently cloud functions
supports
events from the same services used for
triggers that i have just mentioned
including other google services like
bigquery cloud sql and cloud spanner now
when an event triggers the execution of
your cloud function
data associated with the event is passed
via the functions parameters the type of
event determines the parameters that are
passed to your function cloud functions
handles incoming requests by assigning
them to instances of your function now
depending on the volume of requests
as well as the number of existing
function instances cloud functions may
assign a request to an existing instance
or create a new one so the cloud
function will grab the image from cloud
registry and hand off the image along
with the event data to the instance for
processing now each instance of a
function handles only one concurrent
request at a time this means that while
your code is processing one request
there is no possibility of a second
request being routed to the same
instance thus the original request can
use the full amount of resources that
you requested and this is the memory
that you assign to your cloud function
when deploying it now to allow google to
automatically manage and scale the
functions they must be stateless
functions are not meant to be persistent
nor is the data that is passed on to the
function and so once the function has
run and all data has been processed by
the server it is then passed on to
either a vpc or to the internet now by
default functions have public internet
access unless configured otherwise
functions can also be private and used
within your vpc but must be configured
before deployment now there are so many
use cases for cloud functions and there
are many that have already been created
by google for you to try out
and can be located in the documentation
that i've supplied in the lesson text
below now the exam doesn't go into too
much depth on cloud functions but i did
want to give you some exposure to this
fantastic serverless product from google
as it is so commonly used in many
production environments in a simple and
easy way to take in data process it and
return a result from any event you are
given and i have no doubt that once you
get the hang of deploying them that you
will be a huge fan of them as well and
so that's pretty much all i had to cover
when it comes to cloud functions so you
can now mark this lesson as complete and
whenever you're ready join me in the
next one where we go hands-on in the
console creating and deploying your very
first function
welcome back and in this demo we will be
diving into creating and deploying our
very first cloud function we're going to
take a tour of all the options in the
console but we're going to do most of
the work in cloud shell to get a good
feel for doing it in the command line so
with that being said let's dive in and
so i'm logged in here as tony bowties
gmail.com
and i'm in the project of bowtie inc and
so the first thing i want to do is head
on over to cloud functions in the
console so i'm going to go up to the top
left to the navigation menu and i'm
going to scroll down to cloud functions
and as you can see here cloud functions
is getting ready and this is because
we've never used it before and the api
is being enabled okay and the api has
been enabled and we can go ahead and
start creating our function so you can
go ahead and click create function and
you will be prompted with some fields to
fill out for the configuration of your
cloud function and so under basics for
function name i'm going to name this
hello underscore world for region i'm
going to select us east one and under
trigger for trigger type we're gonna
keep this as http although if i click on
the drop down menu you can see that i
will have options for cloud pub sub
cloud storage and the ones that i
mentioned before that are in beta so
we're going to keep things as http and
here under url is the url for the actual
cloud function under authentication i
have the option of choosing require
authentication or allow unauthenticated
invocations and as you can see this is
clearly marked saying that check this if
you are creating a public api or website
which we are and so this is the
authentication method that you want to
select and so now that we have all the
fields filled out for the basic
configuration i'm going to go ahead and
click on save and just to give you a
quick run through of what else is
available i'm going to click on the drop
down here and this will give me access
to variables networking and advanced
settings the first field here memory
allocated i can actually add more memory
depending what i am doing with my cloud
function but i'm going to keep it as the
default if you have a cloud function
that runs a little bit longer and you
need more time to run the cloud function
you can add additional time for the
timeout and as well i have the option of
choosing a different service account for
this cloud function and so moving on
under environment variables you will see
the options to add build environment
variables along with runtime environment
variables and the last option being
connections here you can change the
different networking settings for
ingress and egress traffic under ingress
settings i can allow all traffic which
is the default i can allow internal
traffic only as well i can allow
internal traffic and traffic from cloud
low balancing now as well when it comes
to the egress settings as i said before
by default your cloud function is able
to send requests to the internet but not
to resources in your vpc network and so
this is where you would create a vpc
connector to send requests from your
cloud function to resources in your vpc
so if i click on create a connector
it'll open up a new tab and bring me to
vpc network to add serverless vpc access
and so i don't want to do that right now
so i'm going to close down this tab and
i'm going to go ahead and leave
everything else as is and click on next
and so now that the configuration is
done i can dive right into the code and
so google cloud gives you a inline
editor right here along with the
different runtime environments so if i
click on the drop down menu you can see
i have the options
of net core go java node.js and python
3.7 and 3.8 and so for this demo i'm
going to keep it as node.js 10. the
entry point will be hello world and i'm
going to keep the code exactly as is and
this is a default cloud function that is
packaged with any runtime whenever you
create a function from the console and
so if i had any different code i can
change it here but i'm not going to do
that i'm going to leave everything else
as is and click on deploy and it'll take
a couple minutes here to create my cloud
function and so i'm going to pause the
video here for just a quick sec and i'll
be back in a flash okay and my cloud
function has been deployed and i got a
green check mark which means that i'm
all good and so i want to dive right
into it for just a second so i can get
some more details here i have the
metrics for my cloud function the
invocations per second execution time
memory utilization and active instances
i have my versions up here at the top
but since i only have one version only
one version shows up if i click on
details it'll show me the general
information along with the networking
settings the source will show me the
code for this cloud function as well as
the variables the trigger permissions
logs and testing and here i can write in
some code and test the function and so
in order for me to invoke this function
i can simply go to trigger and it'll
show me the url but a quick way to do
this through the command line is to
simply open up cloud shell and make this
a little bigger for better viewing and
i'm going to paste in the command gcloud
functions describe along with the
function name which is hello underscore
world along with the region flag dash
dash region with the region that my
cloud function has been deployed in
which is us east one and i'm going to
hit enter
it's going to ask me to authorize my api
call yes i want to authorize it and this
command should output some information
on your screen and so what we're looking
for here is the http trigger which you
will find here under https trigger and
it is the same as what you see here in
the console and so just know if you want
to grab the http url trigger you can
also do it from the command line and so
i'm going to now trigger it by going to
this url and you should see in the top
left hand side of your screen hello
world not as exciting as spinning bow
ties but this example gives you an idea
of what an http function can do and so
i'm going to close down this tab and so
now what i want to do is i want to
deploy another function but i want to do
it now through the command line and so
i'm going to now quickly clear my screen
and so since i've already uploaded the
code to the repo i'm going to simply
clone that repo and run it from here so
i'm going to simply do a cd tilde to
make sure i'm in my home directory for
those of you who haven't deleted the
directory you can simply cd into it so
i'm going to run cd google cloud
associate cloud engineer hit enter and
i'm going to run a get pull command
and it pull down all the files that i
needed i'm going to quickly clear my
screen and so i'm going to change
directories into the directory that has
my code and so you're going to find it
under 11 serverless services under zero
to you called hit enter and again i will
have a link in the lesson text for the
full instructions on this demo and it
will list the directory where you can
find this code okay so moving forward
i'm going to run ls and you should see
three files here
main.py
requirements.txt and the text file with
the instructions and so now that i have
everything in place in order to deploy
my code i'm going to paste in the
command to actually deploy my function
which is gcloud functions deploy the
name of the function which is you
underscore called the flag for the
runtime dash dash runtime and the
runtime is going to be python 3.8 the
flag for the trigger which is going to
be http and because i'm a nice guy and i
want everyone to have access to this i'm
going to tag it with the flag dash dash
allow unauthenticated so i'm going to
hit enter okay and this function should
take a couple minutes to deploy so i'm
going to sit here and let it cook and
i'll be back before you can say cat in
the hat okay and our function has been
deployed i'm going to do a quick refresh
here in the console and it deployed
successfully as you can see the green
check mark is here okay and so now that
it's been deployed we want to trigger
our function and so because i just
deployed this function the url trigger
is conveniently located here in my
screen so you can go ahead and click on
it and hello lover of bow ties you
called now although this may be similar
to the hello world demo but i did add a
small feature that might spice things up
and so if you go up to the url and you
type in question mark name equals and
your name and since my name is anthony
i'm going to type in anthony
hit enter and hello anthony you called
and so this is a perfect example of the
many different ways you can use
functions and although i've only
highlighted some very simple
demonstrations there are many different
ways that you can use functions such as
running pipelines running batch jobs and
even event driven security now although
the exam doesn't go into too much depth
on cloud functions it's always good to
know its use cases and where its
strengths lie for when you do decide to
use it in your role as a cloud engineer
now before you go be sure to delete all
the resources you've created by deleting
the functions and the storage buckets
that house the code for the cloud
functions and i will walk you through
the steps right now okay so first i'm
going to close down this tab and next
you're going to select all the functions
and you're going to simply click on
delete you're going to get a prompt to
delete the functions you're going to
click on delete and it's going to take a
minute or two and the functions are
deleted i'm going to close down my cloud
shell and i'm going to head over to
cloud storage
and as you can see here both these
buckets that start with gcf standing for
google cloud functions can be safely
deleted as inside them are the files
that were used for the cloud function so
i'm going to go back out i'm going to
select both of these and i'm going to
click on delete you get a prompt to
delete two buckets you can simply type
in delete and click on delete and the
buckets have now been deleted and you've
pretty much finished your cleanup and so
just as a recap you created a default
cloud function that was available from
the console and then verified it by
triggering the http url you then
deployed another function from the
command line by pulling the code from
the repo and using it for deployment and
then you verified that function by
triggering it using the http url as well
and then you modify the url for a
different output great job on another
successful demo so you can now mark this
as complete and let's move on to the
next one
[Music]
welcome back in this lesson we're going
to dive into cloud storage the go to
storage service from google cloud if
you're an engineer working in google
cloud you've probably used this many
times as a storage solution and if you
haven't this is definitely a service
that you will need to know for both the
exam and your day-to-day role as a cloud
engineer now there's quite a bit to
cover here so with that being said let's
dive in now cloud storage is a
consistent scalable large capacity
highly durable object storage and this
is unlimited storage for objects with no
minimum object size but please remember
that this is object storage and is not
designed to store an operating system on
but to store whole objects like pictures
or videos cloud storage has worldwide
accessibility and worldwide storage
locations so anywhere that there is a
region or zone cloud storage is
available from there and can be accessed
at any time through an internet
connection cloud storage is great for
storing data from data analytics jobs
text files with code pictures of the
latest fashion from paris and videos of
your favorite house dj at the shelter
cloud storage excels for content
delivery big data sets and backups and
are all stored as objects in buckets and
this is the heart of cloud storage that
i will be diving into so starting with
buckets these are the basic containers
or construct that holds your data
everything that you store in cloud
storage must be contained in a bucket
you can use buckets to organize your
data and control access to your data but
unlike directories and folders you
cannot nest buckets and i'll get into
that in just a minute now when you
create a bucket you must specify a
globally unique name as every bucket
resides in a single cloud storage
namespace as well as a name you must
specify a geographic location where the
bucket and its contents are stored and
you have three available geography
choices to choose from from region dual
region and multi-region and so just as a
note choosing dual region and
multi-region is considered geo-redundant
for dual region geo-redundancy is
achieved using a specific pair of
regions for multi-region geo-redundancy
is achieved using a continent that
contains two or more geographic places
basically the more regions your data is
available in the greater your
availability for that data after you've
chosen a geographic location a default
storage class must be chosen and this
applies to objects added to the bucket
that don't have a storage class
explicitly specified and i'll be diving
into storage classes in just a bit and
so after you create a bucket you can
still change its default storage class
to any class supported in the buckets
location with some stipulations
you can only change the bucket name
and location by deleting and recreating
the bucket as well once dual region is
selected it cannot be changed to
multi-region and when selecting
multi-region you will not be able to
change the bucket to be dual region and
lastly you will need to choose what
level of access you want others to have
on your bucket whether you want to apply
permissions using uniform or fine
grained access uniform bucket level
access allows you to use iam alone to
manage permissions iam applies
permissions to all the objects contained
inside the bucket or groups of objects
with common name prefixes the find green
option enables you to use iam and access
control lists or acls
together to manage permissions acls are
a legacy access control system for cloud
storage designed for interoperability
with amazon s3 for those of you who use
aws you can specify access and apply
permissions at both the bucket level and
per individual object and i will also be
diving more into depth with access
control
in just a bit and just as a note labels
are an optional item for bucket creation
like every other resource creation
process in gcp now that we've covered
buckets i wanted to cover what is stored
in those buckets which is objects and
objects are the individual pieces of
data or data chunks that you store in a
cloud storage bucket and there is no
limit on the number of objects that you
can create in a bucket so you can think
of objects kind of like files objects
have two components object data and
object metadata
object data is typically a file that you
want to store in cloud storage and in
this case it is the picture of the plaid
bow tie and object metadata is a
collection of name value pairs that
describe the various properties of that
object an object's name is treated as a
piece of object metadata in cloud
storage and must be unique within the
bucket cloud storage uses a flat
namespace to store objects which means
that cloud storage isn't a file system
hierarchy but sees all objects in a
given bucket as independent with no
relationship towards each other for
convenience
tools such as the console and gsutil
work with objects that use the slash
character as if they were stored in a
virtual hierarchy for example you can
name one object slash bow ties slash
spring 2021 slash plaid bowtie.jpg when
using the cloud console you can then
navigate to these objects as if they
were in a hierarchical directory
structure under the folders bow ties and
spring 2021 now i mentioned before that
the part of the bucket creation is the
selection of a storage class the storage
class you set for an object affects the
object's availability and pricing model
so when you create a bucket you can
specify a default storage class for the
bucket when you add objects to the
bucket they inherit this storage class
unless explicitly set otherwise now i
wanted to touch on these four storage
classes now to give you a better
understanding of the differences between
them the first one is standard storage
and is considered best for hot data or
frequently accessed data and is best for
short-term use as it does not have any
specified storage duration and this is
excellent for use in analytical
workloads and transcoding and the price
for this storage class comes in at two
cents per gigabyte per month next up is
near line storage and this is considered
hot data as well and is a low-cost
storage class for storing in frequently
accessed data nearline storage has a
slightly lower availability a 30-day
minimum storage duration and comes with
the cost for data access nearline
storage is ideal if you're looking to
continuously add files but only plan to
access them once a month and is perfect
for data backup and data archiving the
price for this storage class comes in at
a penny per gigabyte per month now cold
line storage is considered cold data as
it enters into more of the longer term
storage classes and is a very low cost
storage class for storing and frequently
accessed data it comes with slightly
lower availability than nearline storage
a 90-day minimum storage duration and
comes with the cost for data access that
is higher than the retrieval cost for
nearline storage coldline storage is
ideal for data you plan to read or
modify at most once a quarter and is
perfect for data backup and data
archiving the price for this storage
class comes in at less than half of a
penny per gigabyte per month and finally
archive storage is the lowest cost
highly durable storage service for data
archiving online backup and disaster
recovery and even coming in at a lowest
cost the data access is still available
within milliseconds archive storage
comes in at a higher cost for data
retrieval as well as a
day minimum storage duration and is the
best choice for data that you plan to
access less than once a year archive
storage also comes with the highest
price for data retrieval and it is ideal
for archive data storage that's used for
regulatory purposes or disaster recovery
data in the event that there is an
oopsies in your environment the price of
the storage class comes in at a
ridiculously low price per gigabyte per
month at a fraction of a penny per
gigabyte per month now when it comes to
choosing your geographic location this
will determine the availability of your
data here as you can see the highest
availability is the standard
multi-region whereas archive has the
lowest availability when stored in a
regional setting now when it comes to
the durability of your data meaning the
measurement of how healthy and resilient
your data is from data loss or data
corruption google cloud boasts 11 9's
durability annually on all data stored
in any storage class on cloud storage so
know that your data is stored safely and
will be there holding the same integrity
from the day you stored it now when it
comes to granting permissions to your
cloud storage buckets and the objects
within them there are four different
options to choose from the first is iam
permissions and these are the standard
permissions that control all your other
resources in google cloud and follow the
same top-down hierarchy that we
discussed earlier the next available
option are access control list or acls
and these define who has access to your
buckets and objects as well as what type
of access they have and these can work
in tandem with im permissions moving on
to sign urls these are time limited
reader write access urls that can be
created by you to give access to the
object in question for the duration that
you specify and lastly is sign policy
documents and these are documents to
specify what can be uploaded to a bucket
and i will be going into each one of
these in a bit of detail now cloud
storage offers two systems for granting
users permission to access your buckets
and objects iam and access control lists
these systems act in parallel in order
for a user to access a cloud storage
resource only one of the systems needs
to grant the user permission im is
always the recommended method when it
comes to giving access to buckets and
the objects within those buckets
granting roles at the bucket level does
not affect any existing roles that you
granted at the project level and vice
versa giving you two levels of
granularity to customize your
permissions so for instance you can give
a user permission to read objects in any
bucket but permissions to create objects
only in one specific bucket the roles
that are available through iam are the
primitive standard storage roles or the
legacy roles which are equivalent to
acls now acls are there if you need to
customize access and really get granular
with individual objects within a bucket
and are used to define who has access to
your buckets and objects as well as what
level of access they have each acl
consists of one or more entries and
gives a specific user or group the
ability to perform specific actions each
entry consists of two pieces of
information a permission which defines
what actions can be performed and a
scope which defines who can perform the
specified actions now acls should be
used with caution as iam roles and acls
overlap cloud storage will grant a
broader permission so if you allow
specific users access to an object in a
bucket and then an acl is applied to
that object to make it public then it
will be publicly accessible so please be
aware now a signed url is a url that
provides limited permission and time to
make a request sign urls contain
authentication information allowing
users without credentials to perform
specific actions on a resource when you
generate a signed url you specify a user
or service account which must have
sufficient permission to make the
request that the sign url will make
after you generate a signed url anyone
who possesses it can use the sign url to
perform specified actions such as
reading an object within a specified
period of time now if you want to
provide public access to a user who
doesn't have an account you can provide
a signed url to that user which gives
the user read write or delete access to
that resource for a limited time you
specify an expiration date when you
create the sign url so anyone who knows
the url can access the resource until
the expiration time for the url is
reached or the key used to sign the url
is rotated and the command to create the
sign url is shown here and as you can
see has been assigned for a limited time
of 10 minutes so as you've seen when it
comes to cloud storage there are so many
configuration options to choose from and
lots of different ways to store and give
access and this makes this resource from
google cloud such a flexible option and
full of great potential for many
different types of workloads this is
also a service that comes up a lot in
the exam as one of the many different
storage options to choose from and so
knowing the features storage classes
pricing and access options will
definitely give you a leg up when you
are presented with questions regarding
storage and so that's pretty much all i
wanted to cover when it comes to this
overview on cloud storage so you can now
mark this lesson as complete and let's
move on to the next one
[Music]
welcome back and in this lesson i will
be covering object versioning and life
cycle management a feature within cloud
storage that is used to manage and sort
through older files that need to be
deleted along with files that are not in
high need of regular access knowing the
capabilities of these two features
can really help organize accumulated
objects in storage buckets and cut down
on costs so without further ado let's
dive in now to understand a bit more
about objects i wanted to dive into
immutability and versioning now objects
are immutable which means that an
uploaded object cannot change throughout
its storage lifetime an object's storage
lifetime is the time between a
successful object creation or upload and
successful object deletion this means
that you cannot edit objects in place
instead objects are always replaced with
a new version so after the upload of the
new object completes the new version of
the object is served to readers this
replacement marks the end of one
object's life cycle and the beginning of
a new one now to support the retrieval
of objects that are deleted or replaced
cloud storage offers the object
versioning feature object versioning
retains a non-current object version
when the live object version gets
replaced or deleted enabling object
versioning increases storage costs which
can be partially mitigated by
configuring object lifecycle management
to delete older object versions but more
on that in just a bit cloud storage uses
two properties that together identify
the version of an object the generation
which identifies the version of the
object's data
and the meta generation which identifies
the version of the object's metadata
these properties are always present with
every version of the object even if
object versioning is not enabled these
properties can be used to enforce
ordering of updates so in order to
enable object versioning you would do
that by enabling it on a bucket once
enabled older versions remain in your
bucket when a replacement or deletion
occurs so by default when you replace an
object cloud storage deletes the old
version and adds a new version these
older versions retain the name of the
object but are uniquely identified by
their generation number when object
versioning has created an older version
of an object you can use the generation
number to refer to the older version
this allows you to restore a replaced
object in your bucket or permanently
delete older object versions that you no
longer need and so touching back on cost
for just a minute these versions can
really add up and start costing you some
serious money if you have thousands of
files with hundreds of versions and this
is where life cycle management comes
into play now cloud storage offers the
object lifecycle management feature in
order to support some common use cases
like setting a time to live or ttl for
objects
retaining non-current versions of
objects or downgrading storage classes
of objects to help manage costs now in
order to apply this feature to your
objects you would assign a lifecycle
management configuration to a bucket the
configuration contains a set of rules
which apply to current and feature
objects in the bucket when an object
meets the criteria of one of the rules
cloud storage automatically performs the
specified action on the object and so
some example use cases are shown here so
if you're looking to downgrade the
storage class
of objects older than 365 days to cold
line storage for compliance purposes
along with saving money life cycle
management is perfect for this another
use case is when you want to delete
objects created before january 1st of
2020 and this is another great use case
to save money as well with keeping only
the three most recent versions of each
object in a bucket with versioning
enabled to keep from version objects
building up object lifecycle management
has so many other use cases across a
myriad of industries and when used
correctly is a great way to achieve
object management along with saving
money now i wanted to take a moment to
dive into the lifecycle management
configuration each lifecycle management
configuration contains a set of
components these are a set of rules
conditions and the action when the
conditions are met rules are any set of
conditions for any action conditions is
something an object must meet before the
action defined in the rule occurs on the
object and there are various conditions
to choose from that allows you to get
pretty granular and finally the action
which is where you would have the option
to delete or set storage class now when
you delete current versions this will
move the current version into a
non-current state and when you delete a
non-current version you will permanently
delete the version and cannot get it
back and so when you set the storage
class it will transition the object to a
different storage class so when defining
a rule you can specify any set of
conditions for any action if you specify
multiple conditions in a rule an object
has to match all of the conditions for
the action to be taken so if you have
three conditions and one of those
conditions have not been met then the
action will not take place if you
specify multiple rules that contain the
same action the action is taken when an
object matches the conditions in any of
these rules now if multiple rules have
their conditions satisfied
simultaneously for a single object cloud
storage will either perform the delete
action as it takes precedence over the
set storage class action or the set
storage class action that switches the
object to the storage class with the
lowest at rest storage pricing takes
precedence so for example if you have
one rule that deletes an object and
another rule that changes the object
storage class but both rules use the
exact same condition the delete action
always occurs when the condition is met
or if you have one rule that changes the
object storage class to near line
storage and another rule that changes
the object storage class to cold line
storage but both rules use the exact
same condition the object storage class
always changes to cold line storage when
the condition is met and so some
considerations that i wanted to point
out when it comes to cloud storage is
that when it comes to object life cycle
management
changes are in accordance to object
creation date as well once an object is
deleted it cannot be undeleted so please
be careful when permanently deleting a
version as well life cycle rules can
take up to 24 hours to take effect so be
aware when setting them and always be
sure to test these life cycle rules in
development first before rolling them
out into production and so that's pretty
much all i had to cover when it comes to
versioning and object life cycle
management and so you can now mark this
lesson as complete and whenever you're
ready join me in the console where we go
hands-on with versioning object life
cycle management and cloud storage as a
whole
[Music]
welcome back in this demo we're going to
cement the knowledge that we learned
from the past couple lessons on cloud
storage and really dive into the nitty
gritty when it comes to the features and
configuration you're first going to
create a cloud storage bucket and upload
some files to it and then interact with
the bucket and the files using the
console as well you're going to get your
hands dirty using the gsutil command
line tool and this is the tool for
managing cloud storage from the command
line now there's quite a bit of work to
do here so with that being said let's
dive in and so i am logged in here as
tony bowties at gmail.com along with
being in project bowtie inc and so the
first thing i want to do is i want to
create a cloud storage bucket so in
order for me to do that i'm going to
head over to the navigation menu and i'm
going to scroll down to storage
and here i already have a couple of
buckets that i created from earlier
lessons and you may have a couple
buckets as well but you're going to go
ahead and create a new bucket by going
up to the top here and click on create
bucket now i know that we've gone
through this before in previous lessons
but this time i wanted to go through all
the configuration options that are
available and so the first thing that
you're prompted to do here is to name
your bucket as explained in an earlier
lesson it needs to be a globally unique
name and so you can pick any name you
choose and so for me i'm going to call
this bucket bowtie inc dash 2021 i'm
going to hit continue and if it wasn't a
globally unique name it would error out
and you would have to enter in a new
name but since this bucket name is
globally unique i'm able to move forward
for location type you can select from
region dual region and multi region with
multi region under location you can
select from either the americas europe
or asia pacific and under dual region
you have the options of again choosing
from america's europe and asia pacific
and you will be given the regions for
each and so for this demo we're going to
go ahead and choose region and we're
going to keep the location as u.s east
one and once you've selected that you
can go ahead and hit continue and you're
going to be prompted to choose a default
storage class and here you have the
option of selecting from the four
storage classes that we discussed in an
earlier lesson and so for this demo you
can keep it as standard and simply click
on continue and so here you're prompted
to choose access control and because
we're going to be diving into acls you
can keep this as the default fine grain
access control you can go ahead and
click continue and under encryption you
can keep it as the default google manage
key but know that you always have the
option of choosing a customer manage key
and once you've uploaded your customer
manage key you can select it from here
and because i have no customer managed
keys no other keys show up so i'm going
to click on google manage keys and here
under retention policy i know i haven't
touched into that but just to give you
some context when placing a retention
policy on a bucket it ensures that all
current and future objects in the bucket
can't be deleted or replaced until they
reach the age that you define in the
retention policy so if you try to delete
or replace objects where the age is less
than the retention period it will
obviously fail and this is great for
compliance purposes in areas where logs
need to be audited by regulators every
year or where government required
retention periods apply as well with the
retention policy you have the option of
locking that retention policy and when
you lock a retention policy on a bucket
you prevent the policy from ever being
removed or the retention period from
ever being reduced and this feature is
irreversible so please be aware if
you're ever experimenting with lock
retention policies so if i set a
retention policy here i can retain
objects for a certain amount of seconds
days months and years and for this demo
we're not going to set any retention
policies so i'm going to check that off
and i'm going to go ahead and add a
label with the key being environment and
the value being test and just as a note
before you go ahead and click on create
over on the right hand side you will see
a monthly cost estimate and you will be
given an estimate with storage and
retrieval as well as how much it costs
for operations your sla and your
estimated monthly cost and so before
creating any buckets you can always do a
price check to see how much it'll cost
for storage size retrieval to get a good
idea of how much it'll cost you monthly
okay so once you're all done here you
can simply click on create
and it'll go ahead and create your
bucket and so now that your bucket is
created we want to add some files and so
we first want to go into copying files
from an instance to your cloud storage
bucket and so in order to do that we
need to create an instance and so we're
gonna go back over to the navigation
menu we're gonna scroll down to compute
engine and we're gonna create our
instance and for those who do not have
your default vpc set up please be sure
to create one before going ahead and
creating your instance i'm going to go
ahead and click on create i'm going to
name this instance
bowtie instance going to give it a label
of environment test click on save
the region is going to be
east one and you can keep the default
zone as us east 1b the machine type
we're going to change it to e2micro and
you're going to scroll down to access
scopes and here your instance is going
to need access to your cloud storage
bucket and so it's going to need cloud
storage access so you're going to click
on set access for each api scroll down
to storage and for this demo we'll
select full gonna leave everything else
as the default and simply click on
create and so we'll give it a couple
minutes here for instance to create okay
and my instance has been created and so
now i want to create some files and copy
them over to cloud storage so i'm going
to first navigate over to cloud storage
and into my bucket and this way you can
see the files that you upload and so
next you're going to open up cloud shell
and make this a little bigger for better
viewing and so now you're going to ssh
into your instance by using the command
gcloud compute ssh along with your
instance name the zone flag dash dash
zone with the zone of us east 1b i'm
going to go ahead and hit enter and you
may be prompted with a message asking to
authorize this api call and you want to
hit authorize and you're going to be
prompted to enter a passphrase for your
key pair enter it in again
and one more time
and success we're logged into the
instance i'm going to quickly clear my
screen and so i know i could have sshed
into the instance from the compute
engine console but i wanted to display
both the console and the shell on the
same screen to make viewing a bit easier
as i add and remove files to and from
the bucket okay and so now that you're
logged in you want to create your first
file that you can copy over to your
bucket so you can enter in the command
sudo nano file a bow ties dot text hit
enter and this will allow you to open up
the nano editor to edit the file of
bowties.txt and here you can enter in
any message that you'd like for me i'm
going to enter in learning to tie a bow
tie takes time okay and i'm going to hit
ctrl o to save hit enter to verify the
file name to right and ctrl x to exit
and so now i want to copy this file up
to my bucket and so here is where i'm
going to use the gsutil command so i'm
going to type in gsutil cp for copy the
name of the file which is file of
bowties
text along with gs colon forward slash
forward slash and the name of your
bucket which in my case is bow tie ink
dash 2021 and this should copy my file
file a bowties.txt up to my bucket of
bow tie inc
2021 i'm gonna hit enter
okay and it's finished copying over and
if i go up here to the top right and
click on refresh i can see that my file
successfully uploaded and this is a
great and easy method to upload any
files that you may have to cloud storage
okay and so now that you've copied files
from your instance to your bucket you're
going to now copy some files from the
repo to be uploaded to cloud storage for
our next step so you're gonna go ahead
and exit out of the instance by just
simply typing in exit i'm gonna quickly
clear the screen and so here i need to
clone my repo if you already have clone
the repo then you can skip this step i'm
going to cd tilde to make sure i'm in my
home directory i'm going to do an ls and
so i can see here that i've already
cloned my repo so i'm going to cd into
that directory and i'm going to run the
command git pull to get the latest files
fantastic i'm going to now clear my
screen and i'm going to cd back to my
home directory and so now i want to copy
up the files that i want to work with to
my cloud storage bucket and they are two
jpegs by the name of pink
elephant-bowtie as well as plaid bowtie
and these files can be found in the repo
marked 12 storage services under zero
one cloud storage management and i will
be providing this in the lesson text as
well as can be found in the instructions
and so i'm going to simply cd into that
directory by typing in cd google cloud
associate cloud engineer 12 storage
services and 0 1 cloud storage
management i'm going to list all the
files in the directory and as you can
see here pink elephant dash bow tie and
plaid bow tie are both here and so i'm
going to quickly clear my screen and so
now for me to copy these files i'm going
to use the command gsutil
cp for copy star.jpg which is all the
jpegs that are available along with gs
colon forward slash forward slash and
the bucket name which is bow tie inc
dash 2021 i'm going to hit enter and it
says that it's successfully copied the
files i'm going to simply go up to the
top right hand corner and do another
refresh and success the files have been
successfully uploaded another perfect
example of copying files from another
source to your bucket using the gsutil
command line tool and so this is the end
of part one of this demo it was getting
a bit long so i decided to break it up
and this would be a great opportunity
for you to get up and have a stretch get
yourself a coffee or tea and whenever
you're ready part two will be starting
immediately from the end of part one so
you can complete this video and i will
see you in part two
[Music]
this is part two of the managing cloud
storage access demo and we'll be
starting exactly where we left off in
part 1. so with that being said let's
dive in and so now that we've uploaded
all these files we next want to make
this bucket publicly available now
please know that leaving a bucket public
is not common practice and should only
be used on the rare occasion that you
are hosting a static website from your
bucket and should always be kept private
whenever possible especially in a
production environment so please note
that this is only for the purposes of
this demo and so i'm going to quickly
show this to you in the console so i'm
going to shut down the cloud shell for
just a minute and i'm going to go to the
top menu and click on permissions and
under permissions i'm going to click on
add here you can add new members and
because you want to make it publicly
available you want to use the all users
member so you type in all and you should
get a pop-up bringing up all users and
all authenticated users you want to
click on all users and the role that you
want to select for this demo is going to
be storage object viewer so i'm going to
type in storage object viewer and here
it should pop up and select that and
then you can click on save you're going
to be prompted to make sure that this is
what you want to do that you want to
make this bucket public and so yes we do
so you can simply click on allow public
access and you will get a banner up here
at the top saying that this bucket is
public to internet and is a great fail
safe to have in case you were to ever
mistakenly make your bucket public and
if i head back over to objects you can
see that public access is available to
all the files in the bucket and so just
to verify this i'm going to copy the
public url for pink elephant dash bowtie
i'm going to open up a new tab paste in
the url hit enter and as you can see i
have public access to this picture and
close this tab and so now that we've
done our demo to make the bucket
publicly accessible we should go ahead
and remove public access so in order to
remove public permissions i can simply
go up to permissions and simply click on
remove public permissions i'm going to
get a prompt to make sure this is
exactly what i want to do and yes it is
so you can click on remove public
permissions a very simple and elegant
solution in order to remove public
access from your bucket and if you go
back to objects you'll see that all the
public access has been removed from all
the files and so now that you've
experienced how to add public access to
a bucket i wanted to get a little bit
more granular and so we're going to go
ahead and apply acl permissions for one
specific object and because i like pink
elephants let's go ahead and select pink
elephant dash bow tie and so here i can
go up to the top menu and click on edit
permissions and i'll be prompted with a
new window for permissions that are
currently available for this object you
can click on add entry click on the drop
down and select public from the
drop-down and it will automatically auto
populate the name which is all users and
the access which will be reader i'm
going to go ahead and click on save and
a public url will be generated and so
just to verify this i'm going to click
on the public url and success i now have
public access to this picture yet once
again i'm going to close down this tab
and so now that you've configured this
object for public access i want to show
you how to remove public access using
the command line this time so you're
going to go up to the top right hand
corner and open up cloud shell i'm going
to quickly clear my screen and i'm going
to paste in the command here which is
gsutil acl ch for change minus d which
is delete the name of the user which is
all users and if this was a regular user
you could enter in their email address
along with gs colon forward slash
forward slash the bucket name which in
my case is bow tie ink dash 2021 and the
name of the file which is pink elephant
bow tie dot jpeg i'm going to hit enter
and it says that it's been successfully
updated and so if i go back up here to
the console and i back out and go back
into the file i can see here that the
public url has been removed okay and now
there's one last step that we need to do
before ending this demo and this is to
create a signed url for the file so in
order to create a signed url we first
need to create a private key and so
we're gonna do this using a service
account and so i'm gonna head on over to
iam so i'm going to go up to the
navigation menu i'm going to go to i am
an admin and here with the menu on the
left i'm going to click on service
accounts here up at the top menu you're
going to click on create service account
and under service account name you can
enter in any name
but for me i'm going to enter in signed
url i'm going to leave everything else
as is i'm going to simply click on
create i'm going to close down cloud
shell because i don't really need it
right now just select a role and i'm
going to give it the role of storage
object viewer
i'm going to click on continue and i'm
going to leave the rest blank and simply
click on done and you should see a
service account with the name of signed
url and so in order to create a key i'm
going to simply go over to actions and
i'm going to click on the three dots and
i'm going to select create key from the
drop down menu and here i'm going to be
prompted with what type of key that i
want to create and you want to make sure
that json is selected and simply click
on create and this is where your key
will be automatically downloaded to your
downloads folder i'm going to click on
close and so once you have your key
downloaded you're able to start the
process of generating a signed url and
so i'm going to go ahead and use cloud
shell in order to generate this signed
url so i'm going to go ahead back up to
the top and open up cloud shell again
and then you can open up the cloud shell
editor going to go up to the top menu in
editor and click on file and you're
going to select upload files and here's
where you upload your key from your
downloads folder and i can see my key
has been uploaded right here and you can
rename your key file to something a
little bit more human readable so i'm
going to right click i'm going to click
on rename and you can rename this file
as privatekey.json hit ok and so once
you have your key uploaded and renamed
you can now go back into the terminal to
generate a signed url i'm going to
quickly clear the screen i'm going to
make sure that the private key is in my
path by typing in ls and as you can see
here privatekey.json
is indeed in my path and so before i
generate this key i'm going to head back
on over to cloud storage i'm going to
drill down into my bucket and as you can
see here pink elephant dash bow tie does
not have a public url and so when the
sign url is generated you will get a
public url that will not be shown here
in the console and will be private to
only the user that generated it and the
users that the url has been distributed
to okay and once you have everything in
place you can then go ahead and paste in
the command gsutil sign url minus d the
allotted time which is 10 minutes the
private key which is private key dot
json along with gs colon forward slash
forward slash your bucket name which in
my case is bow tie ink dash 2021 along
with the file name of
pinkelephant-bowtie.jpg i'm going to hit
enter and so i purposely left this error
here so you can see that when you
generate a signed url you need pi open
ssl in order to generate it and so the
caveat here is that because python 2 is
being deprecated the command pip install
pi openssl will not work pi open ssl
needs to be installed with python3 and
so to install it you're going to run the
command pip3 install pi open ssl and hit
enter and so once it's finished
installing you can now generate your
signed url i'm going to quickly clear my
screen paste in the command again hit
enter and success you've now generated a
sign url for the object pink elephant
bowtie.jpg and because this is a signed
url you will see under public url there
is no url there available even though it
is publicly accessible and so just to
verify this i'm going to highlight the
link here i'm going to copy it i'm going
to open up a new tab i'm going to paste
in this url hit enter and success this
sign url is working and anyone who has
access to it has viewing permissions of
the file for 10 minutes and so again
this is a great method for giving
someone access to an object who doesn't
have an account and will give them a
limited time to view or edit this object
and so i wanted to congratulate you on
making it through this demo and hope
that it has been extremely useful in
excelling your knowledge on managing
buckets files and access to the buckets
and files in cloud storage and so just
as a recap you created a cloud storage
bucket you then created an instance and
copied a file from that instance to the
bucket you then clone your repo to cloud
shell and copy two jpeg files to your
cloud storage bucket you then assigned
and then removed public access to your
bucket and then applied an acl to a file
in the bucket making it public as well
as removing public access right after
you then created a service account
private key and generated a signed url
to an object in that bucket
congratulations again on a job well done
and so that's pretty much all i wanted
to cover in this demo on managing cloud
storage access so you can now mark this
as complete and let's move on to the
next one
[Music]
welcome back in this demo we're going to
be getting into the weeds with object
versioning and life cycle management
using both the console and the command
line we're going to go through how
versioning works and what happens when
objects get promoted along with creation
configuration and editing these life
cycle policies and so with that being
said let's dive in so we're going to be
starting off from where we left off in
the last demo with all the resources
intact that we created before and we're
going to go ahead and dive right into
versioning and so the first thing that
you want to do is turn on versioning for
your current bucket so in my case for
bow tie ink dash 2021 and we're going to
do this through the command line so i'm
going to first go up to the top right
hand corner and open up cloud shell and
so you first want to see if versioning
is turned on for your bucket and you can
do this by using the command gsutil
versioning get along with gs colon
forward slash forward slash with your
bucket name and hit enter and you may be
prompted with a message asking you to
authorize this api call you definitely
want to authorize and as expected
versioning is not turned on on this
bucket hence the return of suspended and
so in order to turn versioning on we're
going to use a similar command gsutil
versioning and instead of get we're
going to use set on gs colon forward
slash forward slash and the bucket name
and hit enter and versioning has been
enabled and so if i run the command
gsutil version in get again i'll get a
response of enabled okay great now that
we have versioning enabled we can go
ahead with the next step which is to
delete one of the files in the bucket
and so you can go ahead and select plaid
bowtie.jpg
and simply click on delete you can
confirm the deletion and the file has
been deleted now technically the file
has not been deleted it is merely been
converted to a non-current version and
so in order to check the current and
non-current versions i'm going to use
the command
gsutil
ls minus a along with the bucket name of
g s colon forward slash forward slash
bow tie inc dash 2021 i'm gonna hit
enter
and as you can see here plaid bow tie
still shows up the ls minus a command is
a linux command to show all files
including the hidden files and so what's
different about these files is right
after the dot text or dot jpg you will
see a hashtag number and this is the
generation number and this determines
the version of each object and so what i
want to do now is bring back the
non-current version and make it current
so i'm going to promote the non-current
version of plaid bowtie.jpg
to the current version and so in order
to do this i'm going to run the command
gsutil and v for move along with the
bucket of gs colon forward slash forward
slash bowtie inc hyphen 2021 and the
name of the file of plaid bow tie dot
jpeg along with the generation number
and i'm going to copy it from the
currently listed i'm going to paste it
in and so now we need to put in the
target which is going to be the same
without the generation number and paste
that in then hit enter
okay operation completed and so if i go
up to the top right hand corner and
click on refresh i can see that now
there is a current version for plaid bow
tie now just know that using the move
command actually deletes the non-current
version and gives the new current
version a new generation number and so
in order to verify this i'm going to
quickly clear my screen and i'm going to
run the command gsutil ls minus a along
with the bucket name a bow tie inc dash
and the generation number here is
different than that of the last now if i
use the cp or copy command it would
leave the non-current version and create
a new version on top of that leaving two
objects with two different generation
numbers okay so with that step being
done you now want to log into your linux
instance and we're going to be doing
some versioning for file of bowties.text
so i'm going to go ahead and clear my
screen again and i'm going to run the
command gcloud compute ssh bowtie
instance which is the name of my
instance along with the zone flag dash
dash zone of the zone us east 1b i'm
going to hit enter
and you should be prompted for the
passphrase of your key
and i'm in and so here you want to edit
file a bowties.txt to a different
version so you can go ahead and run the
command sudo nano file a bow ties dot
text and hit enter and you should have
learning to tie a bow tie takes time and
what you want to do is append version 2
right at the end ctrl o to save enter to
verify the file name to right and
control x to exit and so now we want to
copy file a bow ties dot text to your
current bucket mine being bow tie ink
dash 2021 so i'm going to go ahead and
run the command gsutil cp the name of
the file which is file of bowties dot
text and the target which is going to be
bowtie inc
2021 and hit enter
and it's copied the file to the bucket
and so if i hit refresh in the console
you can see that there is only one
version of file of bowties.text and so
to check on all the versions that i have
i'm going to go back to my cloud shell
i'm going to quickly clear my screen and
i'm going to run the command gsutil ls
minus a along with the target bucket
hit enter and as you can see here there
are now two versions of file of
bowties.text and if i quickly open this
up
i'm gonna click on the url you can see
here that this is version two and so
this should be the latest generation of
file of bowties.txt that you edited over
in your instance i'm going to close this
tab now and so what i want to do now is
i want to promote the non-current
version to be the current version in
essence making version 2 the non-current
version and so i'm going to run the
command gsutil cp and i'm going to take
the older generation number and i'm
going to copy it and paste it here and
the target is going to be the same
without the generation number and paste
it and hit enter okay and the file has
been copied over so i'm going to do a
quick refresh in the console i'm going
to drill down into file a bowties.txt
and when i click on the url link it
should come up as version 1. and so this
is a way to promote non-current versions
to current versions using the gsutil
copy command or the gsutil move command
i'm going to close on this tab now i'm
going to quickly clear my screen and if
i run the command gsutil ls minus a
again you can see that i have even more
files and so these files and versions of
files will eventually accumulate and
continuously take up space along with
costing you money and so in order to
mitigate this a good idea would be to
put life cycle policies into place and
so you're gonna go ahead now and add a
life cycle policy to the bucket and this
will help manage the ever-growing
accumulation of files as more files are
being added to the bucket and more
versions are being produced something
that is very common that is seen in many
different environments and so we're
going to go ahead and get this done in
the console so i'm going to close down
cloud shell and i'm going to go back to
the main page of the bucket and under
the menu you can click on lifecycle and
here you'll be able to add the lifecycle
rules and so here you're going to click
on add a rule and the first thing that
you're prompted to do is to select an
action and so the first rule you're
going to apply is to delete non-current
objects after seven days so you're gonna
click on delete object you're gonna be
prompted with a warning gonna hit
continue and you'll be prompted to
select object conditions and as
discussed in an earlier lesson there are
many conditions to choose from and
multiple conditions can be selected so
here you're going to select days since
becoming non-current and in the empty
field you're going to type in 7. you can
click on continue and before you click
on create i wanted just to note that any
life cycle rule can take up to 24 hours
to take effect so i'm going to click on
create and here you can see the rule has
been applied to delete objects after
seven days when object becomes
non-current and so now that we added a
delete rule we're going to go ahead and
add another rule to move current files
that are not being used to a storage
class that can save the company money
and so let's go ahead and create another
lifecycle rule but this time to use this
set storage class action and so the
files that accumulate that have been
there for over 90 days you want to set
the storage class the cold line so this
way it'll save you some money and so
you're going to click on add a rule
you're going to select set storage class
to cold line and as a note here it says
archive objects will not be changed to
cold line so you can move forward with
the storage class but you can't move
backwards in other words i can't move
from cold line to near line or archive
the cold line i can only move from near
line to cold line or cold line to
archive so i'm going to go ahead and
click continue for the object conditions
you want to select age and in the field
you want to enter 90 days and here you
want to hit continue and finally click
on create and so in order to actually
see these rules take effect like i said
before it'll take up to 24 hours and so
before we end this demo i wanted to show
you another way to edit a life cycle
policy by editing the json file itself
so you can head on up to the top right
and open up cloud shell i'm going to
bring this down a little bit and you're
going to run the command gsutil
lifecycle get along with the bucket name
and output it to a file called
lifecycle.json and hit enter
and no errors so that's a good sign next
i'm going to run the command ls and as
you can see here the lifecycle.json file
has been written and so i'd like to edit
this file where it changes the set to
cold line rule from 90 days to 120 days
as tony bowtie's manager thinks that
they should keep the files a little bit
longer before sending it to coldline and
so in order to edit this file you're
going to run the command sudo nano
along with the name of the file of
lifecycle.js you hit enter and it's
going to be a long string but if you use
your arrow keys and move down and then
back you'll see the set to cold line
rule with the age of 90 days so i'm
going to move over here and i'm going to
edit this to 120 and i'm going to hit
ctrl o to save enter to verify file name
to write and ctrl x to exit and just
know that you can also edit this file in
cloud shell editor and so in order for
me to put this lifecycle policy in place
i need to set this as the new lifecycle
policy and so in order for me to do that
i'm going to run the command gsutil
lifecycle set along with the name of the
json file which is
lifecycle.json along with the bucket
name and hit enter and it looks like it
said it and i'm going to do quick
refresh in the console just to verify
and success the rule has been changed
from 90 days to 120 days congratulations
on completing this demo now a lot of
what you've experienced here is more of
what you will see in the architect exam
as the cloud engineer exam focuses on
more of the high level theory of these
cloud storage features
but i wanted to show you some real life
scenarios and how to apply the theory
that was shown in previous lessons into
practice and so just as a recap you set
versioning on the current bucket that
you are working in and you deleted a
file and made it non-current you then
brought it back to be current again you
then edited a file on your instance and
copied it over to replace the current
version of that file in your bucket you
then promoted the non-current version as
the new one and moved into lifecycle
rules where you created two separate
rules you created a rule to delete files
along with the rule to set storage class
after a certain age of the file and the
last step you took was to copy the
lifecycle policy to your cloud shell and
edited that policy and set it to a newer
edited version and so that pretty much
covers this demo on object versioning
and lifecycle management congratulations
again on a job well done and so before
you go
make sure you delete all the resources
you've created for the past couple of
demos as you want to make sure that
you're not accumulating any unnecessary
costs and so i'm going to do a quick run
through on deleting these resources and
so i'm going to quickly close down cloud
shell and i'm going to head on over to
the navigation menu go to compute engine
i'm going to delete my instance and i'm
going to head back on over to cloud
storage and delete the bucket there i'm
going to confirm the deletion i'm going
to click on delete and so that covers
the deletion of all the resources so you
can now mark this as complete and i'll
see you in the next one
welcome back and in this lesson i'm
going to be covering cloud sql one of
google cloud's many database offerings
that offers reliable secure and scalable
sql databases without having to worry
about the complexity to set it all up
now there's quite a bit to cover here so
with that being said let's dive in now
cloud sql is a fully managed cloud
native relational database service that
offers mysql postgres and sql server
engines with built-in support for
replication cloud sql is a database as a
service offering from google where
google takes care of all the underlying
infrastructure for the database along
with the operating system and the
database software now because there are
a few different types of database
offerings from google cloud sql was
designed for low latency transactional
and relational database workloads it's
also available in three different
flavors of databases mysql postgres and
the newest edition is sql server and all
of them support standard apis for
connectivity cloud sql offers
replication using different types of
read replicas which i will get into a
little bit later and offers capabilities
for high availability for continuous
access to your data cloud sql also
offers backups in two different flavors
and allows you to restore your database
from these backups with the same amount
of ease now along with your backups
comes point in time recovery for when
you want to restore a database from a
specific point in time cloud sql storage
relies on connected persistent disks in
the same zone that are available in
regular hard disk drives or ssds that
currently give you up to 30 terabytes of
storage capacity and because the same
technologies lie in the background for
persistent disks
automatic storage increase is available
to resize your disks for more storage
cloud sql also offers encryption at rest
and in transit for securing data
entering and leaving your instance and
when it comes to costs you are billed
for cpu memory and storage of the
instance along with egress traffic as
well please be aware that there is a
licensing cost when it comes to windows
instances now cloud sql instances are
not available in the same instance types
as compute engine and are only available
in the shared core
standard and high memory cpu types and
when you see them they will be clearly
marked with a db on the beginning of the
cpu type you cannot customize these
instances like you can with compute
engine and so memory will be pre-defined
when choosing the instance type now
storage types for cloud sql are only
available in hard disk drives and ssds
you are able to size them according to
your needs and as stated earlier can be
sized up to 30 terabytes in size and
when entering the danger zone of having
a full disk you do have the option of
enabling automatic storage increase so
you never have to worry about filling up
your disk before that 30 terabyte limit
now when it comes to connecting to your
cloud sql instance you can configure it
with a public or private ip but know
that after configuring the instance with
a private ip it cannot be changed
although connecting with the private ip
is preferred when connecting from a
client on a resource with access to a
vpc as well it is always best practice
to use private i p addresses for any
database in your environment whenever
you can now moving on to authentication
options the recommended method to
connecting to your cloud sql instance is
using cloud sql proxy the cloud sql
proxy allows you to authorize and secure
your connections using iam permissions
unless using the cloud sql proxy
connections to an instance's public ip
address are only allowed if the
connection comes from an authorized
network authorized networks are ip
addresses or ranges that the user has
specified as having permission to
connect once you are authorized you can
connect to your instance through
external clients or applications and
even other google cloud services like
compute engine gke app engine cloud
functions and cloud run now i wanted to
focus a moment here on the recommended
method for connecting to your instance
which is cloud sql proxy now as
mentioned before the cloud sql proxy
allows you to authorize and secure your
connections using iam permissions the
proxy validates connections using
credentials for a user or service
account and wrapping the connection in
an ssl tls layer that is authorized for
a cloud sql instance using the cloud sql
proxy is the recommended method for
authenticating connections to a cloud
sql instance as it is the most secure
the client proxy is an open source
library distributed as an executable
binary and is available for linux macos
and windows the client proxy acts as an
intermediary server that listens for
incoming connections wraps them in ssl
or tls and then passes them to a cloud
sql instance the cloud sql proxy handles
authentication with cloud sql providing
secure access to cloud sql instances
without the need to manage allowed ip
addresses or configure ssl connections
as well this is also the best solution
for applications that hold ephemeral
eyepiece and while the proxy can listen
on any port
it only creates outgoing connections to
your cloud sql instance on port 3307 now
when it comes to database replication
it's more than just copying your data
from one database to another the primary
reason for using replication is to scale
the use of data in a database without
degrading performance other reasons
include migrating data between regions
and platforms and from an on-premises
database to cloud sql you could also
promote a replica if the original
instance becomes corrupted and i'll be
getting into promoting replicas a little
bit later now when it comes to a cloud
sql instance the instance that is
replicated is called a primary instance
and the copies are called read replicas
the primary instance and read replicas
all reside in cloud sql read replicas
are read-only and you cannot write to
them the read replica processes queries
read requests and analytics traffics
thus reducing the load on the primary
instance read replicas can have more
cpus in memory than the primary instance
but they cannot have any less and you
can have up to 10 read replicas per
primary instance and you can connect to
a replica directly using its connection
name and ip address cloud sql supports
the following types of replicas
read replicas cross region read replicas
external read replicas and cloud sql
replicas when replicating from an
external server now when it comes to
read replicas you would use it to
offload work from a cloud sql instance
the read replica is an exact copy of the
primary instance and data and other
changes on the primary instance are
updated in almost real time on the read
replica a read replica is created in a
different region from the primary
instance and you can create a cross
region read replica the same way as you
would create an in-region replica this
improves read performance by making
replicas available closer to your
application's region it also provides
additional disaster recovery capability
to guard you against a regional failure
it also lets you migrate data from one
region to another with minimum downtime
and lastly when it comes to external
read replicas these are external mysql
instances that replicate from a cloud
sql primary instance
for example a mysql instance running on
compute engine is considered an external
instance and so just as a quick note
here before you can create a read
replica of a primary cloud sql instance
the instance must meet the following
requirements automated backups must be
enabled binary logging must be enabled
which requires point-in-time recovery to
be enabled and at least one backup must
have been created after binary logging
was enabled and so when you have read
replicas in your environment it gives
you the flexibility of promoting those
replicas if needed now promoting
replicas is a feature that can be used
for when your primary database becomes
corrupted or unreachable now you can
promote an in-region read replica or
cross-region re-replica depending on
where you have your read replicas hosted
so when you promote a read replica the
instance stops replication and converts
the instance to a standalone cloud sql
primary instance with read and write
capabilities please note that this
cannot be undone and also note that when
your new primary instance has started
your other read replicas are not
transferred over from the old primary
instance you will need to reconnect your
other read replicas to your new primary
instance and as you can see here
promoting a replica is done manually and
intentionally whereas high availability
has a standby instance that
automatically becomes the primary in
case of a failure horizontal outage now
when it comes to promoting cross-region
replicas there are two common scenarios
for promotion
regional migration which performs a
planned migration of a database to a
different region and disaster recovery
and this is where you would fail over a
database to another region in the event
that the primary instances region
becomes unavailable both use cases
involve setting up cross-region
replication and then promoting the
replica the main difference between them
is whether the promotion of the replica
is planned or unplanned now if you're
promoting your replicas for a regional
migration you can use a cross region
replica to migrate your database to
another region with minimal downtime and
this is so you can create a replica in
another region wait until the
replication catches up promote it and
then direct your applications to the
newly promoted instance the steps
involved in promotion are the same as
for promoting an in-region replica and
so when you're promoting replicas for
disaster recovery cross-region replicas
can be used as part of this disaster
recovery procedure you can promote a
cross-region replica to fail over to
another region should the primary
instances region become unavailable for
an extended period of time so in this
example the entire u.s east 1 region has
gone down yet the reed replica in the
europe region is still up and running
and although there may be a little bit
more latency for your customers in north
america i'm able to promote this read
replica connect it to the needed
resources and get back to business now
moving along to high availability cloud
sql offers aha capabilities out of the
box the aha configuration sometimes
called a cluster provides data
redundancy so a cloud sql instance
configured for ha is also called a
regional instance and is located in a
primary and secondary zone within the
configured region within a regional
instance the configuration is made up of
a primary instance and a standby
instance and through synchronous
replication to each zone's persistent
disk all rights made to the primary
instance are also made to the standby
instance each second the primary
instance writes to a system database as
a heartbeat signal if multiple
heartbeats aren't detected
failover is initiated and so if an
ha-configured instance becomes
unresponsive cloud sql automatically
switches to serving data from the
standby instance and this is called a
failover in this example the primary
instance or zone fails and failover is
initiated so if the primary instance is
unresponsive for approximately 60
seconds or the zone containing the
primary instance experiences an outage
failover will initiate the standby
instance immediately starts serving data
upon reconnection through a shared
static ip address with the primary
instance and the standby instance now
serves data from the secondary zone and
now when the primary instance is
available again a fail back will happen
and this is when traffic will be
redirected back to the primary instance
and the standby instance will go back
into standby mode as well the regional
persistent disk will pick up replication
to the persistent disk in that same zone
and with regards to billing an ha
configured instance is charged at double
the price of a standalone instance
and this includes cpu ram and storage
also note that the standby instance
cannot be used for read queries and this
is where it differs from read replicas
as well a very important note here is
that automatic backups and point in time
recovery must be enabled for high
availability and so the last topic that
i wanted to touch on is backups
and backups help you restore lost data
to your cloud sql instance you can also
restore an instance that is having
problems from a backup you enable
backups for any instance that contains
necessary data backups protect your data
from loss or damage enabling automated
backups along with binary logging is
also required for some operations such
as clone and replica creation by default
cloud sql stores backup data in two
regions for redundancy one region can be
the same region that the instance is in
and the other is a different region if
there are two regions in a continent the
backup data remains on the same
continent cloud sql also lets you select
a custom location for your backup data
and this is great if you need to comply
with data residency regulations for your
business now cloud sql performs two
types of backups on-demand backups and
automated backups now with on-demand
backups you can create a backup at any
time and this is useful for when you're
making risky changes that may go
sideways you can always create on-demand
backups for any instance whether the
instance has automatic backups enabled
or not and these backups persist until
you delete them or until their instance
is deleted now when it comes to
automated backups these use a four hour
backup window these backups start during
the backup window and just as a note
when possible you should schedule your
backups when your instance has the least
activity automated backups occur every
day when your instance is running at any
time in the 36 hour window and by
default up to seven most recent backups
are retained you can also configure how
many automated backups to retain from 1
to
365. now i've touched on this topic many
times in this lesson and i wanted to
highlight it for just a second and this
is point-in-time recovery so
point-in-time recovery helps you recover
an instance to a specific point in time
for example if an error causes a loss of
data you can recover a database to its
state before the error happened a point
in time recovery always creates a new
instance and you cannot perform a point
in time recovery to an existing instance
and point in time recovery is enabled by
default when you create a new cloud sql
instance and so when it comes to billing
by default cloud sql retains seven days
of automated backups plus all on-demand
backups for an instance and so i know
there is a lot to retain in this lesson
on cloud sql but be sure that these
concepts and knowing the difference
between them as well as when to use each
feature will be a sure help in the exam
along with giving you the knowledge you
need to use cloud sql in your role as a
cloud engineer and so that's pretty much
all i had to cover when it comes to
cloud sql so you can now mark this
lesson as complete and let's move on to
the next one
welcome back and in this lesson i wanted
to touch on google cloud's global
relational database called cloud spanner
now cloud spanner is the same in some
ways as cloud sql when it comes to asset
transactions sql querying and strong
consistency but differs in the way that
data is handled under the hood than
cloud sql and so knowing this database
only at a high level is needed for the
exam but i'll be going into a bit more
detail just to give you a better
understanding on how it works so with
that being said let's dive in now cloud
spanner is a fully managed relational
database service that is both strongly
consistent and horizontally scalable
cloud spanner is another database as a
service offering from google and so it
strips away all the headaches of setting
up and maintaining the infrastructure
and software needed to run your database
in the cloud now being strongly
consistent in this context is when data
will get passed on to all the replicas
as soon as a write request comes to one
of the replicas of the database cloud
spanner uses truetime a highly available
distributed atomic clock system that is
provided to applications on all google
servers it applies a time stamp to every
transaction on commit and so
transactions in other regions are always
executed sequentially cloud spanner can
distribute and manage data at a global
scale and support globally consistent
reads along with strongly consistent
distributed transactions now being fully
managed cloud spanner handles any
replicas that are needed for
availability of your data and optimizes
performance by automatically sharding
the data based on request load and size
of the data part of why cloud spanner's
high availability is due to its
automatic synchronous data replication
between all replicas in independent
zones cloud spanner scales horizontally
automatically within regions but it can
also scale across regions for workloads
that have higher availability
requirements making data available
faster to users at a global scale along
with node redundancy quietly added for
every node deployed in the instance and
when you quickly add up all these
features of cloud spanner it's no wonder
that it's available to achieve five
nines availability on a multi-regional
instance and four nines availability on
a regional instance cloud spanner is
highly secure and offers data layer
encryption audit logging and iam
integration cloud spanner was designed
to fit the needs of specific industries
such as financial services
ad tech retail and global supply chain
along with gaming and pricing for cloud
spanner comes in at 90 cents per node
per hour with the cost of storage coming
in at 30 cents per gigabyte per month
definitely not cheap but the features
are plentiful now this isn't in the exam
but i did want to take a moment to dive
into the architecture for a bit more
context as to why this database is of a
different breed than the typical sql
database now to use cloud spanner you
must first create a cloud spanner
instance this instance is an allocation
of resources that is used by cloud
spanner databases created in that
instance instance creation includes two
important choices the instance
configuration and the node count and
these choices determine the location and
the amount of the instances cpu and
memory along with its storage resources
your configuration choice is permanent
for an instance and only the node count
can be changed later if needed an
instance configuration defines the
geographic placement and replication of
the database in that instance either
regional or multi-region and please note
that when you choose a multi-zone
configuration it allows you to replicate
the databases data not just in multiple
zones but in multiple zones across
multiple regions and when it comes to
the node count this determines the
number of nodes to allocate to that
instance these nodes allocate the amount
of cpu memory and storage needed for
your instance to either increase
throughput or storage capacity there is
no instance types to choose from like
cloud sql and so when you need more
power you simply add another node now
for any regional configuration cloud
spanner maintains exactly three read
write replicas each within a different
zone in that region each read write
replica contains a full copy of your
operational database that is able to
serve rewrite and read only requests
cloud spanner uses replicas in different
zones so that if a single zone failure
occurs your database remains available
in a multi-region instance configuration
the instance is allotted a combination
of four read write and read only
replicas and just as a note a three node
configuration minimum is what is
recommended for production by google and
as cloud spanner gets populated with
data
sharding happens which is also known as
a split and cloud spanner creates
replicas of each database split to
improve performance and availability all
of the data in a split is physically
stored together in a replica and cloud
spanner serves each replica out of an
independent failure zone and within each
replica set
one replica is elected to act as the
leader leader replicas are responsible
for handling rights while any read write
or read only replica can serve a read
request without communicating with the
leader and so this is the inner workings
of cloud spanner at a high level and not
meant to confuse you but to give you a
better context of how cloud spanner
although it is a relational sql database
is so different than its cloud sql
cousin now before ending this lesson i
wanted to touch on node performance for
a quick moment and so each cloud spanner
node can provide up to 10 000 queries
per second or qps of reads or 2000 qps
of writes each node provides up to two
terabytes of storage and so if you need
to scale up the serving and storage
resources in your instance you add more
nodes to that instance
and remember as noted earlier that
adding a node does not increase the
number of replicas but rather increases
the resources each replica has in the
instance adding nodes gives each replica
more cpu and ram which increases the
replicas throughput and so if you're
looking to scale up automatically you
can scale the numbers of nodes in your
instance based on the cloud monitoring
metrics on cpu or storage utilization
in conjunction with using cloud
functions to trigger and so when you are
deciding on a relational database that
provides global distribution and
horizontally scalable that handles
transactional workloads in google cloud
cloud spanner will always be the obvious
choice over cloud sql and so that's
pretty much all i have to cover when it
comes to this overview on cloud spanner
so you can now mark this lesson as
complete and let's move on to the next
one
[Music]
welcome back and in this lesson we will
be going over the available nosql
databases available in google cloud this
lesson is meant to be another overview
just to familiarize you with the nosql
database options as they show up in the
exam this lesson is not meant to go in
depth on databases but an overview and
will give you a good understanding on
what features are available for each
and their use cases so with that being
said let's dive in now there are four
managed nosql databases available in
google cloud and i will be briefly going
over them and i'll be starting this off
by discussing bigtable
now cloud bigtable is a fully managed
wide column nosql database designed for
terabyte and petabyte scale workloads
that offers low latency and high
throughput bigtable is built for
real-time application serving workloads
as well as large-scale analytical
workloads cloud bigtable is a regional
service and if using replication a copy
is stored in a different zone or region
for durability cloud bigtable is
designed for storing very large amounts
of single keyed data while still being
able to provide very low latency and
because throughput scales linearly you
can increase the queries per second by
adding more bigtable nodes when you need
them bigtable throughput can be
dynamically adjusted by adding or
removing cluster nodes without
restarting meaning you can increase the
size of a bigtable cluster for just a
few hours to handle a large load and
then reduce the cluster size again and
do it all without any downtime bigtable
is an ideal source
for map reduce operations and integrates
easily with all the existing big data
tools such as hadoop dataproc and
dataflow along with apache hbase and
when it comes to price bigtable is
definitely no joke pricing for bigtable
starts at 65 cents per hour per node
or over 450 dollars a month for a one
node configuration with no data now you
can use bigtable to store and query all
of the following types of data such as
cpu and memory usage over time for
multiple servers marketing data such as
purchase histories and customer
preferences financial data such as
transaction histories stock prices and
currency exchange rates iot data or
internet of things such as usage reports
from energy meters and home appliances
and lastly graph data such as
information about how users are
connected to one another cloud bigtable
excels as a storage engine as it can
batch mapreduce operations
stream processing or analytics as well
as being used for storage for machine
learning applications now moving on to
the next nosql database is cloud
datastore and cloud datastore is a
highly scalable nosql document database
built for automatic scaling high
performance and ease of application
development datastore is redundant
within your location
to minimize impact from points of
failures and therefore can offer high
availability of reads and rights cloud
datastore can execute atomic
transactions where a set of operations
either all succeed or none occur cloud
datastore uses a distributed
architecture to automatically manage
scaling so you never have to worry about
scaling manually as well what's very
unique about cloud datastore is that it
has a sql-like query language that's
available called gql also known as gql
gql maps roughly to sql however a sql
role column lookup is limited to a
single value whereas in gql a property
can be a multiple value property this
consistency model allows an application
to handle large amounts of data and
users while still being able to deliver
a great user experience data is
automatically encrypted before it is
written to disk and automatically
decrypted when read by an authorized
user now this does not reflect in the
exam as of yet and i will be updating
this lesson if and when it happens but
firestore is the newest version of
datastore and introduces several
improvements over datastore existing
datastore users can access these
improvements by creating a new firestore
database instance in datastore mode and
in the near future all existing
datastore databases will be
automatically upgraded to firestore in
datastore mode now moving right along
cloud datastore holds a really cool
feature for developers that's called
datastore emulator and this provides
local emulation of the production
datastore environment so that you can
use to develop and test your application
locally this is a component of the
google cloud sdks gcloud tool and can be
installed by using the gcloud components
install command that we discussed
earlier on in the course and so moving
on to use cases for datastore
it is ideal for applications that rely
on highly available structured data at
scale you can use datastore for things
like product catalogs that provide
real-time inventory and product details
for a retailer user profiles that
deliver a customized experience based on
the user's past activities and
preferences
as well as transactions based on asset
properties for example transferring
funds from one bank account to another
next up we have firestore for firebase
and so this is a flexible scalable nosql
cloud database to store and sync data
for client and server side development
and is available for native c plus unity
node.js java go and python sdks
in addition to rest and rpc apis pretty
much covering the gamut of most major
programming languages now with cloud
firestore you store data in documents
that contain fields mapping to values
these documents are stored in
collections which are containers for
your documents that you can use to
organize your data and build queries
documents support many different data
types as well you can also create sub
collections within documents and build
hierarchical data structures cloud
firestore is serverless with absolutely
no servers to manage update or maintain
and with automatic multi-region
replication and strong consistency
google is able to hold
a five nines availability guarantee and
so when it comes to querying in cloud
firestore it is expressive efficient and
flexible you can create shallow queries
to retrieve data at the document level
without needing to retrieve the entire
collection or any nested subcollections
cloud firestore uses data
synchronization to update data in real
time for any connected device as well it
also caches data that your application
is actively using so that the
application can write read listen to and
query data even if the device is offline
when the device comes back online cloud
firestore synchronizes any local changes
back to cloud firestore you can also
secure your data in cloud firestore with
firebase authentication and cloud
firestore security rules for android ios
and javascript or you can use iam for
server side languages and when it comes
to costs firestore falls into the always
available free tier where you can use
one database holding five gigabytes or
if you need more you can move into their
paid option now firebase also has
another database sharing similar
features like having no servers to
deploy and maintain real-time updates
along with the free tier in this
database is called real time database
and is used for more basic querying
simple data structure and keeping things
to one database
it's something i like to call firestore
lite real time database does not show up
in the exam but i wanted to bring it to
light as it is part of the firebase
family just know that you can use both
databases within the same firebase
application or project as both can store
the same types of data client libraries
work in a similar manner and both hold
real-time updates now although firebase
is a development platform and not a
database service i wanted to give it a
quick mention for those of you who are
unfamiliar with the tie-in to firestore
with firebase firebase is a mobile
application development platform that
provides tools and cloud services to
help enable developers to develop
applications faster and more easily and
since it ties in nicely with firestore
it becomes the perfect platform for
mobile application development okay so
moving on to our last nosql database is
memorystore and memorystore is a fully
managed service from google cloud for
either redis or memcached in memory
datastore to build application caches
and this is a common service used in
many production environments
specifically when the need for caching
arises memory store automates the
administration tasks for redis and
memcached like enabling high
availability failover patching and
monitoring so you don't have to and when
it comes to memory store for redis
instances in the standard tier these are
replicated across zones
monitored for health and have fast
automatic failover standard tier
instances also provide an sla of three
nines availability memory store for
redis also provides the ability to scale
instant sizes seamlessly so that you can
start small and increase the size of the
instance as needed memory store is
protected from the internet using vpc
networks and private ip and also comes
with iam integration systems are
monitored around the clock ensuring that
your data is protected at all times and
know that the versions are always kept
up to date with the latest critical
patches ensuring your instances are
secure now when it comes to use cases of
course the first thing you will see is
caching and this is the main reason to
use memory store as it provides low
latency access and high throughput for
heavily accessed data compared to
accessing the data from a disk common
examples of caching is session
management frequently accessed queries
scripts or pages so when using memory
store for leaderboards and gaming this
is a common use case in the gaming
industry as well as using it for player
profiles memory store is also a perfect
solution for stream processing combined
with data flow memory store for redis
provides a scalable fast in memory store
for storing intermediate data that
thousands of clients can access with
very low latency and so when it comes to
nosql databases these are all the
available options on google cloud and as
i said before it will only show up on
the exam at merely a high level and so
knowing what each of these databases are
used for
will be a huge benefit along with being
an entry to diving deeper into possibly
using these services within your
day-to-day job as a cloud engineer and
so that's pretty much all i wanted to
cover when it comes to nosql databases
available in google cloud so you can now
mark this lesson as complete and let's
move on to the next one
[Music]
welcome back and in this lesson we'll be
going over the big data ecosystem in an
overview just to familiarize you with
the services that are available in
google cloud and are the services that
will show up in the exam this lesson is
not meant to go in depth but is an
overview and will give you a good
understanding on what these services can
do and how they all work together to
make sense of big data as a whole
so getting right into it i wanted to
first ask the question what is big data
i mean many people talk about it but
what is it really well big data refers
to massive amounts of data that would
typically be too expensive to store
manage and analyze using traditional
database systems either relational or
monolithic as the amount of data that we
have been seeing over the past few years
has started to increase these systems
have become very inefficient because of
their lack of flexibility for storing
unstructured data such as images text or
video as well as accommodating high
velocity or real-time data or scaling to
support very large
petabyte scale data volumes for this
reason the past few years has seen the
mainstream adoption of new approaches to
managing and processing big data
including apache hadoop and nosql
database systems however those options
often prove to be complex to deploy
manage and use in an on-premises
situation
now the ability to consistently get
business value from data
fast and efficiently is now becoming the
de facto of successful organizations
across every industry the more data a
company has access to the more business
insights and business value they're able
to achieve
like gain useful insights increase
revenue
get or retain customers and even improve
operations and because machine learning
models get more efficient as they are
trained with more data machine learning
and big data are highly complementary
all in all big data brings some really
great value to the table that is
impossible for any organization to turn
down and so now that we've gone through
that overview of what big data is i
wanted to dive into some shorter
overviews of the services available for
the big data ecosystem on google cloud
and so the first service that i'd like
to start with is bigquery now bigquery
is a fully managed serverless data
warehouse that enables scalable analysis
over petabytes of data this service
supports querying using sql and holds
built-in machine learning capabilities
you start by ingesting data into
bigquery and then you are able to take
advantage of all the power it provides
so big data would ingest that data by
doing a batch upload or by streaming it
in real time and you can use any of the
currently available google cloud
services to load data into bigquery you
can take a manual batch ingestion
approach
or stream using pub sub etl data and
with bigquery data transfer service you
can automatically transfer data from
external google data sources and partner
sas applications to bigquery on a
scheduled and fully managed basis and
the best part is batch and export is
free bigquery's high-speed streaming api
provides an incredible foundation for
real-time analytics making business data
immediately available for analysis and
you can also leverage pub sub and data
flow to stream data into bigquery
bigquery transparently and automatically
provides highly durable replicated
storage in multiple locations for high
availability as well as being able to
achieve easy resource bigquery keeps a
seven day history of changes in case
something were to go wrong bigquery
supports standard sql querying which
reduces the need for code rewrites you
can simply use it as you would for
querying any other sql compliant
database and with dataproc and dataflow
bigquery provides integration with the
apache big data ecosystem allowing
existing hadoop spark and beam workloads
to read or write data directly from
bigquery using the storage api bigquery
also makes it very easy to access this
data by using the cloud console using
the bq command line tool or making calls
to the bigquery rest api using a variety
of client libraries such as java.net or
python there are also a variety of
third-party tools that you can use to
interact with bigquery when visualizing
the data or loading the data bigquery
provides strong security and governance
controls with fine-grained controls
through integration with identity and
access management bigquery gives you the
option of geographic data control
without the headaches of setting up and
managing clusters and other computing
resources in different zones and regions
bigquery also provides fine grain
identity and access management and rest
assured that your data is always
encrypted at rest and in transit now the
way that bigquery calculates billing
charges is by queries and by storage
storing data in bigquery is comparable
in price with storing data in cloud
storage which makes it an easy decision
for storing data in bigquery there is no
upper limit to the amount of data that
can be stored in bigquery so if tables
are not edited for 90 days the price of
storage for that table drops by 50
percent query costs are also available
as on-demand and flat rate pricing and
when it comes to on-demand pricing you
are only charged for bytes read not
bytes returned in the end bigquery
scales seamlessly to store and analyze
petabytes to exabytes of data with ease
now there are so many more features to
list but if you are interested feel free
to dive into the other features with the
supplied link in the lesson text now
moving on to the next service is pub sub
and pub sub is a fully managed real-time
messaging service that allows you to
send and receive messages between
independent applications it acts as
messaging oriented middleware or event
ingestion and delivery for streaming
analytics pipelines and so a publisher
application creates and send messages to
a topic subscriber applications create a
subscription to a topic and receives
messages from it and so i wanted to take
a moment to show you exactly how it
works
so first the publisher creates messages
and sends them to the messaging service
on a specified topic a topic is a named
entity that represents a feed of
messages a publisher application creates
a topic in the pub sub service and sends
messages to that topic a message
contains a payload and optional
attributes that describe the content the
service as a whole ensures that
published messages are retained on
behalf of subscriptions and so a
published message is retained for a
subscription in a message queue shown
here as message storage until it is
acknowledged by any subscriber consuming
messages from that subscription pub sub
then forwards messages from a topic to
all of its subscriptions individually a
subscriber then receives messages either
by pub sub pushing them to the
subscriber's chosen endpoint or by the
subscriber pulling them from the service
the subscriber then sends an
acknowledgement to the pub sub service
for each received message the service
then removes acknowledged messages from
the subscriptions message queue and some
of the use cases for pub sub is
balancing large task queues distributing
event notifications and real-time data
streaming from various sources and so
the next service that i wanted to get
into is composer now composer is a
managed workflow orchestration service
that is built on apache airflow this is
a workflow automation tool for
developers that's based on the open
source apache airflow project similar to
an on-premises deployment cloud composer
deploys multiple components to run
airflow in the cloud airflow is a
platform
created by the community to
programmatically author schedule and
monitor workflows the airflow scheduler
as you see here executes the tasks on an
array of workers while following the
specified dependencies and storing the
data in a database and having a ui
component for easy management now
breaking down these workflows for just a
sec in data analytics a workflow
represents a series of tasks for
ingesting transforming analyzing or
utilizing data in airflow workflows are
created using dags which are a
collection of tasks that you want to
schedule and run
and organizes these tasks to ensure that
each task is executed at the right time
in the right order or with the right
issue handling now in order to run the
specialized workflows
provision environments are needed and so
composer deploys these self-contained
environments on google kubernetes engine
that work with other google cloud
services using connectors built into
airflow the beauty of composer is that
you can create one or more of these
environments in a single google cloud
project using any supported region
without having to do all the heavy
lifting of creating a full-blown apache
airflow environment now when it comes to
data flow dataflow is a serverless fully
managed processing service for executing
apache beam pipelines for batch and
real-time data streaming the apache beam
sdk is an open source programming model
that enables you to develop both batch
and streaming pipelines using one of the
apache beam sdks you build a program
that defines the pipeline then one of
apache beam's supported distributed
processing back-ends such as data flow
executes that pipeline the data flow
service then takes care of all the
low-level details like coordinating
individual workers sharding data sets
auto scaling and exactly once processing
now in its simplest form google cloud
data flow reads the data from a source
transforms it and then writes the data
back to a sink now getting a bit more
granular with how this pipeline works
data flow reads the data presented from
a data source
once the data has been read it is put
together into a collection of data sets
called a p collection and this allows
the data to be read distributed and
processed across multiple machines now
at each step in which the data is
transformed a new p collection is
created and once the final collection
has been created it is written to async
and this is the full pipeline of how
data goes from source to sync this
pipeline within data flow is called a
job and finally here is a high-level
overview of what a data flow job would
look like when you involve other
services within google cloud and put
together in an end-to-end solution from
retrieving the data to visualizing it
and finally when it comes to pricing
data flow jobs are billed in per second
increments so you're only charged for
when you are processing your data now
moving on to data proc this is a fast
and easy way to run spark hadoop hive or
pig on google cloud in an on-premises
environment it takes 5 to 30 minutes to
create spark and hadoop clusters data
proc clusters take 90 seconds or less on
average to be built in google cloud
dataproc has built-in integration with
other google cloud platform services and
use spark and hadoop clusters without
any admin assistance so when you're done
with the cluster you can simply turn it
off so you don't spend money on an idle
cluster as well there's no need to worry
about data loss because data proc is
integrated with cloud storage bigquery
and cloud bigtable the great thing about
dataproc is you don't need to learn new
tools or apis to use it
spark hadoop pig and hive are all
supported and frequently updated and
when it comes to pricing you are billed
at one cent per vcpu in your cluster per
hour on top of the other resources you
use you also have the flexibility of
using preemptable instances for even
lower compute cost now although cloud
data proc and cloud data flow can both
be used to implement etl data
warehousing solutions they each have
their strengths and weaknesses and so i
wanted to take a quick moment to point
them out now with dataproc you can
easily spin up clusters through the
console the sdk or the api and turn it
off when you don't need it with dataflow
it is serverless and fully managed so
there are never any servers to worry
about and when it comes to having any
dependencies to tools in the hadoop or
spark ecosystem data proc would be the
way to go but if you're looking to make
your jobs more portable across different
execution engines apache beam allows you
to do this and is only available on data
flow moving on to the next service is
cloud data lab now cloud data lab is an
interactive developer tool created to
explore analyze transform and visualize
data and build machine learning models
from your data data lab uses open
sourced jupyter notebooks a well-known
format used in the world of data science
it runs on compute engine and connects
to multiple cloud services easily so you
can focus on your data science tasks it
also integrates with all of the google
services that help you simplify data
processing like bigquery and cloud
storage cloud data lab is packaged as a
container and run in a vm instance cloud
data lab uses notebooks instead of text
files containing code notebooks bring
together code documentation written as
markdown and the results of code
execution whether it's text image or
html or javascript like a code editor or
ide notebooks help you write code and
they allow you to execute code in an
interactive and iterative manner
rendering the results alongside the code
cloud data lab notebooks can be stored
in google cloud source repository this
git repository is cloned onto persistent
disk when attached to the vm now when it
comes to prepping your data before
consumption whether it be data cleansing
cleaning prepping or alteration this is
where data prep hits it out of the park
dataprep is a serverless intelligent
data service for visually exploring
cleaning and preparing structured and
unstructured data for analysis reporting
and machine learning it automatically
detects schemas data types possible
joins and anomalies such as missing
values outliers and duplicates so you
don't have to the architecture that i'm
about to show you is how data prep
shines the raw data that's available
from various different sources is
ingested into cloud data prep to clean
and prepare the data data prep then
sends the data off to cloud data flow to
refine that data and then sent off to
cloud storage or bigquery for storage
before being analyzed by one of the many
available bi tools now these big data
services are used by many data analysts
in the field and it's great to know what
services that can be used to help
process the data needed for their
specific job as well for the exam you
only need to know these services at a
high level and not to know them in depth
but if you seem interested in diving
into any of these services to know more
about them i highly encourage you to
dive in after the course and really take
a look at them and that's pretty much
all i have to cover in this lesson on
the services that are available for the
big data ecosystem in google cloud so
you can now mark this lesson as complete
and let's move on to the next one
[Music]
welcome back
this lesson is going to be based on the
foundation of machine learning i'm going
to go over what machine learning is what
it can do for us the machine learning
ecosystem on google cloud
and hopefully answer any questions along
the way this lesson will be a high level
overview of the services available on
google cloud yet these services that are
available are a need to know as they
come up in the exam and hopefully will
give you some really cool ideas on the
possibilities of building something
truly fantastic on google cloud so what
is machine learning
well machine learning is functionality
that helps enable software to perform
tasks without any explicit programming
or rules traditionally considered a
subcategory of artificial intelligence
machine learning involves statistical
techniques such as deep learning also
known as neural networks that are
inspired by theories about how the human
brain processes information it is
trained to recognize patterns in
collected data using algorithmic models
and this collected data includes video
images speech or text and because
machine learning is very expensive to
run on-premises
is an efficient place
for machine learning due to the use of
massive computation at scale
and as explained before machine learning
is always better with big data so now i
wanted to touch on what can machine
learning do for us
well it can categorize images such as
photos faces or satellite imagery
it can look for keywords in text
documents or emails
it can flag potentially fraudulent
transactions when it comes to credit
cards or debit cards it can enable
software to respond accurately to voice
commands it can also translate languages
in text or audio and these are just some
of the common functions that machine
learning can do for us so getting into
google's machine learning platform
itself machine learning has been a
cornerstone of google's internal systems
for years primarily because their need
to automate data-driven systems on a
massive scale
and doing this has provided unique
insight into the right techniques
infrastructure and frameworks that help
their customers get optimal value out of
machine learning the originally
developed open source framework for use
inside of google
called tensorflow
is now the standard in the data science
community in addition to heavily
contributing to the academic and open
source communities
google's machine learning researchers
helped bring that functionality into
google products such as g suite search
and photos in addition to google's
internal operations when it comes to
data center automation
now here is an overview of all the
machine learning services that we will
be covering and that you will need to
know
only at a high level for the exam and
we'll start off with the site api
services
starting with the vision api
the vision api offers powerful
pre-trained machine learning models
that allow you to assign labels to
images
and quickly classify them into millions
of pre-defined categories
vision api
can read printed and handwritten text it
can detect objects and faces
and build metadata into an image catalog
of your choice now when it comes to
video intelligence
it has pre-trained machine learning
models that automatically recognizes
more than 20 000 objects
places and actions in stored and
streaming video you can gain insights
from video in near real time using the
video intelligence streaming video apis
and trigger events based on objects
detected you can easily search a video
catalog the same way you search text
documents and extract metadata that can
be used to index organize and search
video content
now moving on to the language apis
we start off with the natural language
api and this uses machine learning to
reveal the structure and meaning of text
you can extract information about people
places and events
and better understand social media
sentiment and customer conversations
natural language enables you to analyze
text and also integrate it with your
document storage on cloud storage now
with the translation api it enables you
to dynamically translate between
languages using google's pre-trained or
custom machine learning models
translation api
instantly translates text into more than
100 languages for your website and apps
with optional customization features
following another grouping of machine
learning is the conversation apis first
up we have dialog flow dialog flow is a
natural language understanding platform
that makes it easy to design and
integrate a conversational user
interface into your application or
device it could be a mobile app a web
application a bot or an interactive
voice response system using dialogflow
you can provide new and engaging ways
for users to interact with your product
dialogflow can analyze multiple types of
input from your customers
including text or audio inputs
like from a phone or voice recording and
it can also respond to your customers in
a couple of ways either through text or
with synthetic speech now with the
speech-to-text api this api accurately
converts speech into text it can
transcribe content with accurate
captions and deliver better user
experience in products through voice
commands going the other way from text
to speech this api enables developers to
synthesize natural sounding speech with
over a hundred different voices
available in multiple languages and
variants text to speech
allows you to create lifelike
interactions with their users across
many applications and devices and to
finish off our machine learning segment
i wanted to touch on auto ml automl is a
suite of machine learning products that
enables developers with very limited
machine learning expertise
to train high quality models specific to
their business needs in other words
using automl allows making deep learning
easier to use and relies on google's
state-of-the-art transfer learning and
neural architecture search technology so
you can now generate high quality
training data and be able to deploy new
models based on your data in minutes
automl is available for vision
video intelligence translation
natural language tables
inference and recommendation apis
now i know this has been a lot to cover
for this machine learning lesson and the
ecosystem around it but is a necessity
for the exam and will also help you
build really cool products when it comes
to your role as an engineer again all
the services that i have discussed in
this lesson should be known at a high
level only although my recommendation
would be to dive deeper into these
services by checking out the links in
the lesson text below and having some
fun with these products getting to know
these services will really help up your
game when it comes to getting to know
these services a little bit more in
depth and will really help you gain more
momentum when it comes to building any
applications or applying them to any
currently running applications i
personally found it extremely valuable
and really cemented my knowledge when it
came to machine learning i also had a
ton of fun doing it and so that's all i
have for this lesson on machine learning
so you can now mark this lesson as
complete and let's move on to the next
one
[Music]
welcome back and in this lesson we'll be
diving into a suite of tools used on the
google cloud platform that allow you to
operate monitor and troubleshoot your
environment known as operation suite and
previously known as stackdriver this
lesson will be mostly conceptual and
gear more towards what the suite of
tools do as it plays a big part not only
in the exam but for the needs of gaining
insight from all the resources that
exist in your environment now there are
a few tools to cover here so with that
being said let's dive in
now the operation suite is a suite of
tools for logging monitoring and
application diagnostics
operation suite ingests this data and
generates insights using dashboards
charts and alerts this suite of tools
are available for both gcp and aws you
can connect to aws using an aws role and
a gcp service account you can also
monitor vms with specific agents that
again both run on gcp for compute engine
and aws ec2 operation suite also allows
the added functionality of monitoring
any applications that's running on those
vms operation suite is also available
for any on-premises infrastructure or
hybrid cloud environments operation
suite has a native integration within
gcp out of the box so there's no real
configurations that you need to do and
integrates with almost all the resources
on google cloud such as the previously
mentioned compute engine gke app engine
and bigquery and you can find and fix
issues faster due to the many different
tools an operation suite can reduce
downtime with real-time alerting you can
also find support from a growing partner
ecosystem of technology integration
tools to expand your operations security
and compliance capabilities now the
operation suite comprises of six
available products that covers the gamut
of all the available tools you will need
that allows you to monitor troubleshoot
and improve application performance on
your google cloud environment and i will
be going over these products in a bit of
detail starting with monitoring now
cloud monitoring collects measurements
or metrics to help you understand how
your applications and system services
are performing giving you the
information about the source of the
measurements time stamped values and
information of those values that can be
broken down through time series data
cloud monitoring can then take the data
provided and use pre-defined dashboards
that require no setup or configuration
effort cloud monitoring also gives you
the flexibility to create custom
dashboards that display the content you
select you can use the widgets available
or you can install a dashboard
configuration that is stored in github
now in order for you to start using
cloud monitoring you need to configure a
workspace
now workspaces organize monitoring
information in cloud monitoring this is
a single pane of glass where you can
view everything that you're monitoring
in your environment it is also best
practice to use a multi-project
workspace so you can monitor multiple
projects from a single pane of glass now
as i mentioned earlier cloud monitoring
has an agent and this gathers system and
application metrics from your vm and
sends them to cloud monitoring you can
monitor your vms without the agent but
you will only get specific metrics such
as cpu
disk traffic network traffic and uptime
using the agent is optional but is
recommended by google and with the agent
it allows you to monitor many
third-party applications and just as a
note cloud logging has an agent as well
and works well together with cloud
monitoring to create visualize and alert
on metrics based on log data but more on
that a little bit later cloud monitoring
is also available for gke and this will
allow you to monitor your clusters as it
manages the monitoring and logging
together and this will monitor clusters
infrastructure its workloads and
services as well as your nodes pods and
containers so when it comes to alerting
this is defined by policies and
conditions so an a learning policy
defines the conditions under which a
service is considered unhealthy when
these conditions are met the policy is
triggered and it opens a new incident
and sends off a notification a policy
belongs to an individual workspace and
each workspace can contain up to 500
policies now conditions determine when
an alerting policy is triggered so all
conditions watch for three separate
things the first one is a metric the
second one is a behavior in some way and
the third one is for a period of time
describing a condition includes a metric
to be measured and a test for
determining when the metric reaches a
state that you want to know about so
when an alert is triggered you could be
notified using notification channels
such as email
sms
as well as third party tools such as
pagerduty and slack now moving on to
cloud logging cloud logging is a central
repository for log data from multiple
sources and as described earlier logging
can come not just from google but with
aws as well as on-premises environments
cloud logging handles real-time log
management and analysis and has tight
integration with cloud monitoring it
collects platform system and application
logs and you also have the option of
exporting logs to other sources such as
long-term storage like cloud storage or
for analysis like bigquery you can also
export to third-party tools as well now
diving into the concepts of cloud
logging these are associated primarily
with gcp projects so logs viewer only
shows logs from one specific project now
when it comes to log entries log entry
records a status or an event a project
receives log entries when services being
used produce log entries and to get down
to the basics
logs are a named collection of log
entries within a google cloud resource
and just as a note each log entry
includes the name of its log logs only
exist if they have log entries and the
retention period is the length of time
for which your logs are kept so digging
into the types of logs that cloud
logging handles there are three
different types of logs there are audit
logs transparency logs and agent logs
now with audit logs these are logs that
define who did what where and when they
also show admin activity and data access
as well as system events continuing on
to access transparency logs these are
logs for actions taken by google so when
google staff is accessing your data due
to a support ticket the actions that are
taken by the google staff are logged
within cloud logging now when it comes
to agent logs these are the logs that
come from agents that are installed on
vms
the logging agent sends system and
third-party logs on the vm instance to
cloud logging moving on to error
reporting this looks at real-time error
monitoring and alerting it counts
analyzes and aggregates the errors that
happen in your gcp environment and then
alerts you when a new application error
occurs details of the error can be sent
through the api and notifications are
still in beta error reporting is
integrated into cloud functions and
google app engine standard which is
enabled automatically error reporting is
in beta for compute engine kubernetes
engine and app engine flexible as well
as aws ec2 air reporting can be
installed in a variety of languages such
as go java.net
node.js python php and ruby now moving
into debugger this tool debugs a running
application without slowing it down it
captures and inspects the call stack and
local variables in your application this
tool debugs a running application
without slowing it down it captures and
inspects the call stack and local
variables in your application this is
also known as taking a snapshot once the
snapshot has been taken
a log point can be injected to allow you
to start debugging debugger can be used
with or without access to your
application source code and if your repo
is not local it can be hooked into a
remote git repo such as github git lab
or bitbucket debugger is integrated with
google app engine automatically and can
be installed on google compute engine
gke
and google app engine debugger is
integrated with google app engine
automatically and can be installed on
gke debugger is integrated with google
app engine automatically and can be
installed on google compute engine
google kubernetes engine google app
engine and cloud run and just as a note
installation on these products is all
dependent on the library and again
debugger can be installed like trace on
non-gcp environments and is available to
be installed using a variety of
different languages next up is trace and
trace helps you understand how long it
takes your application to handle
incoming requests from users and
applications trace collects latency data
from app engine https load balancers and
applications using the trace api this is
also integrated with google app engine
standard and is applied automatically so
you would use trace for something like a
website that is taking forever to load
to troubleshoot that specific issue
trace can be installed on google compute
engine google kubernetes engine and
google app engine as well it can also be
installed on non-gcp environments and it
can be installed using a variety of
different languages as shown here and
coming up on the last tool of the bunch
is profiler now profiler gathers cpu
usage and memory allocation information
from your applications continuously and
this helps you discover patterns of
resource consumption to help you better
troubleshoot profiler is low profile and
therefore won't take up a lot of memory
or cpu on your system as well in order
to use profiler an agent needs to be
installed profiler can be installed on
compute engine kubernetes engine and app
engine as well and of course it can be
installed on non-gcp environments and
profiler can be installed using the
following languages just go
java node.js and python and so just as a
note for the exam only a high level
overview of these tools are needed and
so this concludes this lesson on a high
level overview of operation suite so you
can now mark this lesson as complete and
let's move on to the next one